foreign
data has evolved in the last decade like
never before and currently data
generation has increased by Leaps and
Bounds and all this data is collectively
termed as Big Data
businesses require Big Data Engineers
who can handle this data and Big Data
Engineers do this with the help of
Frameworks like Hadoop and Spark on that
note hi everyone welcome to this video
on Big Data engineer full course in this
video we will help you understand how
you can become a big data engineer and
we will also cover the fundamentals of
Big Data Hadoop and Spark We Begin this
because by understanding how to become a
big data engineer
we will then understand the top skills
required for big data jobs here we will
also take a close look at other top job
roles in the Big Data domain we will
then understand big data analytics
and understand how big data is used
across several domains by learning a few
crucial Big Data applications
we will then gain a deep understanding
of Big Data its Evolution and its
challenges following which we will learn
about Hadoop and how it solves big data
problems we will also take an individual
look at components of Hadoop like hdfs
mapreduce and yarn we will also be
learning about school high big and
headspace the next topic we will be
covering is spark here we will
understand the architecture of spark and
look at spark streaming
finally we will conclude this full
course by looking into a set of top
Hadoop interview questions and answers
so let's start off with our full course
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn we all use smartphones
but have you ever wondered how much data
it generates in the form of texts phone
calls emails photos videos searches and
music approximately 40 exabytes of data
gets generated every month by a single
smartphone user now imagine this number
multiplied by 5 billion smartphone users
that's a lot for our mind even process
isn't it in fact this amount of data is
quite a lot for traditional Computing
systems to handle and this massive
amount of data is what we term as Big
Data let's have a look at the data
generated per minute on the internet
2.1 million Snaps are shared on Snapchat
3.8 million search queries are made on
Google one 1 million people log on to
Facebook 4.5 million videos are watched
on YouTube
188 million emails are sent that's a lot
of data so how do you classify any data
as Big Data this is possible with the
concept of five V's volume velocity
variety veracity and value let us
understand this with an example from the
healthcare industry Hospitals and
Clinics across the world generate
massive volumes of data 2 314 exabytes
of data are collected annually in the
form of patient records and test results
all this data is generated at a very
high speed which attributes to the
velocity of Big Data variety refers to
the various data types such as
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data examples include Excel
records log files and x-ray images
accuracy and trustworthiness of the
generated data is termed as veracity
analyzing all this data will benefit the
medical sector by enabling faster
disease detection better treatment and
reduced cost this is known as the value
of Big Data but how do we store and
process this big data to do this job we
have various Frameworks such as
Cassandra Hadoop and Spark let us take
Hadoop as an example and see how Hadoop
stores and processes Big Data
Hadoop uses a distributed file system
known as Hadoop distributed file system
to store Big Data if you have a huge
file your file will be broken down into
smaller chunks and stored in various
machines not only that when you break
the file you also make copies of it
which goes into different nodes this way
you store your big data in a distributed
way and make sure that even if one
machine fails your data is safe on
another
mapreduce technique is used to process
Big Data a lengthy task a is broken into
smaller tasks
b c and d now instead of one machine
three machines take up each task and
complete it in a parallel fashion and
assemble the results at the end thanks
to this the processing becomes easy and
fast this is known as parallel
processing
now that we have stored and processed
our big data we can analyze this data
for numerous applications in games like
Halo 3 and Call of Duty designers
analyze user data to understand at which
stage most of the users pause restart or
quit playing this Insight can help them
rework on the storyline of the game and
improve the user experience which in
turn reduces the customer churn rate
similarly Big Data also helped with
disaster management during Hurricane
Sandy in 2012. it was used to gain a
better understanding of the storm's
effect on the east coast of the U.S and
necessary measures were taken it could
predict the Hurricane's landfall five
days in advance which wasn't possible
earlier these are some of the clear
indications of how valuable big data can
be once it is accurately processed and
analyzed today I'm going to tell you how
you can become a big data engineer now
it should come as no surprise for you
guys to know that organizations generate
as well as use a whole lot of data this
vast volume of data is called Big Data
companies use big data to draw
meaningful insights and take business
decisions and Big Data Engineers are the
people who can make sense out of this
enormous amount of data now let's find
out who is a big data engineer a big
data engineer is a professional Who
develops maintains tests and evaluates
the company's Big Data infrastructure in
other words developing Data Solutions
based on a company's requirements they
maintain these solutions they test out
these Solutions as to the company's
requirements they integrate this
solution with various tools and systems
of the organization and finally they
evaluate how well the solution is
working to fulfill the company's
requirements next up let's have a look
at the responsibilities of a big data
engineer now they need to be able to
design Implement verify and maintain
software systems now for the process of
ingesting data as well as processing it
they need to be able to build highly
scalable as well as robust systems they
need to be able to extract data from one
database transform it as well as load it
into another data store with the process
of ETL or the extract transform load
process and they need to research as
well as propose new ways to acquire data
improve the overall data quality and the
efficiency of the system now to ensure
that all the business requirements are
met they need to build a suitable data
architecture they need to be able to
integrate several programming languages
and tools to together so that they can
generate a structured solution they need
to build models that reduce the overall
complexity and increase the efficiency
of the whole system by mining data from
various sources and finally they need to
work well with other teams ones that
include data Architects data analysts
and data scientists next up let's have a
look at the skills required to become a
big data engineer the first step is to
have programming knowledge one of the
most important skills required to become
a big data engineer is that of
experience with programming languages
especially hands-on experience now the
Big Data Solutions that organizations
would want you to create will not be
possible without experience in
programming languages I can even tell
you an easy way through which you can
get experience with programming
languages practice and more practice
some of the most commonly used
programming languages used for Big Data
engineering are python Java and C plus
the second skill that you require is to
have in-depth knowledge about dbms and
SQL you need to know how data is
maintained as well as managed in a data
base you need to know how SQL can be
used to transform as well as perform
actions on a database and by extension
know how to write SQL queries for any
relational database Management Systems
some of the commonly used database
Management systems for Big Data
engineering mySQL rackle database and
the Microsoft SQL Server the third skill
that you require is to have experience
working with ETL and warehousing tools
now you need to know how to construct as
well as use a data warehouse so that you
can perform the ETL operation or the
extract transform and load operations
now as a big data engineer you'll be
constantly tasked with extracting
unstructured data from a number of
different sources transforming it into
meaningful information and loading it
into other data storages databases or
data warehouses now what this is is
basically aggregating unstructured data
from multiple sources analyzing it so
that you can take Better Business
decisions some of the tools used for
this purpose are Talent IBM data stage
pentahoe and Informatica next up we have
the fourth skill that you require which
is knowledge about operating systems now
since most Big Data tools have unique
demands such as root access to operating
system functionality as well as Hardware
having a strong understanding of
operating systems like Linux and Unix is
absolutely mandatory some of the
operating systems used by Big Data
Engineers are Unix Linux and Solaris now
the fifth skill that you require to have
experience with Hadoop based analytics
since Hadoop is one of the most commonly
used tools when it comes to Big Data
engineering it's understood that you
need to have experience with Apache
Hadoop based Technologies Technologies
like hdfs Hadoop mapreduce Apache Edge
base Hive and pig the sixth skill that
you require is to have worked with
real-time processing Frameworks like
Apache spark now as a big data engineer
you'll have to deal with vast volumes of
data so for this data you need an
analytics engine like spark which can be
used for large-scale real-time data
processing now spark can process live
streaming data from a number of
different sources like Facebook
Instagram Twitter and so on it can also
perform interactive analysis and data
integration and now we're at our final
skill requirement which is to have
experience with data mining and modeling
so as a data engineer you'll have to
examine massive pre-existing data so
that you can discover patterns as well
as new information with this you will
create predictive models for your
business so that you can make better
informed decisions some of the tools
used for this are are rapidminer weka
and 9. now let's talk about a big data
engineer's salary as well as other roles
they can look forward to now the average
salary of a big data engineer in the
United States is approximately ninety
thousand dollars per year now this
ranges from sixty six thousand dollars
all the way to 130 000 per annum in
India the average salary is around 7
lakh rupees and ranges from 4 lakhs to
13 lakhs per annum after you've become a
big data engineer some of the job roles
that you can look forward to are that of
a senior Big Data engineer a business
intelligence detect and a data architect
now let's talk about certifications that
a big data engineer can opt for first
off we have the Cloudera CCP data
engineer a cloud data certified
professional data engineer possesses the
skills to develop reliable and scalable
data pipelines that result in optimized
data sets for a variety of workloads it
is one of the industry's most demanding
Performance Based certification CCP
evaluates and recognizes the candidate's
Mastery of the technical skills most
sought after by employers the time limit
for this exam is 240 minutes and it
costs 400 next we have the IBM certified
data architect Big Data certification an
IBM certified Big Data architect
understands the complexity of data and
can Design Systems and models to handle
different data variety including
structured semi-structured unstructured
volume velocity veracity and so on a big
data architect is also able to
effectively address information
governance and security challenges
associated with the system this exam is
75 min it's long and finally we have the
Google Cloud certified data engineer a
Google Certified data engineer enables
data-driven decision making by
collecting transforming and Publishing
data they should also be able to
leverage deploy and continuously train
pre-existing machine learning models the
length of the certification exam is two
hours and its registration fee is 200
now let's have a look at how simply
learn can help you become a big data
engineer simply learn provides the Big
Data architect Masters program this
includes a number of different courses
like big data Hadoop and Spark developer
Apache spark and Scala mongodb developer
and administrator big data and Hadoop
administrator and so much more this
course goes through 50 plus in demand
skills and tools 12 plus real life
projects and the possibility of an
annual average salary of 19 to 26 lakh
rupees per annum it will also help you
get noticed by the top hiring companies
this course will also go through some
major tools like Kafka Apache spark
Flume edgebase DB Hive big map produce
Java Scala and much more now why don't
you head over to simplylearn.com and get
started on your journey to get certified
and get ahead back in the early 2000s
there was relatively less data generated
but with the rise of various social
media platforms and multinational
companies across the globe the
generation of data has increased by
Leaps and Bounds
according to the IDC the total volume of
data is expected to reach 175 zettabytes
in 2025. that's a lot of data
so we can Define Big Data as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
processed and analyzed using the
traditional ways let's now have a look
at the challenges with respect to Big
Data
the first challenge with big data is its
storage storing big data is not easy as
the data generation is endless in
addition to this storing unstructured
data in our traditional databases is a
great challenge unstructured data refers
to data such as photographs and videos
the Second Challenge was processing Big
Data data is only useful to us if it is
processed and analyzed processing Big
Data consumes a lot of time due to its
size and structure
to overcome these challenges of big data
we have various Frameworks such as
Hadoop Cassandra and Spark let us have a
quick look at Hadoop and Spark
so what is Hadoop it is a framework that
stores big data in a distributed way and
processes it parallely how do you think
Hadoop does this
well Hadoop users are distributed file
system known as Hadoop distributed file
system to store Big Data if you have a
huge file your file will be broken out
into smaller chunks and stored in
various machines this is why it is
termed as distributed storage
map reduce is the processing unit of
Hadoop here we have multiple Machines
working parallely to process Big Data
thanks to this technique the processing
becomes easy and fast
let's now move on to spark spark is a
framework that is responsible for
processing data both in batches and in
real time spark is used to analyze data
across various clusters of computers
now that you have understood Big Data
Hadoop and Spark let's look into few of
the different job roles in this domain
career opportunities in this field are
Limitless as organizations are using big
data to enhance their products business
decisions and marketing effectiveness
so here we will understand in depth as
to how to become a big data engineer in
addition to this we will also look into
the various skills required to become a
Hadoop developers Park developer and a
big data architect
starting off with a big data engineer
role do you know who a big data engineer
is
well Big Data Engineers are
professionals who develop maintain test
and evaluate a company's Big Data
infrastructure
they have several responsibilities
firstly they are responsible for
Designing and implementing software
systems they verify and maintain these
systems for their ingestion and
processing of data they built robust
systems extract transform load
operations known as the ETL process is
carried out by Big Data Engineers they
also research various new methods to
obtain data and improve its quality
Big Data Engineers are also responsible
for building data architectures that
meet the business requirements they
provide a solution by integrating
various tools and programming languages
in addition to the about
responsibilities their primary
responsibility is to mine data from
Plenty of different sources to build
efficient business models lastly they
also work closely with data Architects
data scientists and data analysts those
are quite a lot of responsibilities let
us now have a look at the skills
required to achieve these
responsibilities
as you can see on your screens we have
listed the top top seven skills needed
to be possessed by a big data engineer
starting off the essential skill is
programming a big data engineer needs to
have hands-on experience in any one of
the programming languages such as Java C
plus plus or python
as a big data engineer you should also
have in-depth knowledge of bbms and SQL
this is because you have to understand
how data is managed and maintained in a
database hence you need to know how to
write SQL queries for any rdbms systems
some of the commonly used database
Management systems for Big Data
engineering are MySQL Oracle database
and the Microsoft SQL Server
as mentioned earlier carrying out an Eep
carrying out an ETL operation is a big
data engineer's responsibility now you
need to know how to construct as well as
use a data warehouse so that you can
perform these CTL operations as a big
data engineer you will be continuously
tasked with extracting data from various
sources transforming them into
meaningful information and loading it
into other data storages some of the
tools used for this purpose are Talent
IBM data stage pentaho and Informatica
next up we have the fourth skill that
you require which is knowledge about
operating systems
Big Data tools run on operating systems
hence a sound understanding of Unix
Linux windows and Solaris is mandatory
the fifth skill that you require is to
have experience with Hadoop based
Analytics
since Hadoop is one of the most commonly
used Big Data engineering tools it's
understood that you need to have
experience with Apache hadoop-based
Technologies like hdfs mapreduce Apache
Pig Hive and Apache headspace
the sixth skill that you require is to
have worked with real-time processing
Frameworks like Apache spark as a big
data engineer you would deal with large
volumes of data so for this you need an
analytics engine like spark which can be
used for both batch and real-time
processing spark can process live
streaming data from several different
sources like Facebook Instagram Twitter
and so on
and now we are at a final skill
requirement which is to have experience
with data mining and data modeling as a
big data engineer you would have to
examine Master pre-existing data so that
you can discover patterns and new
information this will help you create
predictive models that will help you
make various business business decisions
some of the tools used for this are are
rapidminer Becca and nime
now let's talk about a big data
engineer's salary in the US a big data
engineer's average annual salary is
around 102 000 dollars per annum in
India a big data engineer makes about 7
lakh rupees per annum
that was all about our first role Big
Data engineer moving on to our second
role we have Hadoop developer
as the name suggests a Hadoop developer
looks into the coding and programming of
the various Hadoop applications this job
role is more or less similar to that of
a software developer
moving on to the skills required to
become a Hadoop developer at first it is
a knowledge of the Hadoop ecosystem a
Hadoop developer should have in-depth
knowledge about the Hadoop ecosystem and
its components which include headspace
pink scoop Flume Uzi Etc you should also
have data modeling experience with olap
and oltp knowledge of SQL is required
like a big data engineer a Hadoop
developer must also know popular tools
like pentaho Informatica and talent
finally you should also be well versed
in writing Pig Latin scripts and
mapreduce jobs
the average annual salary of a Hadoop
developer in the US is nearly 76 000 per
annum in India a Hadoop developer makes
approximately 4 lakh 57 000 rupees per
annum
moving to our third job role we have
spark developer we saw What spark is now
let's understand what a spark developer
does
spark developers create spark jobs using
python or Scala for data aggregation and
transformation they also write analytics
code and design data processing
Pipelines
a spark developer needs to have the
following skills they need to know spark
and its components such as spark core
spark streaming spark machine learning
library
Etc they should also know the scripting
languages like python or Perl just like
the previous job roles a spark developer
should also have basic knowledge of SQL
queries and a database structure
in addition to the above a spark
developer is also expected to have a
fairly good understanding of Linux and
its commands
moving to the average annual salary of a
spark developer it is nearly eighty one
thousand dollars per annum in the US in
India a spark developer earns nearly 5
lakh 87 000 rupees per annum
let's now move on to our final job role
that is big data architect so let's
understand who are big data architect is
well a big data architect is a
professional who is responsible for
Designing and planning Big Data Systems
they also manage large-scale development
and deployment of Hadoop applications
moving on to the skills required to
become a big data architect first up the
individual must have Advanced Data
Mining and data analysis skills Big Data
Architects should also be able to
implement and use a nosql database and
cloud computing techniques
they must also have an idea of various
Big Data Technologies like Hadoop
mapreduce hbase Hive and so on finally
Big Data Architects must hold experience
with agile and scrum Frameworks
let's now have a look at the average
annual salary of a big data architect in
the United States and India in the U.S a
big data architect earns a whopping
hundred and eighteen thousand dollars
per annum meanwhile in India a big data
architect makes nearly 19 lakh rupees
per annum these are huge numbers right
so now that we have understood the job
roles of a big data engineer Hadoop
developer spark developer and a big data
architect let us have a look at the
companies hiring these professionals
as you all can see on your screens we
have IBM Amazon American Express Netflix
Microsoft and Bosch to name a few let us
now understand why big data analytics is
required with an example so all of you
listen to music online isn't it here we
will take an example of Spotify which is
a Swedish audio streaming platform and
see how big data analytics is used here
Spotify has nearly 96 plus million users
and all these users generate a
tremendous amount of data data like the
songs which are played repeatedly the
numerous likes shares and the user's
search history all these data can be
termed as Big Data here with respect to
Spotify have you ever wondered what
Spotify does with all this big data well
Spotify analyzes this big data for
suggesting songs to its users I'm sure
all of you might have come across the
recommendation list which is made
available able to each one of you by
Spotify each one of you will have a
totally different recommendation list
this is based on your likes your past
history like the songs you like
listening to and your playlists this
works on something known as the
recommendation system recommendation
systems are nothing but data filtering
tools they collect all the data and then
filter them using various algorithms
this system has the ability to
accurately predict what a user would
like to listen to next with the help of
big data analytics this prediction helps
the users stay on the page for a longer
time and by doing so Spotify engages all
its users the users don't have the need
to go on searching for different songs
this is because Spotify readily provides
them with a variety of songs according
to their taste well this is how big data
analytics is used by Spotify now that we
have understood by big data analytics is
required let us know on to our next
topic that is what is big data analytics
but before that there is another term we
need to understand that is big data we
all hear the term Big Data many a times
but do you know what exactly Big Data
means well we will understand the term
Big Data clearly right now big data is a
term for data sets that cannot be
handled by traditional computers or
tools due to their value volume velocity
and veracity it is defined as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
process and analyzed using various
traditional methods do you know how much
data is being generated every day every
second even as I talk right now there
are millions of data sources which
generate data at a very rapid rate these
data sources are present across the
world as you know social media sites
generate a lot of data let's take an
example of Facebook Facebook generates
over 500 plus terabytes of data every
day this data is mainly generated in
terms of your photographs videos
messages
Etc Big Data also contains data of
different formats like structured data
semi-structured data and unstructured
data data like your Excel sheets all
fall under structured data this data has
a definite format your emails fall under
semi-structured and your pictures and
videos all fall under unstructured data
all this data together make up for Big
Data it is very tough to store process
and analyze big data using rdbms if you
have looked into our previous videos you
would know that Hadoop is the solution
to this Hadoop is a framework that
stores and processes Big Data it stores
big data using the distributed storage
system and it processes big data using
the parallel processing method hence
storing and processing big data is no
more a problem using Hadoop big data in
its raw form is of no use to us we must
try to derive meaningful information
from it in order to benefit from this
big data do you know Amazon uses big
data to monitor its items that are in
its fulfillment centers across the globe
how do you think Amazon does this well
it is done by analyzing big data which
is known as big data analytics what is
big data analytics in simple terms big
data analytics is defined as the process
which is used to extract meaningful
information from Big Data this
information could be your hidden
patterns are known correlations market
trends and so on by using big data
analytics there are many advantages it
can be used for better decision making
to prevent fraudulent activities and
many others we will look into four of
them step by step I will first start off
with big data analytics which is used
for risk management mint BDO which is a
Philippine banking company uses big data
analytics for risk management risk
management is an important aspect for
any organization especially in the field
of banking risk management analysis
comprises a series of measures which are
employed to prevent any sort of
unauthorized activities identifying
fraudulent activities with a main
concern for BDO it was difficult for the
bank to identify the fraud still from a
long list of suspects BDO adopted big
data analytics which helped the bank to
narrow down the entire list of suspects
thus the organization was able to
identify the fraudster in a very short
time this is how big data analytics is
used in the field of banking for risk
management let us now see how big data
analytics is used for product
development and Innovations with an
example all of you are aware of
Rolls-Royce cars right do you also know
that they manufacture jet engines which
are used across the world what is more
interesting is that they use big data
analytics for developing and innovating
this engine a new product is always
developed by trial and error method big
data analytics is used here to analyze
if an engine design is good or bad it is
also used to analyze if there can be
more scope for improvement based on the
previous models and on the future
demands this way big data analytics is
used in designing a product which is of
higher quality using big data analytics
the company can save a lot of time if
the team is struggling to arrive at the
right conclusion big data can be used to
zero in on the right data which have to
be studied and thus the time spent on
the product development is less big data
analytics helps in quicker and better
decision making in organizations the
process of selecting a course of action
from various other Alternatives is known
as decision making lot of organizations
take important decisions based on the
data that they have data driven business
decisions can make or break a company
hence it is important to analyze all the
possibilities thoroughly and quickly
before making important decisions let us
now try to understand this with an use
case Starbucks uses big data analytics
for making important decisions they
decide the location of their new outlet
using big data analytics choosing the
right location is an important factor
for any organization the wrong location
will not be able to attract the required
amount of customers positioning of a new
outlet a few miles here or there can
always make a huge difference for an
outlet especially a one like Starbucks
various factors are involved in choosing
the right location for a new outlet for
example parking adequacy has to be taken
into consideration it would be
inconvenient for people to go to a store
which has no parking facility similarly
the other factors that have to be
considered are the visibility of the
location the accessibility the economic
factors the population of that
particular location and also we would
have to look into the competition in the
vicinity all these factors have to be
thoroughly analyzed before making a
decision as to where the new outlet must
be started without analyzing these
factors it would be impossible for us to
make a wise decision using big data
analytics we can consider all these
factors and analyze them quickly and
thoroughly thus Starbucks makes use of
big data analytics to understand if
their new location would be fruitful or
not finally we will look into how big
data analytics is used to improve
customer experience using an example
Delta and American Airline uses big data
analytics to improve its customer
experiences with the increase in global
air travel it is necessary that an
airline does every everything they can
in order to provide good service and
experience to its customers Delta
Airlines improves its customer
experience by making use of big data
analytics this is done by monitoring
tweets which will give them an idea as
to how their customers Journey was if
the airline comes across a negative
tweet and if it is found to be the
airline's fault the airline goes ahead
and upgrades that particular customers
ticket when this happens the customer is
able to trust the Airlines and without a
doubt the customer will choose Delta for
their next journey by doing so the
customer is happy and the airlines will
be able to build a good brand
recognition thus we see here that by
using analysis Delta Airlines was able
to improve its customer experience
moving on to our next topic that is life
cycle of big data analytics here we will
look into the various stages as to how
data is analyzed from scratch the first
stage is the business case evaluation
stage here the motive behind the
analysis is identified we need to
understand why we are analyzing so that
we know how to do it and what are the
different parameters that have to be
looked into once this is done it is
clear for us and it becomes much easier
for us to proceed with the rest after
which we will look into the various data
sources from where we can gather all the
data which will be required for analysis
once we get the required data we will
have to see if the data that we received
is fit for analysis or not not all the
data that we receive will have
meaningful information some of it will
surely just be corrupt data to remove
this corrupt data we will pass this
entire data through a filtering stage in
this stage all the corrupt data will be
removed now we have the data minus the
corrupt data do you think our data data
is now fit for analysis well it is not
we still have to figure out which data
will be compatible with the tool that we
will be using for analysis if we find
data which is incompatible we first
extract it and then transform it to a
compatible form depending on the tool
that we use in the next stage all the
data with the same Fields will be
integrated this is known as the data
aggregation stage the next stage which
is the analysis stage is a very
important stage in the life cycle of big
data analytics right here in this step
the entire process of evaluating your
data using various analytical and
statistical tools to discover meaningful
information is done like we have
discussed before the entire process of
deriving meaningful information from
data which is known as analysis is done
here in this stage the result of the
data analysis stage is then graphically
communicated using tools like Tableau
power bi click view this analysis result
will then be made available to different
business stakeholders for various
decision making this was the entire life
cycle of big data analytics we just saw
how data is analyzed from scratch now we
will move on to a very important topic
that is the different types of big data
analytics well we have four different
types of big data analytics as you see
here these are the types and below this
are the questions that each type tries
to answer we have descriptive analytics
which asks the question what has
happened then we have diagnostic
analytics which asks why did it happen
Predictive Analytics asking what will
happen and prescriptive analytics which
questions by asking what is the solution
we will look into all these four one by
one with an use case for each we we will
first start off with descriptive
analytics as mentioned earlier
descriptive analytics asks the question
what has happened it can be defined as
the type that summarizes past data into
a form that can be understood by humans
in this type we will look into the past
data and arrive at various conclusions
for example an organization can review
its performance using descriptive
analytics that is it analyzes its past
data such as Revenue over the years and
arrives at a conclusion with the profit
by looking at this graph we can
understand if the company is running at
a profit or not thus descriptive
analytics helps us understand this
easily we can simply say that
descriptive analytics is used for
creating various reports for companies
and also for tabulating various social
media metrics like Facebook likes tweets
Etc now that we have seen what is
descriptive analytics let us look into
and use case of descriptive analytics
the Dow Chemical Company analyzed all
its past data using descriptive
analytics and by doing so they were able
to identify the underutilized space in
their facility descriptive analytics
helped them in this space consolidation
on the whole the company was able to
save nearly 4 million dollars annually
so we now see here that descriptive
analytics not only helps us derive
meaningful information from the past
data but it can also help companies in
cost reduction if it is used wisely let
us now move on to our next type that is
diagnostic analytics diagnostic
analytics asks the question why a
particular problem has occurred as you
can see it will always ask the question
why did it happen it will look into the
root cause of a problem and try to
understand why it has occurred
diagnostic analytics makes use of
various techniques such as data mining
data Discovery and drill down companies
benefit from this type of analytics
because it helps them look into the root
cause of a problem by doing so the next
time the same problem will not arise as
the company already knows why it has
happened and they will arrive at a
particular solution for it init solves
bi query tool is an example of
diagnostic analytics we can use Query
tool for Diagnostic analytics now that
you know why diagnostic analytics is
required and what diagnostic analytics
is I will run you through an example
which shows where diagnostic analytics
can be used all of us shop on e-commerce
sites right have you ever added items to
your cart but ended up not buying it yes
all of us might have done that at some
point an organization tries to
understand why its customers don't end
up buying their products although it has
been added to their cuts and this
understanding is done with the help of
diagnostic analytics an e-com homicide
wonders why they have made few online
sales although they have had a very good
marketing strategy there could have been
various factors as to why this has
happened factors like the shipping fee
which was too high or the page that
didn't load correctly not enough payment
options available and so on all these
factors are analyzed using diagnostic
analytics and the company comes to a
conclusion as to why this has happened
thus we see here that the root cost is
identified so that in future the same
problem doesn't occur again let us now
move on to the third type that is
Predictive Analytics as the name
suggests Predictive Analytics makes
predictions of the Future IT analyzes
the current and historical facts to make
predictions about future it always asks
the question what will happen next
Predictive Analytics is used with the
help of artificial intelligence machine
learning data mining to analyze the data
it can be used for predicting custom
customer Trends market trends customer
Behavior Etc it solely works on
probability it always tries to
understand what can happen next with the
help of all the past and current
information a company like PayPal which
has 260 plus million accounts always has
the need to ensure that their online
fraudulent and unauthorized activities
are brought down to nil fear of constant
fraudulent activities have always been a
major concern for PayPal when a
fraudulent activity occurs people lose
trust in the company and this brings in
a very bad name for the brand it is
inevitable that fraudulent activities
will happen in a company like PayPal
which is one of the largest online
payment processes in the world but
PayPal uses analytics wisely here to
prevent such fraudulent activities and
to minimize them it uses Predictive
Analytics to do so the organization is
able to analyze pass data which includes
a customer's historical payment data a
customer's Behavior Trend and then it
builds an algorithm which works on
predicting what is likely to happen next
with respect to their transaction with
the use of big data and algorithms the
system can gauge which of the
transactions are valid and which could
be potentially a fraudulent activity by
doing so PayPal is always ready with
precautions that they have to take to
protect all their clients against
fraudulent transactions we will now move
on to our last type that is prescriptive
analytics prescriptive analytics as the
name suggests always prescribes a
solution to a particular problem the
problem can be something which is
happening currently hence it can be
termed as the type that always asks a
question what is the solution
prescriptive analytics is related to
both predictive and descriptive
analytics as we saw earlier descriptive
analytics always asks the question what
has happened and Predictive Analytics
helps you understand what can happen
next with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
prescriptive analytics helps you arrive
at the best solution for a particular
problem various business rules
algorithms and computational modeling
procedures are used in prescriptive
analytics let us now have a look at how
and bear prescriptive analytics is used
with an example here we will understand
how prescriptive analytics is used by an
airline for its profit do you know that
when you book a flight ticket the price
of it depends on various factors both
internal and external factors apart from
taxes seed selection there are other
factors like oil prices customer demand
which are all taken into consideration
before the flights fare is displayed
prices change due to availability and
demand holiday seasons are a time when
the rates are much higher than the
normal days Seasons like Christmas and
and school vacations also weakens the
rates will be much higher than weekdays
another factor which determines a
flight's fair is your destination
depending on the place where you are
traveling to the flight Fair will be
adjusted accordingly this is because
there are quite a few places where the
air traffic is less and in such places
the flights fare will also be less so
prescriptive analytics analyzes all
these factors that are discussed and it
builds an algorithm which will
automatically adjust a flight's fare by
doing so the airline is able to maximize
its profit these were the four types of
analytics now let us understand how we
achieve these with the use of Big Data
tools our next topic will be the various
tools used in big data analytics these
are few of the tools that I will be
talking about today we have Hadoop
mongodb talindi Kafka Cassandra spark
and storm we will look into each one of
them one by one we will first start off
with Hadoop when you speak of Big Data
the first framework that comes into
everyone's mind is Hadoop isn't it as I
mentioned earlier Apache Hadoop is used
to store and process big data in a
distributed and parallel fashion it
allows us to process data very fast
Hadoop uses mapreduce big and high for
analyzing this big data Hadoop is easily
one of the most famous Big Data tools
now let us move on to the next one that
is mongodb mongodb is a cross-platform
document oriented database it has the
ability to deal with large amount of
unstructured data processing of data
which is unstructured and processing of
data sets that change very frequently is
done using mongodb Talon D provides
software and services for data
integration data management and cloud
storage it specializes in Big Data
integration talente opens to studio is a
free open source tool for processing
data easily on a big data environment
Cassandra is used widely for an
effective management of large amounts of
data it is similar to Hadoop in its
feature of fall tolerance where data is
automatically replicated to multiple
nodes Cassandra is preferred for
real-time processing spark is another
tool that is used for data processing
this data processing engine is developed
to process data way faster than Hadoop
mapreduce this is done in a way because
spark does all the processing in the
main memory of the data nodes and thus
it prevents unnecessary input output
overheads with the disk whereas map
reduce is disk based and hence spark
proves to be faster than Hadoop
mapreduce storm is a free big data
computational system which is done in
real time it is one of the easiest tools
for Big Data analysis it can be used
with any programming language this
feature makes storm very simple to use
finally we will look into another big
data tool which is known as Kafka Kafka
is a distributed streaming platform
which was developed by LinkedIn and
later given to Apache software
Foundation it is used to provide
real-time analytics result and it is
also used for fault tolerant storage
these were few of the big data analytics
tools now let us move on to our last
topic for today that is big data
application domains here we will look
into the various sectors where big data
analytics is actively used the first
sector is e-commerce nearly 45 percent
of the world is online and they create a
lot of data every second big data can be
used smartly in the field of e-commerce
by predicting customer Trend forecasting
demands adjusting the price and so on
online retailers have the opportunity to
create better shopping experience and
generate higher sales if big data
analytics is used correctly having big
data doesn't automatically lead to a
better marketing strategy meaningful
insights need to be derived from it in
order to make right decisions by
analyzing big data we can have
personalized marketing campaigns which
can result in better and higher sales in
the field of Education depending on the
market requirements new courses are
developed the market requirement needs
to be analyzed correctly with respect to
the scope of a course and accordingly a
scope needs to be developed there is no
point in developing a course which has
no scope in the future hence to analyze
the market requirement and to develop
new courses we use big data analytics
here there are a number of uses of big
data analytics in the field of
healthcare and one of it is to predict a
patient's health issue that is with the
help of the their previous medical
history big data analytics can determine
How likely they are to have a particular
health issue in the future the example
of Spotify that we saw previously showed
how big data analytics is used to
provide a personalized recommendation
list to all its users similarly in the
field of media and entertainment big
data analytics is used to understand the
demands of shows songs movies and so on
to deliver personalized recommendation
lists as we saw with Spotify big data
analytics is used in the field of
banking as we saw previously with a few
use cases big data analytics was used
for risk management in addition to risk
management it is also used to analyze a
customer's income and spend patterns and
to help the bank predict if a particular
customer is going to choose any of the
bank offers such as loans credit cards
schemes and so on this way the bank is
able to identify the right customer who
is interested in its offers it has
noticed that telecom companies have
begun to embrace big data to gain profit
big data analytics helps in analyzing
Network traffic and call data records it
can also improve its service quality and
improve its customer experience let us
now look into how big data analytics is
used by governments across the world in
the field of law enforcement big data
analytics can be applied to analyze all
the available data to understand crime
patterns intelligent Services can use
Predictive Analytics to forecast the
crime which could be committed in Durham
the police department was able to reduce
the crime rate using big data analytics
with the help of data police could
identify whom to Target where to go when
to petrol and how to investigate crimes
big data analytics helped them to
discover patterns of crime emerging in
the area before we move on to the
application locations let's have a quick
look at the big data market revenue
forecast worldwide from 2011 to 2027. so
here's a graph in which the y-axis
represents the revenue in billion US
Dollars and the x-axis represents the
years as it is seen clearly from the
graph big data has grown until 2019 and
statistics predict that this growth will
continue even in the future this growth
is made possible as numerous companies
use big data in various domains to boost
their revenue we will look into few of
such applications the first Big Data
application we will look into is weather
forecast imagine there is a sudden storm
and you're not even prepared that would
be a terrifying situation isn't it
dealing with any calamities such as
hurricane storms floods would be very
inconvenient if we are caught off guard
the solution is to have a tool that
predicts the weather of the coming days
well in advance this tool needs to be
accurate and to make such a tool big
data is used so how does big data help
here well it allows us to gather all the
information required to predict the
weather information such as the climate
change details wind direction
precipitation previous weather reports
and so on after all this data is
collected it becomes easier for us to
spot a trend and identify what's going
to happen next by analyzing all of this
big data a weather prediction engine
works on this analysis it predicts the
weather of every region across the world
for any given time by using such a tool
we can be well prepared to face any
climate change or any natural Calamity
let's take an example of a landslide and
try to understand how big data is used
to tackle such a situation predicting a
landslide is very difficult with just
the basic warning signs lack of this
prediction can cause a huge damage to
life and property this challenge was
studied by the University of Melbourne
and they developed a tool which is
capable of predicting a landslide this
tool predicts the boundary where a
landslide is likely to occur two weeks
before this magical tool works on both
big data and Applied Mathematics an
accurate prediction like this which is
made two weeks before can save lives and
help in relocating people in that
particular region it also gives us an
insight into the magnitude of the
upcoming destruction this is how big
data is used in weather forecasts and in
predicting any natural calamities across
the world let us now move on to our next
application that is big data application
in the field of media and entertainment
the media and the entertainment industry
is a massive one leveraging big data
here can produce sky-high results and
boost the revenue for any company let us
see the different ways in which big data
is used in this industry have you ever
noticed that you come across relevant
advertisements in your social media
sites and in your mailboxes well this is
done by analyzing all your data such as
your pre previous browsing history and
your purchase data Publishers then
display what you like in the form of ads
which will in turn catch your interest
in looking into it next up is customer
sentiment analysis customers are very
important for a company the happier the
customer the greater the company's
Revenue Big Data helps in gathering all
the emotions of a customer through their
posts messages conversations Etc these
emotions are then analyzed to arrive at
a conclusion regarding the customer
satisfaction if the customer is unhappy
the company strives to do better the
next time and provides their customers a
better experience while purchasing an
item from an e-commerce site or while
watching videos on an entertainment site
you might have noticed a segment which
says most recommended list for you this
list is a personalized list which is
made Available to You by analyzing all
the data such as your previous watch
History your subscriptions your likes
and so on recommendation engine is a
tool that filters and analyzes all this
data and provides you with a list that
you would most likely be interested in
by doing so the site is able to retain
and engage its customer for a longer
time next is customer churn analysis in
simple words customer churn happens when
a customer stops a subscription with a
service predicting and preventing this
is of Paramount importance to any
organization by analyzing the behavioral
patterns of previously churned customers
an organization can identify which of
their current customers are likely to
churn by analyzing all of this data the
organization can then Implement
effective programs for customer
retention let us now look into an use
case of Starbucks big data is
effectively used by the Starbucks app 17
million users use this app and you can
imagine how much data they generate data
in the form of their coffee buying
habits the the store they visit and to
the time they purchase all of this data
is fed into the app so when a customer
enters a new Starbucks location the
system analyzes all their data and they
are provided with their preferred order
this app also suggests new products to
the customer in addition to this they
also provide personalized offer and
discounts on special occasions moving on
to our next sector which is Healthcare
it is one of the most important sectors
big data is widely used here to save
lives with all the available Big Data
medical researchers are done very
effectively they are performed
accurately by analyzing all the previous
medical histories and new treatments and
medicines are discovered cure can be
found out even for few of the incurable
diseases there are cases when one
medication need not be effective for
every patient hence Personal Care is
very important person care is provided
to each patient depending on their past
medical history and individuals medical
history along with their body parameters
are analyzed and personal attention is
given to each of them as we all know
Medical Treatments are not very pocket
friendly every time a medical treatment
is taken the amount increases this can
be reduced if readmissions are brought
down analyzing all the data precisely
will deliver a long-term efficient
result which will in turn prevent a
patient's readmission frequently with
globalization came an increase in the
ease for infectious diseases to spread
widely based on geography and
demographics Big Data helps in
predicting where an outbreak of epidemic
viruses are most likely to occur an
American Healthcare Company United
Healthcare uses big data to detect any
online medical fraud activities such as
payment of unauthorized benefits
intentional misrepresentation of data
and so on the Healthcare company runs
disease management programs the success
rates of these programs are predicted
using big data depending on how patients
respond to it the next sector we will
look into is logistics Logistics looks
into the process of transportation and
storage of goods the movement of a
product from its supplier to a consumer
is very important big data is used to
make this process faster and efficient
the most important factor in logistics
is the time taken for the products to
reach their destination to achieve
minimum time sensors within the vehicle
analyze the fastest route this analysis
is based on various data such as the
weather traffic the list of orders and
so on by doing so the fastest route is
obtained and the delivery time is
reduced capacity planning is another
factor which needs to be taken into
consideration details regarding the
workforce and the number of vehicles are
analyzed thoroughly and each vehicle is
allocated a different route this is done
as there is no need for many trucks to
travel in the same direction which will
be pointless depending on the analysis
of the available Workforce and resources
this decision is taken big data
analytics also Finds Its use in managing
warehouses efficiently this analysis
along with tracking sensors provide
information regarding the underutilized
space which results in efficient
resource allocation and eventually
reduces the cost customer satisfaction
is important in logistics just like it
is in any other sector customer
reactions are analyzed from the
available data which will eventually
create an instant feedback loop a happy
customer will always help the company
gain more customers let us now look into
our use case of UPS as you know UPS is
one of the biggest shipping company in
the world they have a huge customer
database and they work on data every
minute UPS uses big data to gather
different kinds of data regarding the
weather the traffic jams the geography
the locations and so on after collecting
all this data they analyze it to
discover the best and the fastest route
to the destination in addition to this
they also use big data to change the
routes in real time this is how
efficiently UPS leverages Big Data next
up we have a very interesting sector
that is the travel and tourism sector
the global tourism Market is expected to
grow in the near future big data is used
in various ways in this sector let us
look into a few of them hotels can
increase their revenue by adjusting the
room tariffs depending on the peak
Seasons such as holiday seasons festive
seasons and so on the tools industry
uses all of this data to anticipate the
demand and maximize their revenue big
data is also used by Resorts and hotels
to analyze various details regarding
their competitors this analysis result
helps them to incorporate all the good
facilities their competitors are
providing and by doing so the hotel is
able to flourish further a customer
always comes back if they are offered
good packages which are more than just
the basic ones looking into a customer's
past travel history likes and
preferences hotels can provide its
customers with personalized experiences
which will interest them highly
investing in an area which could be the
Hub of Tourism is very wise few
countries use big data to examine the
tourism activities in their country and
this in turn helps them discover new and
fruitful investment opportunities let us
look into one of the best online
Homestay networks Airbnb and see how big
data is used by them Airbnb undoubtedly
provides its customers with the best
accommodation across the world big data
is used by it to analyze the different
kinds of available properties depending
on the customer's preferences the
pricing the keywords previous customers
ratings and experiences Airbnb filters
out the best result Big Data Works its
magic yet again now we will move on to
our final sector which is the government
and law enforcement sector maintaining
Law and Order is of utmost importance to
any government it is a huge task by
itself Big Data plays an active role
here and in addition to this it also
helps governments bring in new policies
and schemes for the welfare of its
citizens the police department is able
to predict criminal activities way
before it happens by analyzing big data
information such as the previous crime
records in a particular region this
safety aspect in that region and so on
by analyzing these factors they are able
to predict any activity which breaks the
law and order of the region governments
are able to tackle unemployment to a
great extent by using big data by
analyzing the number of students
graduating every year to the number of
relevant job openings the government can
have an idea of the unemployment rate in
the country and then take necessary
measures to tackle it our next factor is
poverty in large countries it is
difficult to analyze which area requires
attention and development big data
analytics makes it easier for
governments to discover such areas
poverty gradually decreases once these
areas begin to develop governments have
to always be on the lookout for better
development a public survey voices the
opinion of a country's citizens
analyzing all the data collected from
such service can help governments build
better policies and services which will
benefit its citizens let us now move on
to our use case did you know that the
New York Police Department uses big data
analytics to protect its citizens the
department prevents and identifies
Crimes by analyzing a huge amount of
data which includes fingerprints certain
emails and records from previous police
investigations and so on after analyzing
all of this data meaningful insights are
drawn from it which will help the police
in taking the required preventive
measures against crimes now when we talk
about evolution of Big Data we have
known that data has evolved in last five
years like never before now in fact
before going to Big Data or before
understanding these Solutions
and why there is a rush towards Big Data
technology and solution I would like to
ask a question take a couple of minutes
and think why are organizations
interested in
why is there certain rush in Industry
where everyone would want to ramp up
their current infrastructure or would
want to be working on Technologies which
allow them to use the spectators think
about it what is happening and why are
organizations interested in this this
and if you think on this you will start
thinking about what organizations have
been doing in past what organizations
have not done and why are organizations
interested in
living now before we learn on big data
we can always look into internet and
check for use cases where organizations
have failed to use Legacy systems or
relational databases to work on their
data requirements now over in recent or
over past five years or in recent decade
what has happened is organizations have
started understanding the value of data
and they have decided not to ignore any
data as being uneconomical now we can
talk about different platforms through
which data is generated take an example
of social media like Twitter Facebook
Instagram WhatsApp YouTube you have
e-commerce and various portals say eBay
Amazon Flipkart alibaba.com and then you
have various Tech Giants such as Google
Oracle sap Amazon Microsoft and so on so
lots of data is getting generated every
day in every business sector the point
here is that organizations have slowly
started realizing that they would be
interested in working on all the data
now the question which I asked was why
are the organizations interested in big
data and some of you might have already
answered or thought about that
organizations are interested in doing
precise analysis or they want to work on
different formats of data such has
structured unstructured semi-structured
data organizations are interested in
gaining insights or finding the hidden
treasure in the so-called big data and
this is the main reason where
organizations are interested in big now
there are various use cases there are
various use cases we can compare that
organizations from past 50 or more than
50 years have been handling huge amount
of data they have been working on huge
volume of data but the question here is
have they worked on all the data or have
they worked on some portion of it what
have they used to store this data and if
they have used something to store this
data what is happening what is what is
changing now when we talk about the
businesses we cannot avoid talking about
the dynamism involved now any
organization would want to have a
solution which allows them to store data
and store huge amount of data capture it
process it analyze it and also look into
the data to give more value to the data
organizations have then been looking for
Solutions now let's look at some facts
that can convince you or that would
convince you that data is exploding and
needs your attention right 55 billion
messages and 4.5 billion photos are sent
each day on WhatsApp 300 hours of video
are uploaded every minute on YouTube did
you guys know that YouTube is the second
largest search engine after Google every
minute users send 31.25 million messages
and watch 2.77 million videos on
Facebook Walmart handles more than 1
million customer transactions every hour
Google 40 000 search queries are
performed on Google per second that is
3.46 million searches a day in fact you
could also say that a lot of times
people when they are loading up the
Google page is basically just to check
their internet connection however that
is also generating data IDC reports that
by 2025 real-time data will be more than
a quarter of all the data and by 2025
the volume of Digital Data will increase
to 163 Zeta bytes that is we are not
even talking about gigabytes terabytes
anymore we are talking about petabytes
exabytes and zetabytes and zetabytes
means 10 to the power 21 bytes so this
is how data has evolved now you can talk
about different companies which would
want to use their data to take business
decisions they would want to collect the
data store it and analyze it and that's
how they would be interested in drawing
insights for the business now this is
just a simple example about Facebook and
what it does to work on the data now
before we go to Facebook you could
always check in Google by just typing in
companies using big data and if we say
companies using big data we should be
able to find a list of different
companies which are using big data for
different use cases there are various
sources from where you can find we could
also search for solution that is Hadoop
which we'll discuss later but you could
always say companies using Hadoop and
that should take you to the Wiki page
which will basically help you know what
are the different companies which are
using this so-called solution called
Hadoop Ado okay now coming back to what
we were discussing about so
organizations are interested in Big Data
as we discussed in gaining insights they
would want to use the data to find
hidden information which probably they
ignored earlier now take an example of
rdbms what is biggest drawback
using an rdbms now you might think that
rdbms is known for stability and
consistency and organizations would be
interested in storing their data in
Oracle or db2 or MySQL or Microsoft SQL
server and they have been doing that for
many years now so what has changed now
now when we talk about rdbms the first
question which I would ask is do we have
access to 100 of data online in rdbms
the answer is no we would only have 10
or 20 or 30 percent of data online and
rest of the data would be archived which
means that if an organization is
interested in working on all the data
they would have to move the data from
the archived storage to the processing
layer and that would involve bandwidth
consumption now this is one of the
biggest drawbacks of rdbms you do not
have access to 100 of data online in
many of the cases organizations started
realizing that the data which they were
ignoring as being uneconomical had
hidden value which they had never
exploited I had read a presentation
somewhere which said torture the data
and it will confess to anything now
that's the value of data which
organizations have realized in recent
past take an example of Facebook now
this shows what Facebook does with its
big
and we'll come to what is Big Data but
let's understand the use case now
Facebook collects huge volumes of user
data whether that is SMS whether that is
likes whether that is advertisements
whether that is features which people
are liking or photographs or even user
profiles Now by collecting this data and
providing a portal which people can use
to connect Facebook is also accumulating
huge volume of data and that's way
Beyond petabytes they would also be
interested in analyzing this data and
one of the reasons would be they would
want to personalize The Experience take
an example of personalized news feed
depending on a user Behavior depending
on what a user likes what a user would
want to know about they can recommend a
personalized news feed to every
particular user that's just one example
of what Facebook does with its data take
an example of photo tax
now when you log into Facebook account
you could also get suggestions on
different friends whom you would like to
connect to or you would want to tag so
that they could be known by others some
more examples which show how Facebook
uses its data are as follows so the
flashback collection of photos and posts
that receive the most comments and likes
okay there was something called as I
voted that was used for 2016 elections
with reminders and directions to tell
users their time and place of polling
also something called as safety checks
in incidents such as earthquake
hurricane or mass shooting Facebook
gives you safety checks now these are
some examples where Facebook is using
big data and that brings us to the
question what is Big Data this was just
an example where we discussed about one
company which is making use of that data
which has been accumulated and it's not
only for companies which are social
media area entered like Facebook where
data is important take an example of IBM
take an example of JPMorgan Chase the
SE example of G of G or any other
organization which is collecting huge
amount of data they would all want to
gather insights they would want to
analyze the data they would want to be
more precise in building their services
or Solutions which can take care of
their customers so what is Big Data big
data is basically a term it is used to
describe the data that is too large and
complex to store in traditional
databases and as I gave an example it's
not just about storing the data it is
also about what you can do with the data
it also means that if there is a lot of
dynamism involved can you change the
underlying storage and handle any kind
of data that comes in now before we get
into that let's just understand
data so big data is basically a term
which has been given to categorize the
data if it has different characteristics
organizations would want to have the big
data stored processed and then analyzed
to get whatever useful information they
can get from this data now there are
five V's of Big Data volume velocity
variety value velocity although these
are five V's but then there are other
V's which also categorize the data as
Big Data such as volatility validity
viscosity virality of data okay so these
are five V's of big data and if the data
has one or all of these characteristics
then it can be considered as big
including the other ways which I just
mentioned so volume basically means
incredible amount of data huge volumes
of data data generated every second now
that could be used for batch processing
that could be used for real-time stream
processing okay you might have data
being generated from different kind of
devices like your cell phones your
social media websites online
transactions variable devices servers
and these days with iot we are also
talking about data of getting generated
via internet of things that is you could
have different devices which could be
communicated each other you could be
getting data from Radars or leaders or
even camera sensors so there is a huge
volume of data which is getting
generated and if we are talking about
data which has huge volume which is
getting generated constantly or has been
accumulated over a period of time we
would say that is big data velocity now
this is one more important aspect of big
data speed with which the data is
getting generated think about stock
markets think about social media
websites think about online surveys or
marketing campaigns or airline industry
so if the data is getting generated with
a lot of speed where it becomes
difficult to capture collect process
cure mine or analyze the data then we
are certainly talking about Big Data the
next aspect of big data is variety now
this is where we talk about structured
data semi-structured data or
unstructured data and here I would like
to ask a question what is the difference
when do you call the data is structured
semi-structured or unstructured now
let's look at an example before we
theoretically discuss about this I
always would like to use some examples
let's look at a log file and let's see
what is it so if I look at this log file
and if I would say what kind of data is
this which is the highlighted one the
answer would be it is structured data it
has specific delimiters such as space it
has data which is separated by space and
if I had a hundred or thousand or
million rows which had similar kind of
data I could certainly store that in a
table I could have a predefined schema
to store this data so I would call the
one which is highlighted as structured
but if I look at this portion where I
would look at a combination of this kind
of data where some data has a pattern
and some data doesn't now this is an
example of semi-structured data so if I
would have a predefined structure to
store this data probably the pattern of
data would break the structure and if I
look at all the data then I would
certainly call it unstructured data
because there is no clear schema which
can Define this now this is what I mean
by variety of data that is structured
data which basically has a schema or has
a format which could be easily
understood you have semi-structured
which could be like in XML or Json or
even your Excel sheets where you could
have some data which is structured and
the other is unstructured and when we
talk about unstructured we are talking
about absence of schema it does not have
a format it does not have a schema and
it is hard to analyze which brings its
own challenges the next aspect is value
now value refers to the ability to turn
your data useful for business you would
have a lot of data which is being
collected as we mentioned in slides
right there would be lot of data
wrangling or data pre-processing or
cleaning up of data happening and then
finally you would want to draw value
from that data but from all the data
collected what percentage of data gives
us value and if all my data can give me
value then why wouldn't I use it this is
an aspect of big data right veracity now
this means the quality of data billions
of dollars are lost every year by
organizations because the data which was
collected was not of good quality or
probably they collected a lot of data
and then it was erroneous take an
example of autonomous driving projects
which are happening in Europe or us
where there are car fleets which are on
the road collecting data via radar
sensors and Camera sensors and when this
data has to be processed to train
algorithms it has realized that
sometimes the data which was collected
was missing in some values might be was
not appropriate or had a lot of errors
and all this process of collecting the
data becomes a repetitive task because
the quality of data was not good this is
just one example we can take example
from healthcare industry or stock
markets or financial institutions and so
on so extracting loads of data is not
useful if the data is messy or poor in
quality and that basically means that
velocity is a very important V of big
data now apart from velocity volume
variety velocity and value we have the
other v such as viscosity how dense the
data is validity is the data still valid
volatility is my data volatile or
virality is the data viral now all of
these different V's categorize the data
as big data now here we would like to
talk on a big data case study and we
have taken an example of Google which
obviously is one of the companies which
is churning and working on
YouTube data now it's actually said that
if you compare one grain of sand with
one byte of data then Google is
processing or Google is handling Whole
World's sand every
that is the kind of data which Google is
now in early 2000 and since then when
the number of Internet users started
growing Google also faced a lot of pro
storing increasing user data and a using
the traditional servers to manage that
now that was a challenge which Google
started facing could they use
traditional data server to store the
data well yes they could Right storage
devices have been getting cheaper day by
day but then how much time does it take
to retrieve that data what is the seek
time what is the time taken to read and
process that data thousands of search
queries were raised per second No Doubt
now we could say millions and billions
of queries are raised per second every
query read 100 MBS
data and consumed tens of billions of
CPU Cycles based on these queries so the
requirement was that they wanted to have
a large distributed
highly fault tolerant file system large
to store to capture process huge amount
of data
attributed because they could not rely
just on one server even if that had
multiple disks stacked up that was not
an efficient Choice what would happen if
this particular machine failed what
would happen if the whole server was
down so they needed a distributed
storage
and it distributed computing environment
they needed something which can be
highly fault tolerant right so this was
the requirement which Google had and the
solution which came out as a result was
GFS Google file system now let's look at
how GFS works so normally in any
particular Linux system or Linux server
you would have a file system you would
have set of processes you would have set
of files and directories which could
store the data GFS was different so to
facilitate GFS we could store huge
amount of data there was an architecture
an architecture which had
multiple chunk servers or you could say
slave servers slave machines Master
machine was to contain metadata was to
contain data about
we say metadata we are talking about
information about data and then you have
the chunk servers or the slave machines
which could be storing data in a
distributed fashion now any client or an
API or an application which would want
to read the data would first Contact the
master server
and contact the machine where the master
process was running and client would
place a request of reading the data or
showing an interest of reading the data
internally what it is doing is it is
requesting for metadata your API or an
application would want to know from
where it can read the data Master server
which has metadata whether that is in
Ram or disk we can discuss that later
but then Master server would have the
metadata and it would know which are the
chunk servers or the slave machines
where the data was stored in a
distributed fashion Master would respond
back with the metadata information to
the client and then client could use
that information to read
two days slave machines where actually
the data was stored now this is what the
process or set of processes work
together to make GFS So when you say
chunk server we would basically have the
files getting divided into fixed size
chunks now how would they get divided so
there would be some kind of Chunk size
or a block size which would determine
that if the file is bigger than the
pre-decided chunk size then it would be
split into smaller chunks and be
distributed across the chunk servers or
the slave machines if the file was
smaller then it would still use one
chunk or a block to get stored on the
underlying slave machines so these chunk
servers or slave machines are the ones
which actually store the data on local
disks as your Linux files client which
is interacting with Master for metadata
and then interacting with chunk servers
for redride operations would be the one
which would be externally connecting to
the cluster so this is how it would look
so you have a master which would
obviously be receiving some kind of
heartbeats from the chunks that wants to
know their status and receive
information in the form of packets which
would let the master know which machines
were available for storage which
machines already had data and master
would build up the metadata within
itself the files would be broken down
into chunks for example we can look at
file one it is broken down into chunk
one and chunk two to file 2 has one
chunk which is one portion of it and
then you have file to resigning on some
other chunk server which also lets us
know that there is some kind of Auto
replication for this file system right
and the data which is getting stored in
the chunk could have a data of 64 MB now
that chunk size could be changed based
on the data size but Google file system
had the basic size of the chunk as 64 MB
each chunk would be replicated on
multiple servers the default replication
was three and that could again be
increased or decrease
requirement this would also mean that if
a particular slave machine or a chunk
server would die or would get killed or
would crash there would never be any
data loss because a replica of data
residing on the failed machine would
still be available on some other slave
server chunk server or slave machine now
this helped Google to store and process
huge volumes of data in a distributed
Manner and does have a fault tolerant
distributed scalable storage which could
allow them to store huge amount of data
now that was just one example which
actually led to the solution which today
we call
now when we talk about Big Data here I
would like to ask you some questions
that if we were talking about the rdbms
case take an example of uh something
like NASA which was working on a project
called seti search of extraterrestrial
intelligence now this was a project
where they were looking for a solution
to take care of their problem the
problem was that they would roughly send
some waves in space capture those waves
back and then analyze this data to find
if there was any extraterrestrial object
in space have two options for it they
could either have a huge server built
which could take care of storing the
data and processing it or they could go
for volunteer computing now volunteer
Computing basically means that you could
have a lot of people volunteering and be
part of this project and what they would
in turn do is they would be donating
their RAM and storage from their
machines when they are not using it how
would that happen basically download
some kind some kind of patch on their
machine which would run as a screen
saver and if the user is not using his
machine some portion of data could be
transferred to these machines for
intermittent storage and processing
using lab now this sounds very
interesting and this sounds very easy
however it would have its own challenges
right think about security think about
integrity but those those problems are
not bigger as much as is the requirement
of bandwidth and this is the same thing
which happens in rdbms if you would have
to move data from archived solution to
the processing layer that would consume
huge amount bandwidth Big Data brings
its own challenges huge amount of data
is getting generated every day now the
biggest challenge is storing this huge
volume of data and especially when this
data is getting generated with a lot of
variety when it can have different kind
of formats where it could be viral it
could be having a lot of value and
nobody has looked into the veracity of
data but the primary problem would be
handling this huge volume of data
variety of the data would bring in
challenges of storing it in Legacy
systems if processing of the data was
required now here again I would suggest
you need to think what is the difference
between reading a data and process
So reading might just mean bringing in
the data from disk and doing some i o
operations and processing would mean
reading the data probably doing some
Transformations on it extracting some
useful information from it and then
storing it in the same format or
probably in a different format so
processing this massive volume of data
is the Second Challenge organizations
don't just store their big data they
would eventually want to use it to
process it to gather some insights now
processing and extracting insights from
Big Data would take huge amount of time
unless and until there was an efficient
solution
handle and process this big data
securing the data that's again a concern
for organizations
encryption of big data is difficult to
perform if you would think about
different compression mechanisms then
that would also mean decompressing of
data which would also mean that you
could take a hit on the CPU Cycles or on
disk usage providing user authentication
for every team member now that could
also be dangerous so that led to Hadoop
as a solution so big data brings its own
challenges Big Data brings its own
benefits and here we have a solution
which is a
Hadoop now what is Hadoop it's a open
source framework for storing data and
running applications on clusters of
commodity Hardware
Hadoop is an open source framework and
before we discuss on two main components
of Hadoop it would be good to look into
the link which I was suggesting earlier
that is companies using Hadoop and any
person who would be interested in
learning Big Data should start somewhere
here where you could list down different
companies what kind of setup they have
why are they having Hadoop what kind of
processing they are doing and how are
they using these so-called Hadoop
clusters to process and in fact store
capture and process huge amount of data
another link which I would suggest is
looking at different distributions of
Hadoop any person who is interested in
learning in Big Data should know about
different distributions of Hadoop now in
Linux we have different
Windows Centos red hat Suzy dbn in the
same way you have different
distributions of Hadoop which we can
key page and this is the link which
talks about products that include Apache
Hadoop or derivative works and
Commercial support which basically means
that Apache Hadoop the sole products
that can be called a release of Apache
Hadoop come from apache.org that's an
open source community and then you have
various vendor-specific distributions
like Amazon web services you have cloud
data you have hot and works you have
IBM's big Insight you have map R all
these are different distributions of
so basically all of these
vendor-specific distributions are
depending or using on core Apache Hadoop
in brief we can say that these are the
vendors which take up the Apache Hadoop
package it within a cluster management
solution so that users who intend to use
Apache Hadoop would not have
difficulties of setting up a cluster
setting up a framework they could just
use a vendor-specific distribution with
its cluster installation Solutions
cluster management solution and easily
plan deploy install and
let's rewind to the days before the
world turn digital back then minuscule
amounts of data were generated at a
relatively sluggish Pace all the data
was mostly documents and in the form of
rows and columns storing or processing
this data wasn't much trouble as a
single storage unit and processor
combination would do the job but as
years passed by the internet took the
World by storm giving rise to tons of
data generated in a multitude of forms
and formats every microsecond
semi-structured and unstructured data
was available now in the form of emails
images audio and video to name a few all
this data became collectively known as
Big Data although fascinating it became
nearly impossible to handle this big
data and a storage unit processor
combination was obviously not enough so
what was the solution
multiple storage units and processors
were undoubtedly the need of the hour
this concept was incorporated in the
framework of Hadoop that could store and
process vast amounts of any data
efficiently using a cluster of commodity
Hardware Hadoop consisted of three
components that were specifically
designed to work on big data in order to
capitalize on data the first step is
storing it the first component of Hadoop
is its storage unit the Hadoop
distributed file system or hdfs
storing massive data on one computer is
unfeasible hence data is distributed
amongst many computers and stored in
blocks so if you have 600 megabytes of
data to be stored hdfs splits the data
into multiple blocks of data that are
then stored on several data nodes in the
cluster 128 megabytes is the default
size of each block hence 600 megabytes
will be split into four blocks a b c and
d of 128 megabytes each and the
remaining 88 megabytes in the last block
e so now you might be wondering what if
one data node crashes do we lose that
specific piece of data well no that's
the beauty of hdfs hdfs makes copies of
the data and stores it across multiple
systems for example when block a is
created it is replicated with a
replication factor of 3 and stored on
different data nodes this is termed the
replication method by doing so data is
not lost at any cost even if one data
node crashes making hdfs fault tolerant
after storing the data successfully it
needs to be processed this is where the
second component of Hadoop mapreduce
comes into play in the traditional data
processing method entire data would be
processed on a single machine having a
single processor this consumed time and
was inefficient especially when
processing large volumes of a variety of
data to overcome this mapreduce splits
data into parts and processes each of
them separately on different data nodes
the individual results are then
aggregated to give the final output
let's try to count the number of
occurrences of words taking this example
first the input is split into five
separate parts based on full stops the
next step is the mapper phase where the
occurrence of each word is counted and
allocated a number after that depending
on the words similar words are shuffled
sorted and grouped following which in
the reducer phase all the grouped words
are given a count
finally the output is displayed by
aggregating the results all this is done
by writing a simple program similarly
mapreduce processes each part of Big
Data individually and then sums the
result at the end this improves load
balancing and saves a considerable
amount of time
now that we have our mapreduce job ready
it is time for us to run it on the
Hadoop cluster this is done with the
help of a set of resources such as RAM
Network bandwidth and CPU multiple jobs
are run on Hadoop simultaneously and
each of them needs some resources to
complete the tasks successfully to
efficiently manage these resources we
have the third component of Hadoop which
is yarn yet another resource negotiator
or yarn consists of a resource manager
node Manager application master and
containers the resource manager assigns
resources node managers handle the nodes
and monitor the resource usage in the
node the containers hold a collection of
physical resources
suppose we want to process the mapreduce
job we had created first the application
Master requests the container from the
node manager once the node manager gets
the resources it sends them to the
resource manager this way yarn processes
job requests and manages cluster
resources in Hadoop in addition to these
components Hadoop also has various Big
Data tools and Frameworks dedicated to
managing processing and analyzing data
the Hadoop ecosystem comprises several
other components like Hive Pig Apache
spark Flume and scoop to name a few the
Hadoop ecosystem works together on big
data management before we dive into the
technical side of Hadoop we're going to
take a little detour to try to give you
a visual understanding and relate it to
maybe a more life setup we're going to
go to the farm in this case so we have
in a farm far away I almost wish they'd
put far far away it does remind me a
little bit of a Star Wars theme so we're
going to look at fruit at a farm we have
Jack who harvestses grapes and then
sells it in the nearby town after
harvesting he stores his produce in a
storage shed or a storage room in this
case which we found out though is there
was a high demand for other fruits so he
started harvesting apples and oranges as
well hopefully he has a couple fills
with these different fruit trees growing
and he said up there and you can see
that he's working hard to harvest all
these different fruits but he has a
problem here because there's only one of
him so he can't really do more work so
what he needs to do then is hire two
more people to work with him with this
harvesting is done simultaneously so
instead of him trying to harvest all
this different fruit he now has two more
people in there who are putting their
food away and harvesting a forum now the
storage room becomes a bottleneck to
store and access all the fruits in a
single storage area so they can't fit
all the fruit in one place so Jack
decides to distribute the storage area
and give each one of them a separate
storage and you can look at this
computer terms we have our people that
are the processors we have our fruit
that's a data and you can see it's
storing it in the different storage
rooms so you can see me popping up there
getting my uh hello I want fruit basket
of three grapes two apples and three
oranges I'm getting ready for a
breakfast with family a little large
family my family's not that large to
complete the order on time all of them
work parallely with their own storage
space so here we have a process of
retrieving or querying the data and you
can see from the one storage space he
pulls out three grapes she pulls out two
apples and then another storage room he
pulls out three oranges and we complete
a nice fruit basket and this solution
helps them to complete the order on time
without any hassle all of them are happy
they're prepared for an increase in
demand in the future so they now have
this growth system where you can just
keep hiring on new people they can
continue to grow and develop a very
large farm so how does this story relate
to Big Data and I hinted at that a
little bit earlier the limited data only
one processor one storage unit was
needed I remember back in the 90s they
would just upgrade the computer instead
of having a small computer you would
then spend money for a huge Mainframe
with all the flat flashing lights on it
then the cray computers were really
massive nowadays A lot of the computers
it sits on our desktop are powerful as
the main frames they had back then so
it's pretty amazing how time has changed
but used to be able to do everything on
one computer and you had structured data
and a database you stored your
structured data in so most of the time
you're acquiring databases SQL queries
just think of it as a giant spreadsheet
with rows and columns where everything
has a very specific size and fits neatly
in that rows and columns and back in the
90s this was a nice setup you just
upgraded your computer you would get
yourself a nice big sun computer or
Mainframe if you had a lot of data and a
lot of stuff going on and it was very
easy to do soon though the data
generation increased leading to high
volume of data along with different data
formats and so you can imagine in
today's world this year we will generate
more data than all the previous years
summed together we will generate more
data just this year than all the
previous years sum together and that's
the way it's been going for some time
and you can see we have a variety of
data we have our structured data which
is what we're you think about a database
with rows and columns and easy to look
at nice spreadsheet we have our
semi-structured data they have emails as
an example here that would be one
example your XML your HTML web pages and
we have unstructured data if you ever
look through your folder on photos I
have photos that were taken on my phone
with high quality I've got photos from a
long time ago I got web photos low
quality so just in my pictures alone
none of them are the same you know there
certainly are groups of them that are
but overall there are a lot of variety
in size and setup so a single processor
was not enough to process such high
volume of different kinds of data as it
was very time consuming you can imagine
that if you are Twitter with millions of
Twitter feeds you're not going to be
able to do a query across one server
there's just no way that's going to
happen unless people don't mind waiting
a year to get the the history of their
tweets or look something up hence we
start doing multiple processors so
they're used to process high volume of
data and this saved time so we're moving
forward we've got multiple processors
the single storage unit became the
bottlenecked due to which network
overhead was generated so now you have
your network coming in and each one of
these servers has to wait before it can
grab the data from the single stored
unit maybe you have a SQL Server there
with a nice setup or a file system going
the solution was to use distributed
storage for each processor this enabled
easy access to storage and access to
data so this makes a lot of sense you
have multiple workers multiple storage
units just like we had our storage room
and the different fruit coming in your
variety you can see that nice parallel
to working on a farm now we're dealing
with a lot of data it's all about the
data now this method worked and there
were no network overhead generated
you're not getting a bottleneck
somewhere where people are just waiting
for data being pulled they're being
processed this is known as parallel
processing with distributed storage so
parallel processing distributed storage
and you can see here the parallel
processing is your different computers
running the processes and distributed
storage here is a quick demo on setting
up Cloudera quick start VM in case you
are interested in working on a
standalone cluster you can download the
Cloudera quick start VM so you can just
type in download cloud data quick start
VM and you can search for package now
this can be used to set up a quick start
VM which would be a single node Cloudera
based cluster so you can click on this
link and then basically based on the
platform which you would be choosing to
install such as using a VM box or which
version of Cloudera you would install so
here I can select a platform so I can
choose virtual box and then you can
click on get it now so give your details
and basically then it should allow you
you to download the quick start VM which
would look something like this and once
you have the zip file which is
downloaded you can unzip it which can
then be used to set up a single node
Cloudera cluster so once you have
downloaded the zip file that would look
something like this so you would have a
quick start virtual box and then a
virtual boss disk now this can be used
to set up a cluster ignore these files
which are related to Amazon machines and
we you don't need to have that would
just have this and this can be used to
set up a cloud data cluster so for this
to be set up you can click on file
import Appliance and here you can choose
your quick start VM by looking into
downloads quick start VM select this and
click on open now you can click on next
and that shows you the specifications of
CPU Ram which we can then change later
and click on import this will start
importing virtual disk image dot vmdk
file into your VM box once this is done
we will have to change the
specifications or machines to use two
CPU cores minimum and give a little more
RAM because Cloudera quick start VM is
very CPU intensive and it needs good
amount of ram so to survive I will give
two CPU cores and 5gb RAM and that
should be enough for us to bring up a
quick start VM which gives us a Cloudera
distribution of Hadoop in a single node
cluster setup which can be used for
working learning about different
distributions in Cloudera cluster
working with sdfs and other Hadoop
ecosystem components let's just wait for
this importing to finish and then we
will go ahead and set up a quick start
VM for our practice here the importing
of Appliance is done and we see clouder
a quick start machine is added to my
list of machines I can click on this and
click on settings as mentioned I would
like to give it more RAM and more CPU
cores so click on system and here let's
increase the ram to at least five and
click on processor and let's give it two
CPU cores which would at least be better
than using one CPU core Network it goes
for Nat and that's fine click on OK and
we would want to start this machine so
that it uses two CPU cores 5gb RAM and
it should bring up my Cloudera quick
start VM now let's go ahead and start
this machine which has our quick start
VM it might take initially some time to
start up because internally there will
be various Cloud error Services which
will be starting up and those Services
need to be up for our Cloudera quick
start VM to be accessible so unlike your
Apache Hadoop cluster where we start our
cluster and we
and we will be starting all our
processes in case of Cloudera it is your
Cloudera SCM server and agents which
take care of starting up of your
services and starting up of your
different roles for those Services I
explained in my previous session that
for a Cloudera cluster it would be these
Services let me show you that so in case
of Apache cluster we start our services
that is we start our cluster by running
script and then basically those scripts
will individually start the different
processes on different nodes in case of
cloud era we would always have a
Cloudera SCM server which would be
running on one machine and then
including that machine we would have
cloud and ICM agents which would
on multiple machines similarly if we had
a hortonworks cluster we would have
ambari server starting up on the first
machine and the number agents running on
other machines so pure server component
knows what are the services which are
set up what are their configurations and
agents running on every node are
responsible to send heartbeats to the
server receive instructions and then
take care of starting and stopping off
of individual roles on different
machines in case of our single node
cluster setup in quick start VM we would
just have one SCM server and one ICM
agent which will start on the machine
which will then take care of all the
roles which need to be started for your
different services
so we will just wait for our machine to
come up and basically have clouded SCM
server and agent running and once we
have that we need to follow few steps so
that we can have the Cloudera admin
console accessible which allows you to
browse the cluster look at different
Services look at the roles for different
services and also work with your cluster
either using command line or using the
web interface that is Hue now that my
machine has come up and it all is
connected to the internet which we can
see here we need to do certain things so
that we can have our admin console
accessible at this point of time you can
click on Terminal and check if you have
access to the cluster so here type in
hostname and that shows you your host
name which is quickstart.cloud data we
can also type in hdfs command to see if
we have access and if my cluster is
working these commands are same as you
would give them in a Apache Hadoop
cluster or in any other distribution of
Hadoop sometimes when your cluster is up
and you have access to the terminal it
might take few seconds or few minutes
before there is a connection established
between cloud and ICM server and
Cloudera CM agent running in background
which takes care of your cluster I have
given hdf sdfs list command which
basically should show me what by default
exists on my sdfs let's just give it a
couple of seconds before it shows us the
output we can also check by giving a
service Cloud era SCM server status and
here it tells me that if you would want
to use Cloudera Express free run this
command it needs 8GB of RAM and it gives
two virtual CPU cores and it also
mentions it may take several minutes
before cloud manager has
I can login as root here and then give
the command service Cloudera SCM server
status remember the password for root is
is clouded out so it basically says that
if you would want to check the settings
it is good to have Express Edition
running so we can close this my sdfs
access is working fine let's close the
terminal and here we have launch
Cloudera Express click on this and that
will give you that you need to give a
command which is force let's copy this
command let's open a different terminal
and let's give this command like this
which will then go ahead and shut down
your Cloudera Based Services and then it
will restart it only after which you
will be able to access your h
so let's just give it a couple of
minutes before it does this and then we
will have access to our admin console
here if you see it is starting the
Cloudera manager server again it is
waiting for Cloudera manager API then
starting the Cloudera manager agents and
then configuring the deployment as per
the new settings which we have given as
to use the express edition of Cloudera
once all this is done it will say the
cluster has been restarted and the admin
console can be accessed by ID and
password as Cloud error we'll give it a
couple of more minutes and once this is
done we are ready to use our admin
console now that deployment has been
configured client configurations have
also been deployed and it has restarted
the Cloudera Management Service
gives you an access to Quick Start admin
console using username and password as
Cloud error let's try accessing it so we
can open up the browser here and let's
change this to 7180 that's the default
port and that shows the admin console
which is coming up now here we can log
in as Cloud era Cloud error and then
let's click on login now as I said
Cloudera is very CPU intensive and
memory intensive so it would slow down
since we have not given enough GB Ram to
our Cloud error cluster and thus it will
be advisable to stop or even remove the
services which we don't need now as of
now if we look at the services all of
them look in a stop status and that's
good in one way because we can then go
ahead and remove the services which we
will not use in the beginning and later
we can anytime add services to the
cluster so for example I can click on
key value store here and then I can
scroll down where it says delete to
remove this service from the admin
console now anytime you are removing a
particular service it will only remove
the service from the management by Cloud
electric manager all the role groups
under this service will be removed from
host templates so we can click on delete
now if this service was depending on
some other service it would have
prompted me with a message that removed
the relevant services on which this
particular service depends if the
service was already running then it
would have given me a message that the
service has to be stopped before it can
be deleted from the Cloudera admin
so this is my admin console which allows
you to click on Services look at the
different roles and processes which are
running for this service we anyways have
access to our Cloud error cluster from
the terminal using our regular sdfs or
yarn or mapred commands now I removed a
service I will also remove solar which
we will not be using for the beginning
but then it depends on your choice so we
can here scroll down to delete it and
that says that before deleting the solar
service you must remove the dependencies
on this service from the configuration
of following services that is Hue now
Hue is a web interface which allows you
to work with your sdfs and that is
depending on this so click on configure
service dependency and here we can make
sure that our Hue service does not
depend on a particular service we are
removing so that then we can have a
clean removal of the service so I'll
click on none and I will say save
changes once this is done then then we
can go ahead and try removing the solar
service from our admin console which
will reduce some load on my Management
console which will also allow me to work
faster on my cluster now here we have
removed the dependency of hue on solar
so we can click on this and then we can
delete
remember I am only doing this so that my
cluster becomes little lighter and I can
work on my focus services at any point
of time if you want to add more services
to your cluster you can anytime do that
you can fix different configuration
issues like what we see here with
different warning messages and here we
have these Services which are already
existing now if we don't need any of the
service I can click on the drop down and
click on delete again this says that's
group 2 also has relevance to Hue so Hue
as a web interface also depends on scope
2. as of now we'll make it none at any
point of time later you can add the
services by clicking the add service
option now this is a cluster to which
you have admin access and this is a
quick start VM which gives you a single
node Cloudera cluster which you can use
for Learning and practicing so here
we'll click on scope 2 and then we will
say delete as we have configured the
dependency now and we will remove scope
2 also from the list of services which
your admin console
right so once this is done we have
removed three services which we did not
need we can even remove scoop as a
client and if we need we can add that
later now there are various other alerts
which your cloud data admin console
shows and we can always fix them by
clicking on the health issues or
configuration issues we can click here
and see what is the health issue it is
pointing to if that is a critical one or
if that can be ignored so it says there
is an issue with a clock offset which
basically relates to an ntp service
network time protocol which makes sure
that one or multiple machines are in the
same time zone and are in sync so for
now we can click on suppress and we can
just say suppress for all hosts and we
can say look into it later and confirm
so now we will not have that health
issue reported that probably the ntp
service and the machines might not be in
sync now that does not have an impact
for our use case as of now but if we
have a Kerberos kind of setup which is
for security then basically this offset
and time zone becomes important so we
can ignore this message and we are still
good to use the cluster cluster we also
have other configuration issues and you
can click on this which might talk about
the Heap size or the ram which is
available for machines it talks about
zookeeper should be in odd numbers Hue
does not have a load balancer sdfs only
has one data node but all of these
issues are not to be worried upon
because this is a single node cluster
setup so if you want to avoid all of
these warnings you can always click on
suppress and you can avoid and let your
cluster be in
but that's nothing to worry so we can
click on cluster and basically we can
look at the services so we have removed
some Services which we don't intend to
use now I have also suppressed a offset
warning which is not very critical for
my use case and basically I am good to
start the cluster at any point of time
as I said if you would want to add
services this is the actions button
which you can use services we will just
say restart my cluster which will
restart all the services one by one
starting from zookeeper as the first
service to come up we can always click
on this Arrow Mark and see what is
happening in the services what services
are coming up and in which order if you
have any issues you can always click on
the link next to it which will take you
to the logs and we can click on close to
let it happen in the background so this
will basically let my services restart
one by one and my cluster will then
become completely accessible either
using Hue as a web interface or quick
start terminal which allows you to give
your commands now while my machines are
coming up you can click on host and you
can have a look at all the hosts we have
as of now only one which will also tell
you how many rolls or processes are
running on this machine so that is 25
rolls it tells you what is the disk
usage it tells you what is the physical
memory being used and using this host
tab we can add new host to the cluster
we can check the configuration we can
check all the hosts in Diagnostics you
can look at the logs which will give you
access to all the logs you can even
select the sources from which you would
want to have the logs or you can give
the host name you can click on search
you can build your own charts you can
also do the admin stuff by adding
different users or enabling security
using the administration tab so since we
have clicked on restart of a cluster we
will slowly start seeing all the
services one by one coming up starting
with zookeeper to begin with and once we
have our cluster up and running whether
that is showing all services in green or
in a different status we still should be
able to access the service now as we saw
in Apache Hadoop cluster even here we
can click on hdfs and we can access the
web UI once our stfs service is up by
clicking on quick links so the service
is not yet up once it is up we should be
able to see the web UI link which will
allow you to check things from sdfs web
interface similarly yarn as a service
also has a web interface so as soon as
the service comes up under your quick
links we will have access to the yarn UI
and similarly once the service comes up
we will have access to Hue which will
give you the web interface which allows
you to work with your stfs which allows
you to work with your different other
components within the cluster without
even using the command line tools or
command line options so we will have to
give it some time while the Cloudera SCM
agent on every machine
start the roles which are responsible
for your cluster to come up we can
always click here which tells that there
are some running commands in the
background which are trying to start my
go to the terminal and we can switch as
hdfs user remember sdfs user is the
admin user and it does not have a
password unless you have set one so you
can just log in as hdfs which might ask
you for a password initially which we do
not have so the best way to do this is
by logging in as root where the password
is cloud error and then you can log in
as hdfs so that then onwards you can
give your sdfs commands to work with
your file system now since my services
are coming up right now when I try to
give a sdfsdfs command it might not work
or it might also say that it is trying
to connect name node which is not up yet
so we will have to give it some time and
only once the name node is up we will be
able to access our sdfs using commands
so this is how you can quickly set up
your quick start and then you can be
working using the command line options
from the terminal like what you would do
in Apache Hadoop cluster you could use
the web interfaces which allow you to
work with your cluster now if this
usually takes more time so you will have
to give it some time before your
services are up and running and for any
reason if you have issues it might
require you to restart your cluster
several times in the beginning before it
gets accustomed to the settings what you
have given and it starts up the services
at any point of time if you have any
error message then you can always go
back and look in logs and see what is
happening and try starting your cluster
so this is how we set up a quick start
VM and you can be using this to work
with your Cloud error cluster we'll
start with the big data challenges and
the first thing with the big data is you
can see here we have a nice chaotic
image with all these different inputs
server racks all over the place graphs
being generated just about everything
you can imagine and so the problems that
come up with big data is one storing it
how do you store this massive amount of
data and we're not talking about a
terabyte or 10 terabytes we're talking a
minimum of 10 terabytes up to petabytes
of data and then the next question is
processing and so the two go hand in
hand because when you're storing the
data that might take up a huge amount of
space or you might have a small amount
of data that takes a lot of processing
and so either one will drive a series of
data or processing into the Big Data
Arena so with storing data storing Big
Data was a problem due to its massive
volume just straight up people would
have huge backup tapes and then you'd
have to go through the backup tapes for
hours to go find your data and a simple
query could take days and then
processing processing Big Data consumed
more time and so the Hadoop came up with
a cheap way to process the data it used
to be like I've had some processes that
if I ran on my computer without trying
to use multiple cores and multiple
threads would take years to process just
a simple data analysis can get that
heavy in the data processing and so
processing can be as big of a problem as
the size of the data itself so Hadoop as
a solution this is a solution to Big
Data and big data storage storing Big
Data was a problem due to its massive
volume so we take the Hadoop file system
or the hdfs and now we're able to store
huge data across a large number of
machines and access it like this one
file system and processing Big Data
consumed more time we talked about some
processes you can't even do on your
computer so would take years now the
Hadoop with the map reduce processing
Big Data was faster and I'm going to add
a little notation right here that's
really important to note that Hadoop is
the beginning when we talk about data
processing they've added new processes
on top of the map reduce that even
accelerate it your spark set up and some
other different functionalities but
really the basis of all of it where it
all starts with the most basic concept
is your Hadoop mapreduce let us now look
into the hdfs in detail in the
traditional approach all the data was
stored in a single Central database with
the rise of Big Data a single database
was not enough for storage and I
remember the old Sun computers or the
huge IBM machines with all the flashing
lights now all the data on one of those
can be stored on your phone it's almost
a bit of humor how much this has
accelerated over the years the same
thing with our rise of Big Data no
longer can you just store it on one
machine no longer can you go out buy a
sun computer and put it on that one Sun
computer no more can you buy a Craig
machine or an Enterprise IBM server it's
not going to work you're not going to
fit it all into one server the solution
was to use distributed approach to store
the massive amount of data data was
divided and distributed amongst many
individual databases and you can see
here where we have three different
databases going on so you might actually
saw this in one where they divided up
the user accounts a through G so on by
the letter and so the first query would
say what's the first letter of this
whatever ID it was and then it would go
into that database to find it so it had
a database telling it which database to
look for stuff that was a long time ago
and to be honest it didn't work really
well nowadays so that was a distributed
database you'd have to track which
database you put it in so what is hdfs
Hadoop distributed file system hdfs is a
specially designed file system for
storing huge data sets in commodity
hardware and commodity is an interesting
term because I mentioned Enterprise
versus commodity and I'll touch back
upon that it has two core components
name node and data node name node is the
master Daemon there's only one active
name node it manages the data nodes and
stores all the metadata so it stores all
the mapping of where the data is on your
Hadoop file system now the name node is
usually an Enterprise machine you spend
a lot of extra money on it so you have a
very solid name known machine and so
then we have our data nodes our data
node data node data node we have three
here the data node is the slave there
can be multiple data nodes and it stores
the actual data and this is where your
commodity Hardware comes in the best
definition I've heard of commodity
Hardware is the cheap knockoffs this is
where you buy you can buy 10 of these
and you expect one of them not to work
because you know when they come in
they're going to break right away so
you're looking at Hardware that's not as
high-end so where you might have your
main Master node is your Enterprise
server then your data nodes are just as
cheap as you can get them with all the
different features you need on them as
said earlier name node stores the
metadata metadata gives information
regarding the file location block size
and so on so our metadata in the hdfs is
maintained by using two files it has the
edit log and the fs image the edit log
keeps track of the recent changes made
on the Hadoop file system only recent
changes are tracked here the fs image
keeps track of every change made on the
hdfs since the beginning now what
happens when the edit log file size
increases the name node fails these are
big ones so what happens we are at a log
it just keeps so big until it's too big
or our main Enterprise computer that we
spend all that money on so it would
break actually fails because they still
fail the solution we make copies of the
edit log and the fs image files so
that's pretty straightforward you just
copy them over so you have both the most
recent edits going on and the long term
image of your file system and then we
also create a secondary name node is a
node that maintains the copies of the
edit log and the fs image it combines
them both to get an updated version of
the fs image now the secondary name node
only came in the last oh I guess two
three years where it became as part of
the main system and usually your
secondary name node is also an
Enterprise computer and you'll put them
on separate racks so if you have three
racks of computers you would have maybe
the first two racks would have the name
node and the second rack would have the
secondary name node and the reason you
put them on different racks is you can
have a whole rack go down you could have
somebody literally trip over the power
cable or the switch that goes between
the racks is most common goes down well
if the switch goes down you can usually
switch to the secondary name node and
while you're getting your switch
replaced and replacing that Hardware
because of the way the hdfs works it
still is completely functional so let's
take a look at the name node we have our
edit log our FS image and we have our
secondary name node and you take that it
copies the edit log over and it copies
the fs image and you can see right here
you have all the different contents on
your main name node now also on your
secondary name node and then your
secondary name node will actually take
these two your edit log and your FS
image and it will make a copy so you
have a full FS image that contains its
current it's up to date the secondary
nade node creates a periodic checkpoint
of the files and then it updates the new
FS image into the name node now it used
to be this all occurred on the name node
before you had a secondary name node so
now you can use your secondary node to
both back up everything going on the
name node and it does that lifting in
the back where you're combining your
edit log and bring your FS image so it's
current and then you end up with a new
edit log and a new you have your FS
image updated and you start a fresh edit
log this process of updating happens
every hour and that's how it's scheduled
you can actually change those schedules
but that is the standard is to update
every hour so let's we took a look at
the the master node and the you know the
name node and the secondary name node
let's take a look at the cluster
architecture of our Hadoop file system
the hdfs cluster architecture so we have
our name node in this store orders of
metadata and we have our block location
so we have our FS image plus our edit
log and we have the backup FS image and
edit log and then we have so you have
your rack we have our switch on top
remember I was talking about the switch
that's the most common thing to go in
the rack is the switches and underneath
the rack you have your different data
nodes you have your data node one two
three four five maybe you have 10 15 on
this rack you can stack them pretty high
nowadays uh it used to be you'd only get
about 10 servers on there but now you
see racks that contain a lot more and
then you have multiple racks so we're
not talking about just one rack we also
have you know rack two rack three four
five six and so on until you have Rack
in so if you had a hundred data nodes we
would be looking at 10 racks of 10 data
nodes each and that is literally 10
commodity server computers hardware and
we have a core switch which maintains
the network bandwidth and connects the
name node to the data nodes so just like
each rack has a switch that connects all
your nodes on the rack you now have core
switches that can all the racks together
and these also Connect into our name
node setup so now we can look up your FS
image and your edit log and pull that
information your metadata out so we've
looked at the architecture from the name
node coming down and you have your
metadata your Block locations this then
sorts it out you have your core switches
which connect everything all your
different racks and then each individual
rack has their own switches which
connect all the different nodes and to
the core switches so now let's talk
about the actual data blocks what's
actually sitting on those commodity
machines and so the Hadoop file system
splits massive files into small chunks
these chunks are known as data blocks
each file in the Hadoop file system is
stored as a data block and we have a
nice picture here where it looks like a
Lego if you ever played with the Legos
as a kid it's a good example we just
stack that data right on top of each
other but each block has to be the same
symmetry has to be the same size so that
it can track it easily and the default
size of one data block is usually 128
megabytes now you can go in and change
that this standard is pretty solid as
far as most data is concerned when we're
loading up huge amounts of data and
there's certainly reasons to change it
the 128 megabytes is pretty standard
block so why 128 megabytes if the block
size is smaller then there will be two
mini data blocks along with lots of
metadata which will create overhead so
that's why you don't really want to go
smaller on these data blocks unless you
have a very certain kind of data
similarly if the block size is very
large then the processing time for each
block increases then as I pointed out
earlier each block is the same size just
like your Lego blocks are all the same
but the last block can be the same size
or less so you might only be storing 100
megabytes in the last block and you can
think of this as if you had a terabyte
of data that you're storing on here it's
not going to be exactly divided into 128
megabytes we just store all of it 128
megabytes except for the last one which
could have anywhere between 1 and 128
megabytes depending on how evenly your
data is divided now let's look into how
files are stored in Hadoop file system
so we have a file a text let's see it's
520 megabytes we have block a so we take
128 megabytes out of the 520 and we
store it in block a and then we have
Block B again we're taking 128 megabytes
out of our 520 storing it there and so
on Block C block D and then block e we
only have eight megabytes left so when
you add up 128 plus 128 plus 128 plus
128. you only get 512 and so at last
eight megabytes goes into its own block
the final block uses only the remaining
space for storage data node failure and
replication and this is really where
Hadoop shines this is what makes it this
is why you can use it with commodity
computers this is why you can have
multiple racks and have something go
down all the data blocks are stored in
various data nodes you take each block
you store it at 128 megabytes and then
we're going to put it on different nodes
so here's our block a Block B Block C
from our last example and we have node
one node two node 3 node four node 5
node 6. and so each one of these
represents a different computer it
literally splits the data up into
different machines so what happens if
node 5 crashes well that's a big deal I
mean we might not even have just node
five you might have a whole rack go down
and if you're a company that's building
your whole business off of that you're
going to lose a lot of money so what
does happen when node 5 crashes or the
first rack goes down the data stored in
node 5 will be unavailable as there's no
copy stored elsewhere in this particular
image so the Hadoop file system
overcomes the issue of data node failure
by creating copies of the data this is
known as the replication method and you
can see here we have our six nodes
here's our block a but instead of
storing it just on the first machine
we're actually going to store it on the
second and fourth notes so now it's
spread across three different computers
and in this if these are on a rack one
of these is always on a different rack
so you might have two copies on the same
rack but you never have all three on the
same rack and you always have you never
have more than two copies on one node
there's no reason to have more than one
copy per node and you can see we do the
same thing with Block B Block C is then
also spread out across the different
machines and same with block D and
blocky node 5 crashes will the data
blocks b d and e be lost well in this
example no because we have backups of
all three of those on different machines
the blocks have their copies and the
other nodes due to which the data is not
lost even if the node 5 crashes and
again because they're also stored on
different racks even if the whole rack
goes down you are still up and live with
your Hadoop file system the default
replication factor is three and total
we'll have three copies of each data
block now that can be changed for
different reasons or purposes but you
got to remember when you're looking at a
data center this is all in one huge room
these switches are connecting all these
servers so they can Shuffle the data
back and forth really quick and that is
very important when you're dealing with
big data and you can see here each block
is by default replicated three times
that's the standard there is very very
occasions to do four and there's even
fewer reasons to do two blocks I've only
seen four used once and it was because
they had two data centers and so each
data center kept two different copies
rack awareness in the Hadoop file system
rack is a collection of 30 to 40 data
nodes rack awareness is a concept that
helps to decide where the replica of the
data block should be stored so here we
have rack one we have our data node one
to four remember I was saying they used
to be you'd only put 10 machines and
then it went to 20 now it's 30 to 40. so
you can have a rack with 40 servers on
it then we have rack 2 and rack three
and we put block one on there replicas a
block a cannot be in the same rack and
so I'll put the replicas onto a
different rack and notice that these are
actually these two are on the same rack
but you'll never have all three stored
on the same Rack in case the whole rack
goes down and replicas of block a are
created in rack two and they actually do
they do by default create the replicas
onto the same rack and that has to do
with the data exchange and maximizing
your processing time and then we have of
course our Block B and it's replicated
onto rack 3 and Block C which will then
replicate onto rack one and so on for
all of your data all the way up to block
D or whatever how much every data you
have on there hdfs architecture so let's
look at where the architecture is a
bigger picture we looked at the name
node and we store some metadata names
replicas home food data three so it has
all your different info your metadata
stored on there and then we have our
data nodes and you can see our data
nodes are each on different racks with
our different machines and we have our
name node and you're going to see we
have a heartbeat or pulse here and a lot
of times one of the things that confuses
people sometimes in class is they talk
about nodes versus machines so you could
have a data node that's a Hadoop data
node and you could also have a spark
node on there Sparks a different
architecture and these are each daemons
that are running on these computers
that's why you refer to them as nodes
and not just always as server servers
and machines so even though I use them
interchangeable be aware that these
nodes you can even have virtual machines
if you're testing something out it
doesn't make sense to have 10 virtual
nodes on one machine and deploy it
because you might as well just run your
code on the machine and so we have our
heartbeat going on here and the
heartbeat is a signal that data nodes
continuously send to the name nodes this
signal shows the status of the data node
so there's a continual pulse going up
and saying hey I'm here I'm ready for
whatever instructions or data you want
to send me and you can see here we've
divided up into rack one and rack two
and our different data nodes and it also
have the replications we talked about
how to replicate data and replicates it
in three different locations and then we
have a client machine and the client
first requests the name node to read the
data now if you're not familiar with the
client machine the client is you the
programmer the client is you've logged
in external to this Hadoop file system
and you're sending it instructions and
so the client whatever instructions or
script you're saying ending is first
request the name node to read the data
the name node allows a client to read
the requested data from the data nodes
the data is read from the data nodes and
sent to the client and so you can see
here that basically the the name node
connects the client up and says here
here's a data stream and now you have
the query that you've sent out returning
the data you asked for and then of
course it goes and finishes it and says
oh metadata operations and it goes in
there and finalizes your request the
other thing the name node does is you're
sending your information because the
client sends the information in there is
your block operations so your block
operations are performs creation of data
so you're going to create new files and
folders you're going to delete the
folders and also it covers the
replication of the folders which goes on
in the background and so we can see here
that we have a nice full picture you can
see where the client machine comes in it
cues the metadata the metadata goes into
it stores the metadata and then it goes
into block operations and maybe you're
sending the data to the Hadoop file so
system maybe you're querying maybe
you're asking it to delete if you're
sending data in there it then does the
replication on there it goes back so you
have your data client which is writing
the data into the data node and of
course replicating it and that's all
part of the block operations and so
let's talk a little bit about read
mechanisms in the Hadoop file system the
Hadoop file system read mechanism we
have our Hadoop file system client
that's you on your computer and the
client jvm on the client node and so we
have our client jvm or the Java virtual
machine that is going through and then
your client node and we're zooming in on
the read mechanism so we're looking at
this picture here as you can guess your
client is reading the data and I also
have another client down here writing
data we're going to look a little closer
at that and so we have our name node up
here we have our racks of your data
nodes and your racks of computers down
here and so our client the first thing
it does is it opens a connection up with
the distributed file system to the hdfs
and it goes hey can I get the Block
locations and so it goes by using the
RPC see remote procedure call it gets
those locations and the name node first
checks if the client is authorized to
access the requested file and if yes it
then provides a block location and a
token to the client which is shown to
the slave for authentication so here's
the name node it tells a client hey
here's the token the client's going to
come in and get this information from
you and it tells the client oh hey
here's where the information is so this
is what is telling your script you sent
to query your data whether you're
writing your script in one of the many
setups that you have available through
the Hadoop file system or a connection
through your code and so you have your
client machine at this point then reads
so your FS data input stream comes
through and you have and you can see
right here we did one and two which is
verify who you are and give you all the
information you need then three you're
going to read it from the input stream
and then the input stream is going to
grab it from the different nodes where
it's at and it'll Supply the tokens to
those machines saying hey this client
needs this data here's a token for that
we're good to go let me have the data
the client will show the Authentication
token to the data nodes for the read
process to begin so after reaching the
end of the data block the connection is
closed and we can see here where we've
gone through the different steps get
Block locations we have step one you
open up your connection you get the
Block locations by using the RPC then
you actively go through the fs data
input stream to grab all those different
data brings it back into the client and
then once it's done it closes down that
connection and then once the client or
in this case the programmer you know
manager's gone in and pig script you can
do that there's an actual coding in each
in Hadoop or pulling data called pig or
Hive once you get that data back we
close the connection delete all those
randomly huge series of tokens so they
can't be used anymore and then it's done
with that query and we'll go ahead and
zoom in just a little bit more here and
let's look at this even a little closer
here's our Hadoop file system client and
our client jvm our Java virtual machine
on the client node and we have the data
to be read block a Block B and so we
request to read block A and B it goes
into the name node two then it sends the
location in this case IP addresses of
the blocks for the dn1 and dn2 where
those blocks are stored then the client
interacts with the data nodes through
the switches and so you have here the
core switch so your client node comes in
three and it goes to the core switch and
that then goes to rec switch one rack
switch 2 and rack switch 3. now if
you're looking at this you'll
automatically see a point of failure in
the core switch and certainly you want a
high-end switch mechanism for your core
switch you want to use Enterprise
hardware for that and then when you get
to the racks that's all commodity all
your rack switches so one of those goes
down you don't care as much you just
have to get in there and swap it in and
out really quick you can see here we
have block a which is replicated three
times and so is Block B and it will pull
from there so we come in here and here
the data is read from the dn1 and dn2 as
they are the closest to each other and
so you can see here that it's not going
to read from two different racks it's
going to read from one rack whatever the
closest setup is for that query the
reason for this is if you have 10 other
queries going on you want this one to
pull all the data through one setup and
it minimizes that traffic so the
response from the data nodes to the
client that read the operation was
successful it says Ah we've read the
data we're successful which is always
good we like to be successful I don't
know about you I like to be successful
so if we look at the read mechanism
let's go ahead and zoom in and look at
the right mechanism for the Hadoop file
system sorry hdfs rate mechanism and so
when we have the hdfs write mechanism
here's our client machine this is again
the programmer on their in computer and
it's going through the client Java
machine or Java virtual machine the jvm
this is all occurring on the client node
somebody's office or maybe it's on the
local server for the office so we have
our name node we have data nodes and we
have the distributed file system so the
client first executes create file on
distributed file system says hey I'm
going to create this file over here then
it goes through the RPC call just like
our read did The Client First executes
crate file in the distributed file
system then the DFS interacts with the
name node to create a file name node
then provides a location to write the
data and so here we have our hdfs client
and the fs data output Stream So this
time instead of the data going to the
client it's coming from the client and
so here the client writes the data
through the fsdata output stream keep in
mind that this output stream the client
could be a streaming code it could be I
mean you know I always refer to the
client as just being this computer that
your programmer is writing on it could
be you have your SQL Server there where
your data is it's current with all your
current sales and it's archiving all
that information through scoop one of
the tools in the Hadoop file system it
could be streaming data it could be a
connection to the stock servers and
you're pulling stock data down from
those servers at a regular time and
that's all controlled you can actually
set that code up to be controlled old in
many of the different features in the
Hadoop file system and some of the
different resources you have that sit on
top of it so here the client writes the
data through the fs data output state
and the fs data output stream as you can
see goes into right packet so it divides
it up into packets 128 megabytes and the
data is written and the slave further
replicates it so here's our data coming
in and then if you remember correctly
that's part of the fs data setup is it
tells it where to replicate it out but
the data node itself is like oh hey okay
I've got the data coming in and it's
also given the tokens of where to send
the replications to and then
acknowledgment is sent after the
required replicas are made so then that
goes back up saying hey successful I've
written data made three replications on
this as far as our you know going
through the pipeline of the data nodes
and then that goes back and says after
the data is written the client performs
the close method so the client's done
and says okay I'm done here's the end of
the data we're finished and after the
data is written the client performs a
close method and we can see here just a
quick reshape we go in there just like
we did with the read we create the
connection this creates a name node
which lets it know what's going on step
two step three that also includes the
tokens and everything and then we go
into step three where we're now writing
through the fs data output stream and
that sorts it out into whatever data
node it's going to go to and which also
tells it how to replicate it so that
data node then sends it to other data
nodes so we have a replication and of
course you finalize it and close
everything up marks it complete to the
name node and it deletes all those
magical tokens in the background so that
they can't be reused and we can go ahead
and just do this with an example the
same setups and whether you're doing a
read or write they're very similar as we
come in here from our client and our
name node and you can see right here we
actually depicting these as the actual
rack and the switch is going on and so
as the data comes in you have your
request like we saw earlier it sends the
location of the data nodes and this
actually turns your your IP addresses
your Dynamic node connections they come
back to your client your hdfs client and
at that point with the tokens it then
goes into the core switch and the core
switch hey here it goes the client
interacts with the data nodes through
the switches and you can see here where
you're writing in block a replication or
block a and a second replication of
block a on the second server so blocking
is replicated on the second server and
the third server at this point you now
have three replications of block a and
it comes back and says it acknowledges
and says hey we're done and that goes
back into your Hadoop file system to the
client it says okay we're done and
finally the success written to the name
node and it just closes everything down
a quick recap of the Hadoop file system
and the advantages and so the first one
is probably one of the all of these are
huge one you have multiple data copies
are available so it's very fault
tolerant whole racks can go down
switches can go down even your main name
node could go down if you have a
secondary name node something we didn't
talk too much about is how scalable it
is as it uses distributed storage you
run into there and you're oh my gosh I'm
out of space or I need to do some
heavier processing let me just add
another rack of computers so you can
scale it up very quickly and it's a
linear scalability where it used to be
if you bought a server you would have to
pay a lot of money to get that the Craig
computer remember the big Craig
computers coming out in the Craig
computer runs 2 million a year just the
maintenance to liquid cool it that's
very expensive compared to just adding
more racks of computer and extending
your data center so it's very cost
effective since commodity Hardware is
used we're talking cheap knockoff
computers we still need your high-end
Enterprise for the name node but the
rest of them literally it is a tenth of
the cost of storing data on more
traditional high-end computers and then
the data is secure so it has a very
high-end data security and provides data
security for your data so all Theory and
no play doesn't make for much fun so
let's go ahead and show you what it
looks like as far as some of the
dimensions when you're getting into
pulling data or putting data into the
Hadoop file system and you can see here
here I have Oracle virtual machine
virtual box manager I have a couple
different things loaded on there
Cloudera is one of them so we should
probably explain some of these things if
you're new to Virtual machines the
Oracle virtual box allows you to spin up
a machine as if it is a separate
computer so in this case this is running
I believe Centos a Linux and it creates
like a box on my computer so the Centos
is running on my machine while I'm
running my windows 10. it happens to be
a Windows 10 computer and then
underneath here I can actually go under
let me just open up General might be
hard to see there and you can see I can
actually go down to system processor I
happen to be on an eight core it has 16
dedicated threads registers of 16 CPUs
but eight cores and I've only designated
this for one CPU so it's only going to
use one of my dedicated threads on my
computer and this the Oracle virtual
machine is open source you can see right
here we're on the Oracle
www.oracle.com I usually just do a
search for downloading virtualbox if you
search for virtualbox all one word it
will come up with this page and then you
can download it for whatever operating
system you're working with there
certainly are a number of different
options and let me go and point those
out if you're setting this up as a for
demoing for yourself the first thing to
note for doing a virtual box and doing a
Cloudera or Horton setup on that virtual
box for doing the Hadoop system to try
it out you need a minimum of 12
gigabytes it cannot be a Windows 10 home
edition because you'll have problems
with your virtual setup and sometimes
you have to go turn on the virtual
settings so it knows it's in there so if
you're on a home setup there are other
sources there's Cloudera and we'll talk
a little bit about Cloudera here in just
a second but they have the Cloudera
online live we can go try the Cloudera
setup I've never used it but Cloudera is
a pretty good company Cloudera and
hortonworks are two of the common ones
out there and we'll actually be running
a Cloudera Hadoop cluster on on our demo
here so you have Oracle virtual machine
you also have the option of doing it on
different VMware that's another one like
virtual machine this is more of a paid
service there is a free setup for just
doing it for yourself which will work
fine for this and then in the Cloudera
like again they have the new online
setup where you can go in there to the
online and for Cloudera you want to go
underneath the Cloudera quick start if
you type in a search for Cloudera quick
start it'll bring you to this website
and then you can select your platform in
this case I did virtual box there's
VMware we just talked about Docker
Docker is a very high-end virtual setup
unless you already know it you really
don't want to mess with it then your KVM
is if you're on a Linux computer that
sets up multiple systems on that
computer so the two you really want to
use are usually the virtual box or do an
online setup and you can see here with
the download if you're going into the
Horton versions called hortonworks and
they call it sandbox so you'll see the
term hortonworks sandbox and these are
all test demos you're not going to
deploy a single node Hadoop systems that
would just be kind of ridiculous and
defeat the whole purpose of having a
Horton or having a Hadoop system if it's
only installed on one computer in a
virtual node so a lot of different
options if you're not on a professional
Windows version or you don't have at
least 12 gigabytes Ram to run this uh
you'll want to try and see if you can
find an online version and of course
simply learn has our own Labs if you
sign up for our classes we set you up I
don't know what it is now but last time
I was in there was a five node setup so
you could get around and see what's
going on whether you're studying for the
admin side or for the programming side
in script writing and if I go into my
Oracle virtual box and I go under my
Cloudera and I start this up and each
one has their own flavors Horton uses
just a login so you log everything in
through a local host through your
Internet Explorer or like you use Chrome
Cloudera actually opens up a full
interface so you actually are in that
setup and you can see when I start it
let me go back here once I downloaded
this this is a big download by the way I
had to import The Appliance in
virtualbox the first time I ran it it
takes a long time to configure the setup
and the second time it comes up pretty
quick and with the cloud Dera quick
start again this is a pretend single
node it opens up and you'll see that it
actually has Firefox here so here's my
web browser I don't have to go to a
local host I'm actually already in the
quick start for Cloudera and if we come
down here you can see getting started I
have some information analyze your data
manage your cluster your general
information on there and what I always
want to start to do is to go ahead and
open up a terminal window so open up a
terminal widen this a little bit let me
just maximize this out here so you can
see so we are now in a virtual machine
this virtual machine is Centos Linux so
I'm on a Linux computer on my Windows
computer and so when I'm on this
terminal window this is your basic
terminal if I do list you'll see
documents eclipse these are the
different things that are installed with
the quick start guide on the Linux
system so this is a Linux computer and
then Hadoop is running on here so now I
have Hadoop single node so it has both
the name node and the data node and
everything squished together in one
virtual machine we can then do let's do
hdfs telling it that it's a Hadoop file
system DFS minus LS now notice the ls is
the same I have LS for list and LS for
list and I click on here it'll take you
just a second reading the Hadoop file
system and it comes up with nothing so a
quick recap let's go back over this
three different environments I have this
one out here let's just put this in a
bright red so you can actually see it I
have this environment out here which is
my slides I have this environment here
where I did a list that's looking at the
files on the Linux Centos computer and
then we have this system here which is
looking at the files on the Hadoop file
system so three complete separate
environments and then we connect them
and so right now we have I have whatever
files I have my personal files and the
um of course we're also looking at the
screen for my Windows 10 and then we're
looking at the screen here here's our
list there let's look at the files and
this is the screen for Centos Linux and
then this is looking at the files right
here for the Hadoop file system so three
completely separate files this one here
which is the Linux is running in a
virtual box so this is a virtual box I'm
using one core to run it or one CPU and
everything in there is it has its own
file system you can see we have our
desktop and documents and whatever in
there and then you can see here we right
now have no files and our Hadoop file
system and this Hadoop file system
currently is stored on the Linux machine
but it could be stored across 10 Linux
machines 20 100 this could be stored
across in petabytes I mean it could be
really huge or it could just be in this
case just a demo where we're putting it
on just one computer and then once we're
in in here let me just see real quick if
I can go under view zoom in view zoom in
this is just a standard browser so I
could use any like the Control Plus and
stuff like that to zoom in and this is
very common to be in a browser window
with the Hadoop file system so right now
I'm in a Linux and I'm going to do oh
let's just create a file go file my new
file and I'm going to use VI and this is
a VI editor just a basic editor and we
go ahead and type something in here one
two three four maybe it's columns 44 66
77 of course I do file system just like
your regular computer can also so in our
value editor you hit your colon I
actually work with a lot of different
other editors and we'll write quit VI so
let's take a look and see what happened
here I'm in my Linux system I type in LS
for list and we should see my new file
and sure enough we do over here there it
is let me just highlight that my new
file and if I then go into the Hadoop
system hdfs
EFS minus LS for list we still show
nothing it's still empty so what I can
simply do is I can go up hdfs DFS minus
put and then we're going to put my new
file and this is just going to move it
from the Linux system because I'm in
this file folder into the Hadoop file
system and now if we go in and we type
in our list for a new file system you
will see in here that I now have just
the one file on there which is my new
file and very similar to Linux we can do
cat and the cat command simply evokes
reading the file so hdfs DFS minus cat
and I had to look it up remember
Cloudera the the format is going to be a
user then of course the path location
and the file name and in here when we
did the list here's our list so you can
see it lists our file here and we
realize that this is under a user Cloud
Dara and so I can now go user Cloudera
my new file and the minus cat and we'll
be able to read the file in here and you
can see right here this is the file that
was in the Linux system is now copied
into the Cloudera system and it's one
three four five that what I entered in
there and if we go back to the Linux and
do list you'll still see it in here my
new file and we can also do something
like this in our hdfs minus MV I will do
my new file and we're going to change it
to my new new file and if we do that
underneath our Hadoop file system the
minus MV will rename it so if I go back
here to our Hadoop file system LS you'll
now see instead of my new file it has my
new new file coming up and there it is
my new new files we've renamed it we can
also go in here and delete this so I can
now come in here so in our hdfs DFS we
can also do a remove and this will
remove the file and so if we come in
here we run this we'll see that when I
come back and do the list the file is
gone and now we just have another empty
folder with our Hadoop file system and
just like any file system we can take
this and we can go ahead and make
directory create a new directory so MK
for make directory we'll call this my
dur so we're going to make a directory
reminder it'll take it just a second and
of course if we do the list command
you'll see that we now have the
directory in there give it just a second
there it comes myder and just like we
did before I can go in here and we're
going to put the file and if you
remember correctly from our files in the
setup I called it my new file so this is
coming from the Linux system and we're
going to put that into my dir that's the
Target in my Hadoop setup and so if I
hit enter on there I can now do the
Hadoop list and that's not going to show
the files remember I put it in a
subfolder so if I do the quadrupt just
this will show my directory and I can do
list and then I can can do my der for my
directory and you'll see underneath the
my directory in the Hadoop file system
it now has my new file put in there and
with any good operating system we need a
minus help so just like you can type in
help in your Linux you can now come in
here and type in hdfs help and it shows
you a lot of the commands in there
underneath the Hadoop file system most
of them should be very similar to the
Linux on here and we can also do
something like this a Hadoop version and
the Hadoop version shows up that we're
in Hadoop 2.60
CDH is it where Cloudera 5 and compiled
by Jenkins and it has a date and all the
different information on our Hadoop file
system so this is some basics in the
terminal window let me go ahead and
close this out because if you're going
to play with this you should really come
in here let me just maximize the
Cloudera that opens up in a browser
window and so once we're in here again
this is a browser window which you could
access might look like any access for a
Hadoop file system one of the fun things
to do when you're first starting is to
go under Hue you'll see it up here at
the top has Cloudera Hue Hadoop near
hbase your Impala your spark these are
standard installs now and Hue is
basically an overview of the file system
and so come up here and you can see
where you can do queries as far as if
you have a hbase or a hive The Hive
database let me go over here to the top
where it says file browser and if we go
under file browser now this is a Hadoop
file system we're looking at and once we
open up the file browser you can now see
there's my directory which we created
and if I click on my directory there's
my new file which is in here and if I
click on my new file it actually opens
it up and you can see from our Hadoop
file system this is in the Hadoop file
system the file that we created so we
covered the terminal window you can see
here's a terminal window up here it
might be if you were in a web browser
it'll look a little different because it
actually opens up as a web browser
terminal window and we've looked a
little bit at Hue which is one of the
most basic components of Hadoop one of
the original components for going
through at your data and your databases
of course now they're up to the Hue four
it's gone through a number of changes
and you can see there's a lot of
different choices in here for other
different tools in the Hadoop file
system and I'll go ahead and just close
out of this and one of the cool things
with the virtual uh box I can either
save the machine State send the shutdown
signal or power off the machine I'll go
and just power off the machine
completely now suppose you have a
library that has a collection of huge
number of books on each floor and you
want to count the total number of books
present on each floor what would be your
approach you would say I will do it
myself but then don't you think that
will take a lot of time and that's
obviously not an efficient way of
counting the number of books in this
huge collection on every floor by
yourself now there could be a different
approach or an alternative to that you
could think of asking three of your
friends or three of your colleagues and
you could then say if each friend could
count the books on every floor then
obviously that would make your work
faster and easier to count the books on
every floor now this is what we mean by
parallel processing So when you say
parallel processing in technical terms
you're talking about using multiple
machines and each machine would be
contributing its RAM and CPU cores for
processing and your data would be
processed on multiple machines at the
same time now this type of process
involves parallel processing in our case
or in our library example where you
would have person one who would be
taking care of books on floor 1 and
Counting them person two on floor 2 then
you have someone on floor 3 and someone
on floor four so every individual would
be counting the books on every floor in
parallel so that reduces the time
consumed for this activity and then
there should be some mechanism where all
these Counts from every floor can be
aggregated so what is each person doing
here each person is mapping the data of
a particular floor or you can say each
person is doing a kind of activity or
basically a task on every floor and the
task is counting the books on every
floor now then you could have some
aggregation mechanism that could
basically reduce or summarize this total
count and in terms of map reduce we
would say that's the work of reducer so
when you talk about Hadoop map reduce it
processes data on different node
machines now this is the whole concept
of Hadoop framework right that you not
only have your data stored across
machines but you would also want to
process the data locally so instead of
transferring the data from one machine
to other machine or bringing all the
data together into some central
processing unit and then processing it
you would rather have the data processed
on the machines wherever that is stored
so we know in case of Hadoop cluster we
would have our data stored on multiple
data nodes on their multiple disks and
that is the data which needs to be
processed but the requirement is that we
want to process this data as fast as
possible and that could be achieved by
using parallel processing now in case of
mapreduce we basically have the first
phase which is your mapping phase so in
case of mapreduce programming model you
basically have two phases one is mapping
and one is reducing now who takes care
of things in mapping phase it is a
mapper class and this mapper class has
the function which is provided by the
developer which takes care of these
individual map tasks which will work on
multiple nodes in parallel your reducer
class belongs to the reducing phase so a
reducing phase basically uses a reducer
class which provides a function that
will Aggregate and reduce the output of
different data nodes to generate the
final output now that's how your map
reduce Works using mapping and then
obviously reducing now you could have
some other kind of jobs which are map
only jobs wherein there is no reducing
required but we are not talking about
those we are talking about our
requirement where we would want to
process the data using mapping and
reducing especially when data is huge
when data is stored across multiple
machines and you would want to process
the data in parallel so when you talk
about mapreduce you could say it's a
programming model you could say
internally it's a processing engine of
Hadoop that allows you to process and
compute huge volumes of data and when we
say huge volumes of data we can talk
about terabytes we can talk about
petabytes Excel bytes and that amount of
data which needs to be processed on a
huge cluster we could also use mapreduce
programming model and run a mapreduce
algorithm in a local mode but what does
that mean if you would go for a local
mode it basically means it would do all
the mapping and reducing on the same
node using the processing capacity that
is RAM and CPU cores on the same machine
which is not really efficient in fact we
would want to have a
reduce work on multiple nodes which
would obviously have mapping phase
followed by a reducing phase and
intermittently there would be data
generated there would be different other
phases which help this whole processing
so when you talk about Hadoop map reduce
you are mainly talking about two main
components or two main phases that is
mapping and reducing mapping taking care
of map tasks reducing taking care of
reduced tasks so you would have your
data which would be stored on multiple
machines now when we talk about data
data could be in different formats we
could or the developer could specify
what is the format which needs to be
used to understand the data which is
coming in that data then goes through
the mapping internally there would be
some shuffling sorting and then reducing
which gives you your final output so the
way we Access Data from sdfs or the way
our data is getting stored on sdfs we
have our input data which would have one
or multiple files in one or multiple
directories and your final output is
also stored on sdfs to be accessed to be
looked into and to see if the processing
was done correctly so this is how it
looks so you have the input data which
would then be worked upon by multiple
map tasks now how many map tasks that
basically depends on the file that
depends on the input format so normally
we know that in a Hadoop cluster you
would have a file which is broken down
into blocks depending on its size so the
default block size is 128 MB which can
then still be customized based on your
average size of data which is getting
stored on the cluster so if I have
really huge files which are getting
stored on the cluster I would certainly
set a higher block size so that my every
file does not have huge number of blocks
creating a load on name nodes Ram
because that's tracking the number of
elements in your cluster or number of
objects in your cluster so depending on
your file size your file would be split
into multiple chunks and for every Chunk
we would have a map task running now
what is this map task doing that is
specified within the mapper class so
within the mapper class you have the
mapper function which basically says
what each of these map tasks has to do
on each of the chunks which has to be
processed this data intermittently is
written to hdfs where it is sorted and
Shop fault and then you have internal
phases such as partitioner which which
decides how many reduce Stars would be
used or what data goes to which user you
could also have a combiner phase which
is like a mini reducer doing the same
reduce operation before it reaches
so you have your reducing phase which is
taken care by a radio
turnally the reducer function provided
by developers which would have reduced
task running on the data which comes as
an output from map tasks finally your
output is then generated which is stored
on hdfs now in case of Hadoop it accepts
data in different formats your data
could be in compressed format your data
could be in bar k your data could be in
Avro text CSV PSV binary format and all
of these formats are supported however
remember if you are talking about data
being compressed then you have to also
look into what kind of splitability the
compression mechanism supports otherwise
when mapreduce processing happens it
would take the complete file as one
chunk to be processed so sdfs accepts
input data in different formats this
data is stored in sdfs and that is
basically our input which is then
passing through the mapping phase now
what is mapping phase doing as I said it
reads record by record depending on the
input format it reads the data so we
have multiple map tasks running on
multiple chunks once this data is being
read this is broken down into individual
elements and when I say individual
element I could say this is my list of
key value pairs so your records based on
some kind of delimiter or without
delimiter are broken down into
individual elements and thus your math
creates key value pairs now these key
value pairs are not my final output
these key value pairs are basically a
list of elements which will then be
subjected to further processing so you
would have internally shuffling and
sorting of data so that all the relevant
key value pairs are brought together
which basically benefits the processing
and then you have your reducing which
Aggregates the key value pairs into set
of smaller tuples or tuples as you
finally your output is getting stored in
the designated directory as a list of
aggregated key value pairs which gives
you your output so when we talk about
mapreduce one of the key factors here is
the parallel processing which it can
offer so we know that we our data is
getting stored across multiple data
nodes and you would have huge volume of
data which is split and randomly
distributed across data nodes and this
is the data which needs to be processed
and the best way would be parallel
processing so you could have your data
getting stored on multiple data nodes or
multiple slave nodes in each slave node
would have again one or multiple disks
to process this data basically we have
to go for parallel processing approach
we have to use the map
the map now let's look at the mapreduce
workflow to understand how it works so
basically you have your input data
stored on sdfs now this is the data
which needs to be processed it is stored
in input files and the processing which
you want can be done on one single file
or it can be done on a directory which
has multiple files you could also later
have multiple outputs merged which we
achieve by using something called as
chaining of mappers so here you have
your data getting stored on sdfs now
input format is basically something to
define the input specification and how
the input files will be split so there
are various input formats now we can
search for that so we can go to Google
and we can basically search for Hadoop
map reduce Yahoo tutorial this is one of
the good links and if I look into this
link I can search for different input
formats and output formats so let's
search for input format so when we talk
about input format you basically have
something to Define how input files are
split so input files are split up and
read based on what input format is
specified so this is a class that
provides following functionality it
selects the files or other objects that
should be used for input it defines the
input split that break a file into tasks
provides a factory for record reader
objects that read the file so there are
different formats if you look in the
table here and you can see that the text
input format is the default format which
reads lines of a text file and each line
is considered as a record here the key
is the byte offset of the line and the
value is the line content it says you
can have key value input format which
parses lines into key value pairs
everything up to the first tab character
is the key and the remainder is the line
you could also have sequence file input
format which basically works on binary
format so you have input format and in
the same way you can also also search
for output format which takes care of
how the data is handled after the
processing is done so the key value
pairs provided to this output collector
are then returned to Output files the
way they are written is governed by
output format so it functions pretty
much like input format as described in
earlier right so we could set what is
the output format to be followed and
again you have text output sequence file
output format null output format and so
on so these are different classes which
take care of how your data is handled
when it is being read for processing or
how is the data being written when the
processing is done so based on the input
format the file is broken down into
splits and this logically represents the
data to be processed by individual map
tasks or you could say individual mapper
functions so you could have one or
multiple splits which need to need to be
possessed depending on the file size
depending on what properties have been
set now once this is done you have your
input splits which are subjected to
mapping phase internally you have a
record reader which communicates with
the input split and converts the data
into key value pairs suitable to be read
by mapper and what is mapper doing it is
basically working on these key value
pairs the map task giving you an
intermittent output which would then be
forwarded for further processing now
once that is done and we have these key
value pairs which is being worked upon
my map your map tasks as a part of your
mapper function are generating your key
value pairs which are your intermediate
outputs to be processed further now you
could have as I said a combiner phase or
internally a mini reducer phase Now
combiner does not have its own class so
combiner basically uses the same class
as the reducer class provided by the
developer and its main work is to do the
reducing or its main work is to do some
kind of mini aggregation on the key
value pairs which were generated by map
so once the data is coming in from the
combiner then we have internally a
partitioner phase which decides how
outputs from combiners are sent to the
reducers or you could also say that even
if I did not have a combiner partitioner
would decide based on the keys and
values based on the type of keys how
many reducers would be required or how
many reduced tasks would be required to
work on your output which was generated
by map task now once partitioner has
decided that then your data would be
then sorted and shuffled which is then
fed into the reducer so when you talk
about your reducer it would basically
have one or multiple reduced tasks now
that depends on what or what partitioner
decided or determined for your data to
be processed it can also depend on the
configuration properties which have been
set to decide how many radio Stars
should be used now internally all this
data is obviously going through sorting
and shuffling so that you're reducing
your aggregation becomes an easier task
once we have this done we basically have
the reducer which is the code for the
reducer is provided by the developer and
all the intermediate data has then to be
aggregated to give you a final output
which would then be stored on sdfs and
who does this you have an internal
record writer which writes these output
key value pairs from reducer to the
output files now this is how your map
reduce Works wherein the final output
data can be not only stored but then
read or accessed from hdfs or even used
as an input for further mapreduce kind
of processing so this is how it overall
looks so you basically have your data
stored on sdfs based on input format you
have the splits then you have record
reader which gives your data to the
mapping phase which is then taken care
by your mapper function and mapper
function basically means one or multiple
map tasks working on your chunks of data
you could have a combiner phase which is
all functional which is not mandatory
then you have a partitional phase which
decides on how many reduced tasks or how
many reducers would be used to work on
your data internally there is sorting
and shuffling of data happening and then
basically based on your output format
your record reader will write the output
to sdfs directory now internally you
could also remember that data is being
processed locally so you would have the
output of each task which is being
worked upon stored locally however we do
not access the data directly from data
nodes we access it from sdfs so our
output is stored on sdfs so that is your
map reduce workflow when you talk about
mapreduce architecture now this is how
it would look so you would have
basically a edge node or a client
program or an API which intends to
process some data so it submits the job
to the job tracker or you can say
resource manager in case of Hadoop yarn
framework right now before this step we
can also say that an interaction with
name node would have already happened
which would have given information of
data nodes which have the relevant data
stored then your master processor so in
Hadoop version one we had job tracker
and then the slaves were called task
trackers in Hadoop version 2 instead of
job tracker you have resource manager
answer of task trackers you have node
managers so basically your resource
manager has to assign the job to the
task trackers or node managers so your
node managers as we discussed in yarn
are basically taking care of processing
which happens on every node so
internally there is all of this work
Happening by resource manager node
managers and application Master then you
can refer to the yarn based tutorial to
understand more about that so here your
processing Master is basically breaking
down the application into tasks what it
does internally is once your application
is submitted you application to be run
on yarn processing framework is handled
by resource manager now forget about the
yarn part as of now I mean who does the
negotiating of resources who allocates
them how does the processing happen on
the nodes right so that's all to do with
how yarn handles the processing request
so you have your data which is stored in
sdfs broken down into one or multiple
splits depending on the input format
which has been specified by the
developer your input splits are to be
worked upon by your one or multiple map
tasks which will be running within the
container on the nodes basically you
have the resources which are being
utilized so for each map task you would
have some amount of ram which will be
utilized and then further the same data
which has to go through reducing phase
that is your reduced task will also be
utilizing some RAM and CPU cores now
internally you have these functions
which take care of deciding on number of
reducers doing a mini reduce and
basically reading and processing the
data from multiple data nodes now this
is how your mapreduce programming model
makes parallel processing work or
processes your data which is stored
across multiple machines finally you
have your output which is getting stored
on stfs
foreign
so let's have a quick demo on mapreduce
and see how it works on a Hadoop cluster
now we have discussed briefly about
mapreduce which contains mainly two
phases that is your mapping phase and
your reducing phase and mapping phase is
taken care by your mapper function and
your reducing phase is taken care by
your reducer function now in between we
also have sorting and shuffling and then
you have other phases which is
partitioner and combiner and we will
discuss about all those in detail in
later sessions but let's have a quick
demo on how we can run a mapreduce which
is already existing as a package jar
file within your Apache Hadoop cluster
or even in your Cloudera cluster now we
can build our own mapreduce programs we
can package them as jar transfer them to
the cluster and then run it on a Hadoop
cluster on yarn or we could be using
already provided default program so
let's see where they are now these are
my two machines which I have brought up
and basically this would have my Apache
Hadoop cluster running now we can just
do a Simple Start hyphen all dot SH now
I know that this script is deprecated
and it says instead you start DFS and
start yarn but then it will still take
care of static of my cluster on these
two nodes where I would have one single
name node two data nodes one secondary
name node one resource manager and two
node managers now if you have any doubt
in how this cluster came up you can
always look at the previous sessions
where we had a walk through in setting
up a cluster on Apache and then you
could also have your cluster running
using Less Than 3 GB of your total
machine RAM and you could have a Apache
cluster running on your machine now once
this cluster comes up we will also have
a look at the web UI which is available
for name node and results manager now
based on the settings what we have given
our uis will show us details of our
cluster but remember the UI is only to
browse now here my cluster has come up I
can just do a JPS to look at Java
related processes and that will show me
what are the processes which are running
on C1 which is your data node resource
manager node manager and name node and
on my M1 machine which is my second
machine which I have configured here I
can always do a JPS and that shows me
the processes running which also means
that my cluster is up with two data
nodes with two node managers and here I
can have a look at my web UI so I can
just do a refresh and the same thing
with this one just do a refresh so I had
already opened the web pages so you can
always access the web UI using your name
node's host name and 570 Port it tells
me what is my cluster ID what is my blog
post
it gives you information of what is the
space usage how many live nodes you have
and you can even browse your file system
so I have put in a lot of data here I
can click on browse the file system and
this basically shows me multiple
directories and these directories have
one or multiple files which we will use
for our mapreduce example now if you see
here these are my directories which have
some sample files although these files
are very small like 8.7 kilobytes if you
look into this directory if you look
into this I have just pulled in some of
my Hadoop blogs and I have put it on my
sdfs these are a little bigger files and
then we also have some other data which
we can see here and this is data which
I've downloaded from web now we can
either run a mapreduce on a single file
or in a directory which contains
multiple files let's look at that before
looking a demo on map reduce also
remember map reduce will create a output
directory and we need to have that
directory created plus we need to have
the permissions to run the mapreduce job
so by default since I'm running it using
admin ID I should not have any problem
but then if you intend to run mapreduce
with a different user then obviously you
will have to ask the admin or you will
have to give the user permission to read
and write from sdfs so this is the
directory which I've created which will
contain my output once the map reduce
job finishes and this is my cluster file
system if you look on this UI this shows
me about my yarn which is available for
taking care of any processing it as of
now shows that I have total of 8 memory
and I have eight week course now that
can be depending on what configuration
we have set or how many nodes are
available we can look at nodes which are
available and that shows me I have two
node managers running each has 8 GB
memory and 8 V cores now that's not true
actually but then we have not set the
configurations for node managers and
that's why it takes the default
properties that is 8GB RAM and 8B cores
now this is my yarn UI we can also look
at scheduler which basically shows me
the different queues if they have been
configured where you will have to run
the jobs we'll discuss about all these
in later in detail now let's go back to
our terminal and let's see where we can
find some sample applications which we
can run on the cluster so once I go to
the terminal I can well submit the
mapreduce job from any terminal now here
I know that my Hadoop related
directories here and within Hadoop you
have various directories we have
discussed that in binaries you have the
commands which you can run in s bin you
basically have the startup scripts and
here you also notice there is a share
directory in the end if you look in the
Shell directory you would find Hadoop
and within Hadoop you have various sub
directories in which we will look for
mapreduce now this map reduce directory
has some sample jar files which we can
use to run a mapreduce on the cluster
similarly if you are working on a cloud
error cluster you would have to go into
opt Cloudera parcel CDH slash lib and in
that you would have directories for hdfs
mapreduce or sdfs yarn where you can
still find the same jars it is basically
a package which contains your multiple
applications now how do we run a map
reduce we can just type in Hadoop and
hit enter and that shows me that I have
an option called jar which can be used
to run a jar file now at any point of
time if you would want to see what are
the different classes which are
available in a particular
jar you could always do a jar minus xvf
for example I could say jar x v f and I
could say user local Hadoop share Hadoop
map reduce and then list down your jar
file so I'll say Hadoop mapreduce
examples and if I do this this should
basically unpack it to show me what
classes are available within this
particular jar and it has done this it
has created a meta file and it has
created a org directory we can see that
by doing a LS and here if you look in LS
org since I ran the command from your
phone directory I can look into org
patchy Hadoop examples which shows me
the classes which I have and those
classes contain which mapper or reducer
classes so it might not be just mapper
and reducer but you can always have a
look so for example I am targeting to
use word count program which does a word
count on files and gives me a list of
words and how many times they occur in a
particular file or in set of files and
this shows me that what are the classes
which belong to word count so we have a
in some reducer so this is my reducer
class I have tokenizer mapper that is my
mapper class right and basically this is
what is used these classes are used if
you run a word count now there are many
other programs which are part of this
jar file and we can expand and see that
so I can say Hadoop jar and give your
path so I'll say Hadoop jar user local
Hadoop share Hadoop map reduce Hadoop
mapreduce examples and if I hit on enter
that will show me what are the inbuilt
classes which are already available now
these are certain things which we can
use now there are other jar files also
for example I can look at Hadoop and
here we can look at the jar files which
we have in this particular path so this
is one Hadoop mapreduce examples which
you can use you can always look in other
jar files like you can look for Hadoop
mapreduce client job client and then you
can look at a test one so that is also
an interesting one so you can always
look into Hadoop map reduce client job
client and then you have something
ending with this so if I would have
tried this one using my Hadoop jar
command so in my previous example when
we did this it was showing me all the
classes which are available and that
already has a word count now there are
other good programs which you can try
like terrajen to generate dummy data
Terra saw to check your sorting
performance and so on and tell a
validate to validate the results
similarly we can also do a Hadoop jar as
I said on Hadoop mapreduce I think that
was client and then we have job client
and then test chart now this has a lot
of other classes which can be used or
programs which can be used for doing a
stress testing or checking your cluster
status and so on one of them interesting
one is there's the fsio but let's not
get into all the details in first
instance let's see how we can run a map
reduce now if I would want to run a map
reduce I need to give Hadoop jar and
then my jar file and if I hit on enter
it would say it needs the input and
output it needs which class you want to
run so for example I would say word
count and again if I hit on enter it
tells me that you need to give me some
input and output to process and
obviously this processing will be
happening on cluster that is our yarn
processing framework unless and until
you would want to run this job in a
local mode so there is a possibility
that you can run the job in in local
mode but let's first try how it runs on
the cluster so how do we do that now
here I can do a hdfs LS slash command to
see what I have on my sdfs now through
my UI I was already showing you that we
have set of files and directories which
we can use to process now we can take up
one single file so for example if I pick
up new data and M I can look into the
files here what we have and we can
basically run a map reduce on a single
file or multiple files so let's take
this file whatever that contains and I
would like to do a word count so that I
get a list of words and their occurrence
in this file so let me just copy this
now I also need my output to be written
and that will be written here so here if
I want to run a map reduce I can say
Hadoop which we can pull out from
history so Hadoop jar word count now I
need to give my input so that will be
new data and then I will give this file
which we just copied now I am going to
run the word count only on a single file
and I will basically have my output
which will be stored in this directory
the directory which I have created
already Mr output so let's do this
output and this is fair enough now you
can give many other properties you can
specify how many map jobs you want to
run how many reduced jobs you want to
run do you want your output to be
compressed do you want your output to be
merged or many other properties can be
defined when you are specifying word
count and then you can pass in an
argument to pass properties from the
command line which will affect your
output now once I go ahead and submit
this this is basically running a simple
inbuilt mapreduce job on our Hadoop
cluster now obviously internally it will
be looking for name node now we have
some issue here and it says the output
already exists what does that mean so it
basically means that Hadoop will create
an output for you you just need to give
a name but then you don't need to create
it so let's give let's append the output
with number one and then let's go ahead
and run this so I've submitted this
command now this can also be done in
background if you would want to run
multiple jobs on your cluster at the
same time so it takes total input paths
to process is one so that is there is
only one split on which your job has to
work now it will internally try to
contact your resource manager and
basically this is done so here we can
have a look and we can see some counters
here now what I also see is for some
property which it is missing it has run
the job but it has run in a local mode
it has run in a local mode so although
we have submitted so this might be
related to my yarn settings and we can
check that so if I do a refresh when I
have run my application it has completed
it would have created an output but the
only thing is it did not interact with
your yarn it did not interact with your
resource manager we can check those
properties and here if we look into the
job it basically tells me that it went
for mapping and reducing it would have
created an output it worked on my file
but then it ran in a local mode it ran
in a local mode so mapreduce remember is
a programming model right now if you run
it on yarn you get the facilities of
running it on a cluster where yarn takes
care of resource management if you don't
run it on yarn and run it on a local
mode it will use you
use RAM and CPU cores for processing but
then we can quickly look at the output
and then we can also try running this on
yarn so if I look into my hdfs and if I
look into my output Mr output that's the
directory which was not used actually
let's look into the other directory
which is ending with one and that should
show me the output created by this map
reduce although it ran in a local mode
it fetched an input file from your sdfs
and it would have created output in sdfs
now that's my part file which is created
and if you look at part minus r minus
these zeros if you would have more than
one reducer running then you would have
multiple such files created we can look
into this what does this file contain
which should have my word count and here
I can say cat which basically shows me
what is the output created by my map
reduce let's have a look into this so
the file which we gave for processing
has been broken down and now we have the
list of words which occur in the file
plus a count of those words so if there
is some word which is in is more then it
shows me the count so this is a list of
my words and the count for that so this
is how we run a sample mapreduce job I
will also show you how we can run it on
yeah now let's run mapreduce on yarn and
initially when we tried running a map
reduce it not hit yarn but it ran in a
local mode and that was because there
was a property which had to be changed
in mapreduce hyphen site file so
basically if you look into this file the
error was that I had given a property
which says
mapred.framework.name and that was not
the right property name and it was
ignored and that's why it ran in a local
mode so I changed the property to
mapreduce dot framework.name restarted
my cluster and everything should be fine
now and that mapred hyphen site file has
also been copied across the nodes now to
run a mapreduce on a Hadoop cluster so
that it uses yarn and yarn takes care of
resource allocation on one or multiple
machines so I'm just changing the output
here and now I will submit this job
which should first connect to the
resource manager and if it connects to
the resource manager that means our job
will be run using yarn on the Clusters
rather than in a local mode so now now
we have to wait for this application to
internally connect to resource manager
and once it starts there we can always
go back to the web UI and check if our
application has reached yarn so it shows
me that there is one input part to be
processed that's my job ID that's my
application ID which you can even
monitor status from the command line now
here the job has been submitted so let's
go back here and just do a Refresh on my
yarn UI which should show me the new
application which is submitted it tells
me that it is in accepted State
application master has already started
and if you click on this link it will
also give you more details of how many
map and reduced tasks would run so as of
now it says the application Master is
running it would be using the node which
is m one we can always look into the
logs we can see that there is a one task
attempt which is being made and now if I
go back to my terminal I will see that
it is waiting to get some resources from
the cluster and once it gets the
resources it will first start with the
mapping phase where the mapper function
runs it does the map tasks one or
multiple depending on the splits so
right now we have one file and one split
so we will have just one map task
running and once the mapping phase
completes then it will get into reducing
which will finally give me my output so
we can be toggling through these
sessions so here I can just do a refresh
to see what is happening with my
application is it proceeding is it still
waiting for resource manager to allocate
some resources now just couple of
minutes back I tested this application
on yarn and we can see that my first
application completed successfully and
here we will have to give some time so
that yarn can allocate the resources now
if the resources were used by some other
application they will have to be freed
up now internally Yan takes care of all
that which we will learn more detail in
yarn or you might have already followed
the yarn based session now here we will
have to just give it some more time and
let's see if my application proceeds
with the resources what Yan can allocate
to it sometimes you can also see a
slowness in what web UI shows up and
that can be related to the amount of
memory you have allocated to your notes
now for Apache we can have less amount
of memory and we can still run the
cluster and as I said the memory which
shows up here 16 GB and 16 cores is not
the true one those are the default
settings right but then my yarn should
be able to facilitate running of this
application let's just give it couple of
seconds and then let's look into the
output here again I had to make some
changes in the settings because our
application was not getting enough
resources and then basically I restarted
my cluster now let's submit the
application again to the cluster which
first should contact the resource
manager and then basically the map and
reduce process should start so here I
have submitted an application it is
connecting to the resource manager and
then basically it will start internally
an app master that is application Master
it is looking for the number of splits
which is one it's getting the
application ID and it basically then
starts running the job it also gives you
a tracking URL to look at the output and
now we should go back and look at our
yarn UI if our application shows up here
and we will have to give it a couple of
seconds when it can get the final status
change to running and that's where my
application will be getting resources
now if you closely notice here I have
allocated specific amount of memory that
is 1.5 GB for node manager on every node
and I have basically given two cores
each which my machines also have and my
yarn should be utilizing these resources
rather than going for default now the
application has started moving and we
can see the progress bar here which
basically will show what is happening
and if we go back to the terminal it
will show that first it went in deciding
map and reduce it goes for map once the
mapping phase completes then the
reducing phase will come into existence
and here my job has completed so now it
has basically used we can always look at
how many map and reduce SAS were run it
shows me that there was one map and one
reduced task now with the number of map
tasks depends on the number of splits
and we had just one file which is less
than 128 MB so that was one split to be
processed and reduced task is internally
decided by the reducer or depending on
what kind of property has been set in
Hadoop config files now it also tells me
how many input records were read which
basically means these were the number of
lines in the file it tells me output
records which gives me the number of
total words in the file now there might
be duplicates and that which is
processed by internal combiner further
processing or forwarding that
information to reducer and basically
reducer works on 335 records gives us a
list of words and their account now if I
do a refresh here this would obviously
show my application is completed it says
succeeded you can always click on the
application to look for more information
it tells me where it ran now we do not
have a history server running as of now
otherwise we can always access more
information so this leads to history
server where all your applications are
stored but I can click on this attempt
tasks and this will basically show me
the history URL or you can always look
into the logs so this is how you can
submit a sample application which is
inbuilt which is available in the jar on
your Hadoop cluster and that will
utilize your cluster to run now you
could always as I said when you are
running a particular job remember to
change the output directory and if you
would not want it to be processing a
single individual file you could also
point it to a directory that basically
means it will have multiple files and
depending on the file sizes there would
be multiple splits and according to that
multiple map tasks will be selected so
if I click on this this would submit my
second application to the cluster which
should first connect to resource manager
then resource manager has to start an
application Master now here we are
targeting 10 splits now you have to
sometimes give couple of seconds in your
machines so that the resources which
were used are internally already freed
up so that your cluster can pick it up
and then your yarn can take care of
resources so right now my application is
an undefined status but then as soon as
my yarn provides it the resources we
will have the application running on our
yarn cluster so it has already started
if you see it is going further then it
would launch 10 map tasks and it would
the number of reduced tasks would be
decided on either the way your data is
or based on the properties which have
been set at your cluster level let's
just do a quick refresh here on my yarn
UI to show me the progress also take
care that when you are submitting your
application you need to have the output
directory mentioned however to not
create it Hadoop will create that for
you now this is how you run a map reduce
without specifying properties but then
you can specify more properties you can
look into what are the things which can
be changed for your mapper and reducer
or basically having a combiner class
which can do a mini reducing and all
those things can be done so we will
learn about that in the later sessions
now we will compare Hadoop version one
that is with mapreduce version one we
will understand and learn about the
limitations of Hadoop version 1 what is
the need of yarn what is yarn what kind
of workloads can be running on yarn what
are yarn components what is yarn
architecture and finally we will see a
demo on yarn so Hadoop version 1 or
mapreduce version one well that's
outdated now and nobody is using Hadoop
version one but it would be good to
understand what was in Hadoop version 1
and what were the limitations of Hadoop
version 1 which brought in the thought
for the future processing layer that is
yarn now when we talk about Hadoop we
already know that Hadoop is a framework
and Hadoop has two layers one is your
storage layer that is your hdfs Hadoop
distributed file system which allows for
distribute grid storage and processing
which allows fault tolerance by inbuilt
replication and which basically allows
you to store huge amount of data across
multiple commodity machines when we talk
about processing we know that map reduce
is the oldest and the most mature
processing programming model which
basically takes care of your data
processing on your distributed file
system so in Hadoop version 1 mapreduce
performed both data processing and
resource management and that's how it
was problematic in mapreduce we had
basically when we talk about the
processing layer we had the master which
was called job tracker and then you had
the slaves which were the task records
so your job tracker was taking care of
allocating resources it was performing
scheduling and even monitoring the jobs
it basically was taking care of
assigning map and reduced tasks to the
jobs running on task trackers and tasks
crackers which were co-located with data
nodes who are responsible for processing
the jobs so task trackers were the
slaves for the processing layer which
reported their progress to the job
tracker so this is what was happening in
Hadoop version one now when we talk
about Hadoop version 1 we would have say
client machines or an API or an
application which basically submits the
job to the master that is job tracker
now obviously we cannot forget that
there would already be an involvement
from name node which basically tells
which are the machines or which are the
data nodes where the data is already
stored now once the job submission
happens to the job tracker job tracker
being the master demon for taking care
of your processing request and also
resource management job scheduling would
then be interacting with your multiple
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines so each machine would
have a task tracker running and that
task tracker which is a processing slave
would be co-located with the data nodes
now we know that in case of Hadoop you
have the concept of moving the
processing to wherever the data is
stored rather than moving the data to
the processing layer so we would have
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines and these Stars
trackers would be responsible for
handling the tasks what are these tasks
these are the application which is
broken down into smaller tasks which
would work on the data which is
respectively stored on that particular
node now these were your slave demons
right so your job tracker was not only
tracking the resources so your task
trackers were sending heartbeats they
were sending in packets and information
to the job tracker which would then be
knowing how many resources and when we
talk about resources we are talking
about the CPU course we are talking
about the ram which would be available
on every node so task trackers would be
sending in their resource information to
job tracker and your job tracker would
be already aware of what amount of
resources are available on a particular
node how loaded a particular node is
what kind of work could be given to the
task tracker so job tracker was taking
care of resource management and it was
also breaking the application into tasks
and doing the job scheduling part assign
different tasks to these slave domains
that is your task trackers so job
tracker was eventually overburdened
right because it was managing jobs it
was tracking the resources from multiple
task trackers and basically it was
taking care of job scheduling so job
tracker would be overburdened and in a
case if job tracker would fail then it
would affect the overall processing so
if the master is skilled if the master
demand dies then the processing cannot
proceed now this was one of the
limitations of Hadoop person one 1 so
when you talk about scalability that is
the capability to scale due to a single
job tracker scalability would be hitting
a bottleneck you cannot have a cluster
size of more than 4000 nodes and cannot
run more than 40 000 concurrent tasks
now that's just a number we could always
look into the individual resources which
each machine was having and then we can
come up with an appropriate number
however with a single job tracker there
was no horizontal scalability for the
processing layer because we had single
processing Master now when we talk about
availability job tracker as I mentioned
would be a single point of failure now
any failure kills all the queued and
running jobs and jobs would have to be
resubmitted now why would we want that
in a distributed platform in a cluster
which has hundreds and thousands of
machines we would want a processing
layer which can handle huge amount of
processing which could be more scalable
which could be be more available and
could handle different kind of workloads
when it comes to resource utilization
now if you would have a predefined
number of map and reduced slots for each
task tracker you would have issues which
would relate to resource utilization and
that again is putting a burden on the
master which is tracking these resources
which has to assign jobs which can run
on multiple machines in parallel so
limitations in running non mapreduce
applications now that was one more
limitation of Hadoop version 1 and
mapreduce that the only kind of
processing you could do is mapreduce and
mapreduce programming model although it
is good it is oldest it has matured over
a period of time but then it is very
rigid you will have to go for mapping
and reducing approach and that was the
only kind of processing which could be
done in Hadoop version one so when it
comes to doing a real-time analysis or
doing ad hoc query or doing a graph
based processing or massive parallel
processing there were limitations
because that could not be done in Hadoop
person 1 which was having mapreduce
version 1 as the processing component
now that brings us to the need for yarn
so yarn it stands for yet another
resource negotiator so as I mentioned
before yarn in Hadoop version one well
you could have applications which could
be written in different programming
languages but then the only kind of
processing which was possible was
mapreduce we had the storage layer we
had the processing but then kind of
limit processing which could be done now
this was one thing which brought in a
thought that why shouldn't we have a
processing layer which can handle
different kind of workloads as I
mentioned might be graph processing
might be real-time processing might be
massive parallel processing or any other
kind of processing which would be a
requirement of an organization now
designed to run mapreduce jobs only and
having issues in scalability resource
utilization job tracking Etc that led to
the need of something what we call as
yarn now from Hadoop version 2 onwards
we have the two main layers have changed
a little bit you have the storage layer
which is intact that is your sdfs and
then you have the processing layer which
is called ya yet another resource
negotiator now we will understand how
yarn works but then yarn is taking care
of your processing layer it does support
mapreduce So mapreduce processing can
still be done but then now you can have
a support to other processing Frameworks
yarn can be used to solve the issues
which Hadoop version 1 was posing
something like Resource Management
something like different kind of
workload processing something like
scalability resource utilization all
that is now taken care by yarn now when
we talk about yarn we can have now a
cluster size of more than 10 000 nodes
and can run more than 100 000 concurrent
tasks that's just to take care of your
scalability when you talk about
compatibility applications which were
developed for Hadoop version 1 which
were primarily mapreduce kind of
processing can run on yarn without any
disruption or availability issues when
you talk about resource utilization
there is a mechanism which takes care of
dynamic allocation of cluster resources
and this basically improves the resource
utilization when we talk about multi
tenancy so basically now the cluster can
handle different kind of workloads so
you can use open source and proprietary
data access engines you can perform
real-time analysis you can be doing
graph processing you can be doing ad hoc
querying and this can be supported for
multiple workloads which can run in
parallel so this is what yarn offers so
what is Yan as I mentioned yarn stands
for yet another resource negotiator so
it is the cluster Resource Management
layer for your Apache Hadoop ecosystem
which takes care of scheduling jobs and
assigning resources now just imagine
when you would want to run a particular
application you would basically be
telling the cluster that I would want
resources to run my applications that
application might be a mapreduce
application that might be a hive query
which is triggering a mapreduce that
might be a pick script which is
triggering a mapreduce that could be
Hive with days as in execution Engine
That Could Be a spark application that
could be a graph processing application
in any of these cases you would still
you as in in sense client or basically
an API or the application would be
requesting for resources yarn would take
care of that so yarn would provide the
desired resources now when we talk about
resources we are mainly talking about
the network related resources we are
talking about the CPU cores or as in
terms of yarn we say virtual CPU course
we will talk about Ram that is in GB or
MB or in terabytes which would be
offered from multiple machines and Yan
would take care of this so with yarn you
could basically handle different
workloads now these are some of the
workloads which are showing up here you
have the traditional mapreduce which is
mainly batch oriented you could have an
interactive execution engine something
as days you would have H base which is a
column oriented or a four dimensional
database and that would be not only
storing data on sdfs but would also need
some kind of processing you could have
streaming functionalities which would be
from storm or Kafka or spark you could
have graph processing you could have
in-memory processing such as spark and
its components and you could have many
others so these are different Frameworks
which could now run and which can run on
top of yarn so how does yarn do that now
when we talk about yarn this is how a
overall yarn architecture looks so at
one end you have the client now client
could be basically your Edge node where
you have some applications which are
running it could be an API which would
want to interact with your cluster it
could be a user triggered application
which wants to run some jobs which are
doing some processing so this client
would submit a job request now what is
resource manager doing this Source
manager is the master of your processing
layer in Hadoop version 1 we basically
had job tracker and then we had task
trackers which were running on
individual nodes so your task trackers
were sending your heartbeats to the job
tracker your task trackers were sending
it their resource information and job
tracker was the one which was tracking
the resources and it was doing the job
scheduling and that's how as I mentioned
earlier job tracker was overburdened so
job tracker is now replaced by your
resource manager which is the master for
your processing layer your task trackers
are replaced by node managers which
would be then running on every node and
we have a temporary demon which you see
here in blue and that's your app master
so this is what we mentioned when we say
yet another resource negotiator so App
Master would be existing in a Hadoop
version now when we talk about your
resource manager resource manager is the
master for processing layer so it would
already be receiving heartbeats and you
can say resource information from
multiple node managers which would be
running on one or multiple machines and
these node managers are not only
updating their status but they are also
giving an information of the amount of
resources they have now when we talk
about resources we should understand
that if I'm talking about this node
manager then this has been allocated
some amount of RAM for processing and
some amount of CPU cores and that is
just a portion of what the complete node
has so if my node has say imagine my
node has around 100 GB RAM and I have
saved 60 cores all of that cannot be
allocated to node manager so node
manager is just one of the components of
of Hadoop ecosystem it is the slave of
the processing layer so we could say
keeping in all the aspects such as
different Services which are running
might be Cloud era or hot and works
related Services running system
processes running on a particular node
some portion of this would be assigned
to node manager for processing so we
could say for example say 60 GB Ram per
node and say 40 CPU cores so this is
what is allocated for the node manager
on every machine similarly we would have
here similarly we would have here so
node manager is constantly giving an
update to resource manager about the
resources what it has probably there
might be some other applications running
and node manager is already occupied so
it gives an update now we also have a
concept of containers which is basically
we will we will talk about which is
about these resources being broken down
into smaller parts so resource manager
is keeping a track of the resources
which every node manager has and it is
also responsible for taking care of the
job request how do these things happen
now as we see here resource manager at a
higher level you can always say this is
the processing Master which does
everything but in reality it is not the
resource manager which is doing it but
it has internally different services or
components which are helping it to do
what it is supposed to do now let's look
further now as I mentioned your resource
manager has these services or components
which basically helps it to do the
things it is basically a an architecture
where multiple components are working
together to achieve what yarn allows so
resource manager has mainly two
components that is your scheduler an
applications manager and these are at
high level four main components here so
we talk about resource manager which is
the processing Master you have node
managers which are the processing slaves
which are running on every nodes you
have the concept of container and you
have the concept of application Master
how do all these things work now let's
look at yarn components so resource
manager basically has two main
components you can say which assist
resource manager in doing what it is
capable of so you have scheduler and
applications manager now there is when
you talk about resources there is always
a requirement for the applications which
need to run on cluster of resources so
your application which has to run which
was submitted by client needs resources
and these resources are coming in from
multiple machines where ever the
relevant data is stored and a node
manager is running so we always know
that node manager is co-located with
data nodes now what does the scheduler
do so we have different kind of
schedulers here we have basically a
capacity scheduler we have a fair
scheduler or we could have a fee for
scheduler so there are different
schedulers which take care of resource
allocation so your scheduler is
responsible for allocating resources to
various running applications now imagine
a particular environment where you have
different teams or different departments
which are working on the same cluster so
we would call the cluster as a
multi-tenant cluster and on the
multi-terrent cluster you would have
different applications which would want
to run simultaneously accessing the
resources of the cluster how is that
managed so there has to be some
component which has a concept of pooling
or queuing so that different departments
or different users can get dedicated
resources or can share resources on the
cluster so scheduler is responsible for
allocating resources to various running
applications now it does not perform
monitoring or tracking of the status of
applications that's not the part of
scheduler it does not offer any
guarantee about restarting the failed
tasks due to Hardware or network or any
other failures scheduler is mainly
responsible for allocating resources now
as I mentioned you could have different
kind of schedulers you could have a fifo
scheduler which was mainly in older
version of Hadoop which stands for first
in first out you could have a fair
scheduler which basically means multiple
applications could be running in the
cluster and they would have a fair share
of the resources you could have a
capacity scheduler which would basically
have dedicated or fixed amount of
resources across the cluster now
whichever scheduler is being used
scheduler is mainly responsible for
allocating resources then it's your
applications manager now this is
responsible for accepting job
submissions now as I said at higher
level we could always say resource
manager stay doing everything it is
allocating the resources it is
negotiating the resources it is also
taking care of listening to the clients
and taking care of job submissions but
who is doing it in real it is these
components so you have applications
manager which is responsible for
accepting job submissions it negotiates
the first container for executing the
application specific application Master
it provides the service for restarting
the application Master now how does this
work how do these things happen in
coordination now as I said your node
manager is the slave process which would
be running on every machine slave is
track talking the resources what it has
it is tracking the processes it is
taking care of running the jobs and
basically it is tracking each container
resource utilization so let's understand
what is this container so normally when
you talk about a application request
which comes from a client so let's say
this is my client which is requesting or
which is coming up with an application
which needs to run on the cluster now
this application could be anything it
first contacts your master that's your
resource manager which is the master for
your processing layer now as I mentioned
and as we already know that your name
node which is the master of your cluster
has the metadata in its Ram which is
aware of the data being split into
blocks the blocks when stored on
multiple machines and other information
so obviously there was a interaction
with the master which has given this
information of the relevant nodes where
the data exists now for the processing
need your client basically the
application which needs to run on the
cluster so your resource manager which
basically has the scheduler which takes
care of allocating resources and
resource manager has mainly these two
components which are helping it to do
its work now for a particular
application which might be needing data
from multiple machines now we know that
we would have multiple machines where we
would have node manager running we would
have a data node running and data nodes
are responsible for storing the data on
disk so your resource manager has to
negotiate the resources now when I say
negotiating the resources it could
basically ask each of these node
managers for some amount of resources
for example it would be saying can I
have one GB of RAM and one CPU core from
you because there is some data residing
on your machine and that needs to be
processed as part of my application can
I again have 1GB and one CPU core from
you and this is again because some
relevant data is stored and this request
which resource manager makes of holding
the resources of total resources which
the node manager has your resource
manager is negotiating or is asking for
resources from the processing slave so
this request of holding resources can be
considered as a container so resource
manager now we know it is not actually
the resource manager but it is the
application manager which is negotiating
the resources so it negotiates the
resources which are called containers so
this request of holding resource can be
considered as a container so basically a
container can be of different sizes we
will talk about that so resource manager
negotiates the resources with node
manager now node manager which is
already giving an update of the
resources it has what amount of
resources it holds how much busy it is
can basically approve or deny this
request so node manager would basically
approve in saying yes I could hold these
resources I could give you this
container of this particular size now
once the container has been approved or
allocated or you can say granted by your
node manager resource manager now knows
that resources to process the
application are available and guaranteed
by the node manager so resource manager
starts a temporary demon called App
Master so this is a piece of code which
would also be running in one of the
containers it would be running in one of
the containers which would then take
care of execution of tasks in other
containers so your application Master is
per application so if I would have 10
different applications coming in from
the client then we would have 10 app
Masters one app Master being responsible
for per application now what does this
app Master do it basically is a piece of
code which is responsible for execution
of the application so your app Master
would run in one of the containers and
then it would use the other containers
which node manager is guaranteed that it
will give when the request application
request comes to it and using these
containers the App Master will run the
processing tasks Within These designated
resources so it is mainly the
responsibility of application Master to
get the execution done and then
communicate related to the Masters so
resource manager is tracking the
resources it is negotiating the
resources and once the resources have
been negotiated it basically gives the
control to application Master
application Master is then running
within one of the containers on one of
the nodes and using the other containers
to take care of execution this is how it
looks so basically container as I said
is a collection of resources like CPU
memory your disk which would be used or
which already has the data and network
so your node manager is basically
looking into the request from
application master and it basically is
granting this request or basically is
allocating these containers now again we
could have different sizing of the
containers let's take an example here so
as I mentioned from the total resources
which are available for a particular
node some portion of resources are are
allocated to the node manager so let's
imagine this is my node where node
manager has a processing slave is
running so from the total resources
which the node has some portion of RAM
and CPU cores is basically allocated to
the node manager so I could say out of
total 100 GB Ram we can say around 60
cores which the particular node has so
this is my Ram which the node has and
these are the CPU cores which the node
has some portion of it right so we can
say might be 70 or 60 percent of the
total resources so we could say around
60 GB RAM and then we could say around
40 V cores have been allocated to node
manager so there are these settings
which are given in the yarn hyphen site
file now apart from this allocation that
is 60 GB RAM and 40v cores we also have
some properties which say what will be
the container sizes so for example we
could have a small container setting
which could say my every container could
have 2GB RAM and say one virtual CPU
core so this is my smallest container So
based on the total resources you could
calculate how many such small containers
could be running so if I say 2GB Ram
then I could have around 30 containers
but then I'm talking about one virtual
CPU core so totally I could have around
30 small containers which could be
running in parallel on a particular node
and as of that calculation you would say
10 CPU cores are not being utilized you
could have a bigger container size which
could say I would go for two CPU cores
and 3gb RAM so 3gb RAM and 2 CPU cores
so that would give me around 20
containers of bigger size so this is the
container sizing which is again defined
in the yarn hyphen site file so what we
know is on a particular node which has
this kind of allocation either we could
have 30 small containers running or we
could have 20 big containers running and
same would apply to multiple nodes so
node manager based on the request from
application Master can allocate these
containers now remember it is within
this one of these containers you would
have an application Master running and
other containers could be used for your
processing requirement application
Master which is per application it is
the one which uses these resources it
basically manages or uses these
resources for individual application so
remember if we have 10 applications
running on yarn then it would be 10
application Masters one responsible for
each application your application Master
is the one which also interacts with the
scheduler to basically know how much
amount of resources could be allocated
for one application and your application
Master is the one which uses these
resources but it can never negotiate for
more resources to node Manager
application Masters cannot do that
application master has to always go back
to resource manager if it needs more
resources so it is always the resource
manager and internally resource manager
component that is application manager
which negotiates the resources at any
point of time due to some node failures
or due to any other requirements if
application Master needs more resources
on one or multiple nodes it will always
be contacting the resource manager
internally the applications manager for
more
now this is how it looks so your client
submits the job request to resource
manager now we know that resource
manager internally has scheduler an
applications manager node managers which
are running on multiple machines are the
ones which are tracking their resources
giving this information to the source
manager so that resource manager or I
would say its component applications
manager could request resources from
multiple node managers when I say
request resources it is these containers
so your resource manager basically will
request for the resources on one or
multiple nodes node manager is the one
which approves these containers and once
the container has been approved your
resource manager triggers a piece of
code that is application Master which
obviously needs some resources so it
would run in one of the containers and
will use other containers to do the
execution so your client submits an
application to resource manager resource
manager allocates a container or I would
say this is at a high level right
resource manager is negotiating the
resources and internally who is
negotiating the resources it is your
applications manager who is granting
this request it is node manager and
that's how we can say resource manager
allocates a container application Master
basically contacts the related node
manager because it needs to use the
containers node manager is the one which
launches the container or basically
gives those resources within which an
application can run an application
Master itself will then accommodate
itself in one of the containers and then
use other containers for the processing
and it is within these containers the
actual execute happens now that could be
a map task that could be a reduced task
that could be a spark executor taking
care of smart tasks and many other
processing
so before we look into the demo on how
yarn works I would suggest looking into
one of the blogs from cloud era so you
can just look for yarn untangling and
this is really a good blog which
basically talks about the overall
functionality which I explained just now
so as we mentioned here so you basically
have the master process you have the
worker process which basically takes
care of your processing your resource
manager being the master and node
manager being the slave this also talks
about the resources which each node
manager has it talks about the yarn
configuration file where you give all
these properties it basically shows you
node manager which reports the amount of
resources it has to resource manager now
remember if worker node shows 18 to 8
CPU cores and 128 GB RAM and if your
node manager says 64 week course and RAM
128gb then that's not the total capacity
of your node it is some portion of your
node which is allocated to node manager
now once your node manager reports that
your resource manager is requesting for
containers based on the application what
is the container it is basically a
logical name given to a combination of
vcore and RAM it is within this
container where you would have basically
the process running so once your
application starts and once node manager
is guaranteed these containers your
application or your resource manager has
basically already started an application
Master within the container and what
does that application Master do it uses
the other containers where the tasks
would run so this is a very good blog
which you can refer to and this also
talks about mapreduce if you have
already followed the map reduce
tutorials in past then you would know
about the different kind of tasks that
is map and reduce and these map and
reduce tasks could be running within the
container in one or multiple as I said
it could be map task it could be reduced
task it could be a spark based task
which would be running within the
container now once the task finishes
basically that resources can be freed up
so the container is released and the
resources are given back to yarn so that
it can take care of further processing
if you'll further look in this blog you
can also look into the part two of it
where you talk mainly about
configuration settings you can always
look into this which talks about why and
how much resources are allocated to the
node manager it basically talks about
your operating system overhead it talks
about other services it talks about
Cloudera or hortonworks related Services
running and other processes which might
be running and based on that some
portion of RAM and CPU cores would be
allocated to node manager so that's how
it would be done in the yarn hyphen site
file and this basically shows you what
is the total amount of memory and CPU
cores which is allocated to node manager
then within every machine where you have
a node manager running on every machine
in the yarn hyphen site file you would
have such properties which would say
what is the minimum container size what
is the maximum container size in terms
of ram what is the minimum for CPU cores
what is the maximum for CPU cores and
what is the incremental size in where
RAM and CPU cores can increment so these
are some of the properties which Define
how containers are allocated for your
application request so have a look at
this and this could be a good
information which talks about different
properties now you can look further
which talks about scheduling if you look
in this particular blog which also talks
about scheduling where it talks about
scheduling in yarn which talks about
Fair scheduler or you basically having
different cues in which allocations can
be done you also have different ways in
which queues can be managed and
different schedulers can be used so you
can always look at this series of blog
you can also be checking for yarn
schedulers and then search for uh
definitive guide and that could give you
some information on how it looks when
you look for Hadoop definitive guide so
if you look into this book which talks
about the different resources as I
mentioned so you could have a fee for
scheduler that is first in first out
which basically means if a long running
application is submitted to the cluster
all other small running applications
will have to wait there is no other way
but that would not be a preferred option
if you look in V4 scheduler if you look
for capacity scheduler which basically
means that you could have different
queues created and those queues would
have resources allocated so then you
could have a production queue where
production jobs are running in a
particular queue which has fixed amount
of resources allocated you could have a
development queue where development jobs
are running and both of them are running
in parallel you could then also look
into Fair scheduler which basically
means again multiple applications could
be running on the cluster however they
would have a fair share so when I say
fair share in brief what it means is if
I had given 50 percent of resources to a
queue for production and 50 percent of
resources for a queue of development and
if both of them are running in parallel
then they would have access to 50
percent of cluster resources however if
one of the queue is unutilized then
second queue can utilize all cluster
resources so look into the fair
scheduling part it also shows you about
how allocations can be given and you can
learn more about schedulers and how
queues can be used for managing multiple
applications now we will spend some time
in looking into few ways or few quick
ways in interacting with yarn in the
form of a demo to understand and learn
on how yarn works we can look into a
particular cluster now here we have a
the designated cluster which can be used
you could be using the similar kind of
commands on your Apache based cluster or
a Cloudera quick start VM if you already
have or if you have a cloud era or a hot
and works cluster running there are
different ways in which we can interact
with yarn and we can look at the
information one is basically looking
into the admin console so if I would
look into Cloudera manager which is
basically an admin console for a
cloudera's distribution of Hadoop
similarly you could have a hortonworks
cluster then access to the admin console
so if you have even read access for your
cluster and if you have the admin
console then you can search for yarn as
a service which is running you can click
on yarn as a service and that gives you
different tabs so you have the instances
which tells basically what are the
different roles for your yarn service
running so we have here multiple node
managers now some of them show in stop
status but that's nothing to worry so we
have three and six node managers we have
resource manager which is one but then
that can also be in a high availability
where you can have active and standby
you also have a job history server which
would show you the applications once
they have completed now you can look at
the yarn configurations and as I was
explaining you can always look for the
properties which are related to the
allocation so you can here search for
course and that should show you the
properties which talk about the
allocations so here if we see we can be
looking for yarn App mapreduce
application Masters resource CPU course
what is the CPU course allocated for
mapreduce map task reduce task you can
be looking at yarn node manager resource
CPU course which basically says every
node manager on every node would be
along it with 6 CPU cores and the
container sizing is with minimum
allocation of one CPU core and the
maximum could be two CPU cores similarly
you could also be searching for memory
allocation and here you could then
scroll down to see what kind of memory
allocation has been done for the node
manager so if we look further it should
give me information of node manager
which basically says here that the
container minimum allocation is 2GB the
maximum is 3gb and we can look at node
manager which has been given 25 GB per
node so it's a combination of this
memory and CPU cores which is the total
amount of resources which have been
allocated to every node manager now we
can always look into applications tab
that would show us different
applications which are submitted on yarn
for example right now we see there is a
spark application running which is
basically a user who is using spark
shell which has triggered a application
on spark and that is running on yarn you
can look at different applications
workload information you can always do a
search based on the number of days how
many applications have run and so on you
can always go to the web UI and you can
be searching for the resource manager
web UI and if you have access to that it
will give you overall information of
your cluster so this basically says that
here we have 100 GB memory allocated so
that could be say 25 GB per node and if
we have four node managers running and
we have 24 cores which is six cores per
node if we look further here into nodes
I could get more information so this
tells me that I have four node managers
running and node managers basically have
25 GB memory allocated per node and 6
cores out of which some portion is being
utilized we can always look at the
scheduler here which can give us
information what kind of scheduler has
been allocated so we basically see that
there is just a root q and within root
you have default queue and you have
basically users queue based on different
users we can always scroll here and that
can give us information if it is a fair
share so here we see that my root dot
default has 50 of resources and the
other queue also has 50 percent of
resources which also gives me an idea
that a fair scheduler is being used we
can always confirm that if we are using
a fair scheduler or a capacity scheduler
which takes care of allocation so search
for scheduler and that should give you
some understanding of what kind of
scheduler is being used and what are the
allocations given for that particular
scheduler so here we have Fair scheduler
it shows me you have under root you have
the root Q which has been given hundred
percent capacity and then you have
within that default which also takes
hundred percent so this is how you can
understand about yarn by looking into
the yarn web UI you can be looking into
the configurations you can look at
applications you can always look at
different actions now since we do not
have admin access the only information
we have is to download the client
configuration we can always look at the
history server which can give us
information of all the applications
which have successfully completed now
this is from your yarn UI what I can
also do is I can be going into Hue which
is the web interface and your web
interface also basically allows you to
look into the jobs so you can click on
Hue web UI and if you have access to
that it should show up or you should
have a way to get to your Hue which is a
graphical user interface mainly comes
with your Cloud era you can also
configure that with a Apache Hotel Works
has a different way of giving you the
web UI access you can click and get into
Hue and that is also one way where you
can look at yarn you can look at the
jobs which are running if there are some
issues with it and these these are your
web interfaces so either you look from
yarn web UI or here in Hue you have
something called as job browser which
can also give you information of your
different applications which might have
run so here I can just remove this one
which should basically give me a list of
all the different kind of jobs or
workflows which were run so either it
was a spark based application or it was
a map reduce or it was coming from hive
so here I have list of all the
applications and it says this was a map
reduce this was a spark something was
scaled something was successful and this
was basically a probably a hive query
which triggered a mapping reduce job you
can click on the application and that
tells you how many tasks were run for it
so there was a map task which ran for it
you can get into the metadata
information which you can obviously you
can also look from the yarn UI to look
into your applications which can give
you a detailed information of if it was
a map reduce how many map and reduce
tasks were run what were the different
counters if it was a spark application
it can let you follow through spark
history server or job history server so
you can always use the web UI to look
into the jobs you can be finding in a
lot of useful information here you can
also be looking at how many resources
were used and what happened to the job
was it successful did it fail and what
was the job status now apart from web UI
which always you might not have access
to so in a particular cluster in a
production cluster there might be
restrictions and the organization might
not have access given to all all the
users to graphical user interface like
you or might be you would not have
access to the cloud era manager or admin
console because probably organization is
managing multiple clusters using this
admin console so the one way which you
would have access is your web console or
basically your Edge node or client
machine from where you can connect to
the cluster and then you can be working
so let's log in here and now here we can
give different commands so this is the
command line from where you can have
access to different details you can
always check by just typing in mapred
which gives you different options where
you can look at the mapreduce related
jobs you can look at different queues if
there are queues configured you can look
at the history server or you can also be
doing some admin stuff provided you have
access so for example if I just say
mapred and queue here this basically
gives me an option says what would you
want to do would you want to list all
the cues do you want information on a
particular queue so let's try a list and
that should give you different cues
which were being used now here we know
that per user a queue dynamically gets
created which is under root dot users
and that gives me what is the status of
the queue what is the capacity has there
been any kind of maximum capacity or
capping done so we get to see a huge
list of cues which dynamically get
configured in this environment and then
you also look at your root dot default I
could have also picked up one particular
queue and I could have said show me the
jobs so I could do that now here we can
also give a yarn command so let me just
clear the screen and I will say yarn and
that shows me different options so apart
from your web interface something like
web UI apart from your Yarns web UI you
could also be looking for an information
using yarn commands here so these are
some list of commands which we can check
now you can just type in yarn and
version if you would want to see the
version which basically gives you
information of what is the Hadoop
version being used and what is the
vendor specific distribution version so
here we see we are working on cloudera's
distribution 5.14 which is internally
using Hadoop 2.6 now similarly you can
be doing a yarn application list so if
you give this that could be an
exhaustive list of all the applications
which are running or applications which
have completed so here we don't see any
applications because right now probably
there are no applications which are
running it also shows you you could be
pulling out different status such as
submitted accepted or running now you
could also say I would want to see the
services that I've finished running so I
could say yarn application list and app
States as say
so here we could be using our Command so
I could say yarn application list and
then I would want to see the app states
which gives me the applications which
have finished and we would want to list
all the applications which finished now
there that might be applications which
succeeded right and there is a huge list
of application which is coming in from
the history server which is basically
showing you the huge list of
applications which have completed so
this is one way and then you could also
be searching for one particular
application if you would want to search
a particular application if you have the
application ID you could always be doing
a grip that's a simple way I could say
basically let's pick up this one and if
I would want to search for this if I
would want more details on this I could
obviously do that by calling in my
previous command and you could do a grip
if that's what you want to do and if you
would want to search is there an
application which is in the list of my
applications that shows my application I
could pull out more information about my
application so I could look at the log
files for a particular application by
giving the application ID so I could say
yarn logs now that's an option and every
time anytime you have a doubt just hit
enter it will always give you options
what you need to give with a particular
command so I can say yarn log
application ID now we copied an
application ID and we could just give it
here we could give other options like
app owner or if you would want to get
into the Container details or if you
would want to check on a particular node
now here I'm giving yarn logs and then
I'm pointing it to an application ID and
it says the log aggregation has not
completed might be this was might be
this was an application which was
triggered based on a particular
interactive cell or based on a
particular query so there is no log
existing for this particular application
you can always look at the status of an
application you can kill an application
so here you can be saying yarn yarn
application and then what would you want
to do with an application hit and enter
it shows you the different options so we
just tried app States you could always
look at the last one which says status
and then for my status I could be giving
my application ID so that tells me what
is the status of this application it
connects to the resource manager it
tells me what's the application ID what
kind of application it was who ran it
which was the queue where the job was
running what was the start and end time
what is the progress the status of it if
it is finished or if it has succeeded
and then it basically gives me also an
information of where the application
master was running it gives me the
information where you can find this job
details in history server if you are
interested in looking into it also gives
you a aggregate resource allocation
which tells how much GB memory and how
many core seconds it used so this is
basically looking out at the application
details now I could kill an application
if the application was already running I
could always do a yarn application minus
skill and then I could be giving my
application now I could try killing this
however it would say the application is
already finished if I had an application
running and if my application was
already given an application ID by The
Source manager I Could Just Kill it I
can also say yarn node list which would
give me a list of the node managers now
this is what we were looking from the
yarn web UI and we were pulling out the
information so we can get this and kind
of information from your command line
always remember and always try to be
well accustomed with the command line so
you can do various things from the
command line and then obviously you have
the web uis which can help you with a
graphical interface easily able to
access things now you could be also
starting the resource manager which we
would not be doing here because we are
already running in a cluster so you
could give a yarn resource manager you
could get the logs of resource manager
if you would want by giving yarn demin
so we can try that so you can say yarn
and then demon so it says it does not
find the demon so so you can give
something like this get level and here I
will have to give the node and the IP
address where you want to check the logs
of resource manager so you could be
giving this for which we will have to
then get into Cloudera manager to look
into the nodes and the IP address you
could be giving a command something like
this which basically gives you the level
of the log which you have and I got this
resource manager address from the web UI
now I can be giving in this command to
look into the demon log and it basically
says you would want to look at the
resource manager related log and you
have the log 4J which is being used for
logging the kind of level which has been
set as info which can again be changed
in the way you're logging the
information now you can try any other
commands also from yarn for example
looking at the yarn RM admin so you can
always do a yarn RM admin and this
basically gives you a lot of other
informations like refreshing the cues or
refreshing the nodes or basically
looking at the admin ACLS or getting
groups so you could always get group
names for a particular user now we could
search for a particular user such as
yarn or hdfs itself so I could just say
here I would want get groups and then I
could be searching for say username hdfs
so that tells me sdfs belongs to a
Hadoop group similarly you could search
for say mapred or you could search for
yarn so these are service related users
which automatically get created and you
can pull out information related to
these you can always do a refresh nodes
kind of command and that is mainly done
internally this can be useful when you
are doing commissioning decommissioning
but then in case of cloud
hortonworks kind of cluster you would
not be manually giving this command
because if you are doing a commissioning
decommissioning from an admin console
and if you are an administrator then you
could just restart the services which
are affected and that will take care of
this but if you were working in an
Apache cluster and if you were doing
commissioning decommissioning then you
would be using in two commands refresh
notes and basically that's for
refreshing the nodes which should not be
used for processing and similarly you
could have a command refresh notes which
comes with stfs so these are different
options which you can use with your yarn
on the command line you could also be
using curl commands to get more
information about your cluster by giving
curl minus X and then basically pointing
out to your Source manager web UI
address now here I would like to print
out the cluster related metrics and I
could just simply do this which
basically gives me a high level
information of how many applications
were submitted how many are pending what
is the reserved resources what is the
available amount of memory or CPU cores
and all the information similarly you
can be using the same curl commands to
get more information like scheduler
information so you would just replace
the metrics with scheduler and you could
get the information of the different
queues now that's a huge list we can
cancel this and that would give me the
list of all the queues which are
allocated and what are the resources
allocated for each queue you could also
get cluster information on application
IDs and Status running of applications
running in yarn so you would have to
replace the last bit of it and you would
say I would want to look at the
applications and that gives me a huge
list of applications then you can do a
grip and you can be filtering out
specific application related information
similarly you can be looking at the
notes so you can always be looking at
node specific information which gives
you how many nodes you have but this
could be mainly used when you have an
application which wants to or a web
application which wants to use a curl
command and would want to get
information about your cluster from an
HTTP interface now when it comes to
application we can basically try running
a simple or a sample mapreduce job which
could then be triggered on yarn and it
would use the resources now I can look
at my application here and I can be
looking into my specific directory which
is this one which should have a lot of
files and directories which we have here
now I could pick up one of these and I
could be using a simple example to some
processing let's take up this file so
there is a file and I could run a simple
word count or I could be running a hive
query which triggers a mapreduce job I
could even run a spark application which
would then show that the application is
running on the cluster so for example if
I would say spark to Shell now I know
that this is an interactive way of
working with spark but this internally
triggers a spark submit and this runs an
application so here when you do a spark
2 Shell by default it will contact yarn
so it gets an application ID it is
running on yarn with the master being
yarn and now I have access to the
interactive way of working with spark
now if I go and look into applications I
should be able to see my application
which has been started here and it shows
up here so this is my application
3827 which has been started on yarn and
as of now we can also look into the yarn
UI and that shows me the application
which has been started which basically
has one running container which has one
CPU core allocated 2GB RAM and it's in
progress although we are not doing
anything there so we can always look at
our applications from the yarn UI or as
I mentioned from your applications tab
within yarn Services which gives us the
information and you can even click on
this application to follow and see more
information but you should be given
access to that now this is just a simple
application which I triggered using
spark shell similarly I can basically be
running a map reduce now to run a map
reduce I can say Hadoop jar and that
basically needs a class so we can look
for the default path which is opt Cloud
era Parcels CDH lib Hadoop map reduce
Hadoop map reduce examples and then we
can look at this particular our file and
if I hit on enter it shows me the
different classes which are part of this
jar and here I would like to use word
count so I could just give this I could
say word count now remember I could run
the job in a particular queue by giving
in an argument here so I could say minus
d mapred dot job dot Q dot name and then
I can point my job to a particular queue
I can even give different arguments in
saying I would want my mapreduce output
to be compressed or I want it to be
stored in a particular directory and so
on so here I have the word count and
then basically what I can be doing is I
can be pointing into a particular input
path and then I can have my output which
can be getting stored here again a
directory which we need to choose and I
will say output new and I can submit my
job now once I have submitted my job it
connects to resource manager it
basically gets a job ID it gets an
application ID it shows you from where
you can track your application you can
always go to the yarn UI and you can be
looking at your application and the
resources it is using so my application
was not a big one and it has already
completed it triggered one map task it
launched one reduce task it was working
on around 12 466 records where you have
then the output of map which is these
many number of output records which was
then taken by a combiner and finally by
a reducer which basically gives you the
output so this is my yarn application
which has completed now I could be
looking into the yarn UI and if my job
has completed you might not see your
application here so as of now it shows
up here the word count which I ran it
also shows me my previous Park shell job
it shows me my application is completed
and if you would want further
information on this you can click and go
to the history server if you have been
given access to it or directly go to the
history server web UI where your
application shows up it shows how many
map and reduce tasks it was running you
can click on this particular application
which basically gives you information of
your map and reduce tasks you can look
at different counters for your
application right you can always look at
map specific tasks you can always look
into one particular task what it did on
which node it was running or you can be
looking at the complete application log
so you can always click on the logs and
here you have click here for full log
which gives you the information and you
can always look for your application
which can give you information of App
Master being launched or you could have
search for the word container so you
could see a job which needs one or
multiple containers and then you could
say container is being requested then
you could see container is being
allocated then you can see what is the
container size and then basically your
task moves from initializing to running
in the container and finally you can
even search for release which will tell
you that the container was released so
you can always look into the log for
more information so this is how you can
interact with yarn this is how you can
interact with your command line to look
for more information or using your yarn
web UI or you can also be looking into
your Hue for more information welcome to
scoop tutorial one of the many features
of the Hadoop ecosystem for the Hadoop
file system what's in it for you today
we're going to cover the need for scoop
what is scoop scoop features scoop
architecture scoop import scoop export
scoop processing and then finally we'll
have a little Hands-On demo on Scoops
you can see what it looks like so where
does the need for scoop come in and our
big data Hadoop file system processing
huge volumes of data requires loading
data from diverse sources into Hadoop
cluster you can see here we have our
data processing and this process of
loading data from the heterogeneous
sources comes with a set of challenges
so what are the challenges maintaining
data consistency ensuring efficient
utilization of resources especially when
you're talking about big data we can
certainly use up the resources when
importing terabytes and petabytes of
data over the course of time loading
bulk data to Hadoop was not possible it
was one of the big challenges that came
up when they first had the Hadoop file
system going and loading data using
script was very slow in other words
you'd write a script in whatever
language you're in and then it would
very slowly load each piece and parse it
in so the solution scoop scooped helped
in overcoming all the challenges to
traditional approach and could lead bulk
data from rdbms to Hadoop very easily so
think your Enterprise server you want to
take the from MySQL or your SQL and you
want to bring that data into your dupe
Warehouse your data filing system and
that's where scoob comes in so what
exactly is scoop scoop is a tool used to
transfer bulk of data between Hadoop and
external data stores such as relational
databases and MySQL server or the
Microsoft SQL server or MySQL server so
scoop equals SQL plus Hadoop and you can
see here we have our rdbms all the data
we have stored on there and then your
scoop is the middle ground and brings
the import into the Hadoop file system
it also is one of the features that goes
out and grabs the data from Hadoop and
exports it back out into an rdbms let's
take a look at scoop features scoop
features has parallel Import and Export
it has import results of SQL query
connectors for all major rdbms databases
Kerberos security integration provides
full and incremental load so we look at
parallel Import and Export scoop uses
yarn yet another resource negotiator
framework to import an export data this
provides fault Tolerance on a top of
parallelism scoop allows us to import
the result return from an SQL carry into
the Hadoop file system or the hdfs and
you can see here where the import
results of SQL query come in school
provides connectors for multiple
relational database management system
rdbms's databases such as MySQL and
Microsoft SQL server and it has
connectors for all major rdbms databases
scoop supports Kerberos computer network
Authentication Protocol that allows
nodes communicating over a non-secure
network to prove their identity to one
another in a secure manner scoop can
load the whole table or parts of the
table by a single command hence it
supports full and incremental load let's
dig a little deeper into the scoop
architecture we have our client in this
case a hooded wizard behind his laptop
you never know who's going to be
accessing the Hadoop cluster and the
client comes in and sends their command
which goes into scoop the client submits
the import export command to import or
export data data from different
databases is fetched by scoop and so we
have our Enterprise data warehouse
document based systems you have connect
connector for your data warehouse a
connector for document based systems
which reaches out to those two entities
and we have our connector for the rdbms
so connectors help in working with a
range of popular databases multiple
mappers perform map tasks to load the
data onto hdfs the Hadoop file system
and you can see here we have the map
task if you remember from Hadoop Hadoop
is based on mapreduce because we're not
reducing the data we're just mapping it
over it only accesses the mappers and it
opens up multiple mappers to do parallel
processing and you can see here the hdfs
hbase hive is where the target is for
this particular one similarly multiple
map tests will export the data from hdfs
onto rdbms using scoop export command so
just like you can import it you can now
export it using the multiple routines
scoop import so here we have our dbms
data store and we have the folders on
there so maybe it's your company's
database maybe it's an archive at Google
with all the searches going on whatever
it is usually you think with scoop you
think SQL you think MySQL server or
Microsoft SQL Server that kind of setup
so it gathers the metadata and you see
the scoop import so introspect database
to gather metadata primary key
information and then it submits so you
can see submits map only job remember we
talked about mapreduce it only needs the
map side of it because we're not
reducing the data we're just mapping it
over scoop device the input data set
into splits and uses individual map
tests to push the splits into hdfs so
right into the Hadoop file system and
you can see down on the right is kind of
a small depiction of a Hadoop cluster
and then you have scoop export so we're
going to go the other direction and with
the other direction you have your Hadoop
file system storage which is your Hadoop
cluster you have your scoop job and each
one of those clusters then gets a map
mapper comes out to each one of the
computers it has data on it so the first
step is you've got to gather the
metadata so step one you gather the
metadata step two submits map only job
introspect database to gather metadata
primary key information scoop divides
the input data set into splits and uses
individual map tests to push the splits
to rdbms scoop will export Hadoop files
back to rdms tables you can think of
this in a number of different manners
one of them would be if you're restoring
a backup from the Hadoop file system
into your Enterprise machines there's
certainly many others as far as
exploring data and data science so as we
dig a little deeper into scoop input we
have our connect our jdbc and our URL so
specify the jdbc connect string
connecting manager we specify The
Connection Manager class to use you can
see here driver with the class name
manually specify the jdbc driver class
to use Hadoop mapreduce home directory
override Hadoop mapped home username set
authentication username and of course
help print uses instructions and with
the export you'll see that we can
specify the jdbc connect string specify
The Connection Manager class to use
manually specify jdbc driver class to
use you do have to let it know to
override the Hadoop map reduce home and
that's true on both of these and set
authentication username and finally you
can print out all your help setup so you
can see the format for scoop is pretty
straightforward both Import and Export
so let's uh continue on our path and
look at scoop processing and what the
computer goes through for that and we
talk about school processing first scoop
runs in the Hadoop cluster it Imports
data from the rdbms the nosql database
to the Hadoop file system so remember it
might not be importing the data from a
rdbms it might actually be coming from a
nosql and there's many out there it uses
mappers to slice the incoming data into
multiple form formats and load the data
into hdfs it exports data back into an
rdbms while making sure that the schema
of the data in the database is
maintained so now that we've looked at
the basic commands in our scoop in the
scoop processing or at least the basics
as far as theory is concerned let's just
jump in and take a look at a demo on
scoop
[Music]
for this demo I'm going to use our
clouderic quick start if you've been
watching our other demos we've done
you'll see that we've been using that
pretty consistently certainly this will
work in any of your your Horton sandbox
which is also a single node testing
machine Cloudera is one of um there's a
Docker version instead of virtual box
and you can also set up your own Hadoop
cluster plan a little extra time if
you're not an admin it's actually a
pretty significant Endeavor for an admin
if you've been admitting Linux machines
for a very long time and you know a lot
of the commands I find for most admins
it takes them about two to four hours
the first time they go in and create a
virtual machine and set up their own
Hadoop in this case though I mean you're
just learning and getting set up best to
start with Cloudera Cloudera also
includes an install version of MySQL
that way you don't have to worry install
the the SQL version for importing data
from and two once you're in the Cloudera
quick start you'll see it opens an AI
Centos Linux interface and it has a
desktop setup on there this is really
nice for learning so you're not just
looking at command lines and from in
here it should open up by default to Hue
if not you can click on Hue here's a
kind of a fun little web-based interface
under Hue I can go under query I can
pick an editor and we'll go right down
to scoop so now I'm just going to load
the scoop editor inner Hue now I'm going
to switch over and do this all in
command line I just want to show that
you can actually do this in a hue
through the web-based interface the
reason I like to do the command line is
specifically on my computer it runs much
quicker or if I do the command line here
and I run it it tends to have an extra
lag or an added layer in it so for this
we're going to go ahead and open our
command line the second reason I do this
is we're going to need to go ahead and
edit our MySQL so we have something to
scoop in other words I don't have
anything going in there and of course we
zoom in zoom in this and increase the
size of our screen so for the this demo
are Hands-On I'm going to use Oracle
virtualbox manager and the Cloudera
quick start if you're not familiar with
this we do have another tutorial we put
out and you can send a note in the
YouTube video below and let our team
know and they'll send you a link or come
visit
www.simpylearn.com now this creates a
Linux box on my Windows computer so
we're going to be in Linux and it'll be
the Cloudera version with scoop it will
also be using MySQL MySQL server once
inside the Cloudera virtual box we'll go
into the Hue editor now we're going to
do everything in terminal window but I
just want you to be aware that under the
Hue editor you can go under query editor
and you'll see as we come down here
here's our scoop on this so you can run
your Scoop from in here now before we do
this we have to do a little exploration
in my SQL and MySQL server that way we
know what data is coming in so let me go
ahead and open up a terminal window in
Cloudera you have a terminal window at
the top here that you can just click on
and open it up and let me just go ahead
and zoom here we'll go View and zoom in
now to get into my SQL Server you
typically type in MySQL and this part
will depend on your setup now the
Cloudera quick start comes up that the
username is root and the password is
Cloudera kind of a strange Quirk is that
you can put a space between the minus U
and the root but not between the minus p
and the Cloudera usually you'd put in a
minus capital P and then it prompts you
for your password on here for this demo
I don't worry too much about you knowing
the password on that so we'll just go
right into MySQL server since this is
the standard password for this quick
start and you can see we're now into
MySQL and we're going to do just a
couple of quick commands in here there's
show databases and you follow by the
semicolon that's standard in most of
these shell commands so it knows it's
the end of your shell command and you'll
see in here in the quick start Cloudera
quick start the MySQL comes with a
standard set of databases these are just
some of these have to do like with the
uzi which is the uzi part of Hadoop
where others of these like customers and
employees and stuff like that those are
just for demo purposes they come as a
standard setup in there so that people
going in for the first time have a
database to play with which is really
good for us so we don't have to recreate
those databases and you will see in the
list here we have a retail underscore DB
and then we can simply do uh use retail
underscore DB this will set that as a
default in MySQL and then we want to go
ahead and show the tables and if we show
the tables you can see under the
database the retail DB database we have
categories customers departments order
items orders products so there's a
number of tables in here and we're going
to go ahead and just use a standard SQL
command and if you did our Hive language
you'll note remember it's the same for
hql also on this we're just going to
select star everything from departments
so there's our departments table and
we're going to list everything on the
Departments table and you'll see we have
a six line in here and it has a
department ID and a department name two
for Fitness three for Footwear so on and
so forth now at this point I can just go
ahead and exit but it's kind of nice to
have this data up here so we can look at
it and flip back and forth between the
screens so I'm going to open up another
terminal window and we'll go ahead and
zoom in on this also and it isn't too
important for this particular setup but
it's always kind of fun to know what
your setup you're working with what is
your host name and so we'll go ahead and
just type that in this is a Linux
command and it's uh hostname minus F and
you see we're on quick start Cloudera no
surprise there now this next command is
going to be a little bit longer because
we're going to be doing our first scoop
command and I want to do two of them
we're going to list databases and list
tables it's going to take just a moment
to get through this because there's a
bunch of stuff going on here so we have
scoop we have list databases we have
connect and under the connect command we
need to let it know how we're connecting
we're going to use the jdbc this is a
very standard one jdbc MySQL so you'll
see that if you're doing an SQL database
that's how you start it off with and
then the next part this is where you
have to go look it up it's however it
was created so if your admin created a
MySQL server with a certain setup that's
what you have to go by and you'll see
that usually they list this as localhost
so you'll see something like localhost
sometimes there's a lot of different
formats but the most common is either
localhost or the actual connection so in
this case we want to go ahead and do
quick start
3306 and so quick start is the name of
the localhost database and how it's
hosted on here and when you set up the
quick start for for Hadoop under
Cloudera it's Port 3306 is where that's
coming in so that's where all that's
coming from and so there's our path for
that and then we have to put in our
password we typically type password if
you look it up password on the cloud era
quick start is Cloudera and we have to
also let it know the username and again
if you're doing this you'd probably put
in a minus Capital you can actually just
do it for a prompt Cloud for the
password so if you leave that out it'll
prompt you but for this doesn't really
matter I don't care if you see my
password it's the default one for
Cloudera quick start and then the
username on here is simply root and then
we're going to put our semicolon at the
end and so we have here our full setup
then we go ahead and list the databases
and you'll see you may get some warnings
on here I haven't run the updates on the
quick start I suggest you're not running
the updates either if you're doing this
for the first time because it'll do some
reformatting on there and it quickly
pops up and you can see here's all of
our the tables we went in there and if
we go back to on the previous window we
should see that these tables match so
here we come in and here we have our
databases and you can see back up here
where we had the CM customers employees
and so on so the databases match and
then we want to go ahead and list the
tables for a specific database so let's
go ahead and do that I'm a very lazy
typist so I'll put the up arrow in and
you can see here scoop list databases
we're just going to go back and change
this from databases to list tables so we
want to list the tables in here same
connection so most of the connection is
the same except we need to know which
tables we're listing an interesting fact
is you can create a table without being
under a database so if you left this
blank it will show the open tables that
aren't connected directly to a database
or under a database but what we want to
do is right past this last slash on the
33 306 we want to put that retail
underscore DB because that's the
database we're going to be working with
and this will go in there and show the
tables listed under that database and
here we go we got categories customers
departments order items and products if
we flip back here real quick there it is
the same thing we had we had categories
customers departments order items and so
on and so let's go ahead and run our
first import command and again I'm that
lazy typer so we're going to do scoop
and instead of list tables we want to go
ahead and import so there's our import
command and so once we have our import
command in there then we need to tell it
exactly what we're going to import so
everything else is the same we're
importing from the retail DB so we keep
that and then at the very end we're
going to tag on dash dash table that
tells it so we can tell it what table
we're importing from and we're going to
import departments there we go so this
is pretty straightforward because what's
nice about this is you can see the
commands are the same I got the same
connection might change it for the
whatever database I'm in then I come in
here our password and the username are
going to be the same that's all under
the MySQL server setup and then we let
it know what table we're entering in we
run this and this is going to actually
go through the mapper process in Hadoop
so this is a mapping process it takes
the data and it Maps it up to different
parts in the setup in Hadoop on there
and then saves that data into the Hadoop
file system and it does take it a moment
to zip through which I kind of skipped
over for you since it is running a you
know it's designed to run across the
cluster not on a single node so when
you're running on a single node it's
going to run slow even if you dedicate a
couple cores to it I think I put
dedicated four cores to this one and so
you can see right down here we get to
the end it's now mapped in that
information and then we can go in here
we can go under we can flip back to our
Hue and under Hue on the top I have
there's databases and the second icon
over is your Hadoop file system and we
can go in here and look at the Hadoop
file system and you'll see it show up
underneath our document insert as
departments Cloudera departments and you
can see there's always a delay when I'm
working in Hue which I don't like and
that's the quick start issue that's not
necessarily running out on a server when
I'm running it on a server you pretty
much have to run through some kind of
server interface I still prefer the
terminal window it still runs a lot
quicker but we'll flip back on over here
to the command line and we can do the
Hadoop type in the Hadoop fs and then
list minus LS and if we run this you'll
see underneath our Hadoop file system
there is our departments which has been
added in and we can also do Hadoop fs
and this is kind of interesting for
those who've gone through the Hadoop
file system everything you'll you'll
recognize this on here I'm going to list
it the contents of departments and
you'll see underneath departments we
have part part
m0001002003 and so this is interesting
because this is how Hadoop saves these
files this is in the file system this is
not in Hive so we didn't directly import
this into Hive we put this in the Hadoop
file system depending on what you're
doing you would then write the schema
for Hive to look at the Hadoop file
system certainly visit our Hive tutorial
for more information on hive specific uh
so you can see in here are different
files that it forms that are part of
departments and we can do something like
this we can look at the contents of one
of these files FS minus LS or a number
of the files and we'll simply do the
full path which is user Cloudera and
then we already know the next one is
departments and then after departments
we're going to put slash part star so
this is going to say anything that has
part in it so we have part Dash m000 and
so on we can go ahead and cat use that
cat command or that list command to
bring those up and then we can use the
cat command to actually display the
contents and that's a Linux command
Hadoop Linux command the catinate not to
be confused with catatonic catastrophic
there's a lot of cat got your tongue and
we see here Fitness Footwear apparel
that should look really familiar because
that's what we had in our MySQL server
when we went in here we did a select all
on here there it is Fitness Footwear
apparel golf outdoors and fan shop and
then of course it's really important
slip back on over here to be able to
tell it where to put the data so we go
back to our import command so here's our
scoop import we have our connect we have
the DB underneath our connection our
MySQL server we have our password our
username the table going where it's
going to I mean the table where it's
coming from and then we can add a Target
on here we can put in a Target Dash
directory and you do have to put the
full path that's a Hadoop thing it's a
good practice to be in and we're going
to add it to Department we'll just do
Department one and so here we now add a
Target directory in here in user
Cloudera Department one and this will
take just a moment before so I'll go
ahead and skip over the process since
it's going to run very slowly it's only
running on like I said a couple cores
and it's also on a single node and now
we can do the Hadoop let's just do the
up Arrow file system list we want just
straight list and when we do the Hadoop
file system minus LS or list you'll see
that we now have Department one and we
can of course do list Department one and
you can see we have the files inside
Department one and they mirrored what we
saw before with the same files in there
and the part mm0 and so on if we were to
look at him it'd be the same thing we
did before with the cat so except
instead of departments we'd be
Department one there we go one thing
that's going to come up with the same
data we had before now one of the
important things when you're importing
data and it's always a question to ask
is do you fill through the data before
it comes in do we want to filter this
data as it comes in so we're not storing
everything in our file system you would
think Hadoop Big Data put it all in
there I know from experience that
putting it all in there can turn a
couple hundred terabytes into a petabyte
very rapidly and suddenly you're having
to really add on to that data store and
you're storing duplicate data sometimes
so you really need to be able to filter
your data out and so let's go ahead and
use our up Arrow to go to our last
import since it's still a lot the same
stuff so we have all of our commands on
our import we have the target we're
going to change this to Department two
so we're going to create a new directory
for this one and then after departments
there's another command that we didn't
really slide in here and that's our
mapping and I'll show you what this
looks like in a minute we're going to
put M3 in there that doesn't have
nothing to do with the filtering I'll
show you that in a second though what
that's for and we just want to put in
where so where and what is the where in
this case we want to know where
Department ID and if you want to know
where that came from we can flip back on
over here we have Department underscore
IDs this is where that's coming from
that's just the name of the column on
here so we come in here to Department ID
is greater than four simple logic there
you can see where you'd use that for
maybe creating buckets for ages you know
age from 10 to 15 20 to 30. you might be
looking for I mean there's all kinds of
reasons why you could use the where
command on here in filter information
out maybe you're doing word counting and
you want to know words that are used
less than a hundred times you want to
get rid of the and is and and all the
stuff that's used over and over again so
we'll go ahead and put the where and
then Department ID is greater than four
we'll go ahead and hit enter on here and
this will create our department to set
up on this and I'll go ahead and skip
over some of the runtime again it runs
really slow on a single node a real
quick page through our commands
here we go our list and we should see
underneath the list the department two
on here now and there it is Department
two and then I can go ahead and do list
Department two you'll see the contents
in here and you'll see that there is
only three maps and it could be that the
data created three Maps but remember I
set it up to only use three mappers so
there's zero one and two and we can go
ahead and do a cat on there remember
this is Department two so we want to
look at all the contents of these three
different files and there it is it's
greater than four so we have golf is
five outdoor six uh fan shop is seven so
we've effectively filtered out our data
and just storing the data we want on our
file system so if you're going to store
data on here the next stage is to export
the data remember a lot of times you
have MySQL server and we're continually
dumping that data into our long-term
storage and access a Hadoop file system
but what happens when you need to pull
that data out and restore a database or
uh maybe you have um you just merged
with a new company a favorite topic
merging companies emerging databases
that's listed under Nightmare and how
many different names for company can you
have so you can see where being able to
export is also equally important and
let's go ahead and do that and I'm going
to flip back over to my SQL Server here
and we'll need to go ahead and create
our database we're going to export into
now I'm not going to go too much in
detail on this command we're simply
creating a table and the table is going
to have it's pretty much the same table
we already have in here from departments
but in this case we're going to create a
table called Dept so it's the same setup
but it's it's just gonna we're just
giving a different name a different
schema and so we've done that and we'll
go ahead and do a select star from Dept
there we go and it's empty that's what
we expect a new database a new data
table and it's empty in there so now we
need to go ahead and Export our data
that we just filtered out into there so
let's flip back on over here to our
scoop setup which is just our Linux
terminal window and let's go back up to
one of our commands here's scoop Import
in this case instead of import we're
going to take the scoop and we're going
to export so we're going to just change
that export and the connection is going
to remain the same so same connect same
database we're also we're still doing
the retail DB we have the same password
so none of that changes the big change
here is going to be the table instead of
departments remember we changed it and
gave it a new name and so we want to
change it here also Dept so Department
we're not going to worry about the
mapper count and the where was part of
our import there we go and then finally
it needs to know where to export from so
instead of Target directory we have an
export directory that's where it's
coming from still user Cloudera and
we'll keep it as Department two just so
you can see how that data is coming back
with the that we've filtered in and
let's go ahead and run this and I'll
take it just a moment to go through in
steps and again because it's slow I'm
just going to go ahead and skip this so
you don't have to sit through it and
once we've wrapped up our export we'll
flip back on over here to mySQL use the
up arrow and this time we're going to
select star from department and we can
see that there it is it exported the
golf outdoors and fan shop and you can
imagine also that you might have to use
the where command in your export also so
there's a lot of mixing the command line
for scoop is pretty straightforward
you're changing the different variables
in there whether you're creating a table
listing a table listing databases very
powerful tool for bringing your data
into the Hadoop file system and
exporting it so now that we've wrapped
up our demo on scoop and gone through a
lot of basic commands let's dive in with
a brief history of Hive so the history
of Hive begins with Facebook Facebook
begin using Hadoop as a solution to
handle the growing big data and we're
not talking about a data that fits on
one or two or even five computers where
are talking due to the fifth sign if
you've looked at any of our other Hadoop
tutorials you'll know we're talking
about very big data and data pools and
Facebook certainly has a lot of data it
tracks as we know the Hadoop uses map
reduce for processing data mapreduce
required users to write long codes and
so you have these really extensive Java
codes very complicated for the average
person to use not all users reversed in
Java and other coding languages this
proved to be a disadvantage for them
users were comfortable with writing
queries in SQL SQL has been around for a
long time the standard SQL query
language Hive was developed with a
vision to incorporate the concepts of
tables columns just like SQL so why Hive
well the problem was for processing and
analyzing data users found it difficult
to code as not all of them were well
versed with the coding languages if
you're processing if you're analyzing
and so the solution was required a
language similar to SQL which was well
known to all the users and thus the The
Hive or hql language evolved what is
Hive Hive is a data warehouse system
which is used for querying and analyzing
large data sets stored in the hdfs or
the Hadoop file system Hive uses a query
language that we call Hive ql or hql
which is similar to SQL so if we take
our user the user sends out their hive
queries and then that is converted into
a mapreduce tasks and then accesses the
Hadoop mapreduce system let's take a
look at the architecture of Hive
architecture of Hive we have the hive
client so that could be the programmer
or maybe it's a manager who knows enough
SQL to do a basic query to look up the
data they need the hive client supports
different types of client applications
in different languages prefer for
performing queries and so we have our
Thrift application in the hive Thrift
client Thrift is a software framework
Hive server is based on Thrift so it can
serve the request from all programming
language that support threat and then we
have our jdbc application and the hive
jdbc driver jdbc Java database
connectivity jdbc application is
connected through the jdbc driver and
then you have the odbc application or
the hive odbc driver the odbc or open
database connectivity the odbc
application is connected through the
odbc driver with the growing development
of all of our different scripting
languages python C plus plus spark Java
you can find just about any connection
in any of the main scripting languages
and so we have our Hive Services as we
look at deeper into the architecture
Hive supports various services so you
have your Hive server basically your
Thrift application or your hive Thrift
client or your jdbc or your hive jdbc
driver your odbc application or your
hive odbc driver they all Connect into
The Hive server and you have your hive
web interface you also have your CLI now
the hive web interface is a GUI is
provided to execute Hive queries and
we'll actually be using that later on
today so you can see kind of what that
looks like and get a feel for what that
means commands are executed directly in
CLI and then the CLI is a direct
terminal window and I'll also show you
that too so you can see how those two
different interfaces work these then
push the code into the hive driver Hive
driver is responsible for all the
queries submitted so everything goes
through that driver let's take a closer
look at the hive driver The Hive driver
now performs three steps internally one
is a compiler Hive driver passes query
to compiler where it is checked and
analyzed then the optimizer kicks in and
the optimized logical plan in the form
of a graph of mapreduce and hdfs tasks
is obtained and then finally in the
executor in the final step the tasks are
executed when we look at the
architecture we also have to note the
metastore metastore is a repository for
five metadata stores metadata for Hive
tables and you can think of this as your
schema and where is it located and it's
stored on the Apache Derby DB processing
and resource management is all handled
by the map reduce V1 you'll see
mapreduce V2 the yarn and the tests
these are all different ways of managing
these resources depending on what
version of Hadoop you're in Hive uses
mapreduce framework to process queries
and then we have our distributed storage
which is the hdfs and if you looked at
our Hadoop tutorials you'll know that
these are on commodity machines and are
linearly scalable that means they're
very affordable a lot of time when
you're talking about Big Data you're
talking about a tenth of the price of
storing it on Enterprise computers and
then we look at the data flow And Hive
so in our data flow in Hive we have our
Hive in the Hadoop system and underneath
the user interface or the UI we have our
driver our compiler our execution engine
and our metastore that all goes into the
map reduce and the Hadoop file system so
we execute a query and see it coming in
here it goes into the driver step one
step two we get a plan what are we going
to do refers to the query execution then
we go to the metadata it's like well
what kind of metadata are we actually
looking at where is this data located
what is the schema on it uh then this
that comes back with the metadata into
the compiler then the compiler takes all
that information and the send plan
returns it to the driver the driver then
sends the execute plan to the execution
engine once it's in the execution engine
the execution in and acts as a bridge
between Hive and Hadoop to process the
query and that's going into your map
reduce and your Hadoop file system or
your hdfs and then we come back with the
metadata operations it goes back into
the meta store to update or let it know
what's going on which also goes to the
between it's a communication between the
execution engine and The Meta store
execution engine Communications is
bi-directionally with the metastore to
perform operations like create drop
tables metastore stores information
about tables and columns so again we're
talking about the schema of your
database and once we have that we have a
bi-directional send results
communication back into the driver and
then we have the fetch results which
goes back to the client so let's take a
little bit look at the hive data
modeling Hive data modeling so you have
your high data modeling you have your
tables you have your partitions and you
have buckets the tables in however
created the same weight as done in rdbms
so when you're looking at your
traditional SQL server or MySQL server
where you might have Enterprise
equipment and a lot of people pulling
and moving stuff off of there the tables
are going to look very similar and this
makes it very easy to take that
information and let's say you need to
keep current information but you need to
store all of your years of transactions
back into the Hadoop Hive so you match
those those all kind of look the same
the tables are the same your databases
look very similar and you can easily
import them but you can easily store
them into the hive system partitions
here tables are organized into
partitions for grouping same type of
data based on partition key this can
become very important for speeding up
the process of doing queries so if
you're looking at dates as far as like
your employment dates of employees if
that's what you're tracking you might
add a partition there because that might
be one of the key things that you're
always looking up as far as employees
are concerned and finally we have
buckets data present in partitions can
be further divided into buckets for
efficient querying again there's that
efficiency at this level a lot of times
you're taught you're working with the
programmer and the admin of your Hadoop
file system to maximize the efficiency
of that file system so it's usually a
two-person job and we're talking about
Hive data modeling you want to make sure
that they work together and you're
maximizing your resources Hive data
types so we're talking about Hive data
types we have our primitive data types
and our complex data types A lot of this
should look familiar because it mirrors
a lot of stuff in SQL in our primitive
data types we have the numerical data
types string data type date time data
type and miscellaneous data type and
these should be very they're kind of
self-explanatory but just in case
numerical data is your floats your
integers your short integers all of that
numerical data comes in as a number a
string of course is character vectors
and numbers and then you have your date
time step and then we have kind of a
general way of pulling your own created
data types in there that's your
miscellaneous data type and we have
complex data types so you can store
arrays you can store maps you can store
structures and even units in there as we
dig into Hive data types and we have the
primitive data types and the complex
data types so we look at primitive data
types and we're looking at numeric data
types data types like an integer a float
a decimal those are all stored as
numbers in the hive data system a string
data type data types like characters and
strings you store the name of the person
you're working with you know John Doe
the city
State Tennessee maybe it's Boulder
Colorado USA or maybe it's hyperbad
India that's all going to be string
stored as a string character and of
course we have our date time data type
data types like timestamp date interval
those are very common as far as tracking
sales anything like that so you just
think if you can type a stamp of time on
it or maybe you're dealing with the race
and you want to know the interval how
long did the person take to complete
whatever task it was all that is date
time data type and then we talk
miscellaneous data type these are like
Boolean in binary and when you get into
Boolean and binary you can actually
almost create anything in there but your
yes nose zero one now let's take a look
at complex data types a little closer we
have arrays so your syntax is of data
type and it's an array and you can just
think of an array as a collection of
same entities one two three four if
they're all numbers and you have Maps
this is a collection of key value pairs
so understanding is so Central to Hadoop
so we store Maps you have a key which is
a set you can only have one key per
mapped value and so you in Hadoop of
course you collect the same keys and you
can add them all up or do something with
all the contents of the same key but
this is our map as a primitive type data
type in our collection of key value
Pairs and then collection of complex
data with comment so we can have a
structure we have like column name data
type comment column comment so you can
get very complicated structures in here
with your collection of data and your
commented setup and then we have units
and this is a collection of
heterogeneous data types so the Syntax
for this is Union type data type data
type and so on so it's all going to be
the same a little bit different than the
arrays where you can actually mix and
match different modes of Hive Hive
operates in two modes depending on the
number and size of data nodes we have
our local mode and our map reduce mode
when we talk about the local mode it is
used when Hadoop is having one data node
and the data is small processing will be
very fast in a smaller data sets which
are present in local machine and this
might be that you have a local file of
stuff you're uploading into the hive and
you need to do some processes in there
you can go ahead and run those High
processes and queries on it usually you
don't see much in the way of a single
node Hadoop system if you're going to do
that you might as well just use like an
SQL database or even a Java sqlite or
something python ssqlite so you don't
really see a lot of single node Hadoop
databases but you do see the local mode
in Hive where you're working with a
small amount of data that's going to be
integrated into the larger database and
then we have the map reduce mode this is
used when Hadoop is having multiple data
nodes and the data is spread across
various data nodes processing large data
sets can be more efficient using this
mode and this you can think of instead
of it being one two three or even five
computers we're usually talking with the
Hadoop file system we're looking at 10
compute
fifteen a hundred where this data is
spread across all those different Hadoop
nodes difference between Hive and rdbms
remember rdbms stands for the relational
database management system let's take a
look at the difference between Hive and
the rdbms with Hive Hive enforces schema
on read and it's very important that
whatever is coming in that's when hive's
looking at it and making sure that it
fits the model the rdbms enforce
actually writes the data into the
database so it's read the data and then
once it starts to write it that's where
it's going to give you the error or tell
you something's incorrect about your
scheme Hive data size is in petabytes
that is hard to imagine you know we're
looking at your personal computer on
your desk maybe you have 10 terabytes if
it's a high-end computer we're talking
petabytes so that's hundreds of
computers grouped together when an rdbms
data size is in terabytes very rarely do
you see an rdbms system that's spread
over more than five computers and
there's a lot of reasons for that with
the rdbms it actually has a high-end
amount of rights to the hard drive
there's a lot more going on there your
writing and pulling stuff so you really
don't want to get too big with an rdbms
or you're going to run into a lot of
problems with Hive you can take it as
big as you want Hive is based on the
notion of write once and read many times
this is so important and they call it
worm which is right W10 read R many
times m they refer to it as worm and
that's true of any of you a lot of your
Hadoop set up it's it's altered a little
bit but in general we're looking at
archiving data that you want to do data
analysis on we're looking at pulling all
that stuff off your rdbms from years and
years and years of business or whatever
your company does or scientific research
and putting that into a huge data pool
so that you can now do queries on it and
get that information out of it with the
rdbms it's based on the notion of read
and write many times so you're
continually updating this database
you're continually bringing up new stuff
new sales the account changes because
they have a different licensing now
whatever software you're selling all
that kind of stuff where the data is
continually fluctuating and then Hive
resembles a traditional database by
supporting SQL but it is not a database
it is a data warehouse this is very
important it goes with all the other
stuff we've talked about that we're not
looking at a database but a data
warehouse to store the data and still
have fast and easy access to it for
doing queries you can think of Twitter
and Facebook they have so many posts
that are archived back historically
those posts aren't going to change they
made the post they're posted they're
there and they're in their database but
they have to store it in a warehouse in
case they want to pull it back up with
the rdbms it's a type of database
management system which is based on the
relational model of data and then with
Hive easily scalable at a low cost again
we're talking maybe a thousand dollars
per terabyte the rdbms is not scalable
at a low cost when you first start on
the lower end you're talking about ten
thousand per terabyte of data including
all the backup on the models and and all
the added Necessities to support it as
you scale it up you have to scale those
computers and Hardware up so you might
start off with a basic server and then
you upgrade to a sun computer to run it
and you spend you know tens of thousands
of dollars for that Hardware upgrade
with Hive you just put another computer
into your Hadoop file system so let's
look at some of the features of hive
uh when we're looking at the features of
Hive we're talking about the use of SQL
like language called Hive ql a lot of
times you'll see that as hql which is
easier than long codes this is nice if
you're working with your shareholders
you come to them and you say Hey you can
do a basic SQL query on here and pull up
the information you need this way you
don't have to take all have your
programmers jump in every time they want
to look up something in the database
they actually now can easily do that if
they're not skilled in programming and
script writing tables are used which are
similar to The rdbms hence easier to
understand and one of the things I like
about this is when I'm bringing tables
in from a MySQL server or SQL Server
there's almost a direct reflection
between the two so when you're looking
at one which is a data which is
continually changing and then you're
going into the archive database it's not
this huge jump where you have to learn a
whole new language you mirror that same
schema into the hdfs into the hive
making it very easy to go between the
two and then using Hive ql multiple user
simultaneously query data so again you
have multiple clients in there and they
send in their query that's also true
with the rdbms which kind of queues them
up because it's running so fast you
don't notice the lag time well you get
that also with the hql as you add more
computers in the query can go very
quickly depending on how many computers
and how much resources each machine has
to pull the information and Hive
supports a variety of data types so with
Hive it's designed to be on the Hadoop
system which you can put almost anything
into the Hadoop file system so with all
that let's take a look at a demo on hive
ql or hql before I dive into the
Hands-On demo let's take a look at the
website
hive.apache.org that's the main website
since Apache it's an Apache open source
software this is the main software or
the main site for the build and if you
go in here you'll see that they're
slowly migrating Hive into beehive and
so if you see beehive versus Hive note
The Beehive as the new release is coming
out that's all it is it reflects a lot
of the same functionality of Hive it's
the same thing and then we like to pull
up some kind of documentation on
commands and for this I'm actually going
to go to hortonworks Hive cheat sheet
and that's because Horton works and
Cloudera two of the most common used
builds for Hadoop and for which include
Hive and all the different Tools in
there and so hortonworks has a pretty
good PDF you can download cheat sheet on
there I believe Cloudera does too but
we'll go ahead just look at the Horton
one because it's the one that comes up
really good and you can see when we look
at the query language it Compares MySQL
server to Hive ql or hql and you can see
the basic select we select from columns
from table where conditions exist you
know most basic command on there and
they have different things you can do
with it just like you do with your SQL
and if you scroll down you'll see data
types so here's your integer your flow
your binary double string timestamp and
all the different data types you can use
some different semantics different Keys
features functions for running a hive
query command line setup and of course
the hive shell setup in here so you can
see right here if we Loop through it it
has a lot of your basic stuff in it is
we're basically looking at SQL across a
Horton database we're going to go ahead
and run our Hadoop cluster Hive demo and
I'm going to go ahead and use the
Cloudera quick start this is in the
virtual box so again we have an oracle
virtual box which is open source and
then we have our Cloudera quick start
which is the Hadoop setup on a single
node now obviously Hadoop And Hive are
designed to run across a cluster of
computers so we talk about a single node
is for Education testing that kind of
thing and if you have a chance you can
always go back and look at our demo we
had on setting up a Hadoop system in a
single cluster to set a note Down Below
in the YouTube 2 video and our team will
get in contact with you and send you
that link if you don't already have it
or you can contact us at the
www.simplylearn.com now in here it's
always important to note that you do
need on your computer if you're running
on Windows because I'm on a Windows
machine you're going to need it probably
about 12 gigabytes to actually run this
it used to be goodbye with a lot less
but as things have evolved they take up
more and more resources and you need the
professional version if you have the
home version I was able to get that to
run but boy did it take a lot of extra
work to get the home version to let me
use the virtual setup on there and we'll
simply click on the Cloudera quick start
and I'm going to start that up and this
is starting up our Linux so we have our
Windows 10 which is a computer I'm on
and then I have the virtual box which is
going to have a Linux operating system
in it and we'll skip ahead so you don't
have to watch the whole install
something interesting to know about the
Cloudera is that it's running on Linux
Santos and for whatever reason I've
always had to click on it and hit the
escape button for it to spin up and then
you'll see the Dos come in here now that
our Cloudera is spun up on our virtual
machine with the Linux on we can see
here we have our it uses the Thunderbird
browser on here by default and
automatically opens up a number of
different tabs for us and a quick note
because I mentioned like the
restrictions on getting set up on your
own computer if you have a home edition
computer and you're worried about
setting it up on there you can also go
in there and spin up a one month free
service on Amazon web service to play
with this so there's other options
you're not stuck with just doing it on
the quick start menu you can spin this
up in many other ways now the first
thing we want to note is that we've come
in here into Cloudera and I'm going to
access this in two ways the first one is
we're going to use Hue and I'm going to
open up Hue and it'll take it a moment
to load from the setup on here and Hue
is nice if I go in and use Hue as an
editor into Hive or into the Hadoop
setup usually I'm doing it as a from an
admin side because it has a lot more
information a lot of visuals less to do
with you know actually diving in there
and just executing code and you can also
write this code into files and scripts
and there's other things you can other
ways you can upload it into Hive but
today we're going to look at the command
lines and we'll upload it into Hue and
then we'll go into and actually do our
work in a terminal window Under The Hive
shell now in the Hue browser window if
you go under query and click on the pull
down menu and then you go under editor
and you'll see Hive there we go there's
our Hive setup I go and click on hive
and this will open up our query down
here and now it has a nice little B that
shows our Hive going and we can go
something very simple down here like
show databases and we follow it with the
semicolon and that's the standard in
Hive is you always add our punctuation
at the end there and I'll go ahead and
run this and the query will show up
underneath and you'll see down here
since this is a new quick start I just
put on here you'll see it has the
default down here for the databases
that's the database name I haven't
actually created any databases on here
and then there's a lot of other like
assistant function tables your databases
up here there's all kinds of things you
can research you can look at through Hue
as far as a bigger picture the downside
of this is it always seems to lag for me
whenever I'm doing this I always seem to
run slow so if you're in Cloudera you
can open up a terminal window they
actually have an icon at the top you can
also go under applications and under
applications system tools and terminal
either one will work it's just a regular
terminal window and this terminal window
is now running underneath our Linux so
this is a Linux terminal window or on
our virtual machine which is resting on
our regular Windows 10 machine and we'll
go ahead and zoom this in so you can see
the text better on your own video and I
simply just clicked on view and zoom in
and then all we have to do is type in
Hive and this will open up the shell on
here and it takes it just a moment to
load when starting up Hive I also want
to note that depending on your rights on
the computer you're on in your action
you might have to do pseudohive and put
in your password and username most
computers are usually set up with the
hive login again it just depends on how
you're accessing the Linux system and
the hive shell once we're in here we can
go ahead and do a simple hql command
show databases and if we do that we'll
see here that we don't have any
databases so we can go ahead and create
a database and we'll just call it office
for today for this moment now if I do
show we'll just do the up Arrow up arrow
is a hotkey that works in both Linux and
in Hive so I can go back and paste
through all the commands I've typed in
and we can see now that I have my
there's of course the default database
and then there's the office database so
now we've created a database it was
pretty quick and easy and we go ahead
and drop the database we can do drop
Database Office now this will work on
this database because it's empty if your
database was not empty you would have to
do cache skate and that drops all the
tables in the database and the database
itself now if we do show database and
we'll go ahead and recreate our database
because we're going to use the office
database for the rest of this Hands-On
demo a really handy command to Now set
with the SQL or hql is to use office and
what that does is that sets office as
the default database so instead of
having to reference the database every
time we work with a table we now
automatically assumes that's the
database being used whatever tables
we're working on the difference is you
put the database name period table and
I'll show you in just a minute what that
looks like and how that's different if
we're going to have a table and a
database we should probably load some
data into it so let me go ahead and
switch gears here and open up a terminal
window you can just open another
terminal window and it'll open up right
on top of the one that you have Hive
shell running in and when we're in this
terminal window first we're going to go
ahead and just do a list which is of
course a Linux command you can see all
the files I have in here this is the
default load we can change directory to
documents we can list in documents and
we're actually going to be looking at
employee.csv a Linux command is the cat
you can use this actually to combine
documents there's all kinds of things
that cat does but if we want to just
display the contents of our
employee.csv file we can simply do cat
employee CSV and when we're looking at
this we want to know a couple things one
there's a line at the top okay so the
very first thing we notice is that we
have a header line the next thing we
notice is that the data is comma
separated and in this particular case
you'll see a space here generally with
these you got to be real careful with
spaces there's all kinds of things you
got to watch out for because it can
cause issues these spaces won't because
these are all strings that the space is
connected to if this was a space next to
the integer you would get a null value
that comes into the database without
doing something extra in there now with
most of Hadoop that's important to know
that that you're writing the data once
reading it many times and that's true of
almost all your Hadoop things coming in
so you really want to process the data
before it gets into the database and for
those who of you have studied data
transformation that's the adult where
you extract transfer form and then load
the data so you really want to extract
and transform before putting it into the
hive then you load it into the hive with
the transform data and of course we also
want to note the schema we have an
integer string string integer integer so
we kept it pretty simple in here as far
as the way the data is set up the last
thing that you're going to want to look
up is the source since we're doing local
uploads we want to know what the path is
we have the whole path in this case it's
home slash Cloudera slash documents and
these are just text documents we're
working with right now we're not doing
anything fancy so we can do a simple git
edit
employee.csv and you'll see it comes up
here it's just a text document so I can
easily remove these added spaces there
we go and then we go ahead and just save
it and so now it has a new setup in
there we've edited it the G edit is
usually one of the default that loads
into Linux so any text editor will do
back to the hive shell so let's go ahead
and create a table employee and what I
want you to note here is I did not put
the semicolon on the end here a
semicolon tells it to execute that line
so this is kind of nice if you're you
can actually just paste it in if you
have it written on another sheet and you
can see right here where I have create
table employee and it goes into the next
line on there so I can do all of my
commands at once now just so I don't
have any typo errors I went ahead and
just pasted the next three lines in and
the next one is our schema if you
remember correctly from the other side
we had the different values in here
which was ID name Department year of
joining and salary and the ID is an
integer name is a string department
string you're joining energy salary an
integer and they're in Brackets we put
close brackets around them and you could
do this all as one line and then we have
row format delimited Fields terminated
by comma and this is important because
the default is tabs so if I do it now it
won't find any terminated Fields so
you'll get a bunch of null values loaded
into your table and then finally our
table properties we want to skip the
header line count equals one now this is
a lot of work for uploading a single
file it's kind of goofy when you're
uploading a single file that you have to
put all this in here but keep in mind
Hive and Hadoop is designed for writing
many files into the database you write
them all in there and then you can
they're saved it's an archive it's a
data warehouse and then you're able to
do all your queries on them so a lot of
times we're not looking at just the one
file coming up we're loading hundreds of
files you have your reports coming off
of your main database all those reports
are being loaded and you have your log
files you have I mean all this different
data is being dumped into Hadoop and in
this case Hive on top of Hadoop and so
we need to let it know hey how do I
handle these files coming in and then we
have the semicolon at the end which lets
us know to go ahead and run this line
and so we'll go ahead and run that and
now if we do a show tables you can see
there's our employee on there we can
also describe if we do describe employee
you can see that we have our ID integer
name string department string year of
joining integer and salary integer and
then finally let's just do a select star
from employee very basic SQL and hql
command selecting data and it's going to
come up and we haven't put anything in
it so as we expect there's no data in it
so if we flip back to our Linux terminal
window you can see where we did the cat
employee.csv and you can see all the
data we expect to come into it and we
also did our PWD and right here you see
the path you need that full path when
you are loading data you know you can do
a browse and if I did it right now with
just the employee.csv is the name it
will work work but that is a really bad
habit in general when you're loading
data because it's you don't know what
else is going on on the computer you
want to do the full path almost in all
your data loads so let's go ahead and
flip back over here to our Hive shell
we're working in and the command for
this is load data so that says hey we're
loading data that's a hive command hql
and we want local data so you got to put
down local and path so now it needs to
know where the path is now to make this
more legible I'm just going to go ahead
and hit enter then we'll just paste the
full path in there which I have stored
over on the side like a good prepared
demo and you'll see here we have home
Cloudera documents employee.csv so it's
a whole path for this text document in
here and we go ahead and hit enter in
there and then we have to let it know
where the data is going so now we have a
source and we need a destination and
it's going to go into the table and
we'll just call it employee we'll just
match the table in there and because I
wanted to execute we put the semicolon
on the end it goes ahead and executes
all all three lines now if we go back if
you remember we did the select star from
employee just using the up Arrow to page
through my different commands I've
already typed in you can see right here
we have as we expect we have Rose Sam
Mike and Nick and we have all their
information showing in our four rows and
then let's go ahead and do uh select and
count we'll just look at a couple of
these different select options you can
do we're going to count everything from
employee now this is kind of interesting
because the first one just pops up with
the basic select because it doesn't need
to go through the full map reduce phase
but when you start doing a count it does
go through the full map reduce setup in
the hive in Hadoop and because I'm doing
this demo on a single node Cloudera
virtual box on top of a Windows 10. all
the benefits of running it on a cluster
are gone and instead is now going
through all those added layers so it
takes longer to run you know like I said
when you do a single node as I said
earlier it doesn't do any good as an
actual distribution because you're only
running it on one computer and then
you've added all these different layers
to run it and we see it comes up with
four and that's what we expect we have
four rows we expect four at the end and
if you remember from our cheat sheet
which we brought up here from Horton's
it's a pretty good one there's all these
different commands we can do we'll look
at one more command where we do the uh
what they call sub queries right down
here because that's really common to do
a lot of sub queries and so we'll do
select star or all different columns
from employee now if we weren't using
the office database it would look like
this from Office dot employee and either
one will work on this particular one
because we have office set as a default
on there so from office employee and
then the command where creates a subset
and in this case we want to know where
the salary is greater than 25
000. there we go and of course we end
with our semi colon if we run this query
you can see it pops up and there's our
salaries the people top earners we have
Rose and it and Mike and HR kudos to
them of course they're fictitional I
don't actually we don't actually have a
rose and a mic in those positions or
maybe we do so finally we want to go
ahead and do is we're done with this
table now remember you're dealing with
the data warehouse so you usually don't
do a lot of dropping of tables and
databases but we're going to go ahead
and drop this table here before we drop
it one more quick note is we can change
it so what we're going to do is we're
going to alter table office employee and
we want to go ahead and rename it
there's some other commands you can do
in here but rename is pretty common and
we're going to rename it to and it's
going to stay in office and turns out
one of our shareholders really doesn't
like the word employee he wants
employees plural it's a big deal to him
so let's go ahead and change that name
for the table it's that easy because
it's just changing the meta data on
there and now if we do show table tables
you'll see we now have employees not
employee and then at this point maybe
we're doing some house cleaning because
this is all practice so we're going to
go ahead and drop the table and we'll
drop table employees because we changed
the name in there so if we did employee
just give us an error and now if we do
show tables you'll see how the tables
are gone now the next thing we want to
go and take a look at and we're going to
walk back through the loading of data uh
just real quick because we're going to
load two tables in here and let me just
float back to our terminal window so we
can see what those tables are that we're
loading and so up here we have customer
we have a customer file and we have an
order file we want to go ahead and put
the customers and the orders into here
so those are the two we're doing and of
course it's always nice to see what
you're working with so let's do our cat
customer dot CSV we could always do G
edit but we don't really need to edit
these we just want to take a look at the
data in customer and important in here
is again we have a header so we have to
skip a line comma separated nothing odd
with the data we have our schema which
is integer string integer string integer
so you know you'd want to take that note
that down or flip back and forth when
you're doing it and then let's go ahead
and do cat
order.csv and we can see we have oid
which I'm guessing is the order ID we
have a date up something new we've done
integers and strings but we haven't done
date when you're importing new and you
never worked with the date date's always
one of the more trickier fields to port
in and that's true of just about any
scripting language I've worked with all
of them have their own idea of how
date's supposed to be formatted what the
default is this particular format or its
year and it has all four digits Dash
month two digits Dash day is the
standard import for the hive so if
you'll have to look up and see what the
different formats are if you're going to
do a different format in there coming in
or you're not able to pre-process the
data but this would be a pre-processing
of the data thing coming in if you
remember correctly from our ad which is
E just in case you weren't able to hear
me last time e t l which stands for
extract transform then load so you want
to make sure you're transforming this
data before it gets into here and so
we're going to go ahead and bring both
this data in here and really we're doing
this so we can show you the basic join
there is if you remember from our setup
merge join all kinds of different things
you can do but joining different data
sets is so common so it's really
important to know how to do this we need
to go ahead and bring in these two data
sets and you can see where I just
created a table customer here's our
schema the integer name age address
salary here's our delimited by commas
and our table properties where we skip a
line well let's go ahead and load the
data first and then we'll do that with
our order and let's go ahead and put
that in here and I've got it split into
three lines you can see it easily we've
got load data local in path so we know
we're loading data we know it's local
and we have the path here's the complete
path for uh oops this is supposed to be
order CSV grab the wrong one of course
it's going to give me errors because you
can't recreate the same table on there
and here we go create table here's our
integer date customer the basic setup
that we had coming in here for our
schema row format commas table
properties skip header line and then
finally let's load the data into our
order table load data local in path home
Cloudera documents ordered at CSV into
table order now if we did everything
right we should be able to do select
star from customer and you can see we
have all seven customers and then we can
do select star from order and we have
four orders so this is just like a quick
frame we have a lot of times when you
have your customer databases in business
you have thousands of customers from
years and years and some of them you
know they move they close their business
they change names all kinds of things
happen so we want to do is we want to go
ahead and find just the information
connected to these orders and who's
connected to them and so let's go ahead
and do it's a select because we're going
to display information so select and
this is kind of interesting we're going
to do c dot ID and I'm going to Define c
as customer as a customer table in just
a minute then we're going to do c dot
name and again we're going to define the
c c dot age so this means from the
customer we want to know their ID their
name their age and then you know I'd
also like to know the order amount so
let's do o for DOT amount and then this
is where we need to go ahead and Define
what we're doing and I'll go and
capitalize from customer so we're going
to take the customer table in here and
we're going to name it C that's where
the C comes from so that's the customer
table C and we want to join order as o
that's where our o comes from so the O
DOT amount is what we're joining in
there and then we want to do this on we
got to tell it how to connect the two
tables C dot ID equals o Dot customer
underscore ID so now we know how they're
drawn and I remember we have seven
customers in here we have four orders
and as a processes we should get a
return of four different names joined
together and they're joined based on of
course the orders on there and once
we're done we now have the order number
the person who made the order their age
and the amount of the order which came
from the order table uh so you have your
different information and you can see
how the join works here very common use
of tables and hql and SQL and let's do
one more thing with our database and
then I'll show you a couple other Hive
commands and let's go ahead and do a
drop and we're going to drop Database
Office and if you're looking at this and
you remember from earlier this will give
me an error and let's just see what that
looks like it says failed execute
exception one or more tables exist so if
you remember from before you can't just
drop a database unless you tell it to
Cascade that lets it no I don't care I
mean tables are in it let's get rid of
it and in Hadoop since it's an art it's
a warehouse a data warehouse you usually
don't do a lot of dropping maybe at the
beginning when you're developing the
schemas and you realize you messed up
you might drop some stuff but down the
road you're really just adding commodity
machines to take up so you can store
more stuff on it so you usually don't do
a lot of database dropping and some
other fun commands to know is you can do
select round 2.3 as round value you can
do a round off in Hive we can do as
floor value which is going to give us a
2 so it turns it into an integer versus
a float it goes down you know basically
truncates it but it goes down and we can
also do ceiling which is going to round
it up so we're looking for the next
integer above there's a few commands we
didn't show in here because we're on a
single node as as an admin to help
speciate the process you usually add in
partitions for the data and buckets you
can't do that on a single node because
the when you add a partition the
partitions it separate nodes but beyond
that you can see that it's very
straightforward we have SQL coming in
and all your basic queries that are in
SQL are very similar to hql let's get
started with pig why Pig what is pig map
reduce versus Hive versus pig hopefully
you've had a chance to do our Hive
tutorial and our map reduce tutorial if
you haven't send a note over to Simply
learn and we'll follow up with a link to
you we'll look at Pig architecture
working a pig pig latin data model Pig
execution modes a use case Twitter and
features a pick and then we'll tag on a
short demo so you can see Pig In Action
so why pig as we all know Hadoop uses
mapreduce to analyze and process big
data processing Big Data consumed more
time so before we had the Hadoop system
they'd have to spend a lot of money on a
huge set of computers and Enterprise
machines so we introduced the Hadoop map
reduce and so afterwards processing Big
Data was faster using up reduce then
what is the problem with map reduce
prior to 2006 all mapreduce programs
were written in Java non-programmers
found it difficult to write lengthy Java
codes they faced issues in incorporating
map sort reduce to fundamentals of
mapreduce while creating a program you
can see here map phase Shuffle and sort
reduce phase eventually it became a
difficult task to maintain and optimize
a code due to which the processing time
increased you can imagine a manager
trying to go in there and needed in a
simple query to find out data and he has
to go talk to the programmers anytime he
wants anything so that was a big problem
not everybody wants to have a on-call
programmer for every manager on their
team Yahoo faced problems to process and
analyze large data sets using Java as a
cause or complex and lengthy there was a
necessity to develop an easier way to
analyze large data sets without using
time-consuming complex Java modes and
codes and scripts and all that fun stuff
Apache Pig was developed by Yahoo it was
developed with a vision to analyze and
process large data sets without using
complex Java codes Pig was developed
especially for non-programmers pig used
simple steps to analyze data sets which
was time efficient so what exactly is
pick pig is a scripting platform that
runs on Hadoop clusters designed to
process and analyze large data sets and
so you have your pig which uses SQL like
queries they're definitely not SQL but
some of them resemble SQL queries and
then we use that to analyze our data Pig
operates on various types of data like
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data let's take a closer
look at mapreduce versus Hive versus pig
so we start with a compiled language
your map reduce and we have Hive which
is your SQL like query and then we have
pig which is a scripting language it has
some similarities to SQL but it has a
lot of its own stuff remember SQL like
query which is what Hive is based off
looks for structured data and so when we
get into scripting languages like Pig
now we're dealing more with
semi-structure and even unstructured
data with a Hadoop map reduce we have a
need to write long complex codes with
Hive no need to write complex codes you
could just put it in a simple SQL query
or hql Hive ql and in pig no need to
write complex codes as we have pig latin
now remember in the map reduce it can
produce structured semi-structured and
unstructured data and as I mentioned
before Hive can process only structured
data think rows and columns where Pig
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data you can think of
structured data as rows and columns
semi-structured as your HTML XML
documents if you have on your web pages
and unstructured could be anything from
groups of documents and written format
Twitter tweets any of those things come
in as very unstructured data and with
our Hadoop mapreduce we have a lower
level of abstraction with both Hive and
pig we have a higher level abstract so
it's much more easy for someone to use
without having to dive in deep and write
a very lengthy map reduce code and those
map and reduce codes can take 70 80
lines of code when you can do the same
thing in one or two lines with however
Pig this is the advantage Pig has over
Hive it can process only structured data
in Hive while in pig it can process
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data some other features to
note that separates the different query
languages is we look at map and reduce
map reduce supports partitioning
features as does Hive Pig no concept of
partitioning in picks it doesn't support
your partitioning feature your
partitioning features allow you to
partition the data in such a way that it
can be queried quicker you're not
mapreduce uses Java and python while
Hive uses an SQL like query language
known as Hive ql or hql Pig Latin is
used which is a procedural data flow
language mapreduce is used by
programmers pretty much as
straightforward on Java Hive is used by
data analysts pig is used by researchers
and programmers certainly there's a lot
of mix between all three programmers
have been known to go in and use a hive
for quick query and anybody's been able
to use Pig for a quick query or research
under map and reduce code performance is
really good under Hive code performance
is lesser than map and reduce and pick
under Pig Code performance is lesser
than mapreduce but better than Hive so
if we're going to look at speed and time
the map reduce is going to be the
fastest performance on all of those
where Pig will have second and high
follows in the back let's look at
components of pig pig has two main
components we have pig Latin Pig Latin
is the procedural data flow language
used in pig to analyze data is easy to
program using Piglet and it is similar
to SQL and then we have the runtime
engine runtime engine represents the
execution environment created to run Pig
Latin programs it is also a compiler
that produces mapreduce programs uses
hdfs or your Hadoop file system for
storing and retrieving data and as we
dig deeper into the pig architecture
we'll see that we have pig latin scripts
programmers write a script in pig latin
to analyze data using Pig then you have
the grunt shell and it actually says
grunt when we start it up and we'll show
you that here in a little bit which goes
into the pig server and this is where we
have our parser parser checks the syntax
of the pig script after checking the
output will be a dag directed acelic
graph and then we have an Optimizer
which optimizes after your dag your
logical plan is passed to The Logical
Optimizer where an optimization takes
place finally the compiler converts the
dag into mapreduce jobs and then that is
executed on the map reduce under the
execution engine the results are
displayed using dump statement and
stored in hdfs using store statement and
again we'll show you that
kind of end you always want to execute
everything once you've created it and so
dump is kind of our execution statement
and you can see right here as we were
talking about earlier once we get to the
execution engine and it's coded into
mapreduce then the map reduce processes
it onto the hdfs working a pig pig latin
script is written by the users so you
have load data and right Pig script and
pig operations so we look at the working
of pig pig latin script is written by
the users there's step one we load data
and write Pig script and step two in
this step all the pig operations are
performed by parser Optimizer and
compiler so we go into the pig
operations and then we get to step three
execution of the plan in this stage the
results are shown on the screen
otherwise stored in the hdfs as per the
code so it might be of a small amount of
data you're reducing it to and you want
to put that on the screen or you might
be converting a huge amount of data
which you want to put back into the
Hadoop file system for other use let's
take a look at the pig latin data the
data model of pig latin helps pig to
handle various types of data for example
we have Adam Rob or 50. Adam represents
any single value of primitive data type
in pig latin like integer float string
it is stored as a string two bolts so we
go from our atom which are most basic
thing so if you look at just Rob or just
50 that's an atom that's our most basic
object we have in pig latin then you
have a tuple Tuple represents sequence
of fields that can be of any data type
it is the same as a row in rdbms for
example a set of data from a single row
and you can see here we have Rob comma
five and you can imagine with many of
our other examples we've used you might
have the ID number the name where they
live their age their date of starting
the job that would all be one row and
store it as a tuple and then we create a
bag a bag is a collection of tuples it
is the same as a table in rdbms and is
represented by brackets and you can see
here we have our table with Rob 5 mic 10
and we also have a map a map is a set of
key value pairs key is of character
array type and a value can be of any
type it is represented by the brackets
and so we have name and age where the
key value is Mike and 10. pig latin has
a fully nestable data model that means
one data type can be nested within
another here's a diagram representation
of pig latin data model and in this
particular example we have basically an
ID number a name an age and a place and
we break this apart we look at this
model from Pig Latin perspective we
start with our field and if you remember
a field contains basically an atom it is
one particular data type and the atom is
stored as a string which it then
converts it into either an integer or
number or character string next we have
our Tuple and in this case you can see
that it represents a row so our Tuple
would be three comma Joe comma 29 comma
California and finally we have our bag
which contains three rows in it in this
particular example let's take a quick
look at Pig execution modes
C Works in two execution modes depending
on where the data is reciting and where
the pig script is going to run we have
local mode here the pig engine takes
input from the Linux file system and the
output is stored in the same file system
local mode local mode is useful in
analyzing small data sets using Pig and
we have the mapreduce mode here the pig
engine directly interacts and executes
in hdfs and mapreduce in the mapreduce
mode queries written in pig latin are
translated into mapreduce jobs in our
run on a Hadoop cluster by default Pig
runs in this mode there are three modes
in pig depending on how a pig latin code
can be written we have our interactive
mode batch mode and embedded mode the
interactive mode means coding and
executing the script line by line when
we do our example we'll be in the
interactive mode in batch mode all
scripts are coded in a file with the
extension dot Pig and the file is
directly executed and then there's
embedded mode Pig lets its users Define
their own functions udfs in a
programming language such as Java so
let's take a look and see how this works
in a use case in this case use case
Twitter users on Twitter generate about
500 million tweets on a daily basis the
Hadoop mapreduce was used to process and
analyze this data analyzing the number
of tweets created by a user in the Tweet
table was done using mapreduce in Java
programming language and you can see the
problem it was difficult to perform
mapreduce operations as users were not
well versed with written complex Java
codes so Twitter used Apache pig to
overcome these problems and let's see
how let's start with the problem
statement analyze the user table and
tweet table and find out how many tweets
are created by a person and here you can
see we have a user table we have Alice
Tim and John with their ID numbers one
two three and we have a tweet table in
the Tweet table you have your the ID of
the user and then what they tweeted
Google was a good whatever it was
tennis. spacecraft Olympics politics
whatever they're tweeting about the
following operations were perform for
analyzing given data first the Twitter
data is loaded into the pig storage
using load command and you can see here
we have our data coming in and then
that's going into Pig storage and this
data is probably on an Enterprise
computer so this is actually active
twitters going on and then it goes into
Hadoop file system remember the Hadoop
file system is a data warehouse for
storing data and so the first step is we
want to go ahead and load it into the
pig storage into our data storage system
the remaining operations performed are
shown Below in join and group operation
the tweet and user tables are joined and
grouped using co-group command and you
can see here where we add a whole column
when we go from user names and tweet to
the ID link directly to the name so
Alice was user one Tim was 2 and John 3
and so now they're listed with their
actual tweet the next operation is the
aggregation the tweets are counted
according to the names the command used
is count so it's very straightforward we
just want to count how many tweets each
user is doing and finally the result
after the count operation is joined with
the user table to find out the username
and you can see here where Alice had
three Tim two and John 1. Pig reduces
the complexity of the operations which
would have been lengthy using mapreduce
and joining group operation the tweet
and user tables are joined and grouped
using co-group command the next
operation is the aggregation the tweets
are counted according to the names the
command used as count the result after
the count operation is joined with the
user table to find out the username and
you can see we're talking about three
lines of script versus a mapreduce code
of about 80 lines finally we could find
out the number of tweets created by a
user in a simple way so let's go quickly
over some of the features of pig that we
already went through most of these first
ease of programming as Pig Latin is
similar to SQL lesser lines of code need
to be written short development time as
the code is simpler so we can get our
queries out rather quickly instead of
having to have a programmer spend hours
handles all kind of data like structured
semi-structured and unstructured pig
lets us create user defined functions
Pig offers a large set of operators such
as join filter and so on it allows for
multiple queries to process unparallel
and optimization and compilation is easy
as it is done automatically and
internally
[Music]
so enough Theory let's dive in and show
you a quick demo on some of the commands
you can do and pick today's setup will
continue as we have in the last three
demos to go ahead and use Cloudera quick
start and we'll be doing this in Virtual
box we do have a tutorial in setting
that up you can send a note to our
simply learned team and then get that
linked to you once your Cloudera quick
start has spun up and remember this is
virtualbox we've created a virtual
machine and this virtual machine is
Centos Linux once it's spun up you'll be
in a full Linux system here and it's you
can see we have Thunderbird browser
which opens up to the Hadoop basic
system browser and we can go underneath
the Hue where it comes up by default if
you click on the pull down menu and go
under editor you can see there's our
Impala our Hive uh Pig along with a
bunch of other query languages you can
use and we're going under Pig and then
once you're in pig we can go ahead and
use our command line here and just click
that little blue button to start it up
and running we will actually be working
in terminal window and so if you're in
the Cloudera quick start you can open up
the terminal window up top or if you're
in your own setup and you're logged in
you can easily use all of your commands
here in terminal window and we'll zoom
in that way you get a nice view of
what's going on there we go now for our
first command we're going to do a Hadoop
command and import some data into the
Hadoop system in this case a pig input
let's just take a look at this we have
uh Hadoop let's know it's going to be a
Hadoop command DFS there's actually Four
variations of DFS so if you have hdfs or
you know whatever that's fine all four
of them Point used to be different
setups underneath different things and
now they all do the same thing and we
want to put this file which in this case
is under home Cloudera documents and
Sample and we just want to take that and
put it into the pig input and let's take
a look at that file if I go under my
document browsers and open this up
you'll see it's got a simple ID name
profession and age we have one Jack
engineer 25. and that was in one of our
earlier things we had in there and so
let's go ahead and hit enter and execute
this and now we've uploaded that data
and it's gone into our Pig input and
then a lot of the Hadoop commands mimic
the Linux commands and so you'll see we
have cat as one of our commands or it
has a hyphen before it so we execute
that with Hadoop DFS hyphen cat pull it
back up pig input because that's what we
called it that's where we put our sample
CSV at and we actually cute this you can
see from our Hadoop system it's going to
go ahead and pull that up and sure
enough it pulls out the data file we
just put in there and then we can simply
enter the pig Latin or Pig editor mode
by typing in pick and we can see here by
our grunt I told you that's how it was
going to tell you we're in pig latin
there's our grunt command line so we are
now in the pig shell and then we'll go
ahead and put our load command in here
and the way this works is I'm going to
have office equals load and here's my
load when this case is going to be Pig
input we have that in single brackets
remember that's where the data is in the
Hadoop file system where we dumped it
into there we're going to using Pig
storage our data was separated as with a
comma so there's our comma separator and
then we have as and in this case we have
an ID character array name character
array profession character array and age
character array and we're just going to
do a model's character arrays just to
keep this simple for this one and then
when I hit put this all in here you can
see that's our full command line going
in and we have our semicolon at the end
so when I hit enter it's now set office
up but it hasn't actually done anything
yet it doesn't do anything until we do
dump office so there's our Command to
execute whatever we've loaded or
whatever setup we have in here and we
run that you can see it go through the
different languages and this is going
through the map reduce remember we're
not doing this locally we're doing this
on the Hadoop setup and once we've
finished our dump you can see we have ID
name profession age and all the
information that we just dumped into our
pick oh we can now do let's say oh let's
say we have a request just for we'll
keep it simple in here but just for the
name and age and so we can go office
we'll call it each as our variable
underscore each and we'll say for each
office generate name comma H and for
each means that we're going to do this
for each row and if you're thinking map
reduce you know that this is a map
function because this may mapping each
row and generating name and age on here
and of course we want to go ahead and
close it with a semicolon and then once
we've created our query or the command
line in here let's go ahead and dump
office underscore each and with our
semicolon and this will go through our
map reduce setup on here and if we were
on a large cluster the same processing
time would happen in fact it's really
slow because I have multiple things on
this computer and this particular
virtual box is only using a quarter of
my processor it's only dedicated to this
and you can see here there it is name
and age and it also included the top row
since we didn't delete that out of there
or tell it not to and that's fine for
this example you need to be aware of
those things when you're processing a
significantly large amount of data or
any data and we can also do office and
we'll call this DSC for descending so
maybe the boss comes to you and says hey
can we order office by ID descending and
of course your boss you've taught them
how to to your shareholder it sounds a
little derogatory we say boss you've
talked to the shareholder and you said
and you've taught him a little bit of
Pig Latin and they know that they can
now create office description and we can
order office by ID description and of
course once we do that we have to dump
office underscore description so that
it'll actually execute and there goes
into our map reduce it'll take just a
moment for it to come up because again
I'm running on all the quarter of my
processor and you can see we now have
our IDs in descending order returned
let's also look at and this is so
important with anytime you're dealing
with big data let's create office with a
limit and you can of course do any of
this instead of with office we could do
this with office descending so you get
just the top two IDs on there we're
going to limit just to two and of course
to execute that we have to dump office
underscore limit and you can just think
of dumping your garbage into the pigpen
for the pig to eat there we go dump
office limit two and that's going to
just limit our office to the top 2. and
for our output we get our first row
which had our ID name profession and age
and our second row which is Jack who's
an engineer Let's do an uh filter we'll
call it office underscore filter you
guessed it equals filter office by
profession equals and keep note this is
uh similar to how python does it with
the double equal signs for equal for
doing a true false statement so for your
logic statement remember to use two
equal signs in Pig and we're going to
say it equals doctor so we want to find
out how many doctors do we have on our
list and we'll go ahead and do our dump
we're dumping all our garbage into the
pig pen and we're letting Pig take over
and see what it can find out and see
who's a doctor on our list and we find
uh employee ID number two Bob is a
doctor 30 years old for this next
section we're going to cover something
we see it a lot nowadays in data
analysis and that's word counting
tokenization that is one of the next big
steps as we move forward in our data
analysis where we go from say stock
market analysis of highs and lows and
all the numbers to what are people
saying about companies on Twitter what
are they saying on the web pages and on
Facebook something you need to start
counting words and finding out how many
words are totaled I mean in the first
part of the document and so on we're
going to cover a very basic word count
example and in this case I've created a
document called wordrows.txt and you can
see here we have simply learned is a
company supporting online learning
simply learn helps people attain their
certifications simply learn as an online
community I love simply learn I love
programming I love data analysis and I
went and saved this into my documents
folder so we could use it and let me go
ahead and open up a new terminal window
for our word count let me go and close
the old one so we're going to go in here
and instead of doing this as Pig we're
going to do pig minus X local and what
I'm doing is I'm telling the pig to
start the pig shell but we're going to
be looking at files local to our virtual
box or the Centos machine and let me go
ahead and hit enter on there just map
this up there we go and it will load Pig
up and it's going to look just the same
as the pig we were doing which was
defaulted to high to our Hadoop system
to our hdfs this is now defaulted to the
local system now we're going to create
lines we're going to load it straight
from the file remember last time we took
the hdfs and loaded it into there and
then loaded it into Pig since we've gone
the local we're just going to run a
local script we have lines equals load
home the actual full path home Cloudera
documents and I called it wordrows.txt
and as line is a character array so each
line and I've actually you can change
this to read each document I certainly
have done a lot of document analysis and
then you go through and do word counts
and different kind of counts in there so
once we go ahead and create our line
instead of doing the dump we're going to
go ahead and start entering all of our
different setups for each of our steps
we want to go through and let's just
take a look at this next one because the
load is straightforward we're loading
from this particular file since we're
locals loading it directly from here
instead of going into the Hadoop file
system and it says as and then each line
is read as a character array now we're
going to do words equal for each of the
lines generate Flat tokenize Line space
as word now there's a lot of ways to do
this this is if you're a programmer
you're just splitting the line up by
spaces there's actual ways to tokenize
it you gotta look for periods
capitalization there's all kinds of
other things you play with with this but
for the most basic word count we're just
going to separate it by spaces the
flattened takes the line and just
creates a it flattens each of the words
out so this is we're just going to
generate a bunch of words for each line
and then each each of those words is as
a word a little confusing in there but
if you really think about it we're just
going down each line separating it out
and we're generating a list of words one
thing to note is the default for
tokenize you can just do tokenized line
without the space in there if you do
that it'll automatically tokenize it by
space you can do either one and then
we're going to do group we're going to
group it by words so we're going to
group words by word so when we we split
it up each token is a word and it's a
list of words and so we're going to
grouped equals group words by word so
we're going to group all the same words
together and if we're going to group
them then we want to go ahead and count
them and so for count we'll go ahead and
create a word count variable and here's
our four each so for each grouped
grouped is our line where we group all
the words in the line that are similar
we're going to generate a group and then
we're going to count the words for each
grouped so for each line regroup the
words together we're going to generate a
group and that's going to count the
words we want to know the word count in
each of those and that comes back in our
word count and finally we want to take
this and we want to go ahead and dump
word count and this is a little bit more
what you see when you start looking at
run scripts you'll see right here these
these lines right here we have have each
of the steps you take to get there so we
load our file for each of our lines
we're going to generate and tokenize it
into words then we're going to take the
words and we're going to group them by
same words for each grouped we're going
to generate a group and we're just going
to count the words so we're going to
summarize all the words in here and
let's go ahead and do our dump word
count which executes all this and it
goes through our mapreduce it's actually
a local Runner you'll see down here you
start seeing where they still have
mapreduce but it's a special Runner
we're mapping it that's a part of each
row being counted and grouped and then
when we do the word count that's the
reducer the reducer creates these keys
and you can see I is used three times a
came up once and came up once is to
continue on down here to attain online
people company analysis simply learn
they took the top rating with four
certification so all these things are
encountered in the how many words are
used in a data analysis this is probably
the very the beginnings of data analysis
where you might look at it and say oh
they mentioned love three times so
whatever's going on in this post it's
about love and uh what do they love and
then you might attach that to the
different objects in here so you can see
that pig latin is fairly easy to use
there's nothing really you know it may
it takes a little bit to learn the
script depending on how good your memory
is as I get older my memory leaks a
little bit more so I don't memorize it
as much but that was pretty
straightforward the script we put in
there and then it goes through the full
map reduce localized run comes out and
like I said it's very easy to use that's
why people like Pig Latin is because
it's intuitive one of the things I like
about Pig Latin is when I'm
troubleshooting when we're
troubleshooting a lot of times you're
working with a small amount of data and
you start doing one line at a time and
so I can go lines equal load and there's
my loaded text and maybe I'll just dump
lines and then it's going to run it's
going to show me how all the lines that
I'm working on in the small amount of
data and that way I can test that if I
got an error on there that said oh this
isn't working maybe I'll be like oh my
gosh I'm in mapreduce or I'm in the
basic grunt shell instead of the local
path current so maybe it'll generate an
error on there and you can see here it
just shows each of the lines going down
Hive versus pig on one side we'll have
our sharp Stinger on our black and
yellow friend and on the other side our
thick hide on our Pig let's start with
an introduction to hbase back in the
days data used to be less and was mostly
structured we can see we have structured
data here we usually had it like in a
database where you had every field was
exactly the correct length so if you had
a name field at exactly 32 characters I
remember the old access database in
Microsoft the files are small if we had
you know hundreds of people in one
database that was considered Big Data
this data could be easily stored in
relational database or rdbms and we talk
about relational database you might
think of Oracle you might to go SQL
Microsoft SQL MySQL all of these have
evolved even from back then to do a lot
more today than they did but they still
fall short in a lot of ways and they're
all examples of an rdms or relationship
database then internet evolved and huge
volumes of structured and
semi-structured data got generated and
you can see here with the
semi-structured data we have email if
you look at my spam filter you know
we're talking about all the HTML Pages
XML which is a lot of time is displayed
on our HTML and help desk Pages Json all
of this really has just even in the last
each year it almost doubles from the
year before how much of this is
generated so storing and processing this
data on an rdbms has become a major
problem and so the solution is we use
Apache hbase Apache hbase was the
solution for this let's take a look at
the history the hbase history and we
look at the hbase history we're going to
start back in 2 2006 November Google
released a paper on big table and then
in 2017 just a few months later
age-based prototype was created as a
Hadoop contribution later on in the Year
2007 in October first usable hbase along
with the Hadoop .15 was released and
then in January 2008 hbase became the
sub-project of Hadoop and later on that
year in October all the way into
September the next year hbase was
released to 0.81 version the 0.19
version and 0.20 and finally in May of
2010 hbase became Apache top level
project and so you can see in the course
of about four years hbase started off as
just an idea on paper and has evolved
all the way till 2010 as a solid project
under the Apache and since 2010 it's
continued to evolve and grow as a major
source for storing data in
semi-structured data so what is hbase
hbase is a column oriented database
management system derived from Google's
nosql database bigtable that runs on top
of the Hadoop file system or the hdfs
it's an open source project that is
horizontally scalable and that's very
important to understand that you don't
have to buy a bunch of huge expensive
computers you're expanding it by
continually adding commodity machines
and so it's a linear cost expansion as
opposed to being exponential no SQL
database written in Java which permits
faster querying so Java is the back end
for the hbase setup and it's well suited
for sparse data sets so can contain
missing or n a values and this doesn't
Boggle it down like it would in other
database companies using hbase so let's
take a look and see who is using this no
SQL database for their servers and for
storing their data and we have
hortonworks which isn't a surprise
because they're one of the like Cloudera
hortonworks they are behind Hadoop and
one of the big developments and backing
of it and of course Apache hbase is the
open source behind it and we have
Capital One as Banks you also see Bank
of America where they're collecting
information on people and tracking it so
their information might be very sparse
they might have one Bank way back when
the collected information as far as the
person's family and what their income
for the whole family is and their
personal income and maybe another one
doesn't collect the family income as you
start seeing where you have data that is
very difficult to store where it's
missing a bunch of data hubspot's using
it Facebook certainly all of your
Facebook Twitter most of your social
medias are using it and then of course
there's JPMorgan Chase and Company
another bank that uses the hbase as
their data warehouse for NOS SQL let's
take a look at an hbase use case so we
can dig a little bit more into it to see
how it functions telecommunication
company that provides mobile voice and
multimedia Services across China the
China mobile and China mobile they
generate billions of call detailed
records or CDR and so these cdrs and all
these records of these calls and how
long they are and different aspects of
the call maybe the tower they're
broadcasted from all of that is being
recorded so they can track it a
traditional database systems were unable
to scale up to the vast volumes of data
and provide a cost-effective solution no
good so storing in real-time analysis of
billions of call records was a major
problem for this company solution Apache
H base hbase stores billions of rows of
detailed call records HP performs fast
processing of Records using SQL queries
so you can mix your SQL and nosql
queries and usually just say nosql
queries because the way the query Works
applications of hbase one of them would
be in the medical industry hbase is used
for storing genome sequences storing
disease history of people of an area and
you can imagine how sparsat is as far as
both of those a genome sequence might be
only have pieces to it that each person
is unique or is unique to different
people and the same thing with disease
you really don't need a column for every
possible disease a person could get you
just want to know what those diseases
those people have had to deal with in
that area e-commerce hbase is used for
storing logs about customer search
history performs analytics and Target
advertisement for Better Business
insights sports hbase stores match
details in the history of each match
uses this data for better prediction so
when we look at eight space we all want
to know what's the difference between
hbase versus rdbms that is a relational
database management system hbase versus
rdbms so the a space does not have a
fixed schema a schema less defines only
column families and we'll show you what
that means later on an rdbms has a fixed
schema which describes the structure of
the tables and you can think of this as
you have a row and you have columns and
each column is a very specific structure
how much data can go in there and what
it does with the age base it works well
with structured and semi-structured data
with the Rd dbms it works only well with
structured data with the age space it
can have denormalized data it can
contain missing or null values with the
rdbms it can store only normalized data
now you can still store a null value in
the rdbms but it still takes up the same
space as if you're storing a regular
value in many cases and it also for the
hbase is built for y tables it can be
scaled horizontally for instance if you
were doing a tokenizer of words and word
clusters you might have 1.4 million
different words that you're pulling up
and combinations of words so with an
rdbms it's built for thin tables that
are hard to scale you don't want to
store 1.4 million columns in your SQL
it's going to crash and it's going to be
very hard to do searches with the age
base it only stores that data which is
part of whatever row you're working on
let's look at some of the features of
the hbase it's scalable data can be
scaled across various nodes as it is
stored in the hdfs and I always think
about this it's a linear add-on for each
terabyte of data I'm adding on roughly a
thousand dollars in commodity Computing
with an Enterprise machine we're looking
at about 10 000 at the lower end for
each terabyte of data and that includes
all your backup and redundancy so it's a
big difference it's like a tenth of the
cost to store it across the hbase it has
automatic failure support right ahead
log across clusters which provides
automatic support against failure
consistent read and write hbase provides
consistent read and write of the data
it's a Java API for client access
provides easy to use Java API for
clients block cache and Bloom filters so
the hbase supports block caching and
Bloom filters for high volume query
optimization let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase storage a space column
oriented storage and I told you we're
going to look into this to see how it
stores the data and here you can see you
have a row key this is really one of the
important references is each row has to
have its own key or your row ID and then
you have your column family and in here
you can see we have column family one
column family two column family three
and you have your column qualifiers so
you can have in column family one you
can have three columns in there and
there might not be any data in that so
when you go into column family one and
do a query for every column that
contains a certain thing that row might
not have anything in there and not be
queried where in column family two maybe
you have column one filled out and
column three filled out and so on and so
forth and then each cell is connected to
the row where the data is actually
stored let's take a look at this at what
it looks like when you fill the data in
so in here we have a row key with a row
ID and we have our employee ID one two
three that's pretty straightforward you
probably would even have that on an SQL
server and then you have your column
family this is where it starts really
separating out your column family might
have personal data and under personal
data you would have name City age you
might have a lot more than just that you
might have number of children you might
have degree all those kinds of different
things that go into personal data and
some of them might be missing you might
only have the name and the age of an
employee you might only have the name
the city and how many children and not
the age and so you can see with the
personal data you can now collect a
large variety of data and stored in the
hbase very easily and then maybe you
have a family of professional data your
designation your salary all the stuff
that the employee is doing for you in
that company let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase architecture and so you
can see here what looks to be a
complicated chart it's not as
complicated as you think from the Apache
a space we have the Zookeeper which is
used for monitoring what's going on and
you have your age Master this is the
hbase master of science regions and load
balancing and then underneath the region
or the hbase master then under the H
master or H base Master you have your
reader server serves data for read and
write and the region server which is all
your different computers you have in
your Hadoop cluster you'll have a region
an H log you'll have a store memory
store and then you have your different
files for H file that are stored on
there and those are separated across the
different computers and that's all part
of the hdfs storage system so we look at
the Architectural Components or regions
and we're looking at we're drilling down
a little bit hbase tables are divided
horizontally by a row so you have a key
range into regions so each of those IDs
you might have IDs one to twenty twenty
one to 50 or whatever they are regions
are assigned to the nodes in the cluster
called region servers a region contains
all rows in the table between the region
start key and the End Key again 1 to 10
11 to 20 and so forth these servers
serve data for read and write and you
can see here we have the client and the
get and the git sends it out and it
finds out where that startup is between
which start keys and in keys and then it
pulls the data from that different
region server and so the region sign
data definition language operation
create delete are handled by the H
master so the hmaster is telling it what
are we doing with with this data what's
going out there assigning and
reassigning regions for Recovery or load
balancing and monitoring all servers so
that's also part of it so you know if
your IDs if you have 500 IDs across
three servers you're not going to put
400 IDs on server 1 and 100 on the
server 2 and leaves Region 3 and Region
4 empty you're going to split that up
and that's all handled by the H master
and you can see here it monitors region
servers assigns regions to region
servers assigns regions to Regions
servers and so forth and so forth hbase
has a distributed environment where age
Master alone is not sufficient to manage
everything hence zookeeper was
introduced it works with hmaster so you
have an active h Master which sends a
heartbeat signal to zookeeper indicating
that it's active and the Zookeeper also
has a heartbeat to the region servers so
the region servers send their status to
zookeeper indicating they are ready for
read and write operation inactive server
acts as a backup if the active age
Master fails it will come to the the
rescue active age master and region
servers connect with a session to
zookeeper so you see your activate
Master selection your region server
session they're all looking at the
Zookeeper keeping that pulse an active
age Master region server connects with a
session to the zoo keeper and you can
see here where we have ephemeral nodes
for active sessions via heartbeats to
indicate that the region servers are up
and running so let's take a look at
hbase read or write going on there's a
special hbase catalog table called The
Meta table which holds a location of the
regions in the cluster here's what
happens the first time a client reads or
writes data to age base the client gets
the region server the host the meta
table from zookeeper and you can see
right here the client has a request for
your region server and goes hey
zookeeper can you handle this the
Zookeeper takes a look at it and goes ah
metal location is stored in Zookeeper so
it looks at its metadata on there and
then the metadata table location is sent
back to the client the client will query
The Meta server to get the region server
course responding to the row key if it
wants to access the client caches this
information along with the meta table
location and you can see here the client
going back and forth to the region
server with the information and it might
be going across multiple region servers
depending on what you're querying so we
get the region server for row key from
The Meta table that's where that row key
comes in and says hey this is where
we're going with this and so once it
gets the row key from the corresponding
region server we can now put row or get
Row from that region server let's take a
look at the hbase meta table special
hbase catalog table that maintains a
list of all the region servers in the
hbase storage system so you see here we
have the meta table we have a row key
and a value table key region region
server so the meta table is used to find
the region for the given table key and
you can see down here you know our meta
table comes in is going to fire out
where it's going with the region server
and we look a little closer at the write
mechanism in hbase we have right ahead
log or wall as you abbreviate it kind of
a way to remember wall is write a head
log it's a file used to store new data
that is yet to be put on permanent
storage it is used for Recovery in the
case of failure so you can see here
where the client comes in and it
literally puts the new data coming in
into this kind of temporary storage or
the wall on there once it's gone into
the wall then the memory store mem store
is the right cache that stores a new
data that's not yet been written to disk
there is one mem store per column family
per region and once we've done that we
have three ack once the data is placed
in mimstore the client then receives the
acknowledgment when the minister reaches
the threshold it dumps or commits the
data into H file and so you can see
right here we've taken our or has gone
into the wall the wall then Source it
into the different memory stores and
then the memory stores it says Hey we've
reached we're ready to dump that into
our H files and then it moves it into
the age files age files store the Roses
data as stored key value on disk so here
we've done a lot of theory let's dive in
and just take a look and see some of
these commands look like and what
happens in our age base when we're
manipulating a no SQL setup
[Music]
so if you're learning a new setup it's
always good to start with where is this
coming from it's open source by Apache
and you can go to
hbase.apache.org and you'll see that it
has a lot of information you can
actually download the hbase separate
from the Hadoop although most people
just install the Hadoop because it's
bundled with it and if you go in here
you'll find a reference guide and so you
can go through the Apache reference
guide and there's a number of things to
look at but we're going to be going
through Apache H based shell that's what
we're going to be working with and
there's a lot of other interfaces on the
setup and you can look up a lot of the
different commands on here so we go into
the Apache hbase reference guide we can
go down to read hbase shell commands
from a command file you can see here
where it gives you different options of
formats for putting the data in and
listing the data certainly you can also
create files and scripts to do this too
but we're going to look at the basics
we're going to go through this on a
basic hbase shell and one last thing to
look at that is of course if you
continue down the setup you can see here
where they have more detail as far as
how to create and how to get to your
data on your hbase now I will be working
in a virtual box and this is by Oracle
you can download the Oracle virtual box
you can put a note in below for the
YouTube as we did have a previous
session on setting up virtual setup to
run your Hadoop system in there I'm
using the Cloudera quick start installed
in here there's Hortons you can also use
the Amazon web service there's a number
of options for trying this out in this
case we have Cloudera on the Oracle
virtual box the virtual box has Linux
Centos installed on it and then the
Hadoop it has all the different Hadoop
flavors including hbase and I bring this
up because my computer is a Windows 10
the operating system of the virtual box
is Linux and we're looking at the hbase
data warehouse and so we have three very
different entities all running on my
computer and that can be confusing if
it's a first time in and working with
this setup now you'll notice in our
Cloudera setup they actually have some
hbase monitoring so I can go underneath
here and click on each base and master
and it'll tell me what's going on with
my region servers it'll tell me what's
going on with our backup tables right
now I don't have any user tables because
we haven't created any and this is only
a single node and a single hbase tour so
you're not going to expect anything too
extensive in here since this is for
practice and education and perhaps
testing out package you're working on
it's not for really you can deploy
Cloudera of course but when you talk
about a quick start or a single node
setup that's what it's really for so we
can go through all the different hbase
and you'll see all kinds of different
information with zookeeper if you saw it
flash by down here what version we're
working in some zookeepers part of the
hbase setup where we want to go is we
want to open up a terminal window and in
Cloudera it happens to be up at the top
and when you click on here you'll see
your Cloudera terminal window open and
let me just expand this so we have a
nice full screen and then I'm also going
to zoom in and we have a nice big
picture and you can see what I'm typing
and what's going on and to open up your
age base shell simply type hbase shell
to get in and hit enter and you'll see
it takes just a moment to load and we'll
be in our H based shell for doing hbase
commands once we've gotten into our H
base shell you'll see you'll have the
hbase prompt information ahead of it we
can do something simple like list this
is going to list whatever tables we have
it so happens that there's a base table
that comes with hbase now we can go
ahead and create and I'm going to type
in just create what's nice about this is
it's going to throw me kind of a it's
going to say hey there's no just
straight create but does come up and
tell me all these different formats we
can use for create so we can create our
table and one of our families you can
add splits names versions all kinds of
things you can do with this let's just
start with a very basic one on here and
let's go ahead and create and we'll call
it new table now this is to call it new
TBL for table new table and then we also
want to do let's do knowledge so let's
take a look at this I'm creating a new
table and it's going to have a family of
knowledge in it and let me hit enter and
it's going to come up it's going to take
it a second to go ahead and create it
now we have our new table in here so if
I go list you'll now see table and new
table so you can now see that we have
the new table and of course the default
table that's set up in here and we can
do something like uh describe we can
describe and then we're going to do new
TBL and when we describe it it's going
to come up it's going to say hey name I
have knowledge data block encoding none
Bloom filter row or replication scope
version all the different information
you need new minimum version 0 forever
deleted cells false block size in memory
and you can look this stuff up on
apache.org to really track it down one
of the things that's important to note
is versions so you have your different
versions of the data that's stored and
that's always important to understand
that we might talk about that a little
bit later on and then we have to
describe it we can also do a status the
status says I have one active Master
going on that's our H base as a whole we
can do status summary I should do the
same thing as status so we got the same
thing coming up and now that we've
created let's go ahead and put something
in it so we're going to put new TBL and
then we want Row one you know what
before I even do this let's just type in
put and you can see when I type in put
it gives us like a lot of different
options of how it works and different
ways of formatting our data as it goes
in and all of them usually begin with
the new table new TBL then we have in
this case we'll call it Row one and then
we'll have knowledge if you remember we
created knowledge already and we'll do
knowledge Sports and then in knowledge
and sports we're going to set that equal
to Cricut so we're going to put
underneath this our knowledge setup that
we have a thing called Sports in there
and we'll see what this looks like in
just a second let's go ahead and put in
we'll do a couple of these let's see
let's do another Row 1 and this time
instead of sports Let's Do Science you
know this person not only you know we
have Row one which is both knowledgeable
and cricket and also in chemistry so
it's a chemist who plays Cricket in row
one and let's see if we have let's do
another row one just to keep it going
and we'll do science in this case let's
do physics not only in chemistry but
also physicist I have quite a joy in
physics myself so here we go we have Row
one there we go and then let's do row
two let's see what that looks like when
we start putting in row two and in row
two this person is has knowledge in
economics this is a master of business
and how or maybe it's Global economics
maybe it's just for the business and how
it fits in with the country's economics
and we'll call it macroeconomics so I
guess it is for the whole country there
so we have knowledge economics
macroeconomics and then let's just do
one more we'll keep it as row two and
this time our Economist is also a museum
position so we'll put music and they
happen to have knowledge and they enjoy
oh let's do pop music they're into the
current pop music going on so we've
loaded our database and you'll see we
have two rows Row one and row two in
here and we can do is we can list the
contents of our database by simply doing
scan uh scan and then let's just do scan
by itself so you can see how that looks
you can always just type in there and it
tells you all the different setups you
can do with scan and how it works in
this case we want to do scan new TBL and
in our scan new TBL we have Row one row
one row two row two and you'll see Row
one as a column called knowledge science
time step value crickets value physics
so it has the information is when it was
created when the timestamp is Row one
also has knowledge Sports and a value of
Cricut so we have sports and Science and
this is interesting because if you
remember up here we also gave it
originally we told it to come in here
and have chemistry we had science
chemistry and science physics and we
come down here I don't see the chemistry
why because we've now replaced chemistry
with physics so the new value is physics
on here let me go ahead and clear down a
little bit and in this we're going to
ask the question is enabled new table
when I hit enter in here you're going to
see it comes out true and then we'll go
ahead and disable it let's go ahead and
disable new table make sure I have our
quotes around it and now that we've
disabled it what happens when we do the
scan we do the scan new table and hit
enter you're going to see that we get an
error coming up so once it's disabled
you can't do anything with it until we
re-enable it now before we enable the
table Let's do an alteration on it and
here's our new table and this should
look a little familiar because it's very
similar to create we'll call this test
info we'll hit enter in there it'll take
just a moment for updating and then we
want to go ahead and enable it so let's
go ahead and enable our new table so
it's back up and running and then we
want to describe describe new table and
we come in here you'll now see we have
name knowledge and under there we have
our data encoding and all the
information under knowledge and then we
also have down below test info so now we
have the name test info and all the
information concerning the test info on
here and we'll simply enable it new
table so now it's enabled oops I already
did that I guess we'll enable it twice
and so let's start looking at well we
had scan new table and you can see here
where it brings up the information like
this what if we want to go ahead and get
a row so we'll do R1 and when we do
hbase R1 you can see we have knowledge
science and it has a timestamp value
physics and we have knowledge Sports and
it has a time stamp on it and value
Cricut and then let's see what happens
when we put into our new table and in
here we want Row one and if you can
guess from earlier because we did
something similar we're going to do
knowledge economics and then it's going
to be as sort of I think it was what
macroeconomics is now market economics
and we'll go back and do our git command
and now see what it looks like and we
can see here where we have knowledge
economics it has a time stamp value
market economics physics and Cricut and
this is because we have economics
science and sports those are the three
different columns that we have and then
each one has different information in it
and so if you've managed to go through
all these commands and look at Basics on
here you'll now have the ability to
create a very basic hbase setup no SQL
setup based on your columns and your
rows and just for fun we'll go back to
the Cloudera where they have the website
up for the hbase master status and I'll
go ahead and refresh it and then we can
go down here and you'll see user tables
table set one and we can click on
details and here's what we just did it
goes through so if you're the admin
looking at this you can go oh someone
just created new TBL and this is is what
they have underneath of it in their new
table in there here we will learn on
Apache spark history of spark what is
spark Hadoop which is a framework again
West spark components of Apache spark
that is spark core spark SQL spark
streaming spark ml lib and Graphics then
we will learn on spark architecture
applications of spark spark use cases so
let's begin with understanding about
history of Apache spark it all started
in 2009 as a project at UC Berkeley amp
Labs by matissah area in 2010 it was
open source under a BST license in 2013
spark became an Apache top level project
and in 2014 used by data bricks to sort
large scale data sets and it set in New
World Record so that's how Apache spark
started and today it is one of the most
in demand processing framework or I
would say in memory Computing framework
which is used across the Big Data
industry so what is Apache spark let's
learn about this Apache spark is a open
source in memory Computing framework or
you could say data processing engine
which is used to process data in batch
and also in real time across various
cluster computers and it has a very
simple programming language behind the
scenes that is Scala which is used
although if users would want to work on
spark they can work with python they can
work with Scala they can work with Java
and so on even R for that matter so it
supports all these programming languages
and that's one of the reasons that it is
called polyglot wherein you have good
set of libraries and support from all
the programming languages and developers
and data scientists incorporate spark
into their applications or build Spark
based applications to process analyze
query and transform data at a very large
scale so these are key features of
Apache spark now if you compare Hadoop
Wes spark we know that Hadoop is a
framework and it basically has mapreduce
which comes with Hadoop for processing
data however processing data using
mapreduce in Hadoop is quite slow
because it is a batch oriented operation
and it is time consuming if you if you
talk about spark spark can process the
same data 100 times faster than
mapreduce as it is a in memory Computing
framework well there can always be
conflicting ideas saying what if my
spark application is not really
efficiently coded and my mapreduce
application has been very efficiently
coded well then it's a different case
however normally if you talk about code
which is efficiently written format
reduce or for spark based processing
spark will win the battle by doing
almost 100 times faster than mapreduce
so as I mentioned Hadoop performs batch
processing and that is one of the
paradigms of mapreduce programming model
which involves mapping and reducing and
that's quite rigid so it performs batch
processing the intermittent data is
written to sdfs and written right back
from sdfs and that makes hadoops
mapreduce processing slower in case of
spark it can perform both batch and
real-time processing however a lot of
use cases are based on real-time
processing take an example of Macy's
take an example of retail giant such as
Walmart and there are many use cases who
would prefer to do real time processing
or I would say near real-time processing
so when we say real time or near real
time it is about processing the data as
it comes in or you're talking about
streaming kind of data now Hadoop or
hadoop's map reduce obviously was
started to be written in Java now you
could also write it in Scala or in
Python however if you talk about
mapreduce it will have more lines of
code since it is written in Java and it
will take more times to execute you have
to manage the dependencies you have to
do the right declarations you have to
create your mapper and reducer and
Driver classes however if you compare
spark it has few lines of code as it is
implemented in Scala and Scala is a
statically typed dynamically inferred
language it's very very concise and the
benefit is it has features from both
functional programming and object
oriented language and in case of Scala
whatever code is written that is
converted into byte codes and then it
runs in the jvm now Hadoop supports
Kerberos authentication there are
different kind of authentication
mechanisms Kerberos is one of the
well-known ones and it can really get
difficult to manage now spark supports
authentication via a shared secret it
can also run on yarn leveraging the
capability of capitals so what are spark
features which really makes it unique or
in demand processing framework when we
talk about spark features one of the key
features is fast processing so spark
contains resilient distributed data sets
so rdds are the building blocks for
spark and we learn more about rdds later
so spark contains rdds which saves huge
time taken in reading and writing
operations so it can be 100 times or you
can say 10 to 100 times faster than
Hadoop when we say in memory Computing
here I would like to make a note that
there is a difference between caching
and in-memory Computing think about it
caching is mainly to support read ahead
mechanism where you have your data
pre-loaded so that it can benefit it
further queries however when we say in
memory Computing we are talking about
lazy evaluation we are talking about
data being loaded into memory only and
only when a specific kind of action is
invoked so data is stored in Ram so here
we can say Ram is not only used for
processing but it can also be used for
storage and we can again decide whether
we would want that Ram to be used for
persistence or just for computing so it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics now
spark is quite flexible it supports
multiple languages as I already
mentioned and it allows the developers
to write applications in Java Scala r or
python it's quite fault tolerance so
spark contains these rdds or you could
say execution logic or you could say
temporary data sets which initially do
not have any data loaded and the data
will be loaded into rdds only when
execution is happening so these can be
fault tolerant as these rdds are
distributed across multiple nodes so
failure of one worker node in the
cluster will really not affect the rdds
because that portion can be recomputed
so it ensures loss of data it ensures
that there is no data loss and it is
absolutely fault tolerant it is for
better than analytics so sparked has
Rich set of SQL queries machine learning
algorithms complex analytics all of this
supported by various spark components
which we will learn in coming slides
with all these functionalities analytics
can be performed better in terms of
spark so these are some of the key
features of spark however there are many
more features which are related to
different components of spark and we
will learn about them so what are these
components of spark which I'm talking
about Spark core so this is the core
component which basically has rdds which
has a core engine which takes care of
your processing now you also have spark
SQL so people who would be interested in
working on structured data or data which
can be structurized would want to prefer
using spark SQL and Spark SQL internally
has components or features like data
frames and data sets which can be used
to process your structured data in a
much much faster way you have spark
streaming now that's again an important
component of spark which allows you to
create your spark streaming applications
which not only works on data which is
being streamed in or data which is
constantly getting generated but you
would also or you could also transform
the data you could analyze or process
the data as it comes in in smaller
chunks you have Sparks mlib now this is
basically a set of libraries which
allows developers or data scientists to
build their machine learning algorithms
so that they can do Predictive Analytics
or prescriptive descriptive preemptive
analytics or they could build their
recommendation systems or bigger smarter
machine learning algorithms using these
libraries and then you have Graphics so
think about organizations like LinkedIn
or say Twitter where you have data which
naturally has a network kind of flow so
data which could be represented in the
form of graphs now here when I talk
about graphs I'm not talking about pie
charts or bar charts but I'm talking
about Network related data that is data
which can be networked together which
can have some kind of relationship think
about Facebook think about LinkedIn
where you have one person connected to
other person or one company connected to
other companies so if we have our data
which can be represented in the form of
network graphs then spark has a
component called Graphics which I allows
you to do graph based processing so
these are some of the components of
Apache spark spark core spark SQL spark
streaming spark ml lib and Graphics so
to learn more about components of spark
let's learn here about spark core now
this is the base engine and this is used
for large scale parallel and distributed
data processing so when you work with
spark at least and the minimum you would
work with is spark core which has rdds
as the building blocks of your spark so
it is responsible for your memory
management your fault recovery
scheduling Distributing and monitoring
jobs on a cluster and interacting with
storage systems so here I would like to
make a key point that Spar by itself
does not have its own storage it relies
on storage now that storage could be
your sdfs that is hadoop's distributed
file system it could be a database like
nosql database such as hbase or it could
be any other database say rdbms from
where you could connect your spark and
then fetch the data extract the data
process it analyze it so let's learn a
little bit about your rdds resilient
distributed data sets now spark core
which is the base engine or the core
engine is embedded with the building
blocks of spark which is nothing but
your resilient distributed data set so
as the name says it is resilient so it
is existing for a shorter period of time
distributed so it is distributed across
nodes and it is a data set where the
data will be loaded or where the data
will be existing for processing so it is
immutable fault tolerant distributed
collection of objects so that's what
your rdd is and there are mainly two
operations which can be performed on and
rdd now to take an example of this say I
want to process a particular file now
here I could write a simple code in
Scala and that would basically mean
something like this so if I say well
which is to declare the variable I would
say well X and then I could use what we
call as spark context which is basically
the most important entry point of your
application so then I could use a method
of spark context for example that is
text file and then I could point it to a
particular file so this is just a method
of your spark context and Spark context
is the entry point of your application
now here I could just give a path in
this method so what does this step do it
does not do any evaluation so when I say
Val X I'm creating a immutable variable
and to that variable I'm assigning a
file now what this step does is is it
actually creates a rdd resilient
distributed data set so we can imagine
this as a simple execution logic a EMT
data set which is created in memory of
your node so if I would say I have
multiple nodes in which my data is split
and stored I'm imagining that your yarn
your spark is working with Hadoop so I
have Hadoop which is using say two nodes
and this is my distributed file system
sdfs which basically means my file is
written to hdfs and it also means that
the file related blocks are stored in
the underlying disk of these machines so
when I say Val x equals SC dot text file
that is using a method of spark context
now there are various other methods like
whole text files parallelize and so on
this step will create an rdt so you can
imagine this as a logical data set which
is created in memory across these nodes
because these nodes have the data
however no data is loaded here so this
is the first rdd and I can say first
step in what we call as a tag a dag
which will have series of steps which
will get executed at later stage now
later I could do further processing on
this I could say well Y and then I could
do something on X so I could say x dot
map and I would want to apply a function
to every record or every element in this
file and I could give a logic here x dot
map now this second step is again
creating an rdd a resilient distributed
data set you can say second step in my
dag okay and here you have a external
rdd one more rdd created which depends
on the first RTD so my first RTD becomes
the base rdd or parent ID D and the
resultant RTD becomes the child rdd then
we can go further and we could say well
Z and I would say okay now I would want
to do some filter on y so this filter
which I am doing here and then I could
give a logic might be I'm searching for
a word I am searching for some pattern
so I could say well Z equals y dot
filter which again creates one more rdd
a resilient distributed data set in
memory and a you can say this is nothing
but one more step in the dag so this is
my tag which is a series of steps which
will be executed now here when does the
execution happen when the data gets when
will the data get loaded into these rdds
so all of this that is using a method
using a transformation like map using a
transformation like filter or flat map
or anything else these are your
Transformations so the operations such
as map filter join Union and many others
will only create rdds which basically
means it is only creating execution
Logic No data is evaluated no operation
is happening right now only and only
when you invoke an action that is might
be you want to print some result might
be you want to take some elements and
see that might be you want to do a count
so those are actions which will actually
trigger the execution of this dag right
from the beginning so if I hear say Z
dot count where I would want to just
count the number of words which I am
filtering this is an action which is
invoked and this will trigger the
execution of dag right from the
beginning so this is what happens in a
spark now if I do a z dot count again it
will start the whole execution of dag
again right from the beginning so my Z
dot count second time in action is
invoked again the data will be loaded in
the first RTD then you will have map
then you will have filter and finally
you will have result so this is the core
concept of your rdds and this is how RTD
works so mainly in spark there are two
kind of operations one is your
Transformations and one is your actions
Transformations or using a method of
spark context will always and always
create an RTD or you could say a step in
the tag actions are something which will
invoke the execution which will invoke
the execution from the first rdd till
the last rdd where you can get your
result so this is how your rdds work now
when we talk about components of spark
let's learn a little bit about spark SQL
so spark SQL is a component type
processing framework which is used for
structured and semi-structured data
processing so usually people might have
their structured data stored in rdbms or
in files where data is structured with
particular delimiters and has a pattern
and if one wants to process the
structured data if one wants to use
spark to do in memory processing and
work on the structured data they would
prefer to use spark SQL so you can work
on different data formats say CSV Json
you can even work on smarter formats
like Avro parquet even your binary files
or sequence files you could have your
data coming in from an rdbms which can
then be extracted using a jdbc
connection so at the bottom level when
you talk about spark SQL it has a data
source API which basically allows you to
get the data in whichever format it is
now Spark SQL has something called as
data frame API so what are data frames
data frames in short you can visualize
or imagine as rows and columns or if
your data can be represented in the form
of rows and columns with some column
headings so data frame API allows you to
create data frames so like my previous
example when you work on a file when you
want to process it you would convert
that into an rdd using a method of smart
context or by doing some Transformations
so in the similar way when you use data
frame so when you want to use spark SQL
you would use
Sparks context which is SQL context or
Hive context or spark which allows you
to work with data frames so like in my
earlier example we were saying Val x
equals SC dot text file now in case of
data frames instead of SC you would be
using say spark dot something so spark
context is available for your data
frames API to be used in older versions
like spark 1.6 and so on we were using
Hive context or SQL context so if you
were working with spark 1.6 you would be
saying well x equals SQL context dot
here we would be using spark dot so data
frame API basically allows you to create
data frames out of your structured data
which also lets spark know that data is
already in a particular structure it
follows a format and based on that your
Sparks back in DAC scheduler right so
when I say about dag I talk about your
sequence of steps so spark is already
aware of what are the different steps
involved in your application so your
data frame API basically allows you to
create data frames out of your data and
data frames when I say I am talking
about rows and columns with some
headings and then you have your data
frame DSL language or you can use spark
SQL or Hive query language any of these
options can be used to work with your
data frames so to learn more about data
frames follow in the next sessions when
you talk about spark streaming now this
is very interesting for organizations
who would want to work on streaming data
imagine a store like Macy's where they
would want to have machine learning
algorithms now what would these machine
learning algorithms do suppose you have
lot of customers walking in the store
and they are searching for particular
product or particular item so there
could be cameras placed in the store and
this is being already done there are
cameras placed in the store which will
keep monitoring in which corner of the
store there are more customers now once
camera captures this information this
information can be streamed in to be
processed by algorithms and those
algorithms will see which product or
which series of product customers might
be interested in and if this algorithm
in real time can process based on the
number of customers based on the
available product in the store it can
come up with a attractive alternative
price so that which the price can be
displayed on the screen and probably
customers would buy the product now this
is a real-time processing where the data
comes in algorithms work on it do some
computation and give out some result and
which can then result in customers
buying a particular product so the whole
essence of this machine learning and
real-time processing will really hold
good if and when customers are in the
store or this could relate to even a
online shopping portal where there might
be machine learning algorithms which
might be doing real-time processing
based on the clicks which customer is
doing based on the clicks based on
customer history free based on customer
Behavior algorithms can come up with
recommendation of products or better
altered price so that the sale happens
now in this case we would be seeing the
essence of real-time processing only in
a fixed or in a particular duration of
time and this also means that you should
have something which can process the
data as it comes in so spark streaming
is a lightweight API that allows
developers to perform batch processing
and also real-time streaming and
processing of data so it provides secure
reliable fast processing of live data
streams so what happens here in spark
streaming in brief so you have a input
data stream now that data stream could
be a file which is constantly getting
appended it could be some kind of
metrics it could be some kind of events
based on the clicks which customers are
doing or based on the products which
they are choosing in a store this input
data stream is then pushed in through a
spark streaming application now spark
streaming application will broke break
this content into smaller streams what
we call as discreticized streams or
batches of smaller data on which
processing can happen in frames so you
could say process my file every five
seconds for the latest data which has
come in now there are also some windows
based uh options like when I say windows
I mean a window of past three events
window of past three events each event
being of five seconds so your batches of
smaller data is processed by Spark
engine and this process data can then be
stored or can be used for further
processing so that's what spark
streaming does when you talk about mlib
it's a low level machine learning
library that is simple to use scalable
and compatible with various programming
languages now Hadoop also has some
libraries like you have Apache mahaut
which can be used for machine learning
algorithm items however in terms of
spark we are talking about machine
learning algorithms which can be built
using ml Libs libraries and then spark
can be used for processing so mlib eases
the deployment and development of
scalable machine learning algorithms I
mean think about your clustering
techniques so think about your
classification where you would want to
classify the data where you would want
to do supervised or unsupervised
learning think about collaborative
filtering and many other data science
related techniques or techniques which
are required to build your
recommendation engines or machine
learning algorithms can be built using
Sparks ml lip Graphics is Spark's own
graph computation engine so this is
mainly if you are interested in doing a
graph based processing think about
Facebook think about LinkedIn where you
can have your data which can be stored
and that data has some kind of network
connections or you could say it is well
networked I could say x is connected to
y y is connected to z z is connected to
a so x y z a all of these are in terms
of graph terminologies we call as
vertices or vertex which are basically
being connected and the connection
between these are called edges so I
could say a is friend to B so A and B
are vertices and friend a relation
between them is The Edge now if I have
my data which can be represented in the
form of graphs if I would want to do a
processing in such way this could be not
only for social media it could be for
your network devices it could be a cloud
platform it could be about different
applications which are connected in a
particular environment so if you have
data which can be represented in the
form of graph then Graphics can be used
to do ETI L that is extraction
transformation load to do your data
analysis and also do interactive graph
computation so Graphics is quite
powerful now when you talk about spark
your spark can work with your different
clustering Technologies so it can work
with Apache mesos that's how Spar came
in where it was initially to prove The
credibility of Apache mesos spark can
work with yarn which is usually you will
see in different working environments
spark can also work as Standalone that
means without Hadoop spark can have its
own setup with master and workout
processes so usually or you can say
technically spark uses a Master Slave
architecture now that consists of a
driver program that can run on a master
node it can also run on a client node it
depends on how you have configured or
what your application is and then you
have multiple executors which can run on
work nodes so your master node has a
driver program and this driver program
internally has the spark context so your
spark Every Spark application will have
a driver program and that's driver
program has a inbuilt or internally used
spark context which is basically your
entry point of application for any spark
functionality so your driver or your
driver program interacts with your
cluster manager now when I say interacts
with cluster manager so you have your
spark context which is the entry point
that takes your application request to
the cluster manager now as I said your
cluster manager could be say Apache
missiles it could be yarn it could be
spark Standalone Master itself so your
cluster manager in terms of yarn is your
resource manager so your spark
application internally runs as series or
setup tasks and processes your driver
program wherever that is run will have a
spark context and Spark context will
take care of your application execution
how does that do it spark context will
talk to Cluster manager so your cluster
manager could be on and in terms of when
I say cluster manager for yarn would be
resource manager so at high level we can
say a job is split into multiple tasks
and those tasks will be distributed over
the slave nodes or worker nodes so
whenever you do some kind of
transformation or you use a method of
spark context and rdd is created and
this rdd is distributed across multiple
nodes as I explained earlier worker
nodes are the slaves that run different
tasks so this is how a spark
architecture looks like now we can learn
more about spark architecture and its
interaction with yarn so usually what
happens when your spark context
interacts with the cluster manager so in
terms of yarn I could say resource
manager now we already know about yarn
so you would have say node managers
running on multiple machines and each
machine has some RAM and CPU cores
allocated for your node manager on the
same machine you have the data nodes
running which obviously are there to
have the Hadoop related data so whenever
the application wants to process the
data your application via spark contacts
contacts the cluster managers that is
resource manager now what does resource
manager do resource manager makes a
request so resource manager makes
request to the node manager of the
machines wherever the relevant data
resides asking for containers so your
resource manager is negotiating or
asking for containers from node manager
saying hey can I have a container of 1GB
RAM and one CPU core can I have a
container of 1GB RAM and one CPU core
and your node manager based on the kind
of processing it is doing will approve
or deny it so node manager would say
fine I can give you the container and
once this container is allocated or
approved by node manager resource
manager will basically start an extra
piece of code called App Master so App
Master is responsible for execution of
your applications whether those are
spark applications or mapreduce so your
application Master which is a piece of
code will run in one of the containers
that is it will use the RAM and CPU core
and then it will use the other
containers which were allocated by node
manager to run the tasks so it is within
this container which can take care of
execution so what is a container a
combination of RAM and CPU core so it is
within this container we will have a
executed process which would run and
this executed process is taking care of
your application related tasks so that's
how overall spark Works in integration
with yarn now let's learn about this
spark cluster managers as I said spark
can work in a standalone mode so that is
without Hadoop so by default application
submitted to spark Standalone mode
cluster will run in fifo order and each
application will try to use all the
available nodes so you could have a
spark Standalone cluster which basically
means you could have multiple nodes on
one of the nodes you would have the
master process running and on the other
nodes you would have the spark worker
processes running so here we would not
have any distributed file system because
spark is Standalone and it will rely on
an external storage to get the data or
probably the file system of the nodes
where the data is stored and processing
will happen across the nodes where your
worker processes are running you could
have spark working with Apache mesos now
as I said Apache my source is a open
source project to manage your computer
clusters and can also run Hadoop
applications Apache mesos was introduced
earlier and Spark came in and has
existence to prove The credibility of
Apache missiles you can have spark
working with hadoop's yarn this is
something which widely you will see in
different working environments so yarn
which takes care of your processing and
can take care of different processing
Frameworks also supports spark you could
have kubernetes now that is something
which is making a lot of news in today's
world it is a open source system for
automating deployment scaling and
management of containerized applications
so where you could have multiple Docker
based images which can be connecting to
each other so spark also works with
kubernetes now let's look at some
applications of spark so JPMorgan Chase
and company uses Spark to detect
fraudulent transactions analyze the
business spends of an individual to
suggest offers and identify patterns to
decide how much to invest and where to
invest so this this is one of the
examples of banking a lot of banking
environments are using spark due to its
real-time processing capabilities and in
memory faster processing where they
could be working on fraud detection or
credit analysis or pattern
identification and many other use cases
Alibaba group that uses also spark to
analyze large data sets of data such as
real-time transaction details now that
might be based online or in the stores
looking at the browsing history in the
form of spark jobs and then provides
recommendations to its users so Alibaba
group is using spark in its e-commerce
domain you have IQ via now this is a
leading Healthcare company that uses
Spark to analyze patients data identify
possible health issue use and diagnose
it based on the medical history so there
is a lot of work happening in healthcare
industry where real-time processing is
finding a lot of importance and real
time and faster processing is what is
required so healthcare industry and iqvi
is also using spark you have Netflix
which is known and you have Riot games
so entertainment and gaming companies
like Netflix and ride games use Apache
spark to Showcase relevant
advertisements to their users based on
the videos that they have watched shared
or liked so these are few domains which
find use cases of spark that is banking
e-commerce Healthcare entertainment and
then there are many more which are using
spark in their day-to-day activities for
real time in memory faster processing
now let's discuss about the Spark's use
case and let's talk about conviva which
is world's leading video streaming
companies so video streaming is a
challenge now if you talk about YouTube
which has data you could always read
about it so YouTube has data which is
worth watching 10 years so that is huge
amount of data where people are
uploading their videos or companies are
doing advertisements and this videos are
streamed in or can be watched by users
so video streaming is a challenge and
especially with increasing demand for
high quality streaming experiences
conviva collects data about video
streaming quality to give their
customers visibility into the end user
experience they are delivering now how
do they do it Apache spark again using
Apache spark convert delivers a better
quality of service to its customers by
removing the screen buffering and
learning in detail about Network
conditions in real time this information
is then stored in the video player to
manage live video traffic effect coming
in from 4 billion video feeds every
month to ensure maximum retention Now
using Apache spark conveyor has created
an auto diagnostics alert it
automatically detects anomalies along
the video streaming Pipeline and
diagnosis the root cause of the issue
now this really makes it one of the
leading video streaming companies based
on auto diagnostic alerts it reduces
waiting time before the video starts it
avoids buffering and recovers the video
from a technical error and the whole
goal is to maximize the viewer
engagement so this is Spark's use case
where conviva is using spark in
different ways to stay ahead in video
streaming related deliveries if we have
understood and learned about your spark
components your spark architecture we
can also see running a spark application
now a spark application can run in a
standalone mode that is you could set up
your IDE such as Eclipse with a Scala
plugin and then you could have your
coded application which is written in
Eclipse to be run in local mode now here
I have an example of application which
can be run in a local mode or on a
cluster so this application is importing
some packages that is spark context
spark conf I have created an object
which is first app it is the main class
of your project and other classes can
just be extending app rather than having
main here we declare a variable called X
which is pointing to a file in my
project directory it looks for a file
which is abc1 dot text and this file
basically has some content what are we
doing in the application so we create a
variable where we assign the file then
we Define name or initializers for
context so remember whenever you work
with IDE you don't have spark context or
spark available implicitly that has to
be defined so here we create a
configuration object we set our
application name we set the master as
local if you want to run it in a local
mode if you want to run it say on your
Windows machine or if you would want to
run on a spark Standalone cluster if I
would be running it on yarn then I would
remove this property that is set master
now once you have defined your
configuration object you can be
basically using spark context you can
use method of it which will result in
RTD that is what is happening in line 13
Val Y and then finally I can create a
variable where I would want to do a flat
map transformation on Y which would
result in an internal rdd followed by a
map transformation which would again
result in an rdd and finally Reduce by
key which is doing an aggregation once
all these steps are done I can decide to
display the result on the screen or I
can even use save as text file point it
to a particular location and then have
my application run now this is my
Eclipse refer to other sessions where I
have explained how you can set up Ide on
windows with different environment
variables and then you can run your
applications on a particular cluster if
I would want to run this application on
a cluster then I will have to give a
particular path so here in this case I
can say let's do this and I will say my
file is abc1.txt let's save it and I'll
also say my output will be getting
stored in a default location as I intend
to run it I intend to run this
application on a cluster now in that
case the cluster would usually be set up
on Linux machines would have a Hadoop
cluster where you can run this
application so if I would want to run
this application on a cluster but not
locally on the machine I can just delete
this part I can keep my application now
if you see my application already
compiles and does not show any error
message and that is because in my
Project's build path I have added all
the spark related jars all the spark
related jars you can get from your spark
directory or you can be getting in
manually all the dependencies some
people would prefer to use Maven or say
SBT for packaging your application as
jar and that can also be done so here my
code compiles code is fine it is
pointing to a file and then it is also
creating an output which will have word
count now what I can do is since I have
my code already written I know that I
have SBT installed on this machine
because I would want to package this
code AS jar and run it on a cluster so
for that we can look in our Command
Prompt and here I can go into workspace
is I can go into my Scala project and if
you see here we have your build dot SBT
file you have your binaries and you have
your source so you might not have these
spark related directories now these
exist in my case because I have been
using spark and I've done some previous
runs now this is what we have within my
spark apps so to build my package I need
a build dot spt file we can see what
does that contain so your build.sbt
contains your name version of your
package or Scala version spark version
and then repository which spark will
refer to when it wants to have the
dependencies for all of your components
such as bar core spark SQL ml lab and so
on so this is my build.spd file which
exists in the project folder and if you
are intending to use SBT to package your
code AS jar and then run it on the
cluster in that case I can even skip
adding spark related charge to the build
path so that is only done to make sure
that your code compiles now once I have
my code written I have SBT installed I
have made the file path changes I can
just go to the command line within my
project folder and I can say SBT package
now this will basically resolve all the
dependencies based on whatever you have
given in the code it will create a jar
file and place it in a particular
location and then we can use the same
jar file to run on a particular cluster
so SVD package is busy in creating the
jar now meanwhile what I can do is I can
open up a lab content and what I can do
is I can just say for example simply
learn and here I already have a lab set
up so you could have your own spark
Standalone cluster where you you could
also run this jar file you could have
spark with Hadoop which is what I have
here and I will use that to submit an
application on the yarn cluster and
let's go to the web console let me copy
my link I'll close this I'll say launch
lab and then I can log in here I can
just do paste my password and I'm logged
in so I can just say spark to Shell now
that's how it has been configured here
to work with your spark version 2. so
this is an interactive way of bringing
you your spark shell and running your
application but what we are interested
in is running the application as HR file
so let's go and see here where we have
our code and let's see if SBT has done
the packaging yes it has done and it has
created a jar file in this location so
what I can do is I need to get this jar
file from this location onto my cluster
so what I can do is I can come in here I
can do a FTP so this basically allows me
to push whatever jars I have on my web
console so I'll go in here I'll say
connect now I'll search if there is
already existing jar file which might
create a conflict so I have something
here so I can for now just delete it
it's done I will say upload file and I
am interested in getting the jar file so
here we can click on users win 10 I have
my workspace project I can get into
Target Scala 2.11 and take my jar file
and say open so this will upload my jar
file on the web console or The Terminal
wherein I can connect to my cluster now
let's go in here let's quit from spark
shell as we want to run an application
on the cluster how do I do it so I again
search if I have my jar file existing
it's here so I'll say spark to submit
and then I will point to my jar file and
then I can simply say class and I know
my code has a package and a class name
so this is package and this is my object
or class name so I can say main dot
Scala DOT first app now it will be good
if we check if the file exists which are
code points to so I'll just for now
comment it out I will check in my stfs
LS in my default user directory this is
where it will search for a file and here
we can search if I have a file called
ABC so I don't see anything here so
let's do this what I can do is I can
again go to FTP and basically I can do a
upload file like what we did earlier and
this time I'll pick up this existing ABC
one file which I showed you and upload
it once this is done I can put it on my
cluster by just saying hdfs DFS put
let's take the ABC one file and let's
put it in my directory so this will be
my input so I'm putting in a file there
and now I can do a spark submit to
submit the application on the cluster so
if you see here it has basically started
the application it contacts the resource
manager it gets an application ID and
now it is doing the processing of my
file where I would want to get once this
is done it will be completed and the
temporary directory will be deleted so
this is how I run a spark application on
a cluster now once this is done I can
also go to Sparks history server by
saying this is the path for my spark
history server it shows an application
which was run today which was doing a
word count you can click on the
application it says it ended with save
as text file you can click on this and
then it shows you the dag visualization
it says we started with text file we did
a flat map we did a map and then there
was some shuffling because we wanted to
do Reduce by key so as I said every RDP
e by default has two partitions and if
you want to do some aggregate or wider
Transformations like Reduce by key sort
by key Group by key count by key and so
on in that case similar key related data
has to be shuffled and brought into one
partition that's where we see shuffling
happening here and it also tells what
are the number of tasks which have run
per partition so here we ran a spark
application by packaging it as jar using
your SBT so SBD created the jar file and
then basically we brought our jar file
onto the cluster and then submitted it
using spark submit so this is how a
spark application runs on the cluster so
as I said your application has a driver
program now your spark applications run
as independent processes and they can
run on a cluster across the nodes so we
just saw how we can run s spark
application on a cluster now we can
always look at spark applications
progress or after it has completed by
looking into the spark UI your spark
application as I mentioned has a driver
program and when you run your
application on the cluster you can
always specify where would you want your
driver program to run so in our case
when we ran our spark application here
we basically just did a simple spark
submit and we gave our jar and the class
name I could also say master and then I
could specify if I would want my
application to run in a local mode or I
could say yarn but that is default or if
it was a spark stand alone cluster then
I could be giving something like this
your host name and then your Port so you
could do all of these options by
specifying minus minus master I could
also specify how many executors I need
how much memory per executor how much
cores per executor I need and I could
also say deploy mode as client which
basically means my driver will run on
this machine however my execution of
application will happen on cluster nodes
I can also say deploy mode as cluster
which basically means my driver will run
on one of the nodes of the cluster you
could submit your application and then
based on whatever arguments you have
given your application will be submitted
on the cluster and it will run so you
can have your application running so as
I said you have an application which has
a driver and it also has either spark
session or spark context which takes
your application request to the resource
manager now if your application is
completed you can always come back and
look into the spark history server or
spark UI if I choose this as my
application which I have run I can go to
executors and that shows me that there
was one for your driver now that was
running on this particular node which is
my client node then I have my executors
on my other nodes which are nodes of my
cluster which used one core which ran
two tasks for the partitions which they
were working on and there was some
shuffling involved as we were doing a
world count which uses Reduce by key so
when you run your application your yarn
or your cluster manager such as resource
manager negotiates the resources to the
slave processes your worker node
basically will have the resources
available for any kind of execution now
as I said your resource manager will
request for containers your worker nodes
will approve those containers and then
within those containers you will have
the executor which will run which will
take care of the task to process the
data so what is a task it is a unit of
work for the data set which has to be
worked upon so your rdds which get
created have partitions and for every
partition you have a task which is taken
care by the executor so the data is
loaded into the rdd when action is
invoked and then your task is worked
upon by the executor so what does it do
it basically gets the data into the
partition of rdd and then does the
execution as a task on that particular
partition results are then sent back to
the driver and you can also have your
output saved on the disk so this is how
your application run whenever you run a
particular application you can always go
to your web console and scroll or look
into the logs for more information so
here our application was run and we can
see right from the beginning here when
we talk about spark submit which is done
here it says running spark version 2.2
it basically then will see that there
will be a driver which will be started
you can further see that it does some
memory calculations it then starts as
spark UI and here we can see that
requesting a new application from
cluster with four node managers verify
our application has not requested more
than maximum memory capability of the
cluster so the container sizing at the
cluster level is 3gb per container and
your application should not be
requesting for a container bigger than
that it starts a application Master
container with specific amount of memory
and then finally your execution starts
if we scroll down and look into the logs
we will see where my driver runs it will
also see show you how much memory was
utilized and it will talk about tax
scheduler which is taking care of
execution of your dag that is series of
your rdds and finally you will see the
result getting generated or saved so
this this is how you run your spark
application this is how you can see your
spark applications in history server or
spark UI and this is how overall Apache
spark Works utilizing your cluster
manager help getting the resources from
the worker processes and then running
the executors within those here we will
learn on what is spark streaming spark
streaming data sources features of spark
streaming working of spark streaming
disk criticized streams caching or
persistence as we call checkpointing in
spark streaming and we will then have a
demo on spark streaming so let's learn
on what is spark streaming and what it
is capable of so it's an extension of
core spark API that basically enables
scalable High throughput fault tolerant
stream processing of live data streams
now data can be ingested from different
sources like Kafka Flume kinosis or TCP
sockets and then it can be processed
using complex algorithms expressed with
different kind of functions such as map
reduce join in window and when we have
the data processed that data can be
pushed out to your file systems
databases and live dashboards so if we
look on this image we can clearly see
that we would be working on a input data
stream which goes into spark streaming
component of spark which gives us
batches of input data or you could say
the streaming data is broken down into
smaller patches which would then be
worked upon by spark core engine and you
have finally batches of processed data
now when we talk about spark streaming
and the data sources you could have
streaming data sources coming in from
Kafka or Flume or say Twitter API or
also with different formats such as
parquet you you could also have static
data sources coming in from mongodb
hbase MySQL and postgres so when we talk
about spark streaming it receives the
input data streams divides the data into
batches which can then be processed by
Spark engine to generate your final
stream of results again in batches so
your spark streaming actually provides a
high level abstraction called
discreticized stream and we will learn
about that or what we call as dstream
which represents a continuous stream of
data now when we look at your different
data sources from where the data can
come in spark streaming would take in
this input and then you could have even
your mlib component which could be used
that is Sparks component to build
machine learning algorithms wherein you
can train your models with live data and
you can even use your trained model you
could be also going for structured
processing or processing the data which
is structurized and that could be done
by using Sparks components that is spark
SQL which has data frames and data sets
so you could process your data with data
frames interactively query with SQL when
spark streaming is working on the data
which is constantly flowing in finally
the data which is processed can be
stored in your distributed file system
such as sdfs or any other nosql or SQL
based database now when we talk about
spark streaming it is good to know some
of the features of spark streaming and
here you have some of the features so it
enables fast recovery from failures
while it is working on streaming data
you have better load balancing and
resource usage and you can also combine
the streaming data with static data sets
and perform interactive queries now your
spark streaming also supports native
integration with Advanced processing
libraries and that is one of the
benefits users can have when they are
used using spark streaming let's learn
about working of spark streaming so as I
mentioned earlier at one end you have
your data streams now those data streams
are then caught or perceived by your
receivers which we have to enable in our
application your data streams or
streaming data which is constantly
getting generated and flowing in is
broken down into smaller batches which
will then be processed by spark so you
would have your final processed results
now if we look at the bigger picture
here we will talk about live input data
streams that could be divided into
smaller batches and when we say batches
these are batches of input data as rdps
so spark streaming performs computation
expressed using these streams it
generates rdd Transformations so you
would have your spark pad jobs to
execute rdd Transformations which would
give you your final processed result now
there are various examples and we'll
look at examples later so once your
spark streaming works on Breaking the
input into smaller streams it can then
process the data finally giving you
batches of your result and that is again
on the streaming data now what is these
D streams let's understand about these
streams or discretized streams so that's
the basic abstraction provided by spark
streaming now it represents a continuous
stream of data either the input data
stream received from The Source or the
process data stream generated by
transforming the input stream now here
if we look at the dstream we would say
you would have series of rdds or series
of Transformations applied on the data
which is flowing in for a particular
time frame now here we say data from
time 0 to 1 and that would result in
some of the Transformations which you
would perform on the data when it has
come in between this time zone or time
frame you would have again data from
time one to two and so on so that that's
how your spark streaming works so if we
look at your different Transformations
now there could be various
Transformations which could be applied
on your data so this is something like
your streaming data which comes in you
would want to say have a receiver which
monitors a particular socket or a
particular port and looks for data
coming in we would also Define the time
interval and for that time interval the
data is taken so that's a smaller batch
or a d stream on which you could have
your processing done now within your
application you would have series of
steps which are nothing but
Transformations which would be performed
on this data within this time frame
giving you a result which could be
stored which could be seen on your
console or which could just be pushed
further for processing and this keeps
happening at regular type intervals
whatever you have specified till the
spark streaming application continues
now when we talk about spark we already
know that there are different kind of
Transformations which can be applied so
you have map transformation wherein you
have map and then you pass in a function
which basically says you would want to
perform a function on every element so
when we say map function that would
return a new D stream by passing each
element of the source D stream through a
function which is passed similarly it is
for flat map where you would be passing
in a function you would want to perform
a flat map transformation on the data
stream or D stream which comes in so
each input item can be mapped to zero or
more output elements you could be doing
a filter wherein you return a d stream
by selecting only the records of the
source V stream on which the function
returns true so filtering is used when
you want to run a transformation where
you would want to look at the input data
for a particular time interval as I
mentioned earlier and you would want to
filter that data as per whatever your
function is applied now you could be
doing a union where you could basically
be having a union of multiple D streams
so that this would return a new D stream
that contains Union of elements in the
source restraint and a other dstream you
could be doing a transform function that
contains the union of elements you could
be doing a count you could be doing a
join so these are some of the
Transformations which can be performed
on your D streams now there is also a
concept of windowing and that is
basically to process the data for a
series of time intervals so when I
mention windowed stream processing I am
saying spark streaming would allow you
to apply Transformations over a sliding
window of data now this operation is
called as windowed computation let's see
how it looks like so if you have your
original D stream which is being which
is basically your data coming in now
that would be looked upon for specific
time intervals such as time 1 time 2 and
then you could be doing a windowed
computation which could basically mean
that I could have a window which is a
series of these time intervals on which
you would want to perform series of your
rdd Transformations so you have a window
dstream at time one then at time two and
time three so that could be one window
wherein you would want to get an output
so here we see window at time three now
you could also have a another sliding
window which would take your time series
and we have time 3 Time 4 and time 5
where you could be performing the series
of Transformations so this is usually
helpful where you would not only want to
process the data at particular time
interval but you would want a
Consolidated processing for series of
intervals and that's what we mean by
windowed computation now before we
understand about caching and persistence
we can talk a little bit more on
windowing so if one would want to
understand the window stream processing
or as we say spark streaming's feature
of windowed computations we need to
think it as applying Transformations
over a sliding window of data now as we
see here every time the window slides
over a source D stream the source rdds
that fall within the window are combined
and operated upon to produce the rdds of
windowed stream now in this specific
case we can say the operation is applied
over last three time units of data and
slides by two time units this shows that
any window operation needs to specify
two parameters one is the window length
which is basically the duration of
window so for example we can say 3 as we
see in the figure here and then you have
a sliding interval which is basically
the interval at which window operation
is performed so these two parameters
must be multiples of the batch interval
of source D stream so that's what we do
when we talk about window now there are
various other Transformations which can
be applied for window based operations
which can be done on your D streams here
to talk a little bit more on these
streams which is as I said it's a basic
abstraction provided by spark streaming
it represents a just remember it has a
continuous stream of data now either the
input data stream received from Source
or the process data stream which is
generated by transforming the input
Stream So a d stream is represented by
you could say a continuous series of
rtds which is Sparks abstraction of a
immutable distributed data set so any
operation applied on a dstream it is
basically translating to operations on
the underlying rdds now for example we
can say converting a stream of lines to
word the flat map operation is applied
on each rdd in the line lines now D
stream to generate the rdds of your
words T Stream So when we talk about
your discretized streams understand that
you would have a series of
Transformations which would be applied
for this time interval whatever has been
specified now when you talk about your
streaming or smart streaming
architecture as I mentioned here that is
your receivers now that plays a very
important role here so your input D
streams or data streams are representing
the stream of input data that is
received from your streaming sources now
we could have different kind of data and
we could be doing different kind of
Transformations so your receiver is
basically an object which receives the
data from a source and stores it in
Sparks memory for processing and that's
the main role of your receiver now spark
streaming provides two categories of
building streaming sources so you have
basic sources that is sources directly
available in streaming context which is
a class we learn about it such as your
file systems or socket connections so
those could be your basic sources from
where the data is coming in you could
have advanced sources like your Kafka
Flume kindnesses Etc and they would be
available through extra utility classes
so your receiver is going to be looking
into the data which is constantly
getting generated and then basically
forwarding it for processing by your
spark streaming you know when we talk
about your spark streaming one more
important aspect is basically
understanding the caching and
persistence now as we know from the
spark core engine or as you should know
that rdds are say your logical steps or
rdds are created when you perform some
Transformations and these
Transformations or these computations or
these rdds can be cached so that it can
improve the performance of your
application so the computed rtds or the
rdds which are result of some performing
some Transformations they can be cached
so that they can be reutilized down your
application for your further processing
so when we talk about your caching in
persistence these streams also allows
developers to purchase the stream data
in memory so similar to your concept of
rdds these streams can allow you to
purchase the particular streams data in
memory now that is by doing or using
your persist method on a dstream which
will automatically persist every rdd of
that dstream in memory it could be every
rdd or it could be specifically chosen
rdds now this is really useful if the
data in dstream has to be or would be
computed multiple times say in your
application so for example if we say
window based operations like Reduce by
window or reduced by key and window
wherein you have group of operations
being done or you you could have state
based operations like update state by
key now in any of these cases your D
streams generated by say window based
operations are automatically persisted
in memory without the developer calling
for the persist method now for input
streams that receive data over networks
such as Kafka Flume sockets Etc the
default persistence level is set to
replicate the data to two nodes for
fault tolerance now one thing which we
should remember is unlike your rdds the
default persistence level of T streams
keeps the data data serialized in memory
and that we can discuss again further
about your serializations or
deserialization now one important aspect
which takes care of your fault recovery
is checkpointing mechanism in spark
streaming now when I say checkpointing a
streaming application as in real
scenario we would want must operate 24
bar 7 and if the stream application is
constantly running then there has to be
a mechanism which can make your
streaming application resilient to
failures which can be unrelated to your
application logic so spark streaming
needs to do the checkpointing it needs
to checkpoint enough information to a
fault tolerant underlying storage system
such that it can recover from failures
so your checkpointing is the process to
make streaming applications more fault
tolerant or resilient to your failures
now this is usually used when you would
want to recover from failure of a node
running the driver of streaming
application now we know driver is
existing for every application and it is
basically one which knows the flow of
your application driver also has the
context in case of streaming application
we would have say the spark streaming
context which is the entry point of your
application now when we talk about your
checkpointing to ensure your screen
gaming application is more fault
tolerant you have two kinds of
checkpointing here so you could have a
metadata checkpointing and you could
have data checkpointing now when we talk
about metadata what does that include so
metadata includes configuration dstream
operations or even incomplete batches so
when we talk about metadata it has
configuration so configuration that was
used to create the streaming application
you could have t-stream operations that
is set of dstream operations that Define
the streaming application that is your
series of rdds and then you have
incomplete batches or batches whose jobs
are queued but not have completed so
this would have to be checkpointed so
metadata checkpointing is used for
recovering from a node failure running
the streaming application driver now
your metadata which has your
configuration incomplete batches and D
stream operations need to be saved in an
underlying storage system now when you
talk about data checkpointing it is
mainly about saving the generated rtds
to reliable storage that is whatever
rdds are computed so saving the
information which is saving the
computations to a storage like sdfs now
that is used in stateful Transformations
combining data across various batches so
when we talk about Transformations
whatever rtds are generated that depend
on rdds of previous batches if we are
talking about stateful and that can
cause the length of dependency chain to
increase or keep increasing with time
now to avoid any kind of increase in the
recovery time intermediate rtds can be
periodically checkpointed and that could
be done to a reliable storage to
basically cut off the growing dependency
changes so if we would want to summarize
we would say metadata checkpointing is
primarily needed for recovery from
driver failures whereas data or RTD
checkpointing is necessary even for
basic functioning if stateful
Transformations are used and we should
remember we are talking about stateful
Transformations here so when we talk
about checkpointing now the question is
when would you enable checkpointing or
what would you do to enable
checkpointing so checkpointing must be
enabled for applications with different
kind of requirements so for example if
you are using stateful Transformations
where one series of rtds depend on the
result of your previous matches so
something like update state by key or
reduced by key in window now if these
kind of operations are used in your
application then checkpoint directory
must be provided to allow for periodic
rdd checkpointing when we say about
requirements then recovering from
failures of the driver which is taking
care of your application metadata
checkpoints should be used when we talk
about simple streaming applications
without the stateful Transformations
they could be run without enabling
checkpointing because you are one batch
of rdds it does not depend on the
previous set of rdds which were done in
the previous time frame now recovery
from driver failures will also be
partial in that case when you talk about
your stateless so some might be received
and your unprocessed data might be lost
but then that's pretty much acceptable
when you talk over spark streaming
applications so here we look at your
checkpointing so we say start now you
have a checkpointing now whenever your
application is creating a streaming
context it would create it would set a
checkpoint path and then you would
Define your D stream which is nothing
but series of your rdd Transformations
your streaming context starts which is
basically your application entry point
into the cluster for processing and at
any point of time if there is any
failure you could always recover using
the checkpoint which was created in case
of spark streaming one more thing we
need to remember is that your
checkpointing can be enabled by setting
a direct Tree in a fault tolerant
reliable file system such as sdfs
wherein the checkpointing information
will be saved so we will have to add
some methods within your application
like streaming context with a checkpoint
and then pointing to a checkpoint
directory and in that way we can have
our stateful Transformations or metadata
information stored in the underlying
storage whichever we have chosen now
that we have discussed about spark
streaming some basics of spark streaming
let's also understand about shared
variables or what we call as accumulator
and broadcast variables so normally when
you talk about your spark operations
such as your map or reduce these are
executed on one of the node of your
cluster and what happens is when you
talk about your operations they work on
separate copies of all variables used in
the function now in this case variables
are copied to each machine and no
updates to the variables on remote
machines are propagated back to the
driver program now when we talk about
read write shared variables across tasks
that would be inefficient so spark
actually provides two limited types of
shared variables for common usage
patterns and those are your broadcast
variables and your accumulators now when
you talk about your accumulators these
are variables that are only added
through an associative or commutative
operation so spark natively supports
accumulators of numeric types and
programmers can add support for your new
types so when we talk about accumulators
they can be used to implement counters
such as your map reduce or sums so as a
user you can create named or unnamed
accumulators now as we see in the image
here a named accumulator in this
instance counter will display in web UI
for the stage that modifies that
accumulator spark displays the value for
each accumulator Modified by a task in
the tasks table now tracking
accumulators in the UI can be useful for
understanding the progress of your
running stages but we should remember
that as of now this is not supported in
Python might be in future the support
for python will also be added now when
you talk about your accumulators you can
have say a numeric accumulator created
by calling a spark context and its
method such as long accumulator or you
could have double accumulator to
accumulate values of type long or double
respectively so tasks running on a
cluster can then add to it using the add
method now we cannot I mean in this case
the value cannot be read but driver
program can read the accumulators value
using its Value method we can look at
some examples to understand this later
now when you talk about your broadcast
variable that is one more type of
variables which allows the programmers
to keep a read-only variable cast on
each machine rather than shipping a copy
of it with tasks now what we know is
sometimes you might be doing very
costlier operations like joins where you
might be working on multiple rtds they
need to be joined and these rtds could
also be pair rdds which could be key
value pairs now whenever you are
performing a join there would be kind of
two level of shuffling one within a
particular rdd so if you are joining two
rdds the first RTD which might have data
in the form of key value pairs that rdd
would have to have some shuffling where
all the similar keys can be brought into
one partition and this would happen on
the second RTD also which has again key
value Pairs and then if you are doing a
join these rtds will be shipped to the
node or basically the data would be
loaded in the memory and then basically
your transformation will happen this can
be a costlier affair so what can be done
is you could create broadcast variables
so for example if we have two rtds and
we want to perform a join operation and
if one rdd is known to be smaller then
we can create a broadcast variable of
the smaller rdd so that this variable
itself can be shipped to each machine
and then this variable can be used for
your join operations with the other rdd
which is existing in the memory of those
nodes so that saves time and that
improves your performance so spark
basically attempts to distribute the
broadcast variable using efficient
broadcast algorithms to reduce the
communication cost now if for example
you have multiple nodes in a cluster and
if you would want to give every node a
copy of large input data set in an
efficient manner so spark actions are
executed through a set of stages now we
know that and stages are separated by
your Shuffle operations so whenever we
talk about narrow dependencies such as
map flat map filter you would not have
any shuffling involved but if you go for
group by key Reduce by key and such
operations to bring the similar Keys
together there would be shuffling
involved and also this applies when you
are doing some join operations so in
that case broadcast variables could be a
really plus where one set of data or rdd
which is already computed that could be
broadcasted to other nodes so the data
broadcasted will be cached in serialized
form and deserialized before running
each task this means that explicitly
creating broadcast variables can be
useful when tasks across multiple stages
need the same data or when caching the
data in deserialized form is important
so we can create broadcast variables
using spark context and its method
called broadcast and your broadcast
variable can then be shipped to other
nodes which can be used for your other
operations now when you talk about smart
streaming it is used in various use
cases I mean you could talk about speech
recognition you could talk about
sentiment analysis you could talk about
uh streaming applications which would be
performing some kind of analytics on the
data which is coming in it is also used
widely in retail chain companies now if
we look at the example here so big
retail chain companies would want to
build real-time dashboards so that they
can keep a track of their inventory and
operations and for this they would need
one streaming data or data which is
constantly getting generated as source
which needs to be processed on and this
information can then be populating your
dashboards to give you a real-time
scenario or real-time information of
what is happening so in case of an
inventory dashboard you could use then
these interactive dashboards wherein you
could draw insights about the business
and that's what retail companies are
doing so how many products are being
purchased or products that have been
shipped or how many products have been
delivered to customers and this kind of
information would be good to capture in
real time so when the streaming data is
basically being processed so at one end
you have your data which is getting
generated that might be based on the
sales which are happening that might be
based on the products which are being
shipped or that might be based on the
acknowledgment that the products have
been received now while this data is
getting generated at various sources it
can be subjected to a spark streaming
application which will look into the
streaming data perform series of
Transformations which you would want to
process the data at regular time
intervals and then pushing it to your
dashboards or to your storage layer
wherein it could then be used to answer
such questions so when we talk about
spark streaming it's an ideal choice to
process this kind of data in real time
and there are various use cases so at
one end if you see you have a input
stream which shows the product status
that is how many products were purchased
or shipped or delivered now this would
be then handled by your spark streaming
and also your spark core engine which
would then process the data to give you
an output stream which gives you a
status such as what was the total count
of products which are purchased products
which were shipped and products which
were delivered so this was a quick and
brief introduction to spark streaming
and how it works now we can also see how
spark streaming works or how we create
an application for that what we can do
is we can basically set up our Eclipse
to have your Scala based spark
applications and for that what you could
do is you could have your Eclipse which
can then be having a Scala plugin added
to it now if somebody would want to look
at the Scala plugin then you can always
go to Scala Dot
ide.org and this is the place where you
can scroll towards the bottom you can
click on stable and that basically also
shows you a video how Scala plugin can
be added to your Eclipse it also tells
from where you can get the Scala latest
release and this can be added to your
Eclipse so in my case it has already
been added to the eclipse I'm bringing
it up here and then you can have your
applications built using your IDE people
would prefer to use IntelliJ and that's
also fine so you could also look for
videos on setting up IntelliJ with your
Scala plugin now there are two ways one
you can build your application run it on
your Windows machine when you could have
some kind of utility like netcat which
can be used to send in some messages in
a streaming fashion you could have a
receiver which looks at a particular
socket at a particular port and you
could build a streaming application
within your IDE run it on your Windows
machine in a local mode which would then
be looking at your Source where the data
is getting generated that's one option
the second option is you could build
your application package it as jar and
then run it on a cluster now that could
be a spark Standalone cluster or spark
with yarn and then you could be
packaging your application using tools
like SBT and then use spark submit to
submit your application now I'll show
you both the ways in which you can work
with streaming applications so first is
get your eclipse and make sure that
scalar plugin is already added now in my
case on the right top corner I see Scala
symbol that says I can be using Scala
perspective now here I have some
projects so what you can do is you can
create a project by saying new Scala
project you can give it a name name so
for example I could say my apps 3 and
then you can say finish so that creates
a project now within your project what
you can do is you can create a package
so for example I could say something
like main dot Scala and then say finish
so that creates your package now also
one thing to remember is it would be
good to change your compiler instead of
2.12 to 2.11 normally for different
environments you might have spark with
different versions and Scala with 2.10
or 2.11 so it would be good to have the
compiler change to the bundle 2.11 so we
can select this project I can do a right
click I can go to the build path I can
say configure build path and then I can
click on Scala compiler where I will use
project settings and I will choose to
2.11 bundle so that would make sure that
your applications can compile just say
okay it might say the compiler settings
have changed a full rebuild is required
for changes to take a effect just hit on
OK so that's the first thing you need to
do the second thing is for your code to
compile it would be good to have your
jars added to your build path now we
could do that on as I said you could be
writing your application which might not
compile within your IDE but you could
package it using SBT and then run it as
jar so what I'm doing here is on my
machine within my C drive I already have
spark distribution which I've downloaded
so basically I have downloaded spark and
then untied it so spark 2.4.3 I have
unzipped or untied it I have kept it in
my C and this basically has my spark now
within which I have my jars and this has
all my spark related charts so
technically speaking I can even use
Windows command line and I can start
working on spark in an interactive way
or packaging my application and running
it in a local mode so you could all also
do this so basically have your spark and
then if you see on my desktop I have a
Hadoop folder within which I have a bin
folder and within which I have a win
utils.exe and this will be basically
required when you want to try out your
spark based applications whether that is
streaming or data frames to be tested on
your Windows machine so you can always
search and download the win utils.exe
place it in a Hadoop folder within the
bin folder on your machine so once you
get your win utils.exe once you have
your jars what you can do is for your
project you can just say right click you
can go to the build path and you can say
configure build path and here you had
add external jars so we can select all
of these jars here which I would want to
add to my build path so that my code can
compile and I can test it on the Windows
machine itself I can say open and then
then just basically do apply and okay so
that has created my project with a
package my compiler is changed to 2.11 I
have added the external charge the spark
related jars and that is good enough for
my code now what we need is a streaming
application which we need to build so
let me show you from my existing project
how it looks like so within your Source
the same way I have main package and
here I have a streaming application so
this streaming application is to test or
to work on capturing the data which is
generated at this particular stream on a
particular IP and a particular port and
I would want to do some series of
Transformations on that so this gives me
an example of doing a word count and
then I would want to print the results I
could also be saving the output in a
particular location so for this
application we need basically to import
certain packages that is sales spark
streaming spark context and also you
have spark conf so these are the
packages which we need to import now
here I have created an object I've
called this fifth app and I'm saying
extends app and this is because within
my project I already have an application
which has been defined as main so if
your application has been defined as
main one application is already existing
then you can just have your new objects
with extending app so we don't need to
define the main method here now here I
am saying while conf new spark conf so I
am creating a configuration object I am
setting my application name and to test
it on Windows we will have to set the
master as local and it is advisable to
give it more than one thread because you
would be creating a receiver within your
application that would utilize one
thread so here I am saying set master
local and then I am saying two threads I
am also creating my spark context which
we need to initialize based on the
configuration object we just created in
the previous step then we need to create
a spark streaming context and this
streaming context depends on spark
context and I've given a time interval
of 10 seconds so this is the time
interval which I am setting for which I
would want to work on the stream of data
which comes in every 10 seconds on a
particular socket now here we are
setting up a receiver so I say stream
rdd which is basically be spark
streaming context and then you use your
socket text stream now there are various
methods of spark streaming context for
example if I just go here and if I just
do a dot it shows me what are the
different options you have file stream
you have q stream you have socket stream
receiver stream and so on so I am using
socket text stream and I would want to
point it to this machine so I'll say
127.0.0.1 I I will also specify Port
2222 okay and here once I have created
my configuration object my spark context
my spark streaming context with the time
interval and I have set my receiver to
use the socket text stream method on
this particular IP on this particular
Port now then I am specifying what I
would want to do on the data which gets
generated on this machine at this
particular Port so I'm saying well word
counts so I would want to work on the
stream RTD that is the D stream I would
want to do a flat map on it to split the
data based on space I would want to map
every word to word comma 1 and then I
would want to do a Reduce by key now
Reduce by key you can pass in
specifically the function you would want
to do I could do a count of this I could
print the result or I could even save it
with an output using the Java method to
create a random string attached to the
output once you are done with this here
I'm in mentioning spark streaming
context start now this will basically
trigger my spark streaming context to
start and it will run till we terminate
this application now here to run this on
Windows machine you can always look into
your run configuration and what I have
done is in my environment I basically
want to use let's say okay now let's
look at the configuration what you need
to set so here I have my streaming
application and let's look at the Run
configuration which basically shows my
application has started and it's running
on the environment so if you see here I
have added Hadoop underscore home
pointing to this Hadoop directory which
has been and when utils X I have also
given spark local IP which is
127.0.0.1 so that is my run
configuration now if you see here my
streaming application has started my
streaming application has not yet
started probably it is running a
different app application so we can come
back and check this so we can go to run
as Scala application and let's see what
it does so it tries to connect to
127.0.0.1 so receiver is trying to do
that but it does not find anything on
that particular machine on that
particular Port so my receiver is not
able to find it is not able to establish
a connection now what I can do is I can
go to my command line and here I will go
into downloads so I've already
downloaded the netcat utility for
Windows and here we can basically search
for something which I have on my machine
within downloads and that is your netcat
utility so what I would do is I will
come back here and I would say NC DOT
exe lvp and then I could say my port
which I have specified in my streaming
application and I can just start this
netcat utility now here it says
listening on 222 it says connection to
127.0.0.1 and then if I look in the
background my receiver will now be able
to establish a connection establish a
connection with this netcat utility now
whatever I type here will be taken for
processing every 10 seconds and we would
see a word count while my application is
running so let's test this so I'll say
this is a test test is being done and as
soon as I pass in this message we see
that there is a word count happening for
the stream of data which is coming in we
can say Winters are coming Winters will
be cold and once I given these messages
we will see our streaming application
which will try to work on the data which
is coming in and process it and show us
the result so we can say this is a test
of winters and let's see if it continues
to do the processing and shows us down
right so my streaming application is
running fine it is looking at The Words
which we are passing in and we can say
if it is able to process my data and
every 10 seconds the tech stock socket
stream is looking on this machine at
this particular Port doing a series of
Transformations and these series of
Transformations and then are seen within
your console now in my application if I
had used word counts.save as text file
then I could also have my output getting
generated at every 10 second interval
and that would get saved here I could
also decide to have my output saved and
stored on a sdfs or any other storage so
this is a simple streaming application
what we saw which is using socket text
stream it is looking at this machine on
a particular Port where we are running a
netcat utility it does series of your
rdd Transformations that is flat map map
and then you're reduced by key and
finally we are invoking an action such
as print which basically triggers these
rdts which work on my streaming data so
this is one example now what I could
also be doing is this is particularly my
application now I already have SBT for
windows installed so I can be going into
my project space so I could say
workspace I could go into my apps and
I'm in my project folder so I could say
SBD package and this will basically then
based on my build file which I already
have within my project folder so if you
see here this is my build file which
says name the version Scala version
spark version and the repository with
the spark to manage the dependencies for
all its components like spark core SQL
MLM streaming And Hive so you need to
have this build Dot SBT file within your
project folder which can be used to
package your application as jar now we
have done the packaging and it shows me
that it has created a jar of my
applications within this particular
folder now once I have this I can
basically then import this package into
my cluster where I can run it on a
cluster using spark submit now to run
the spark streaming application on a
cluster here I have a two node cluster
which will then have my spark Standalone
cluster you could look at the previous
videos with wherein I explain how to set
up a spark Standalone cluster now here I
can go into the spark directory and then
I could just say s bin start all dot sh
which will start my spark master and
worker node now I do have Hadoop cluster
also set up on this but right now I am
running a spark Standalone cluster which
shows me I have a mass certain worker
process on this machine and I have a
worker process on this machine so my
spark Standalone cluster is running we
can always bring up the UI to see how it
looks like so here I can just be giving
HTTP slash slash um1 8080 so that's my
spark Standalone cluster with two worker
nodes right now there is no application
running we can come back here and we can
check if we have my jar file so I've
already placed my jar here now at any
point of time if you have your jar which
has been packaged you can always go and
do a jar minus x v f and you can choose
your jar to see what is within your jar
which I have already done on this
machine so if I look in the main folder
I have Scala and within Scala if you see
these are the different classes what we
have so my code was packaged as a jar it
has a fifth app class which we would
want to run here so what I can do is I I
can just be saying spark submit because
now I would want my application to run
on the cluster so I can say class main
dot Scala and then my object name so I
will say fifth app now that's my class
my jar is this one and we will also say
master which is going to be spark which
is running on um1 and it listens on 7077
Port so that would basically start my
streaming application but what we would
also need is like our windows we would
also need some utility like netcat so
basically what I can do is I can here
use a netcat utility to basically
connect or send in some messages for our
streaming application so let's say let
me search if I have already the netcat
which I might have used here so let's
see so we on your window machine you
will have to in install your netcat
utility by saying a aptkit netcat so
here I can say NC minus L and then I can
say Port which is 2 2 2 so we can see if
this is working so this is a test and
let's see if it works so let's start our
application streaming application which
then needs the receiver to establish a
connection with the particular machine
and let's see if that is done so here I
could also be canceling this and give it
a particular Port so I can say 192 168
0.18 now the only problem is when we
packaged our application when we
packaged our application we should be
specifically giving the IP and also
comment out the local so when I package
this to run on the cluster I commented
out this part and I obviously would not
be giving 127 but the IP where my netcat
is running so right now let's test it so
we will say this is a test new test for
our application and I'm sending in some
messages so it is already doing the word
count as we expected it to do and if
while we are doing it if you come back
here so you would see your application
is now running on the cluster so it is
my application it is using for Cores
what is the memory per executor and you
can basically click on your application
now here you can look at the application
detail UI to see what is being done so
for our application we have streaming
job running receiver which says this is
my application it says it is running you
can basically click at this click on
this and it says your dag visualization
which will say the streaming job which
is running you can look at the stages if
you would want to see if there are
multiple stages which we don't have
because we are not doing any wider
transformation we can look at storage if
we have used some persisting or caching
we can look at the executors which are
being used and one of the important
things when you talk about your
streaming is the streaming tab which
gets activated now that does not show up
when you run your patch applications but
in your streaming applications you have
the UI shows you the streaming Tab and
that basically says running batches of
10 seconds for 2 minutes 9 seconds
already now we see the input rate we see
the receivers we see if there is any
delay in scheduling what is the
processing time how many batches it has
completed and it basically shows me what
is the processing time how many tasks
were run and so on so my application is
running fine and unless and until we go
ahead and cancel this my application
will continue to run it will keep
looking for messages which we keep
typing in so for example if I would want
to just copy this and start again where
I would keep passing in this is a test
one test one is this where we test
streaming application right and I can be
seeing that my messages are being
processed I'm getting a word count so we
can say winter winter summer Old Winter
and you can always look at if your
streaming application is doing the word
count so this is a simple way where you
can run your streaming application
either on a Windows machine in a local
mode or you could be running on a spark
Standalone cluster or you could also
deploy your application to run on a yarn
based cluster now that we have seen a
streaming application which does a word
count it will be interesting to also see
the window based computation or
windowing operation which is supported
in spark streaming as I explained and
for that we can look at a different
application here which is streaming with
a window option let's look into this
what this application does so here I am
importing some packages that is
streaming streaming context your spark
and Spark context spark configuration
I'm also using the spark API Java
function I am then using spark streaming
API and I'm also using Storage level
because I also intend to have the
persistence or caching done now here we
create an application say streaming app
extends app we create our configuration
object where we say app name and then we
set master with appropriate number of
threads we create the spark streaming
context that's we initialize it and then
we have the spark streaming context
which depends on SC and we have given a
time interval of 10 seconds we then set
up a receiver so we say stream rdd which
will use socket extreme like we did
earlier with which will look for this
particular machine at this port wherein
I am also using Storage level so what I
would want is that the data stream which
would get generated here every 10
seconds should be cached in memory now
we could use different storage levels
that is we could use memory only disk
only memory and disk you could have
memory and disk with replication Factor
so you have different storage levels now
here we are then doing some series of
Transformations like what we did earlier
but if you see in my previous example we
just had reduced by key and here I am
using a transformation which is reduced
by key and window now this one basically
takes the function as I said the
windowing takes associative or
commutative functions so instead of
using the shortcut wave we will be
specifying our function so we say it
takes a and b and basically it uses this
function now here we have to give the
interval that is 30 seconds that's my
window time frame and then within that
what will be my each in interval which
we would want to look at so these are
the two main aspects One is using your
window based transformation and then
also specifying your time interval for
your windowing which basically means we
would still do a word count but then
here we would basically not only be
doing a word count for every 10 seconds
for the data which is coming in here but
we would also want to have a
Consolidated set of computation done
every 30 seconds so that is looking at
the last three time intervals now if you
also notice I am also doing a check
pointing here wherein I have not
specified a specific directory but what
I am saying here is I would want to
checkpoint or I would want to basically
save my computations for any kind of
fault recovery now this is a streaming
application with window based
computation we are using Storage level
for persistence we are also doing the
checkpointing which takes care of fault
recovery now to run this application we
have already set our environment
variables and so on so I can basically
start this application by just doing a
run as Scala application now this would
start my streaming application with
window based computations now we can
open up our command line where we would
want to start a netcat utility so I
could go to downloads let me just
minimize this window here and what I can
do is I can then be starting my netcat
utility so I could say NC DOT exe minus
lvp and on a port 222 as soon as I do
this in background my application
receiver will be able to establish
connection to this netcat utility
running on this particular Port now
that's done so we can see if the word
count happens for our 10 second interval
so let's do that so I'll say this is my
first test and if I do this it should
give me the word count for the data
which I have passed in now I can say
this is my second test this is my third
test and if you see here it basically is
doing this now if I say this is my first
test again so since we are doing window
based operation also we will see a
Consolidated set of Transformations
which happen for a window of three
intervals so if you see here now my this
is giving me a count but it is not
showing me totally this as 4 or say this
because it is only looking at a window
of last two or three time intervals so
now it is back because it is looking at
the last one so if I say this is my test
test is done test is done so if you do
this it will show you the word count
which is for or whatever you have passed
in like test is done is twice test is
Thrice but then since windowing based
operation is done you will look at the
time interval of the messages which were
passed within that particular window now
we can also since my application is
running and it is on Windows we can
bring up your spark UI so I can go to
http and slash slash I can be looking at
my machine and the port so for example I
could do this this shows my streaming
application which is running in wherein
I can see the window based application
which is running but what would be
interesting is to look at the stages if
there is any kind of shuffling which is
happening looking at the storage should
show me the persistence which we are
doing now if you see here it shows me
that we have been persisting in the
memory what size it occupies how many
partitions were cast and this is because
of the persistence or the Storage level
what we have used as memory only now if
we change that to disk we will see our
rdds will be cached on disk and then you
can look at your streaming tab which
gives you more information about your
batches so this is a very simple example
obviously you can change what kind of
RTD computations you would want to do
here whether you want to do a word count
or something else whether you want to
save your processed output now here we
are able to do that you can always do a
Refresh on your project and here what we
see is we see some entries of a folder
getting created right and we can decide
whether we would want our output to be
created we can also see within this what
would be containing and since we have
set checkpointing in the project folder
it would also be checkpointing
temporarily the information for any kind
of failure so this is a classic example
of streaming application use using
window based computations persisting
your computations and also doing the
checkpointing simultaneously in this
tutorial here we have some list of
questions and an explanation of those so
that you can be well prepared for your
Hadoop interviews now let's look at some
general Hadoop questions so what are the
different vendor specific distributions
of Hadoop now all of you might be aware
that Hadoop or Apache Hadoop is the core
distribution of Hadoop and then you have
different vendors in the market which
have packaged the Apache Hadoop in a
cluster management solution which allows
everyone to easily deploy manage monitor
upgrade your clusters so here are some
vendor specific distributions we have
Cloudera which is the dominant one in
the market we have hortonworks and now
you might be aware that clouder and
hortonworks have merged so it has become
a bigger entity you have mapper you have
Microsoft Azure I IBM's infosphere and
Amazon web services so these are some
popularly known vendor-specific
distributions if you would want to know
more about the Hadoop distributions you
should basically look into Google and
you should check for Hadoop different
distributions wiki page so if I type
Hadoop different distributions and then
I check for the Wiki page that will take
me to the distributions and Commercial
support page and this basically says
that the sold products that can be
called a release of Apache Hadoop come
from apache.org so that's your open
source community and then you have
various vendor specific distributions
which basically are running in one or
the other way Apache Hadoop but they
have packaged it as a solution like a
installer so that you can easily set up
clusters on set of machines so have a
look at this page and read through about
different distributions of Hadoop coming
let's look at our next question so what
are the different Hadoop configuration
files now whether you're talking about
Apache Hadoop Cloudera hortonworks map r
or no matter which other distribution
these config files are the most
important and existing in every
distribution of Hadoop so you have
Hadoop environment.sh wherein you will
have environment variables such as your
Java path what would be your process ID
path where will your logs get stored
what kind of metrics will be collected
and so on your core hyphen site file has
the hdfs path now this has many other
properties like enabling trash or
enabling High availability or discussing
or mentioning about your zookeeper but
this is one of the most important file
you have hdfs hyphen site file now this
file will have other information related
to your Hadoop cluster such as your
replication Factor where will name node
store its metadata on disk if a data
node is running where would data node
store its data if a secondary name node
is running where would that store a copy
of name nodes metadata and so on your
mapred hyphen site file is a file which
will have properties related to your map
reduce processing you also have Masters
and slaves now these might be deprecated
in a vendor-specific distribution and in
fact you would have a yarn hyphen site
file which is based on the yarn
processing framework which was
introduced in Hadoop version 2 and this
would have all your resource allocation
Source manager and node manager related
property
properties again if you would want to
look at default properties for any one
of these for example let's say hdfs
hyphen site file I could just go to
Google and type in one of the properties
for example I would say DFS dot name
node.name dot directory and as I know
this property belongs to hdfs hyphen
site file and if you search for this it
will take you to the first link which
says stfs default XML you can click on
this and this will show you all the
properties which can be given in your
stfs hyphen site file it also shows you
which version you are looking at and you
can always change the version here so
for example if I would want to look at
2.6.5 I just need to change the version
and that should show me the properties
similarly you can just give a property
which belongs to say core hyphen site
file for example I would say FS dot
default fs and that's a property which
is in core hyphen sci-fi and somewhere
here you would see core minus default
dot XML and this will show you all the
properties so similarly you could search
for properties which are related to yarn
hyphen site file or mapred hyphen site
file so I could say yarn dot resource
manager and I could look at one of these
properties which will directly take me
to yarn default XML and I can see all
the properties which can be given in
yarn and similarly you could say map
reduce dot job dot reduces and I know
this property belongs to mapreduce
hyphen site file and this takes you to
the default XML so these are important
config files and no matter which
distribution of Hadoop you are working
on you should be knowing about these
config files whether you work as a
Hadoop admin or you work as a Hadoop
developer knowing these config
properties would be very important and
that would also showcase your internal
knowledge about the configs which drive
your Hadoop cluster let's look at the
next question so what are the three
modes in which Hadoop can run so you can
have Hadoop running in a standalone mode
now that's your default mode it would
basically use a local file system and a
single Java process so when you say
Standalone mode it is as you downloading
Hadoop related package on one single
machine but you would not have any
process running that would just be to
test Hadoop functionalities you could
have a pseudo distributed mode which
basically means it's a single node
Hadoop deployment now Hadoop as a
framework has many many services so it
has a lot of services and those Services
would be running irrespective of your
distribution each service would then
have multiple processes so your pseudo
distributed mode is a mode of cluster
where you would have all the important
processes belonging to one or multiple
Services running on a single node if you
would want to work on a pseudo
distributed mode and using a Cloudera
you can always go to Google and search
for cloudera's quick start VM you can
download it by just saying Cloud era
quick start VM and you can search for
this and that will allow you to download
a quick start VM follow the instructions
and you can have a single node Cloudera
cluster running on your virtual machines
for more information you can refer to
the YouTube tutorial where I have
explained about how to set up a quick
start VM coming back you could have
finally a production setup or a fully
distributed mode which basically means
that your Hadoop framework and its
components would be spread across
multiple machines so you would have
multiple services such as hdfs yarn
Flume scope Kafka hbase Hive Impala and
for these Services there would be one or
multiple processes distributed across
multiple nodes so this is normally what
is used in production environment so you
could say Standalone would be good for
testing pseudo distributed could be good
for testing and development and fully
distributed would be mainly for your
production setup now what are the
differences between regular file system
and hdfs
So when you say regular file system you
could be talking about a Linux file
system or you could be talking about a
Windows based operating system so in
regular file system we would have data
maintained in a single system so the
single system is where you have all your
files and directories so it is having
low fault tolerance right so if the
machine crashes your data recovery would
be very difficult unless and until you
have a backup of that data that also
affects your processing so if the
machine crashes or if the machine fails
then your processing would be blocked
now the biggest challenge with regular
file system is the seek time the time
taken to read the data so you might have
one single machine with huge amount of
disks and huge amount of ram but then
the time taken to read that data when
all the data is stored in one machine
would be very high and that would be
with least fault tolerance if you talk
about sdfs your data is distributed so
sdfs stands for Hadoop distributed file
system so here your data is distributed
and maintained on multiple systems so it
is never one single machine it is also
supporting reliability so whatever is
stored in hdfs say a file being stored
depending on its size is split into
blocks and those blocks will be spread
across multiple nodes not only that
every block which is stored on a node
will have its replicas stored on other
nodes replication Factor depends but
this makes sdfs more reliable in cases
of your slave nodes or data nodes
crashing you will rarely have data loss
because of Auto replication feature now
time taken to read the data is
comparatively more as you might have
situations where your data is
distributed across the nodes and even if
you are doing a parallel read your data
read might take more time because it
needs coordination for multiple machines
however if you are working with huge
data which is getting stored it will
still be beneficial in comparison to
reading from a single machine so you
should always think about its
reliability through Auto replication
feature its fault tolerance because of
your data getting stored across multiple
machines and its capability to scale so
when you talk about sdfs we are talking
about horizontal scalability or scaling
out when you talk about regular file
system you are talking about vertical
scalability which is scaling up now
let's look at some specific sdfs
questions what is this why is sdfs Fault
tolerant now as I just explained in
previous slides your sdfs is Fault
tolerant as it replicates data on
different data nodes so you have a
master node and you have multiple slave
nodes or data nodes where actually the
data is getting stored now we also have
a default block size of 128 MB that's
the minimum since Hadoop version 2. so
any file which is up to 128 MB would be
using one logical block and if the file
size is bigger than 128 MB then it will
be split into blocks and those blocks
will be stored across multiple machines
now since these blocks are stored across
multiple machines it makes it more fault
tolerant because even if your machines
fail you would still have a copy of your
block existing on some other machine now
there are two aspects here one we talk
about the first rule of replication
which basically means you will never
have two identical blocks sitting on the
same machine and the second rule of
replication is in terms of rack
awareness so if your machines are placed
in racks as we see in the right image
you will never have all the replicas
placed on the same rack even if they are
on different machines so it has to be
fault tolerant and it has to maintain
redundancy so at least one replica will
be placed on some other node on some
other rack that's how as DFS is Fault
tolerant now here let's understand the
architecture of sdfs now as I mentioned
earlier you would in a Hadoop cluster
the main service is your hdfs so for
your sdfs service you would have a name
node which is your master process
running on one of the machines and you
would have data nodes which are your
slave machines getting stored across
marketing or the processes running
across multiple machines each one of
these processes has an important role to
play when you talk about sdfs whatever
data is written to hdfs that data is
split into blocks depending on its size
and the blocks are randomly distributed
across nodes with auto replication
feature these blocks are also Auto
replicated across multiple machines with
the first condition that no two
identical blocks will sit on the same
machine now as soon as the cluster comes
up you
which are part of the cluster and based
on config files would start sending
their heartbeat to the name node and
this would be every three seconds what
does name node do with that name node
will store this information in its Ram
so name node starts building a metadata
in its RAM and that metadata has
information of what are the data nodes
which are available in the beginning now
when a data writing activity starts and
the blocks are distributed across data
nodes data nodes every 10 seconds will
also send a block report to name node so
name node is again adding up this
information in its Ram or the metadata
in Ram which earlier had only data node
information now name node will also have
information about what are the files the
files are split in which blocks the
blocks are stored on which machines and
what are the file permissions now while
name node is maintaining this metadata
in Ram name node is also maintaining
metadata in disk so that is what we see
in the red box which basically has
information of whatever information was
written to hdfs
so to summarize your name node has
metadata in Ram and metadata in disk
your data nodes are the machines where
your blocks or data is actually getting
stored and then there is a auto
replication feature which is always
existing unless and until you have
disabled it and your read and write
activity is a parallel activity however
replication is in sequential activity
now this is what I mentioned about when
you talk about name node which is the
master process hosting metadata in disk
and RAM so when we talk about disk it
basically has a edit log which is your
transaction log and your FS image which
is your file system image right from the
time the cluster was started this
metadata in disk was existing and this
gets appended every time read write or
any other operations happen on stfs
metadata m is dynamically built every
time the cluster comes up which
basically means that if your cluster is
coming up name node in the initial few
seconds or few minutes would be in a
safe mode which basically means it is
busy registering the information from
data nodes so name node is one of the
most critical processes if name node is
down and if all other processes are
running you will not be able to access
the cluster name nodes metadata in disk
is very important for name node to come
up and maintain the cluster name nodes
metadata in Ram is basically for all or
satisfying all your client requests now
when we look at data nodes as I
mentioned data nodes hold the actual
data blocks and they are sending these
block reports every 10 seconds so the
metadata in name nodes are Ram is
constantly getting updated and metadata
in disk is also constantly getting
updated based on any kind of write
activity happening on the cluster now
data node which is storing the block
will also help in any kind of read
activity whenever a client requests so
whenever a client or an application or
an API would want to read the data it
would first talk to name node name node
would look into its metadata online
and confirm to the client which machines
could be reached to get
to get that's where your client would
try to read the data from sdfs which is
actually getting the data from data
nodes and that's how your read write
requests are satisfied now what are the
two types of metadata in name node
server holds as I mentioned earlier
metadata in disk very important to
remember edit log NFS image metadata in
Ram which is information about your data
nodes files files being split into
blocks blocks residing on data nodes and
file permissions so I will share a very
good link on this and you can always
look for more detailed information about
your metadata so you can search for sdfs
metadata directories explained now this
is from hot and works however it talks
about the metadata in disk which name
node manages and details about this so
have a look at this link if you are more
interested in learning about metadata on
disk coming back let's look at the next
question what is the difference between
Federation and high availability now
these are the features which were
introduced in Hadoop version 2. both of
these features are about horizontal
scalability of name node prior to
version 2 the only possibility was that
you could have one single Master which
basically means means that your cluster
could become unavailable if name node
would crash so Hadoop version 2
introduced two new features Federation
and high availability however High
availability is a popular one so when
you talk about Federation it basically
means any number of name nodes so there
is no limitation to the number of name
nodes your name nodes are in a Federated
cluster which basically means name nodes
still belong to the same cluster but
they are not coordinating with each
other so whenever a write request comes
in one of the name node picks up that
request and it guides that request for
the blocks to be written on data nodes
but for this your name node does not
have to coordinate with other name node
to find out if the block ID which was
being assigned was the same one as
assigned by other name node so all of
them belong to a Federated cluster they
are linked via a cluster ID so whenever
an application or an API is trying to
talk to Cluster it is always going via
an cluster ID and one of the name node
would pick up the read activity or write
activity or processing activity so all
the name nodes are sharing a pool of
metadata in which each name node will
have its own dedicated pool and we can
remember that by a term called namespace
or name service so this also provides
High fault tolerance suppose your one
name node goes down it will not affect
or make your cluster unavailable you
will still have your cluster reachable
because there are other name nodes
running and they are available now when
it comes to heartbeats all your data
nodes are sending their heartbeats to
all the name nodes and all the name
nodes are aware of all the data nodes
when you talk about high availability
this is where you would only have two
name nodes so you would have an active
and you would have a standby now
normally in any environment you would
see a high availability setup with
zookeeper so zookeeper is a centralized
coordination service so when you talk
about your active and stand by name
notes election of a name node to be to
be made as active and taking care of a
automatic failover is done by your
zookeeper High availability can be set
up without zookeeper but that would mean
that a admins intervention would be
required to make a name node as active
from standby or also to take care of
failover now at any point of time in
high availability a active name node
would be taking care of storing the
edits about whatever updates are
happening on sdfs and it is also writing
these edits to a shared location standby
name node is the one which is constantly
looking for these latest updates and
applying to its metadata which is
actually a copy of whatever your active
name node has so in this way your
standby name node is always in sync with
the active name node and if for any
reason active name node fails your
standby name node will take over and
become the active remember zookeeper
plays a very important role here it's a
centralized coordination service one
more thing to remember here is that in
your high availability secondary name
node will not be allowed so you would
have a active name node and then you
will have a standby name node which will
be configured on a separate machine and
both of these will be having access to a
shared location now that shared location
could be NFS or it could be a quorum of
General nodes so for more information
refer to the tutorial where I have
explained about sdfs high availability
and Federation now let's look at some
logical question here so if you have a
input file of 3 MB which
version 28 MB how many input splits
would be created by sdfs
what would be the size of each input
split so for this you need to remember
that by default the minimum block size
is 128 MB now that's customizable if
your environment has more number of
larger files written on an average then
obviously you have to go for a bigger
block size if your environment has a lot
of files being written but these files
are of smaller size you could be okay
with 128 MB remember in Hadoop every
entity that is your directory on sdfs
file on sdfs and a file having multiple
blocks each of these are considered as
objects and for each object
Loops name nodes Ram 150 bytes is
utilized so if your block size is very
small then you would have more number of
blocks which would directly affect the
name nodes of M if you keep a block size
very high that will reduce the number of
blocks but remember that might affect in
processing because processing also
depends on split
split more number of splits more the
parallel processing so setting of block
size has to be done with consideration
about your parallelism requirement and
your name nodes Ram which is available
now coming to the question if you have a
file of 350 MB that would be split into
three blocks and here two blocks would
have 128 MB data and the third block
although the block size would still be
128 it would have only 94 MB of data so
this would be the split of this
particular file now let's understand
about rack awareness how does rack
awareness work or why do we even have
racks so organizations always would want
to place their nodes or machines in a
systematic way there can be different
approaches you could have a rack which
would have machines running on the
master processes and the intention would
be that this particular rack could have
higher bandwidth more cooling dedicated
power supply top of rack switch and so
on the second approach could be that you
could have one master process running on
one machine of every rack and then you
could have other slave processes running
now when you talk about your rack
awareness one thing to understand is
that if your machines are placed within
racks and we are aware that Hadoop
follows Auto replication the rule of
replication in a rack aware cluster
would be that you would never have all
the replicas placed on the same rack so
if we look at this if we have block a in
blue color you will never have all the
three blue boxes in the same rack even
if they are on different nodes because
that makes us that makes it less fault
tolerant so you would have at least one
copy of block which would be stored on a
different rack on a different note now
let's look at this so basically here we
are talking about replicas being placed
in such a way now somebody could ask a
question can I have my block and its
replicas spread across three racks and
yes you can do that but then in order to
make it more redundant you are
increasing your bandwidth requirement so
the better approach would be two blocks
on the same rack on different machines
one copy on a different track now let's
proceed how can you restart name node
and all demons in Hadoop so if you were
working on an Apache Hadoop cluster then
you could be doing a start and stop
using Hadoop demon scripts so there are
these Hadoop demon scripts which would
be used to start and stop your Hadoop
and this is when you talk about your
Apache Hadoop so let's look at one
particular file which I would like to
show you more information here and this
talks about your different clusters so
let's look into this and so let's look
at the start and stop and here I have a
file let's look at this one and this
gives you highlights so if you talk
about Apache Hadoop this is how the
setup would be done so you would have it
download the Hadoop tar file you would
have to untie it edit the config files
you would have to do formatting and then
start your cluster and here I have said
using scripts so this is in case of
Apache Hadoop you could be using a start
all script that internally triggers
start DFS and start yarn and these
scripts start DFS internally would run
Hadoop them in multiple times based on
your configs to start your different
processes then your start yarn would run
yarn demand script to start your
processing related process
so this is how it happens in Apache
Hadoop now in case of cloud era or
hortonworks which is basically a vendor
specific distribution you would have say
multiple Services which would have one
or multiple demons running across the
machines let's take an example here that
you would have machine one machine two
and machine 3 with your processes spread
across however in case of cloud era and
hot remarks these are cluster Management
Solutions so you would never be involved
in running a script individually to
start and stop your processes in fact in
case of Cloudera you would have a
Cloudera SCM server running on one of
the machines and then Cloudera SCM
agents running on every machine if you
talk about hortonworks you would have
ambari server and ambari agent running
so your agents which are running on
every machine are responsible to monitor
the processes send also their heartbeat
to the master that is your server and
your server is the one or a service
which basically will give instructions
to the agents so in case of vendor
specific distribution your start and
stop of processes is automatically taken
care by these underlying services and
these Services internally are still
running these commands however only in
Apache Hadoop you have to manually
follow these to start and stop coming
back we can look into some command
related questions so which command will
help you find the status of blocks and
file system health so you can always go
for a file system check command now that
can show you the files for a particular
sdfs path it can show you the blocks and
it can also give you information on
status such as under replicated blocks
over replicated blocks misreplicated
blocks default replication and so on so
your fsck file system check utility does
not repair if there is any problem with
the blocks but it can give you
information of blocks related to the
files on which machines they are stored
if they are replicated as per the
replication factor or if there is any
problem with any particular replica now
what would happen if you store too many
small files in a cluster and this
relates to the block information which I
give some time back so remember Hadoop
is coded in Java so here every directory
every file and file related block is
considered as an object and for every
object we within your Hadoop cluster
name nodes Ram gets utilized so more
number of blocks you have more would be
usage of name node slam and if you're
storing too many small files it would
not affect your disk it would directly
affect your name node's Ram that's why
in production clusters admin guys or
infrastructure specialist will take care
that everyone who is writing data to
hdfs follows a quota system so that you
could be controlled in the amount of
data you write plus the count of data
and individual rights on hdfs now how do
you copy data from local system onto
sdfs so you can use a put command or a
copy from local and then given your
local path which is your source and then
your destination which is your sdfs path
remember you can always do a copy from
local using a minus F option that's a
flag option and that also helps you in
writing the same file or a new file to
hdfs so with your minus F you have a
chance of overwriting or rewriting the
data which is existing on sdfs so copy
from local or minus put both of them do
the same thing and you can also pass an
argument when you are copying to control
your replication or other aspects of
your file now when do you use DFS admin
refresh notes or RM admin refresh notes
so as the command says this is basically
to do with refreshing the node
information so your refresh notes is
mainly used when say a commissioning or
decommissioning of nodes is done so when
in node is added into the cluster or
when a node is removed from the cluster
you are actually informing Hadoop master
that this particular node would not be
used for storage and would not be used
for processing now in that case you
would be once you are done with the
process of commissioning or
decommissioning you would be giving
these commands that is refresh notes and
other I might win refresh notes so
internally when you talk about
commissioning decommissioning there are
include and exclude files which are
updated and these include and exclude
files will have entry of machines which
are being added to the cluster or
machines which are being removed from
the cluster and while this is being done
the cluster is still running so you do
not have to restart your master process
however you can just use this refresh
commands to take care of your commenting
decommissioning activities now is there
any way to change replication of files
on sdfs after they are already written
and the answer is of course yes so if
you would want to set a replication
Factor at a cluster level and if you
have admin access then you could edit
your sdfs hyphen site file or you could
say Hadoop hyphen site file and that
would take care of replication Factor
being set at a cluster level however if
you would want to change the replication
after the data has been written you
could always use a set rep command so
set rep command is basically to change
the replication after the data is
written you could also write the data
with a different replication and for
that you could use a minus D DFS dot
replication and give your application
Factor when you are writing data to the
class
so in Hadoop you can let your data be
replicated as per the property set in
the config file you could write the data
with a different replication you could
change the replication after the data is
written so all these options are
available now who takes care of
replication consistency in a Hadoop
cluster and what do you mean by under
over replicated blocks now as I
mentioned your fsck command can give you
information of over or under replicated
blocks now in a cluster it is always and
always name node which takes care of
replication
so for example if you have set up a
replication of three and since we know
the first rule of replication which
basically means that you cannot have two
replicas residing on the same node it
would mean that if your application is 3
we would need at least three data nodes
available now say for example you had a
cluster with three nodes and replication
was set to three at one point of time
one of your name node crashed and if
that happens your blocks would be under
replicated that means there was an
application Factor set but now your
blocks are not replicated or there are
not enough replicas as per the
replication Factor set this is not a
problem your master process or name node
will wait for some time before it will
start the replication of data again so
if a data road is not responding or if a
disk has crashed and if name node does
not get information of a replica name
node will wait for some time and then it
will start re-replication of those
missing blocks from the available nodes
however while name node is doing it the
blocks are in under replicated situation
now when you talk about over replicated
this is a situation where name node
realizes that there are extra copies of
block now this might be the case that
you had three nodes running with the
replication of three one of the node
went down you Network failure or some
other issue within few minutes name node
re-replicated the data and then the
failed node is back with
set of blocks
blocks again name node is smart enough
this is a over replication situation and
it will delete set of blocks from one of
the nodes it might be the node which has
been recently added it might be your old
node which has joined your cluster again
or any node that depends on the load on
a particular
now we discussed about Hadoop we
discussed about sdfs now we will discuss
about mapreduce which is the programming
model and you can say processing
framework what is distributed cache in
mapreduce now we know that when we talk
about mapreduce the data which has to be
processed might be existing on multiple
nodes so when you would have your
mapreduce program running it would
basically
from the underlying disks now this could
be a costly operation if every time the
data has to be read from disk so
distributed cache is a mechanism wherein
data set or data which is coming from
the disk can be cached and available for
all worker nodes now how will this
benefit so when a map reduce is running
instead of every time reading the data
from disk it would pick up the data from
distributed cache and this this will
benefit your map reduce
so distributed cash can be set in your
job conf where you can specify that a
file should be picked up from
distributed cache now let's understand
about these roles so what is a record
reader what is a combiner what is a
partitioner and what kind of roles do
they play in a map reduce processing
Paradigm or mapreduce operation so
record reader communicates with the
input split and it basically converts
the data into key value Pairs and these
key value pairs are the ones which will
be worked upon by the mapper your
combiner is an optional face it's like
mini reduce so combiner does not have
its own class it relies on the reducer
class basically your combiner would
receive the data from your map tasks
which would have completed works on it
based on whatever reducer class mentions
and then passes its output to the
reduced surface partitioner is basically
a phase which decides how many reduced
tasks would be used aggregate or
summarize your data so partitioner is a
phase which would decide based on the
number of keys based on the number of
map tasks your partitioner would decide
if one or multiple reduced tasks
take care of
process so either it could be
partitioner which decides on how many
reduce tasks would run or it could be
based on the properties which we have
set within the cluster which will take
care of the number of reduced tasks
which would be used always remember your
partitioner decides how outputs from
combiner are sent to reducer and to how
many reducers it controls the
partitioning of keys of your
intermediate map outputs so map phase
whatever output it generates is an
intermediate output and that has to be
taken by your partitioner or by a
combiner and then partitioner to be sent
to one or multiple reduce tasks this is
one of the common questions which you
might face why is mapreduce slower in
processing so we know mapreduce goes for
parallel processing we know we can have
multiple map tasks running on multiple
nodes at the same time we also know that
multiple reduced tasks could be running
now why does then mapreduce become a
slower approach first of all your map
reduce is a batch oriented operation now
mapreduce is very rigid and it strictly
uses mapping and reducing phases so no
matter what kind of processing you would
want to do you would have to still
provide the mapper function and the
reducer function to work on data not
only this whenever your map phase
completes the output of your map phase
which is an intermittent output would be
written to hdfs and thereafter
underlying discs and this data would
then be shuffled and sorted and picked
up for reducing phase so every time your
data being written to hdfs and retrieved
from sdfs makes mapreduce a slower
approach the question is for a map
release job is it possible to change the
number of mappers to be created Now by
default you cannot change the number of
map tasks because number of map tasks
depends on the input splits however
there are different ways in which you
can either set a property to have more
number of map tasks which can be used or
you can customize your code or make it
use a different format which can then
control the number of map tasks
by default number of map tasks are equal
to the number of splits of file you are
processing
so if you have a 1GB of file that is
split into eight blocks of 128 MB there
would be eight map tasks running on the
cluster these map tasks are basically
running your mapper function if you have
hard coded properties in your mapred
hyphen site file to specify more number
of map tasks then you could control the
number of map tasks let's also talk
about some data types so when you
prepare for Hadoop when you want to get
into Big Data field you you should start
learning about different data
now there are different data formats
such as Avro parquet you have a sequence
file or binary format and these are
different formats which are used now
when you talk about your data types in
Hadoop these are implementation of your
writable and writable comparable
interfaces so for every data type in
Java you have a equivalent in Hadoop so
end in Java would be in writable in
Hadoop float would be float writable
long would be long writable double
writable Boolean writable array writable
map writable and object writable so
these are your different data types that
could be used
within your mapreduce program and these
are implementation of writable and
writable comparable interfaces what is
speculative execution now imagine you
have a cluster which has huge number of
nodes and your data is spread across
multiple slave machines or multiple
nodes now at a point of time due to a
disk degrade on network issues or
machine heating up or more load being on
a particular node there can be a
situation where your data node will
execute task in a slower manner now in
this case if speculative execution is
turned on there would be a shadow task
or a another
similar task running on some other node
for the same processing so whichever
task finishes first will be accepted and
the other task would be killed so
speculative execution could be could be
good if you are working in an intensive
workload kind of environment where if a
particular node is slower you could
benefit from a unoccupied or a node
which has less load to take care of your
processing going further this is how we
can understand so node a which might be
having a slower task you would have a
scheduler which is maintaining or having
knowledge of what are the resources
available so if speculative execution
has a property is turned on then the
task which was running slow a copy of
that task or you can say shadow task
would run on some other node and
whichever task completes first will be
considered this is what happens in your
speculative execution now how is
identity mapper different from chain
mapper now this is where we are getting
deeper into mapreduce Concepts so when
you talk about mapper identity mapper is
the default mapper which is chosen when
no mapper is specified in mapreduce
driver class so for every mapreduce
program you would have a map class which
is taking care of your mapping phase
which basically has a mapper function
and which would run one or multiple map
tasks right your programming your
program would also have a reduced class
which would be running a reducer
function which takes care of reduced
tasks running on multiple nodes now if a
mapper is not specified within your
driver class so driver class is
something which has all information
about your flow what's your map class
what is your reduce class what's your
input format what's your output format
what are the job configurations and so
on so identity mapper is the default
mapper which is chosen when no mapper
class is mentioned in your driver
it basically implements an identity
function which directly writes all its
key pairs into output and it was defined
in old map reduce API in this particular
package but when you talk about chaining
mappers or chain mapper this is
basically a class to run multiple
mappers in a single map task or
basically you could say multiple math
tasks would run as a part of your
processing the output of first mapper
would become as an input to Second
mapper and so on and this can be defined
in the under mentioned class or package
what are the major configuration
parameters required in a mapreduce
program obviously we need to have the
input location we need to have the
output location so input location is
where the files will be picked up from
and this would preferably on sdfs
directory output location is the path
where your job output would be written
by your mapreduce program you also need
to specify input and output formats if
you don't specify the defaults are
considered then we need to also have the
classes which have your map and reduce
functions and if you intend to run the
code on a cluster you need to package
your class in a jar file export it to
your cluster and then this jar file
would have your mapper reducer and
Driver classes so these are important
configuration parameters which you need
to consider for a mapreduce program now
what is the difference or what do you
mean by Maps height join and reduce side
join map side join is basically when the
join is performed at the mapping level
or at the mapping phase or is performed
by the mapper so each input data which
is being worked upon has to be divided
into same number of partitions
input to each map is in the form of a
structured partition and is in sorted
order so Maps I join you can understand
it in a simpler way that if you compare
it with rdbms Concepts where you had two
tables which were being joined it will
always be advisable to give your bigger
table as the left side table or the
first table for your join condition and
it would be your smaller table on the
left side and your bigger table on the
right side which basically means the
smaller table could be loaded in memory
and could be used for joining so map
side join is a similar kind of mechanism
where input data is divided into same
number of parties
when you talk about reduced side join
here the join is performed by the
reducer so it is easier to implement
than map side join as all the sorting
and shuffling will send the values or
send all the values having identical
keys to the same reducer so you don't
need to have your data set in a
structured form so look into your map
site join or reduce side join and other
joints just to understand how mapreduce
Works however I would suggest not to
focus more on this because mapreduce is
still being used for processing but the
amount of mapreduce based processing has
decreased overall or across the industry
now what is the role of output committer
class in a mapreduce job so output
committer as the name says describes the
commit of task output for a mapreduce
job so we would have this as mentioned
our Apache Hadoop map reduce output
committer you could have a class which
extends output committer class so
mapreduce relies on this map reduce
relies on the output committer of the
job to set up the job initialization
cleaning up the job after the job
completion that means all the resources
which were being used by a particular
job setting up the task temporary output
checking whether a task needs a commit
committing the task output and
discarding the task so this is a very
important class and can be used within
your mapreduce job what is the process
of spilling in mapreduce what does that
mean so spilling is basically a process
of copying the data from memory buffer
to disk when obviously the buffer usage
reaches a certain threshold so if there
is not enough memory in your buffer in
your memory then the content which is
stored in buffer or memory has to be
flushed out so by default a background
thread starts spelling the content from
memory to disk after 80 percent of
buffer size is filled now when is the
buffer being used so when your map
reduce processing is happening the data
from data is being read from the disk
loaded into the buffer and then some
processing happens same thing also
happens when you are writing data to the
cluster so you can imagine for a hundred
megabyte size buffer the spilling will
start after the content of buffer
reaches 80 megabytes this is
customizable how can you set the mappers
and reducers for a mapreduce job so
these are the properties so number of
mappers and reducers as I mentioned
earlier can be customized so by default
your number of map tasks depends on the
split and number of reduced tasks
depends on the partitioning phase which
decides number of reduced tasks which
would be used
depending on the keys however we can set
these properties either in the config
files or provide them on the command
line or also make them part of our code
and this can control the number of map
tasks or reduce tasks which would be run
for a particular job let's look at one
more interesting question what happens
when a node running a map task fails
before sending the output to the reducer
so there was a node which was running a
map task and we know that there could be
one or multiple map tasks or multiple
nodes and all the map tasks have to be
completed before the further stages that
such as combiner or reducer come into
existence so in a case if a node crashes
where a map task was assigned to it the
whole task will have to be run again on
some other node so in Hadoop version 2
yarn framework has a temporary demon
called application master
your application Master is taking care
of execution of your application and if
a particular task on a particular node
failed due to unavailability of node it
is the role of application Master to
have this task scheduled on some other
node now can we write the output of
mapreduce in different formats of course
we can so Hadoop supports various input
and output formats so you can write the
output of mapreduce in different formats
so you could have the default format
that is text output format wherein
records are written as line of text you
could have sequence file which is
basically to write sequence files or
your binary format files where your
output files need to be fed into another
mapreduce jobs you could go for a map
file output format to write output as
map files you could go for a sequence
file as a binary output format so that's
again a variant of your sequence file
input format it basically writes keys
and values to a sequence file so when we
talk about binary format we are talking
about a non-human readable format DB
output format now this is basically used
when you want to write data to say
relational databases or say nosql
databases such as hbase so this format
also sends the reduce output to a SQL
table now let's learn a little bit about
yarn yarn which stands for yet another
resource negotiator it's the processing
framework so what benefits did Yan bring
in Hadoop version 2 and how did it solve
the issues of mapreduce version 1. so
map reduce version 1 had major issues
when it comes to scalability or
availability because sorry in Hadoop
version 1 you had only one master
process for processing layer and that is
your job tracker so your job tracker was
listening to all the task trackers which
were running on multiple machines so
your job tracker was responsible for
resource tracking and job scheduling in
yarn you still have a processing Master
but that's called resource manager
instead of job tracker and now with
Hadoop version 2 you could even have
resource manager running in high
availability mode you have node managers
which would be running on multiple
machines and then you have a temporary
demon called application master so in
case of Hadoop version 2 your resource
manager or Master is only handling the
client connections and taking care of
tracking the resources the jobs
scheduling or basically taking care of
execution across multiple nodes is
controlled by application Master till
the application comes
so in yarn you can have different kind
of resource allocations that could be
done and there is a concept of container
so container is basically a combination
of RAM and CPU cores yarn can run
different kind of workloads so it is not
just map reduce kind of workload which
can be run on Hadoop version 2 but you
would have graph processing massive
parallel processing you could have a
real-time processing and huge processing
applications could run on a cluster
based on yarn so when we talk about
scalability in case of your Hadoop
version 2 you can have a cluster size of
more than 10 000 nodes and can run more
than 100 000 concurrent tasks and this
is because for every application which
is launched you have this temporary
demon called application master
so if I would have 10 applications
running I would have 10 app Masters
running taking care of execution of
these applications across multiple nodes
compatibility so Hadoop version 2 is
fully compatible with whatever was
developed as per Hadoop version 1 and
all your processing needs would be taken
care by yarn
so Dynamic allocation of cluster
resources taking care of different
workloads allocating resources across
multiple machines and using them for
execution all that is taken care by yarn
multi-tenancy which basically means you
could have multiple users or multiple
teams
you could have open source and propriety
data access engines and all of these
could be basically hosted using the same
cluster now how does yarn allocate
resources to an application with Alpha
help with architecture so basically you
have a client or an application or an
API which talks to resource manager
resource manager is as I mentioned
managing the resource allocation in the
Clusters when you talk about resource
manager you have its internal two
components one is your scheduler and one
is your applications manager so when we
say resource manager being the master is
tracking the resources The Source
manager is the one which is negotiating
the resources with slave it is not
actually resource manager who is doing
it but these internal components so you
have a scheduler which allocates
resources to various running
applications so scheduler is not
bothered about tracking your resources
or basically tracking your applications
so we can have different kind of
schedulers such as feed ful which is
which is first in first out you could
have a fair scheduler or you could have
a capacity scheduler and these
schedulers basically control how
resources are allocated to multiple
applications when they are running in
parallel so there is a queue mechanism
so scheduler will schedule resources
based on requirements of application but
it is not monitoring or tracking the
status of application
your applications manager is the one
which is accepting the job submissions
it is monitoring and restarting the
application Masters so it's application
manager which is basically then
launching a application Master which is
responsible for an application so this
is how it looks so whenever a job
submission happens we already know that
resource manager is aware of the
resources which are available with every
node manager so on every node which has
fixed amount of RAM and CPU cores some
portion of resources that is your RAM
and CPU cores are allocated to node
manager now resource manager is already
aware of how much resources are
available across nodes so whenever a
client request comes in resource manager
will make a request to node manager it
will basically request node manager to
hold some resources for processing node
manager would basically approve or
disapprove this request
holding the sources and these resources
that is a combination of RAM and Co
course are nothing but containers we can
allocate containers of different sizes
within yarn hyphen site file so your
node manager based on a request from
resource manager guarantees the
container which would be available for
processing that's when your resource
manager starts a temporary demon called
application Master to take care of your
execution so your app Master which was
launched by resource manager or we can
say internally applications manager will
run in one of the containers because
application Master is also a piece of
code so it will run in one of the
containers and then other containers
will be utilized for execution
this is how yarn is basically taking
care of your allocation your application
Master is managing resource needs it is
the one which is interacting with
scheduler and if a particular node
crashes it is the responsibility of App
Master to go back to the master which is
resource manager and negotiate for more
resources so your app Master will never
ever negotiate Resources with node
manager directly it will always talk to
resource manager and the source manager
is the one which negotiates the
resources container as I said is a
collection of resources like your RAM
CPU Network bandwidth and your container
is located based on the availability of
resources on a particular node so which
of the following has occupied the place
of a job tracker of mapreduce so it is
your resource manager so resource
manager is the name of the master
process in Ado version 2. now if you
would have to write yarn commands to
check the status of an application so we
could just say yarn application minus
status and then the application ID and
you could kill it also from the command
line remember your yarn has a UI and you
can even look at your applications from
the UI you can even kill your
applications from the UI however knowing
the command line commands would be very
useful useful can we have more than one
resource manager in a yarn-based cluster
yes we can that is what Hadoop version 2
allows
I'll have you can have a high
availability yarn cluster where you have
a active and standby and the
coordination is taking care by your
zookeeper at a particular time there can
only be one active resource manager and
if active resource manager fails your
standby resource manager comes and
becomes active however zookeeper is
playing a very important role remember
zookeeper is the one which is
coordinating the server State and it is
doing the election of active to standby
failover what are the different
schedulers available in yarn so you have
a fee for scheduler that is first in
first out and this is not a desirable
option because in this case a longer
running application might block all
other small running applications Your
Capacity scheduler is basically a
scheduler where dedicated queues are
created and they have fixed amount of
resources so you can have multiple
applications accessing the cluster at
the same time and they would be using
their own cues and the resources
allocated to them if you talk about Fair
scheduler you don't need to have a fixed
amount of sources you can just have a
percentage and you could decide what
kind of fairness is to be followed which
basically means that if you were
allocated 20 gigabytes of memory however
the cluster has 100 gigabytes and the
other team was assigned 80 gigabytes of
memory then you have 20 access to the
cluster another team has 80 percent
however if the other team does not come
up or does not use the cluster in a fair
scheduler you can go up to maximum of
100 percent of your cluster to find out
more information about your schedulers
you could either look in Hadoop
definitive guide or what you could do is
you could just go to Google and you
could type for example yarn scheduler
let's search for yarn scheduler and then
you can look in Hadoop definitive guide
and so this is your Hadoop definitive
guide and it beautifully explains about
your different schedulers how do
multiple applications run and that could
be in your fifo kind of scheduling it
could be in capacity scheduler or it
could be in a fair scheduling so have a
look at this link it's a very good link
you can also search for yarn untangling
and this is a Blog of four or this is a
series of four blocks where it's
beautifully explained about your yarn
how it works how the resource allocation
happens what is a container and what
runs within the container so you can
scroll down you can be reading through
this and you can then also search for
part two of it which talks about
allocation and so on so coming back
we basically have these schedulers what
happens if a resource manager fails
while executing an application in a high
availability cluster so in a high
availability cluster we know that we
would have two resource managers one
being active one being standby and
zookeeper which is keeping a track of
the server States so if a RM fails in
case of high availability the standby
will be elected as active and then
basically your resource manager or the
standby would become the active one and
this one would instruct the application
Master to a bot in the beginning then
your resource manager recovers its
running state so there is something
called as RM State Store where all the
applications which are running their
status is stored so resource manager
recovers its running state by looking at
your state store by taking advantage of
container statuses and then continues to
care of your processing now in a cluster
of 10 data nodes each having 16 GB and
10 cores what would be total processing
capacity of the cluster take a minute to
think 10 data nodes 6 16 GB Ram per node
10 cores so if you mention the answer as
160 GB RAM and 100 cores then you went
wrong now think of a cluster which has
10 data nodes each having 16 GB RAM and
10 cores remember on every node in a
Hadoop cluster you would have one or
multiple processes running those
processes would need RAM the machine
itself which has a Linux file system
would have its own processes so that
would also be having some RAM usage
which basically means that if you talk
about 10 data nodes you should deduct at
least 20 to 30 percent towards the
overheads towards the cloud database
Services towards the other processes
which are running and in that case I
could say that you could have 11 or 12
GB available on every machine for
processing and say six or seven cores
multiply that by 10 and that's your
processing capacity capacity remember
the same thing applies to the disk usage
also so if somebody asks you in a 10
data node cluster where each machine has
20 terabytes of disks what is my total
storage capacity
DFS so the answer would not be 200 you
have to consider the overheads and this
is basically which gives you your
processing capacity now let's look at
one more question so what happens if
requested memory or CPU cores Beyond or
goes beyond the size of container now as
I said you can have your configurations
which can say that in a particular data
node which has 100 GB Ram I could
allocate say 50 GB for the processing
like out of 100 cores I could say 50
cores for processing so if you have 100
GB RAM and 100 cores you could ideally
allocate 100 for processing but that's
not ideally possible so if you have 100
GB Ram you would over 50 GB and if you
have 100 cores you would go for 50
. now within this RAM and CPU course
have the concept of containers right so
container is a combination of RAM and
CPU cores so you could have a minimum
size container and maximum size content
now at any point of time if your
application starts demanding more memory
or more CPU cores and this cannot fit
into a container location your
application will fail your application
will fail because you requested for a
memory or a combination of memory and
CPU cores which is is more than the
maximum container so look into this yarn
tangling website which I mentioned and
look for the second blog in those series
which explains about these
now here we will discuss on hive Peg
hbase and these components of two which
are being used in the industry for
various use cases let's look at some
questions here and let's look how you
should prepare for them so first of all
we will learn on hive which is a data
warehousing package so the question is
what are the different components of a
hive architecture now when we talk about
Hive we already know that Hive is a data
warehousing package which basically
allows you to work on structured data or
data which can be structurized so
normally people are well versed with
querying or basically processing the
data using SQL queries a lot of people
come from database backgrounds and they
would find it comfortable if they know
structured query language Hive is one of
the data warehousing package which
resides within a Hadoop ecosystem it
uses hadoop's distributed file system to
store the data and it uses rdbm mess
usually to store the metadata although
metadata can be stored locally also so
what are the different components of a
hive architecture so it has a user
interface so user interface calls the
execute interface to the driver this
creates a session to the query and then
it sends the query to the compiler to
generate an execution plan for it
usually whenever Hive is set up it would
have its metadata stored in an rdbms now
to establish the connection between
rdbms and Hadoop we need odbc or jdbc
connector jar file and that connector
jar file has a driver class now this
driver class is mandatory to create a
connection between Hive and Hadoop so
user interface creates this interface
using the driver now we have metastore
metastore stores the metadata
information so any object which you
create such as database table indexes
their metadata is stored in metastore
and usually this meta store is stored in
an rdbms so that multiple users can
connect to Hive so your meta store
stores the metadata information and
sends that to the compiler for execution
of a query what does the compiler do it
generates the execution plan it has a
tag now tag stands for direct cyclic
graph so it has a tag of stages where
each stage is either a metadata
operation a map or reduced job or an
operation on sdfs and finally we have
execution engine that acts as a bridge
between Hive and Hadoop to process the
query so execution engine communicates
bi-directionally with metastore to
perform operations like create or drop
tables so these are four important
components of Hive architecture now what
is the difference between external table
and manage stable and Hive so we have
various kinds of table in Hive such as
external table manage table partition
table the major difference between your
managed and external table is in respect
to what happens to the data if the table
is dropped usually whenever we create a
table in Hive it creates a manage table
or we could also call that as an
internal table now this manages the data
and moves it into warehouse directory by
default whether you create a manage
stable or external table usually the
data can reside in hive's default
Warehouse directory or it could be
residing in a location chosen however
when we talk about manage table if one
drops a manage table not only the
metadata information is deleted but the
tables data is also deleted from sdfs if
we talk about external table it is
created with an external keyword
explicitly and if an external table is
dropped nothing happens to the data
which resides in sdfs so that's the main
difference between your managed and
external table what might be the use
case if somebody asks you there might be
a migration kind of activity or you are
interested in creating a lot of tables
using your queries so in that case you
could dump all the data on sdfs and then
you could create a table by pointing to
a particular directory or multiple
directories now you could then do some
testing of your tables and would decide
that you might not need all the tables
so in that case it would be advisable to
create external tables so that even if
the table is later dropped the data on
sdfs will be intact unlike your manage
table where dropping of table will
delete the data from sdfs Also let's
learn a little bit on partition so what
is partition And Hive and why is
partitioning required in high life if
somebody asks you that now normally in
world of rdbms partition is the process
to group similar type of data together
and that is usually done on basis of a
column or what we call as partitioning
key now each table usually has one
column in context of rdbms which could
be used to partition the data and why do
we do that so that we can avoid scanning
the complete table for a query and
restrict the scan to set of data or to a
particular partition in Hive we can have
any number of partition keys so
partitioning provides granularity in
Hive table it reduces the query latency
by scanning only relevant partition data
instead of whole data set we can
partition at various levels now if I
compare rdbms with Hive in case of rdbms
you could have one column which could be
used for partitioning and then then you
could be squaring the specific partition
so in case of rdbms your partition
column is usually a part of the table
definition so for example if I have an
employee table I might have employee ID
employee name employee age and employee
salary has four columns and I would
decide to partition the table based on
salary column now why would I partition
it because I feel that employee table is
growing very fast it is or it will have
huge amount of data and later when we
query the table we don't want to scan
the complete table so I could split my
data into multiple partition based on a
salary column giving some ranges in Hive
it is a little different in Hive you can
do partitioning and there is a concept
of static and dynamic partitioning but
in Hive the partition column is not part
of table definition so you might have an
employee table with employee ID name a H
and that that's it that would be the
table definition but you could then have
partitioning done based on salary column
which will then create a specific folder
on sdfs in that case when we query the
data we can see the partition column
also showing up so we can partition the
transaction data for a bank for example
based on month like Chan Feb Etc and any
operation regarding a particular month
will then allow us to query that
particular folder that is where
partitioning is useful now why does Hive
not store metadata information in a CFS
if somebody asks you so we know that
hives data is stored in sdfs which is
Hadoop distributed file system however
the metadata is either stored locally
and that mode of high would be called as
embedded mode or you could have hives
metadata stored in rdbms so that
multiple clients can initiate data
connection now this metadata which is
very important for Hive would not be
stored in sdfs so we already know that
sdfs read and write operations are time
consuming it is a distributed file
system and it can accommodate huge
amount of data so Hive stores metadata
information in meta store using rdbms
instead of sdfs so this allows to
achieve low latency and faster data
access now if somebody asks what are the
components used in Hive query processor
so usually we have the main components
are your parser your execution engine
logical plan generation Optimizer and
type checking so whenever a query is
submitted it will go through a parser
and parser would check the syntax it
would check for objects which are being
queried and other things to see if the
query is fine now internally you have a
semantic analyzer which will also look
at the query you have an execution
engine which basically will work on the
execution part that is the best
generated execution plan which could be
used to get the results for the query
you could also have user defined
functions which a user would want to use
and these are normally created in Java
or Java programming language and then
basically these user defined functions
are added to the class path now you
would have a logical plan generation
with which basically looks at your query
and then generates a logical plan or the
best execution path which would be
required to get to the results
internally there is a physical plan
generated which is then looked in by
Optimizer to get the best path to get to
the data and that might also be checking
your different operators which you are
using within your query finally we would
also have type checking so these are
important components in Hive so somebody
might ask you if you are querying your
data using Hive what are the different
components involved or if you could
explain what are the different
components which work when a query is
submitted so these are the components
now let's look a scenario based question
Suppose there are a lot of small CSV
files which are present in a is DFS
directory and you want to create a
single Hive table from these files so
data in these files have Fields like
registration number name email address
so if this is what needs to be done what
will be your approach to solve it where
will you create a single Hive table for
lots of small files without degrading
the performance of the system so there
can be different approaches now we know
that there are a lot of small CSV files
which are present in a directory so we
know that when we create a table in Hive
we can use a location parameter so I
could say create table give a table name
give the column and their data types I
could specify the delimiters and finally
I could say location and then point it
to a directory on sdfs and this
directory might be the directory which
has lot of CSV files so in this case I
will avoid loading the data in the table
because table being Point table pointing
to the directory will directly pick up
the data from one or multiple files and
we also know that Hive does schema check
on read so does not do a schema check on
write so in case there were one or two
files which did not follow the schema of
the table it would not prevent data
loading data would anyways be loaded
only when you query the data it might
show you null values if data which was
loaded does not follow the schema of the
table this is one approach what is the
other approach so let's look at that you
can think about sequence file format
which is basically a smart format or a
binary format and you can group these
small files together to form a sequence
file now this could be one other smarter
approach so we could create a temporary
table so we could say create table give
a table name give the column names and
their data types we could specify the
delimiters as it shows here that is row
format and Fields terminated by and
finally we can store that as text file
then we can load data into this table by
giving a local file system path and then
we can create a table that will store
data in sequence file format so my point
one is storing the data in this text
file 0.3 would be storing the data in
sequence file format so we say create
table give the specifications we say row
format delimited fields are terminated
by comma stored as sequence file then we
can move the data from test table into
test sequence file table so I could just
say insert overwrite my new table as
select star from other table remember in
Hive you cannot do insert update delete
however if the table is existing you can
do a insert overwrite from an existing
table into a new table so this could be
one approach where we could have lot of
CSV files or smaller files club together
as one big sequence file and then store
it in the table now if somebody asks you
write a query to in insert a new column
that is integer data type into a hive
table and the requirement might be that
you would want to insert this table at a
position before an existing column now
that's possible by doing an alter table
giving your table name and then
specifying change column giving your new
column with the data type before an
existing column this is a simple way
where you can insert a new column into a
hive table what are the key differences
between Hive and pick now some of you
might have heard High Visa data
warehousing package and Peg is more of a
scripting language both of them are used
for data analysis or Trend detection
hypothesis testing data transformation
and many other use cases so if we
compare Hive and pick Hive uses a
declarative language called Hive ql that
is Hive querying language similar to SQL
and it is for reporting or for data
analysis even for data transformation or
for your data extraction big uses a high
level procedural language called Pig
Latin for programming both of them
remember use mapreduce processing
framework so when we run a query in Hive
to process the data or when we create
and submit a big script both of them
trigger a mapreduce job unless and until
we have set them to Local mode Hive
operates on the server side of the
cluster and basically works on
structured data or data which can be
structuralized pig usually works or
operates on the client side of the
cluster and allows both structured
unstructured or even I could say
semi-structured data Hive does not
support Avro file format by default
however that can be done by using the
write serializer deserializer so we can
have Hive table related data stored in
Avro format in sequence file format in
parquet format or even as a text file
format however when we are working on
smarter formats like Avro or sequence
file or parquet we might have to use
specific serializers deserializers for
Avro this is the package which allows us
to use Avro format Pig supports Agro
format by default Hive was developed by
Facebook and it supports partitioning
and Peg was developed by Yahoo and it
does not support partitioning so these
are high level differences there are
lots and lots of differences remember
Hive is more of a data warehousing
package and Peg is more of a scripting
language or a strictly procedural flow
following scripting language which
allows us to process the data now let's
get more and let's get more deeper and
learn about big which is as I mentioned
a scripting language which can be used
for your data processing it also uses
map reduce although we can even have big
run in a local mode let's learn about
pig in the next section now let's learn
on some questions about Pig which is a
scripting language and it is extensively
used for data processing and data
analysis so the question is how is
Apache Pig different from mapreduce now
we all know that mapreduce is a
programming model it is it's quite rigid
when it comes to processing the data
because you have to do the mapping and
reducing you have to write huge code
usually mapreduce is written in Java but
now it can also be written in Python it
can be written in Scala and other
programming languages so if we compare
Pig with mapreduce pig obviously is very
concise it has less lines of code when
compared to mapreduce now we also know
that big script internally will trigger
a mapreduce job however user need not
know about mapreduce programming model
they can simply write simple scripts in
Pig and that will automatically be
converted into mapreduce however
mapreduce has more lines of code Peak is
high level language which can easily
perform join operations or other data
processing operations map reduce is a
low level language which cannot perform
job join operations easily so we can do
join using mapreduce however it's not
really easy in comparison to Pig now as
I said on execution every Pig operator
is converted internally into a mapreduce
job so every big script which is run
which would be converted into mapreduce
job now map reduce overall is a batch
oriented processing so it takes more
time to compile it takes more time to
execute either when you run a mapreduce
job or when it is triggered by Pink
script Pig works with all versions of
Hadoop and when we talk about mapreduce
program which is written in one Hadoop
version may not work with other versions
it might work or it might not it depends
on what are the dependencies what is the
compiler you're using what programming
language you have used and what version
of Hadoop you are working on so these
are the main differences between Apache
Pig and mapreduce what are the different
ways of executing pick script so you
could create a script file store it in
dot pick or dot text and then you could
execute it using the pick command you
could be bringing up the grunt shell
that is Pig's shell now that usually
starts with mapreduce mode but then we
can also bring it up in a local mode and
we can also run pick embedded as an
embedded script in other programming
language so these are the different ways
of executing your pick script now what
are the major components of pig
execution environment this is this is a
very common question interviewers would
always want to know different components
of Hive different component currents of
pig even different components which are
involved in Hadoop ecosystem so when we
want to learn about major components of
big execution environment here are some
so you have pick scripts now that is
written in pig latin using built-in
operators and user-defined functions and
submitted to the execution environment
that's what happens when you would want
to process the data using pick now there
is a parser which does type checking and
checks the syntax of the script the
output of parser is a tag direct a
cyclic graph so look in Wikipedia for
tag so dag is basically a sequence of
steps which run in One Direction then
you have an Optimizer now this Optimizer
performs optimization using merge
transform split Etc it aims to reduce
the amount of data in the pipeline
that's the whole purpose of Optimizer
you have a internal compiler so big
compiler converts the optimized code
into a mapreduce job and here user need
not know the mapreduce programming model
or how it works or how it is written
they all need to know about running the
pick script which would be internally
converted into a mapreduce job and
finally we have an execution engine so
mapreduce jobs are submitted to the
execution engine to generate the desired
results so these are major components of
pick execution environment now let's
learn about different complex data types
in big big supports various data types
the main ones are Tuple bag and map what
is Tuple or Tuple as you might have
heard a tuple is an ordered set of
fields which can contain different data
types for each field so in Array you
would have multiple elements but that
would be of same types list can also
have different types your Tuple is a
collection which has different fields
and each field can be of different type
now we could have an example is 1 comma
3 or 1 comma 3 comma a string or a float
element and all of that form a tuple bag
is a set of tuples so that's represented
by curly braces so you could also
imagine this like a dictionary which has
various different correction elements
what is a map map is a set of key value
pairs used to represent data so when you
work in Big Data field you need to know
about different data types which are
supported by Peg which are supported by
Hive which are supported in other
components of Ado so pupil pack map
array array buffer you can think about
list you can think about dictionaries
you can think about map which is key
value pair so these are your different
complex data types other than the
primitive data types such as integer
character string Boolean float and so on
now what are the various diagnostic
operators available in Apache pick so
these are some of the operators or
options which you can give in a pick
script you can do a thumb now dump
operator runs the pig latin scripts and
displays the result on the screen so
either I could do a dumb and see the
output on the screen or I can even do a
dump into and I could store my output in
a particular file so we can load the
data using load operator in Pig and then
Pig also has different internal storage
like Json loader or pick storage which
can be used if you are working on
specific kind of data and then you could
do a dump either before processing or
after processing and dump would produce
the result the result could be stored in
a file or seen on the screen you also
have a describe operator now that is
used to view the schema of a relation so
you can load the data and then you can
view the schema of relation using
describe operator explain as we might
already know displays the physical
logical and mapreduce execution plans so
normally in rdbms when we use X-Plane we
would like to see what happens behind
the scenes when a particular script or a
query runs so we could load the data
using load operator as in any other case
and if we would want to display The
Logical physical and mapreduce execution
plans we could use explain operator
there is also an illustrate operator now
that gives the step-by-step execution of
sequence of statements so sometimes when
we would want to analyze our script to
see how good or bad they are or would
that really serve our purpose we could
use illustrate and again you can test
that by loading the data using load
operator and you could just use a
illustrate operator to have a look at
the step-by-step execution of the
sequence of statements which you would
want to execute so these are different
diagnostic operators available in Apache
pick now if somebody asks State the
usage of group order by and distinct
keywords in big script so as I said big
is a scripting language so you could use
various operators so group basically
collects various records with the same
key and groups the data in one or more
relations here is an example you could
do a group data so that is basically a
variable or you can give some other name
and you can say group relation Name by H
now say I have a file where I have field
various fields and one of the field is a
relational name so I could group that by
a different field order by is used to
display the contents of relation in a
sorted order whether ascending or
descending so I could create a variable
called relation 2 and then I could say
order relation name 1 by ascending or
descending order distinct basically
removes the duplicate records and it is
implemented only on entire records not
on individual records so if you would
like want to find out the distinct
values and relation name field I could
use distinct what are the relational
operators in pig so you have various
relational operators which help data
scientists or data analysts or
developers who are analyzing the data
such as go Group which joins two or more
tables and then performs group operation
on the join table result you have cross
it is used to compute the cross product
that is a Cartesian product of two or
more relations for each is basically to
do some iteration so if it will iterate
through tuples of a relation generating
a data transformation so for example if
I say variable a equals and then I load
a file in a and then I could create a
variable called B where I could say for
each a I would want to do something say
group join is to join two or more tables
in a relation limit is to limit the
number of output tuples or output
results split is to split the relation
into two or more relations Union is to
get a combination that it will merge the
contents of two or more relations and
order is to get a sorted result so these
are some relational operators which are
extensively used in pig for analysis
what is the use of having filters in
Apache pick now say for example I have
some data which has three Fields here
product quantity and this is my phone
sales data so filter operator could be
used to select the required values from
a relation based on a condition it also
allows you to remove unwanted records
from data file so for example filter the
products where quantity is greater than
thousand so I see that I have one row
wherein or multiple rows where the
quantity is greater than thousands such
as fifteen hundred Seventeen hundred
twelve hundred so I could create a
variable called a I would load my file
using pick storage as I explained
earlier big storage is an internal
parameter which can be used to specify
the delimiters now here my delimiter is
comma so I could say using pick storage
as and then I could specify the data
type for each field so here being
integer product being character array
and quantity being integer then B I
could say filter a whatever we have in a
by quantity greater than thousand so
it's very concise it's very simple and
it allows us to extract and process data
in a simpler way now Suppose there is a
file called test dot txt having 150
records in sdfs so this is a file which
is stored on sdfs and it has 150 records
where we can consider every record being
one line and if somebody asks you to
write a pick command to retrieve the
first 10 records of the file first we
will have to load the data so I could
create a variable called test underscore
data and I would say load my file using
pick storage specifying the delimiter as
comma as and then I could specify my
Fields what whatever Fields our file
have and then I would want to get only
10 records for which I could use the
limit operator so I could say limit on
test data and give me 10 records this is
very simple and we can extract 10
records from 150 records which are
stored in the file on sdfs now we have
learned on Pig we have learned some
questions on hive you could always look
more in books like programming in Hive
or programming in pick and look for some
more examples and try out these examples
on a existing Hadoop setup now let's
learn on hbase which is a nosql database
now edgebase is a four dimensional
database in comparison to your rdbms
which usually are two dimensional so
rdbms have rows and columns but hbase
has four coordinates it has row key
which is always unique column family
which can be any number column
qualifiers which can again be any number
per column family and then you have a
version so these four coordinates make H
base a four dimensional key value store
or a column family store which is unique
for storing huge amount of data and
extracting data from hbase there is a
very good link which I would suggest
everyone can look at if you would want
to learn more on edgebase and you could
just say hbase mapper and this basically
brings up a documentation which is from
mapper but then that's not specific to
map R and you can look at this link
which will give you a detailed
explanation of HP is how it works what
are the Architectural Components and how
data is stored and how it makes edgebase
a very powerful nosql database so let's
learn on some of the important or
critical questions on hbase which might
be asked by the interviewer in an
interview when you are applying for a
Big Data admin or a developer position
role so what are the key components of
edgebase now as I said this is one of
the favorite questions of interviewers
where they would want to understand your
knowledge on different components for a
particular service edgebase as I said is
a nosql database and that comes as a
part of service with Cloudera or
hortonworks and with Apache Hadoop you
could also set up Edge base as an
independent package so what are the key
components of hbase edgebase has a
region server now edgebase follows the
similar kind of topology like Hadoop now
Hadoop has a master process that is name
node and slave processes such as data
nodes and secondary name node in the
same way edgebase also has a master
which is Edge master and the slave
processes are called region servers so
these region servers are usually
co-located with data nodes however it is
not mandatory that if you have 100 data
nodes you would have 100 region servers
so it purely depends on admin so what
does this region server contain so
region server contains hbase tables that
are divided horizontally into regions or
you could say group of rows is called
regions so in edgebase you have two
aspects one is group of columns which is
called column family and one is group of
rows which is called regions now these
regions or these rows are grouped based
on the key values or I would say row
Keys which are always unique when you
store your data in edgebase you would
have data in the form of rows and
columns so group of rows are called
regions or you could say these are
horizontal partitions of the table so a
region server manages these regions on
the Node where a data node is running a
region server can have up to thousand
regions it runs on every node and
decides the size of region so region
server as I said is a slave process
which is responsible for managing HPS
data on the Node each region server is a
worker node or a worker process
co-located with data node which will
take care of your read write update
delete request from the clients now when
we talk about more components of
edgebase as I said you have HP H master
so you would always have a connection
coming in from a client or an
application what does etch Master do it
assigns regions it monitors the region
servers it assigns regions to region
servers for load balancing and it cannot
do that without the help of Zookeeper so
if we talk about components of hbase
there are three main components you have
zookeeper you have etch master and you
have region server region server being
the slave process your Edge Master being
the master process which takes care of
all your table operations assigning
regions to the region servers taking
care of read and write requests which
come from client and for all of this
Edge Master will take in help of
Zookeeper which is a centralized
coordination service so whenever a
client wants to read or write or change
the schema or any other metadata
operations it will contact H Master Edge
Master internally will contact zookeeper
so you could have edgebase setup also in
high availability mode where you could
have a active Edge master in a backup
Edge Master you would have a zookeeper
Quorum which is the way zookeeper works
so zookeeper is a centralized
coordination service which will always
run with a quorum of processes so
zookeeper would always run with odd
number of processes such as 3 5 and 7
because zookeeper works on the concept
of maturity consensus now zookeeper
which is a centralized coordination
service is keeping a track of all the
servers which are alive available and
also keeps a track of their status for
every server which zookeeper is
monitoring zookeeper keeps a session
alive with that particular server Edge
Master would always check with zookeeper
which region servers are available alive
so that regions can be assigned to the
region server at one end you have region
server which are sending their status to
the Zookeeper indicating if they are
ready for any kind of read or write
operation and at other end Edge Master
is querying the Zookeeper to check the
status now zookeeper internally manages
a meta table now that meta table will
have information of which regions are
residing on which region server and what
rookies those regions contain so in case
of a read activity Edge Master will
zookeeper to find out the region server
which contains that meta table once etch
Master gets the information of meta
table it can look into the meta table to
find out the row keys and the
corresponding region servers which
contain the regions for those row Keys
now if we would want to understand row
key and column families in hbase let's
look at this and it would be good if we
could look this on an Excel sheet so row
key is always unique it acts as a
primary key for any hbase table it
allows a logical grouping of cells and
make sure that all cells with the same
row key are co-located on the same
server so as I said you have four
coordinates for hbase you have a row key
which is always unique you have column
families which is nothing but group of
columns and when I say column families
one column family can have any number of
columns so when I talk about hbase hbase
is four dimensional and in terms of H
base it is also called as a column
oriented database which basically means
that every Row in one column could have
a different data type now you have a row
key which uniquely identifies the row
you have column families which could be
one or many depending on how the table
has been defined and a column family can
have any number of columns or I could
say for every row within a column family
you could have different number of
columns so I could say for my Row one I
could just have two columns such as name
and City within the column family for my
Row 2 I could have name City age
designation salary for my third row I
could have thousand columns and all that
could belong to one column family so
this is a horizontally scalable database
so column family consists of group of
columns which is defined during table
creation and each column family can have
any number of column qualifiers
separated by a delimiter now a
combination of row key column family
column qualifier such as name City age
and the value within the cell is makes
the hbase a unique four dimensional
database for more information if you
would want to learn on hbase please
refer this link which is hbase mapper
and this gives a complete edgebase
architecture that has three components
of name node three components that is
name node region servers and zookeeper
how it works how hbase H Master
interacts with zookeeper what zookeeper
does in coordination how are the
components working together and how does
hbase take care of read and write coming
back and continuing why do we need to
disable a table so there are different
table operations what you can didn't do
in hbase and one of them is disabling a
table now if you would want to check the
status of table you could check that by
is disabled and giving the table name or
is enabled and the table name so the
question is why do we need to disable a
table now if we would want to modify a
table or we are doing some kind of
Maintenance activity in that case we can
disable the table so that we can modify
or changes settings when a table is
disabled it cannot be accessed through
the scan command now if we have to write
a code to open a connection in hbase now
to interact with hbase one could either
use a graphical user interface such as
Hue or you could be using the command
line hbase shell or you could be using
hbase admin API if you are working with
Java or say happy base if you are
working with python where you may want
to open a connection with hbase so that
you can work with database
programmatically in that case we have to
create a configuration object that is
configuration my conf and then create a
configuration object and then you can
use different classes like Edge table
interface to work on a new table you
could use each column qualifier and many
other classes which are available in
hbase admin API what does replication
mean in terms of hbase so edgebase as I
said Works in a cluster way and when you
talk about cluster you could always set
up a replication from one hbase cluster
to other edgebase cluster so this
replication feature in hbase provides a
mechanism to copy data between clusters
or sync the data between different
clusters this feature can be used as a
disaster recovery solution that provides
High availability for hbase so if I have
hbase cluster 1 where I have one master
and multiple region servers running in a
Hadoop cluster I could use the same
Hadoop cluster to create a hbase replica
cluster or I could have a totally
different edgebase replica cluster where
my intention is that if things are
changing in a particular table in
cluster one I would want them to be
replicated across different cluster so I
could alter the edge base table and set
the replication scope to 1. now a
replication scope of 0 indicates that
table is not replicated but if we set
the replication to 1 we basically will
have to set up ahbs cluster where we can
replicate hbase tables data from cluster
1 to Cluster so these are the commands
which can be used to enable replication
and then replicate the data of table
across clusters can we Import and Export
in hbase of course we can it is possible
to Import and Export tables from one
edgebase cluster to other hbase cluster
or even within a cluster so we can use
the hbase export utility which comes in
this particular package give a table
name and then a Target location so that
will export the data of hbase table into
a directory on sdfs then I could create
a different table which would follow
some kind of same definition as the
table which was exported and then I
could use import to import the data from
the directory on sdfs to my table if you
would want to learn more on hbase Import
and Export you could look at hbase
import operations let's search for the
link and this is the link where you
could learn more about hbase import
export utilities how you could do a bulk
import bulk export which internally uses
mapreduce and then you could do a Import
and Export into edgebase tables moving
further what do we mean by compaction in
edgebase now we all know that hbase is a
nosql database which can be used to
store huge amount of data however
whenever a data is written in hbase it
is first written to what we call as
write ahead log and also to mem store
which is write cache now once the data
is written involved and your mem store
it is offloaded to form an internal
edgebase format file which is called H5
and usually these edge files are very
small in nature so we also know that
sdfs is good when we talk about few
number of larger files in comparison to
large number of smaller files due to the
limitation of name nodes memory
compaction is process of merging hbase
files that is the smaller edge files
into a single large file this is done to
reduce the amount of memory required to
store the files and number of disk seeks
needed so we could have lot of H files
which get created when the data is
written to hbase and these smaller files
can then be compacted through a major or
minor compaction creating one big Edge
file which internally would then be
written to osdfs and sdfs format of
blocks that is the benefit of compaction
there is also a feature called Bloom
filter so how does Bloom filter work so
Bloom filter or hbase Bloom filter is a
mechanism to test whether a h file
contains a specific row or a row column
cell Bloom filter is named after its
creator button covered Bloom it is a
data structure which predicts whether a
given element is a member of a set of
data it provides an in-memory index
structure that reduces the disk that
reads and determines the probability of
finding a row in a particular file this
is one of very useful features of hbase
which allows for faster access and
avoids disk syncs thus edgebase have any
concept of namespace so namespace is
when you have similar elements grouped
together so namespace yes hway supports
such names space so namespace is a
logical grouping of tables analogous to
a database in rdbms so you can create
hbase namespace to the schema of rdbms
database so you could create a namespace
by saying create namespace and giving it
a name and then you could also list the
tables within a namespace you could
create tables within a specific
namespace now this is usually done in
production environment where a cluster
might be multi-tenant cluster and there
might be different users of the same
nosql database in that case admin would
create specific namespace and for
specific name space you would have
different directories on hdfs and users
of a particular business unit or a team
can work on their edgebase objects
within a specific name space this is a
question which is again very important
to understand about the rights or reads
so how does right ahead log wall hell
when a region server crashes now as I
said when a write happens it will happen
into mem store and wall that is your
edit log or write ahead log so whenever
a write happens it will happen in two
places mem store which is the right
cache and wall which is a edit log only
when the data is written in both these
places and based on the limitation of
mem store the data will be flushed to
create an edgebase format file called H5
these files are then compacted and
created into one bigger file which will
then be stored on sdfs and sdfs data as
we know is stored in the form of blocks
on the underlying data nodes so if a
region server hosting a mem store
crashes now where is region server
running that would be co-located with
data node so if a data node crashes or
if a region server which was hosting the
mem store Write cash crashes data in
memory the data that in memory which was
not persisted is lost now how does
edgebase recover from this as I said
your data is written into wall and mem
store at the same time hbase recovers
against that by writing to wall before
the write completes so whenever a write
happens it happens in mem store and wall
at the same time HBS cluster keeps a
wall to record changes as they happen
and that's why we call it as also an
edit log if edgebase goes down or the
node that goes down the data that was
not flushed from mem store to Edge file
can be recovered by replaying the right
ahead log and that's the benefit of your
edit log or write ahead log now if we
would have to write hbase command to
list the contents and update the column
families of a table I could just do a
scan and that would give me complete
data of a table if you are very specific
and if you would want to look at a
particular row then you could do a get
table name and then give the rocky
however you could do a scan to get the
complete data of a particular table you
could also do a describe to see what are
the different column families and if you
would want to alter the table and add a
new column family it is very simple you
can just say alter give the HB stable
name and then give you a new column
family name which will then be added to
the table what are catalog tables in
hbase so as I mentioned your zookeeper
knows the location of this internal
catalog table or what we call as The
Meta table now catalog tables in
edgebase have two tables one is hbase
meta table and one is hyphen root the
catalog table Edge base meta exists as
an hbase table and is filtered out of
hbase shells list command so if I give a
list command on edgebase it would list
all the tables which h space contains
but not the meta table it's an internal
table this meta table keeps a list of
all regions in the system and location
of hbase method stored in Zookeeper so
if somebody wants to find out or look
for particular rows they need to know
the regions which contain that data and
those regions are located on region
server to get all this information one
has to look into this meta table however
we will not be looking into meta table
directly we would just be giving a write
or a read operation internally your
hbase master queries the Zookeeper
zookeeper has the information of where
the meta table exists and that meta
table which is existing on region server
contains information of row keys and the
region servers where those rows can be
found your root table keeps a track of
location of The Meta table what is hot
spotting in hbase and how to avoid hot
spotting now this is a common problem
and always admin guys or guy guys who
are managing the infrastructure would
think about it so one of the main idea
is that edgebase would be leveraging the
benefit of sdfs you are all read and
write request should be uniformly
distributed across all of the regions
and region servers otherwise what's the
benefit of having a distributed cluster
so you would have your data stored
across region servers in the form of
regions which are horizontal partitions
of the table and whenever read and write
requests happen they should be uniformly
distributed across all the regions in
the region servers now hotspotting
occurs when a given region serviced by a
region server receives most or all of
read and write request which is
basically a unbalanced way of read write
operations now hotspot can be avoided by
designing the row key in such a way that
data being written should go to multiple
regions across the cluster so you could
do techniques such as salting hashing
reversing the key and many other
techniques which are employed by users
of hbase we need to just make sure that
when the regions are distributed across
region servers they should be spread
across region servers so that your read
and write request can be satisfied from
different region servers in parallel
rather than all read and write request
hitting the same region server
overloading the region server which may
also lead to the crashing of a
particular page and server so these were
some of the important questions of hbase
and then there are many more please
refer to the link which I specified in
during my discussion and that gives you
a detailed explanation of how edgebase
works you can also look into hbase
definitive guide by O'Reilly or hbase in
action and these are really good books
to understand about hbase internals and
how it works now that we have learned on
hive which is a data warehousing package
we have learned on Pig which is a
scripting or a scripting language which
allows you to do data analysis and we
have learned some questions on a nosql
database just note it that there are
more than 225 nosql databases existing
in market and if you would want to learn
and know about more nosql databases you
can just go to Google and type no SQL
databases org and that will take you to
the link which is for nosql databases
and this shows there are more than 225
nosql databases existing in market and
these are for different use cases used
by different users and for with
different features so have a look at
this link now when you talk about data
ingestion so let's look at data
ingestion and this is one good link
which I would suggest to have a look at
which lists down around 18 different
injection tools so when you talk about
different data ingestion tools some are
for structured data some are for
streaming data some are for data
governance some are for data ingestion
and transformation and so on so have a
look at this link which also gives you a
comparison of different data ingestion
tools so here let's learn about some
questions on scoop which is one of the
data ingestion tools mainly used for
structured data or you could say data
which is coming in from rdbms or data
which is already structured and you
would want to ingest that you would want
to store that on sdfs which could then
be used for Hive which could be used for
any kind of processing using mapreduce
or Hive or pig or spark or any other
processing Frameworks or you would want
to load that data into say hi for regime
Stables scoop is mainly for structured
data it is extensively used when
organizations are migrating from rdbms
to a big data platform and they would be
interested in ingesting the data that is
doing Import and Export of data from
rdbms to sdfs or vice versa so let's
learn about some important questions on
scope which you may be asked by an
interviewer when you apply for a big
data related position how is scoop
different from Flume so this is a very
common question which is asked scoop
which is mainly for structured data so
scoop works with rdbms it also works
with nosql databases to Import and
Export data so you can import data into
sdfs you can import data into Data
browsing packets such as Hive directly
or also in hbase and you could also
export data from Hadoop ecosystem to
your rdbms however when it comes to flow
Flume is more of a data ingestion tool
which works with streaming data or
unstructured data so data which is
constantly getting generated for example
log files or metrics from server or some
chat messenger and so on so if you are
interested in working on capturing and
storing the streaming data in a storage
layer such as sdfs or edgebase you could
be using Flume there could be other
tools also like Kafka or storm or chukwa
or some nifi and so on scoop however is
mainly for structured data you're
loading data in scope is not event
driven so it is not based on event it
basically works on data which is already
stored in rdbms in terms of Flume it is
completely event driven that is as the
messages or as the events happen as the
data is getting generated you can have
that data ingested using flow Zoom scoop
works with structured data sources and
you have various scope connectors which
are used to fetch data from external
data structures or rdbms so for every
rdbms such as MySQL Oracle tb2 Microsoft
SQL Server you have different connectors
which are available Flume it works on
fetching streaming data such as tweets
or log files or server metrics from your
different sources where the data is
getting generated and if you are
interested in not only ingesting that
data which is getting generated in a
streaming fashion but if you would be
interested in processing the data as it
arrives scoop can import data from rdbms
onto sdfs and also export it back to
rdbms Flume is then used for streaming
data now you could have one to one one
to many or many to one kind of relation
so in terms of Flume you have components
such as your Source sync and channel
that's the main difference between your
scoop and flow what are the different
file formats to import data using scope
well there are lots and lots of formats
in which you can import data into scoop
when you talk about scoop you can have
delimited text file format now that's
the default import format it can be
specified explicitly using as text file
argument so when I want to import data
from an rdbms I could get that data in
hdfs using different compression schemes
or in different formats using the
specific arguments so I could specify an
argument which will write string based
representation of each record to Output
files with delimiters between individual
columns and rows so that is the default
format which is used to import data in
using scoop so to learn more about your
scoop and different arguments which are
available you can click on scoop dot
apache.org you can look into the
documentation and I would suggest
choosing one of the versions and looking
into the user guide and here you can
search for arguments and look for
specific control arguments which show
how you can import data using scoop so
here we have common arguments and then
you also have import control arguments
wherein we have different options like
getting data as Avro as sequence file as
text file or parquet file these are
different formats you can also get data
in default compression scheme that is
gzip or you can specify compression
codec and then you can specify What
compression mechanism you would want to
use when you are importing your data
using school when it comes to default
format for Flume we could say sequence
file which is a binary format that
stores individual records in record
specific data types so these data types
are manifested as Java classes and scoop
will automatically generate these data
types for you so scoop does that when we
talk about your sequence file format in
terms of your scoop you could be
extracting storage of all data in binary
representation so as I mentioned you can
import data in different formats such as
Avro parquet sequence file that is
binary format or machine readable format
and then you could also have data in
different compression schemes let me
just show you some quick examples here
so if I look in uh the content and here
I could search for a scoop based file
where I have listed down some examples
so if I would want to use different
compression schemes here are some
examples have a look at these so I'm
doing a scoop import I'm also giving an
argument so that scope which also
triggers a map reduced job or I would
say map only job so when you run a scoop
import it triggers a map only job no
reduce happens here and you could
specify this parameter or this argument
on the command line mapreduce dot
framework.name so that you could run
your map only job in in local mode to
save time or that would interact with
yarn and run a full-fledged map only job
we can give the connection and then
connect to whatever rdbms we are
connecting mentioning the database name
give your username and password give the
table name give it Target directory or
it would create a directory same as the
table name which would work only once
and then I could say minus Z to get data
in a compressed format that is gzip or I
could be specifying compression codec
and then I could specify What
compression codec I would want to use
say Snappy B is lz4 default I could also
run a query by giving a scope import and
when I am specifying a query I if you
notice I have not given any table name
because that would be included in the
query I can get my data as a sequence
file format which is a binary format
which will create a huge file so we
could also have compression enabled and
then I could say the output of my map
job should use a compression at record
level for my data coming in sequence
file so sequence file or a binary format
supports compression at record level or
at Block Level I could get my data in a
Avro file where data has embedded schema
within the file or a parquet file also
so these are different ways in which you
can set up different compression schemes
or you can even get data in different
formats and you could be doing a simple
scope import for these looking further
what is the importance of eval tool in
scope so there is something called as
eval tool so scoop eval tool allows
users to execute user defined queries
against respective database servers and
preview the result in the console so
either I could be running a straight
away query to import the data into
mystfs or I could just use scoop eval
connect to my external rdbms specify my
username and password and then I could
be giving in a query to see what would
be the result of the query which we
intend to import now let's learn about
how scoop imports and exports data
between rdbms and sdfs with its
architecture so rdbms as we know has
your database structures your tables
which all of them are logical and
internally there is always metadata
which is stored your scope import
connects to an external rdbms and for
this connection it uses an internal
connector jar file which has a driver
class so that's something which needs to
be set up by admin but they need to make
sure that whichever rdbms you intend to
connect to they need to have the jdbc
connector for that particular rdbms
stored within the scoop lib folder so
scoop import gets the metadata and then
for your scoop command it converts that
into a map only job which might have one
or multiple map tasks now that depends
on your scoop command you could be
specifying that you would want to do a
import only in one task or in multiple
tasks these multiple map tasks will then
run on a section of data from rdbms and
then store it in sdfs so at high level
we could say scoop will introspect
database to get gather the metadata it
divides the input data set into splits
and this division of data into splits
mainly happens on primary key column of
the table now if somebody might ask what
if my table in rdbms does not have a
primary key column then when you are
doing a scope import either you will
have to import it using one mapper task
by specifying hyphen hyphen m equals one
or you would have to say split by
parameter to specify a numeric column
from rdbms and that's how you can import
the data let me just show you a quick
example on this so I could just look in
again into the scoop command file and
here we could be looking at an example
so if you see this one here we are
specifying minus minus m equals 1 which
basically means I would want to import
the data using one map task now in this
case whether the table has a primary key
column or does not have a primary key
column will not matter but if I say a
minus minus ms6 where I am specifying
multiple map tasks to be imported then
this will look for a primary key column
in the table which you are importing now
if the table does not have a primary key
column then I could be specifying a
split by and then specify the column so
that the data could be split into
multiple chunks and multiple map tasks
would take it now if the second scenario
is your table does not have a primary
key column and it does not have a
numeric column on which you could do a
split by in that case and if you would
want to use multiple mappers you could
still say split by on a textual column
but you will have to add this property
so that it allows splitting the data
which is
non-numeric all of these options are
given in the scoop apache.org link going
further how scoop imports and exports
data between rdbms and sdfs with its
architecture so as I said it submits the
map only job to the cluster and then it
basically does a import or export so if
we are exporting the data from sdfs in
that case again there would be a map
only job it would look at multiple
splits of the data which is existing
which your map only job would process
through one or one table map task and
then export it to rdbms suppose you have
a database test DB in MySQL we if
somebody asked you to write a command to
connect this database and import tables
to scoop so here is a quick example as I
showed you in the command file so you
could say scoop import this is what we
would want to do you connect using jdbc
now this will only work if the jdbc
connector already exists within your
scope lib directory admin has to set up
that so you can connect to your rdbms
you can point to the database so here
our database name is test underscore DB
I could give username and then either I
could give password on the command line
or just say capital P so that I would be
prompted for the password and then I
could give the table name which I would
want to import I could also be
specifying minus minus M and specify how
many map tasks do I want to use for this
import as I showed in previous screen
how to export a table back to rdbms now
for this we need the data in a directory
on hdfs so for example there is a
departments table in retail database
which is already imported into scoop and
you need to export this table back to
rdbms so this is the content of the
table now create a new Department table
in rdbms so I could create a table
specifying the column names whether that
supports null or no if that has a
primary key column which is always
recommended and then I can do a scope
export I can connect to the rdbms
specifying my username and password
specify the table into which you want to
export the data and then you give export
directory pointing to a directory on
hdfs which contains the data this is how
you can export data into table seeing
example on this so I could again look
into my file and here I have an example
of import this is where you are
importing data directly into Hive and
you have scoop import where you are
importing data directly into hbase table
and you can then query your hbase table
to look at the data you could also do a
export by running your map only job in a
local mode connecting to the rdbms
specifying your username specifying the
table where you would want to export and
the directory on scfs where you have
kept the relevant data this is a simple
example of export looking further what
is the role of jdbc driver in scoop
setup so as I said if you would want to
use scoop to connect to an external
rdbms we need the jdbc odbc connector
jar file now one or admin could download
the jdbc connector jar file and then
place the jar file within the scoop lib
directory wherever scoop is installed
and this jdbc connector jar file
contains a driver now jdbc driver is a
standard Java API which is used for
accessing different databases in rdpms
so this connector jar file is very much
required and this connector jar file has
a driver class
and this driver class enables the
connection between your rdbms and your
Hadoop structure each database vendor is
responsible for writing their own
implementation that will allow
communication with the corresponding
database and we need to download the
drivers which allow our scope to connect
to external rdbms so your jdbc driver
alone is not enough to connect to scoop
we also need connectors to interact with
different database so a connector is a
plugable piece that is used to fetch
metadata and allow scope to overcome the
differences in SQL dialects so this is
how connection can be established so
normally your admins would when they are
setting up scoop and Hadoop they would
download say MySQL jdbc connector and
this is how they would go to the MySQL
connectors if you are connecting to
mySQL similar early for your other rdbms
you could be say going in here you could
be looking for a previous version
depending you could be going for
platform independent and then you could
be downloading the connected jar file
now if you enter this jar file you would
see a MySQL connector jar and if we look
in com dot
mysql.jdbc.com.mysql.dbc.driver so this
is the package which is within the
connector jar file and this has the
driver class which allows the connection
of your scoop with your rdbms so these
things will have to be done by your
admin so that you can have your scoop
connecting to an external rdbms now how
do you update the columns that are
already exported so if I do a export and
I put my data in rdbms can I really
update the columns that are already
exported yes I can using a update key
parameter so scoop export command
Remains the Same the only thing I will
have to specify now is the table name
your Fields terminated by if you have a
specific delimiter and then you can say
update key and then the column name so
this allows us to update the columns
that are already exported in rdbms what
is code gen so scoop commands translate
into your mapreduce job or map only job
so code gen is basically a tool in scope
that generates data access objects Dao
Java classes that encapsulate and
interpret imported records so if I do a
scoop code gen connect to an rdbms using
my username and give a table this will
generate a Java code for employee table
in in the test database so this code gen
can be useful for us to understand what
data we have in this particular table
finally can scope be used to convert
data in different formats I think I
already answered that right if no which
tools can be used for this purpose so
scoop can be used to convert data in
different formats and that depends on
the different arguments which you use
when you do a import such as avrofile
parquet file binary format with record
or Block Level compression so if you are
interested in knowing more on different
data formats then I think I can suggest
a link for that and we can say Hadoop
for match
I think it is Tech Mackie afro parquet
Let's see we can find out the Link tech
Maggie yeah this is a very good link
which specifies or talks about different
data formats which you should know such
as your text file format different
compression schemes how is data
organization what are the common formats
what do you have in text file structured
binary sequence files with compression
without compression what is record level
what is Block Level what is a Avro data
file what is a sequel what is a parquet
data file or a columnar format another
format like orc RC and so on so please
have a look at this and with that we
have come to the end of this video on
Big Data engineer full course I hope it
was informative and interesting if you
have any questions related to the topics
that we covered in this video please ask
away in the comment section below our
team will help you solve your queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here